hi everyone welcome to another video
tutorial by simply loan now this is a
full course video on artificial
intelligence engineer we are going to
discuss artificial intelligence machine
learning deep learning and the skills
you need to possess to become a
successful ai engineer a team of
experienced trainers will take you
through this course
but before i begin make sure to
subscribe to the simply learn channel
for more interesting tech videos
[Music]
so we'll start by understanding what is
artificial intelligence in a short
animated video
then we'll see the top skills that will
help you become a successful ai engineer
we will look at the top applications of
artificial intelligence and learn the
basics of machine learning we will
explore the various algorithms with
hands-on demonstrations in python
so we will understand about linear
regression logistic regression decision
tree k nearest neighbors principal
component analysis as well as
reinforcement learning moving ahead
you will look at deep learning and how
neural networks work we will also see
how tensorflow and keras libraries work
then you will look at the future of ai
and the top machine learning and deep
learning interview questions that are
crucial to become a successful ai
engineer so let's get started
picture this a machine that could
organize your cupboard just as you like
it or serve every member of the house a
customized cup of coffee makes your day
easier doesn't it these are the products
of artificial intelligence but why use
the term artificial intelligence well
these machines are artificially
incorporated with human-like
intelligence to perform tasks as we do
this intelligence is built using complex
algorithms and mathematical functions
but ai may not be as obvious as in the
previous examples in fact ai is used in
smartphones cars social media feeds
video games banking surveillance and
many other aspects of our daily life the
real question is what does an ai do at
its core here is a robot we built in our
lab which is now dropped onto a field in
spite of a variation in lighting
landscape and dimensions of the field
the ai robot must perform as expected
this ability to react appropriately to a
new situation is called generalized
learning the robot is now at a crossroad
one that is paved and the other rocky
the robot must determine which path to
take based on the circumstances this
portrays the robot's reasoning ability
after a short stroll the robot now
encounters a stream that it cannot swim
across using the plank provided as an
input the robot is able to cross this
stream so our robot uses the given input
and finds the solution for a problem
this is problem solving these three
capabilities make the robot artificially
intelligent in short ai provides
machines with the capability to adapt
reason and provide solutions
well now that we know what ai is let's
have a look at the two broad categories
an ais classified into
weak ai also called narrow ai focuses
solely on one task
for example alphago is a maestro of the
game go but you can't expect it to be
even remotely good at chess
this makes alphago a weak ai
you might say alexa is definitely not a
weak ai since it can perform multiple
tasks well that's not really true when
you ask alexa to play despacito it picks
up the keywords play and despacito
and runs a program and is trained to
alexa cannot respond to a question it
isn't trained to answer for instance try
asking alexa the status of traffic from
work to home
alexa cannot provide you this
information as she is not trained to
and that brings us to our second
category of ai strong ai
now this is much like the robots that
only exist in fiction as of now
ultron from avengers is an ideal example
of a strong ai
that's because it's self-aware and
eventually even develops emotions
this makes the ai's response
unpredictable
you must be wondering well how is
artificial intelligence different from
machine learning and deep learning
we saw what ai is machine learning is a
technique to achieve ai and deep
learning in turn is a subset of machine
learning
machine learning provides a machine with
the capability to learn from data and
experience through algorithms
deep learning does this learning through
ways inspired by the human brain this
means through deep learning data and
patterns can be better perceived ray
kurzweil a well-known futurist predicts
that by the year 2045 we would have
robots as smart as humans
this is called the point of singularity
well that's not all
in fact elon musk predicts that the
human mind and body will be enhanced by
ai implants which would make us partly
cyborgs
so here's a question for you which of
the below ai projects don't exist yet
a an ai robot with citizenship
b a robot with a muscular skeletal
system
c ai that can read its owner's emotions
d ai that develops emotions over time
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comment section below since the
human brain is still a mystery it's no
surprise that ai2 has a lot of
unventured domains
for now ai is built to work with humans
and make our tasks easier
however with the maturation of
technology we can only wait and watch
what the future of ai holds for us hi
guys i'm rahul from simply learn and
today i'm going to tell you how you can
become an ai engineer so first off let's
ask the important question what is
artificial intelligence now artificial
intelligence is the ability of a
computer system to mimic human behavior
now this is the sort of intelligence
that's demonstrated by machines and this
is in contrast to natural intelligence
that's shown by humans as well as
animals so how does artificial
intelligence work firstly it learns from
past data now whatever machines that are
artificially intelligent learn from
their actions which are positive or
negative now with this new information
the machine is able to make corrections
to itself so that these problems don't
resurface and make some adjustments to
handle new inputs and finally the
machine is able to perform human-like
tasks so who is an artificial
intelligence engineer an a engineer
builds ai models using machine learning
algorithms and deep learning neural
networks to draw business insights now
these insights can be used to make
business decisions that affect the
entire organization not to mention they
also create weak or strong ais depending
on what goal they want to achieve now
air engineers have a sound understanding
of programming software engineering as
well as data science they use different
tools and techniques so that they can
process data and they develop as well as
maintain ai systems now let's talk about
the responsibilities of an ai engineer
firstly they need to develop test and
deploy ai models this can be done
through a number of different
programming algorithms like random
forest logistic regression linear
regression and so on they need to be
able to convert the machine learning
models into apis or application program
interfaces so that other applications
can use it they're responsible for
building ai models from scratch and help
the different components of the
organization such as product managers
and stakeholders understand what they
stand to gain from the model they need
to build data ingestion and data
transformation infrastructure they need
to automate infrastructure that's used
by the data science team they need to be
able to perform statistical analysis and
tune the results so that the
organization can take better informed
decisions they need to set up as well as
manage ai development and product
infrastructure and they need to be good
at teamwork since they'll be
coordinating work with teams of data as
well as business analysts next up let's
talk about the skills required to become
an ai engineer first off programming
skills now the first skill required to
become an ai engineer is programming
skills now for you to become well versed
in ai it is very important that you
start learning programming languages
such as python r java and c plus plus so
that you are able to build as well as
implement so that you will be able to
build as well as implement models the
second skill required is linear algebra
probability and statistics now to
understand as well as implement
different ai models such as hidden
markov models naive bayes gaussian
mixture models linear discriminant
analysis and so on you need to have
detailed knowledge of linear algebra
probability and statistics the third
skill required is knowledge about spark
and big data technologies now since ai
engineers work with large volumes of
data which could be streaming or
real-time production level data
production level data in terabytes or
even petabytes they need to know about
spark and other big data technologies to
make sense of this along with apache
spark you could also use other big data
technologies like hadoop cassandra and
mongodb the next skill that you require
is to be well versed with algorithms and
frameworks now understanding how machine
learning algorithms like linear
regression k nn navbase svm and others
work will help you implement machine
learning models with ease also to build
ai models with unstructured data you
need to understand deep learning
algorithms like cnn which is the
convolutional neural network rnn which
is the recurrent neural network and gan
which is the generative adversarial
network and so so that you can implement
it using a framework some of the
frameworks used in artificial
intelligence are pytorch theano
tensorflow and cafe the final skill
required to become an ai engineer is
communication and problem solving skills
now you need to be very good at
communication so that you're able to
pitch your product and idea to the
stakeholders you should also have
excellent problem solving skills to
resolve obstacles for decision making
and draw helpful business insights now
let's talk about an ai engineer's salary
the average salary of an ai engineer is
111 000 dollars per annum in the united
states and rupees 13 lakhs per annum in
india now let's talk about the career
and roles in artificial intelligence
since several industries around the
world use ai to some degree or the other
there has been an exponential growth in
the career opportunities within the
field of ai let's have a look at some of
these job roles first off we have ai
developer now these individuals work
closely with electrical engineers and
develop software to create artificially
intelligent robots next up we have ai
architect now these people work closely
with clients so that they can provide
business as well as system integration
services while at the same time creating
and maintaining the entire architecture
the next role we're going to talk about
is machine learning engineer now these
individuals build predictive models
using wasps using vast volumes of data
have in-depth knowledge of machine
learning algorithms deep learning
algorithms and deep learning frameworks
next up we have data scientists now data
scientists collect clean analyze and
interpret large and complex data sets by
leveraging both machine learning and
predictive analytics and finally we have
bi developer or business intelligence
developer they're responsible for
designing modeling and analyzing complex
data to identify business as well as
market trends so how can simply learn
help you simply learn has now tied up
with ibm and is offering the ai
engineers masters program this program
consists of a number of different
courses such as introduction to
artificial intelligence data science
with python machine learning deep
learning fundamentals by ibm deep
learning with tensorflow and the ai
capstone project after completing this
course you'll get a certificate from
both ibm as well as simplylearn which is
recognized across the world ibm is the
second largest predictive analysis and
machine learning solutions provider
globally a joint partnership with
simplylearn and ibm introduces you to
integrated blended learning and making
you an expert in artificial intelligence
and data science the program code
developed with ibm will make you
industry ready for artificial
intelligence as well as data science job
roles as benefit you get simply learn
job assist you perform capstone and 15
plus real life projects and assistance
with 20 plus in demand skills and tools
tools such as numpy scipy apache spark
watson keras python r and much more you
also have certain other benefits such as
access to exclusive forums which are
moderated by expert faculty and industry
thought leaders thousand two hundred
dollars worth of ibm cloud credits that
you can leverage for hands-on exposure
access to ibm cloud platforms such as
ibm watson which is ibm's own
supercomputer and other software for 24
7 practice access to digital badges from
ibm and of course the industry
recognized master certificate from
simply learn so if your dream is to
become an ai engineer i suggest you go
on to simplylearn.com and get started on
your journey to getting certified and
getting ahead now let's have a look at
how artificial intelligence is used in
different domains
first off ai applications in e-commerce
ai offers you personalized shopping with
ai you have a recommendation engine
through which you can engage better with
your customers
these recommendations are made by taking
into consideration their usage history
their preferences and interests
by providing these recommendations what
you're doing is basically improving your
relationship with your customers you are
improving their loyalty towards your
brand and by extension causing an
increase in the number of conversions
with ai you can provide users the
ability to perform visual searches users
can upload an image of the item they
require search results are shown that
match their query so all of this can be
done without them having to type a
single word next we have ai powered
assistance assistants like virtual
shopping assistants and chat bots help
improve use experience while shopping
online for this techniques like nlp or
natural language processing are used to
make the conversation sound as human and
personal as possible did you know that
soon customer service could be handled
by chatbots on amazon.com moreover these
assistants can have real-time engagement
with your customers they can handle
multiple situations like if the customer
has some feedback the chatbot will take
it from them or if they have some basic
questions about your brand the chatbot
can help them out these assistants can
help further emphasize the point to the
users about how important they are to
your organization
next under e-commerce we have smart
purchasing customer trends are often
difficult to predict
but with ai they don't have to be ai can
focus demands related to a particular
product with this knowledge your
decisions on what products to stock up
and when it needs to be done can be
positively impacted doing this you're
meeting customer expectations and
improving their experience with your
brand
finally under e-commerce we have fraud
prevention
two of the biggest issues that
e-commerce companies have to deal with
are credit card fraud and fake reviews
by taking into consideration usage
patterns ai can help deal with reducing
the possibility of credit card frauds
taking place
talking about fake reviews did you know
that more than 80 percent of customers
decide to buy a product or service based
on their customer reviews ai can help
identify and handle fake reviews by
making sure they're handled you are
improving customer trust in your brand
and products some of the organizations
that have already started ai are amazon
alibaba.com and ebay based on research
performed by mit gps technology can
provide users with accurate timely and
detailed information to improve safety
the technology uses a combination of
conventional neural networks and graph
neural network which makes lives easier
for users by automatically determining
the number of lanes and road types
behind obstructions on the roads
next up we have ai applications in
robotics first off let's have a look at
mobility
robots that are powered by ai will use
real-time updates they would be able to
maneuver through a particular part of
travel with this path the robot can
sense obstacles in its path and then
pre-plan its journey it can be used for
carrying goods in factories warehouses
and hospitals cleaning offices and large
equipments inventory management and it
is also used for exploring environments
that are too dangerous for humans
ai can also be used in process
optimization
data obtained by sensors can be analyzed
to enhance ai intelligence with this
knowledge unnecessary breakdowns are
prevented and it can also reduce
associated costs of major issues
next up let's see how ai is applied in
the human resources domain
now this is something most people
wouldn't have expected did you know that
companies use software to ease the
hiring process
artificial intelligence helps with blind
hiring
software that uses machine learning can
be used to sift through applications
based on specific parameters ai can be
used to scan job candidates profiles and
resumes to provide recruiters an
understanding of the talent pool they
must choose from now let's have a look
at ai applications in healthcare first
off let's have a look at how ai is used
in patient care so there are these
things called prescription errors which
are basically caused due to slips lapses
or mistakes in a doctor's prescription
let's face it a dosage too high can be
the difference between life and death
audit systems that use ai can help
prevent these kinds of errors from being
handled and the diseases are properly
identified some of the popular uses are
jvon analytic and well frame next let's
see how ai is used with medical imaging
and diagnostics
ai can help with early diagnosis to
analyze chronic conditions taking into
consideration laboratory and other
medical data it is also used with
advanced medical imaging through which
you can analyze and transform images
through this you can create models for
possible scenarios next up is ai
applications in research and development
ai is really important when it comes to
the discovery of new drugs this is made
possible with the help of a combination
of historical data and medical
intelligence it also helps understand
the human gene and its components it
also helps predict the different
outcomes possible if gene editing is
performed right now there's probably
scientists racing to develop the gene
sequence for covid19 and towards the
creation of the vaccine now that we have
reached midwest i have a question to ask
are you guys using ai powered software
in your workplace let me know in the
live chat if you enjoy watching
informative tech videos like this one
consider subscribing to simply learn's
channel to stay up to date on the
trending technologies and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update in the
future next up let's talk about ai
applications in agriculture first off ai
helps with monitoring crop and soil
health it can help with identifying
defects and nutrient deficiency in the
soil by analyzing images of soil and
patterns in them soil defects plant
pests and diseases can be identified
next ai helps decrease pesticide usage
using technology like computer vision
robotics and machine learning using this
kind of technology it can be determined
where weeds are grown this way
herbicides can be sprayed only where the
weeds are with this herbicide usage is
limited ai also helps with agriculture
bots it can be used to reduce human
labor by harvesting crops at a faster
rate and a higher volume next let's have
a look at artificial intelligence in
gaming one of the most important things
that game companies need to handle which
is labor costs this is done to generate
levels maps textures weapons characters
etc ai can be used to create smart
human-like npcs to interact with players
it can also be used to predict human
behavior using which game design and
testing can be improved
now this example isn't a recent one but
that of a 2014 game called alien
isolation
now if you know about the movies you
know it's from the alien series of
movies so in this game the titular alien
stalks the player throughout the game
the alien uses two ais to hunt the
player a director ai that always knows
the position of the location of the
player and an alien ai which is driven
by sensors and behaviors that constantly
hunt the player the director ai only
gives the alien ai clues to the player's
location which it needs to figure out
now let's have a look at ai application
in automobiles first off we have
driverless automobiles by taking a
combination of information obtained from
the vehicle's camera radar cloud
services gps and control signals that
can be used to operate the vehicle it's
thanks to all of this that the car is
able to drive itself next ai offers
driver assistance ai can be used to
improve the in-vehicle experience as
well systems like emergency braking
blind spot monitoring driver asset
steering are used next up ai and social
media first let's see how facebook is
able to use ai one of the ways ai is
being used is for analyzing pictures
this can be used to identify the people
in an image ai is also used in a tool
called deep text so with the help of ai
can be used to analyze posts that
represent suicidal thoughts the tool can
also be used to translate posts from
different languages
next let's have a look at ai used by
instagram ai takes into account your
likes and the accounts you follow to
determine what posts you are shown on
your explore tab the deep text tool has
also been used recently to identify and
remove spam messages from user accounts
ai is also used for handling
cyberbullying to check content based on
hashtags from other users next up ai and
twitter ai is used to determine fraud
propaganda and hateful content on the
platform it is also used to recommend
tweets that the users might enjoy based
on what tweets that you engage with
it is also used to filter through
inappropriate content and remote from
the platform ai is also used for
automatically cropping images based on
face recognition it is also used to
filter through inappropriate content and
remove it from the platform ai is also
used for automatically cropping images
based on face recognition
and finally let's have a look at ai
applications and marketing
first off ai enables programmatic
advertising ai enables highly targeted
and personalized ads by taking into
consideration behavioral analysis
pattern recognition and much more ai
also enables you to re-target audiences
at right time to make sure they are
given appropriate results and ensure
feelings of annoyance and distrust next
up that's personalized narratives ai can
help with content marketing in a way
that matches the brand style and voice
it can also be used to handle routine
tasks like performance campaign reports
and much more then ai helps with setting
up chat bots chat bots are powered by ai
natural language processing natural
language generation natural language
understanding that can understand what
the user's language and respond in the
ways humans do then we have personalized
ui and ux it can be used to provide
users with real-time personalization
basically these smart systems can
process information about site visitors
or app users then apply changes to the
model in ways that optimize it for
future use by continually learning and
adjusting the algorithms improves the
user's experience to offer a more
engaging personalized experience next ai
helps with localization it can help with
editing and optimizing market campaigns
to fit the needs of the local market by
automated editing of certain variables
like ctas ad copies etc the campaigns
would be able to connect better with a
local audience
i am keethana and today we shall be
talking about the top 10 artificial
intelligence technologies
natural language generation
communicating or conveying the
information efficiently and
transparently is very much crucial in
communication
to say the right words in the right
sequence to convey the message clearly
humans often find it tricky and when it
comes to machines it's trickier
natural language generation is a
sub-discipline of artificial
intelligence and is a trendy technology
that converts the structured data into a
native language
the machines are programmed in such a
way that the algorithms convert the data
into a desirable format for the users
this technology is widely used in
customer service report generation and
summarizing business intelligence
insights
some of the sample vendors are a tvo
automated insights sas cambridge
semantics digital reasoning narrative
science
etc
on the list next we have smart devices
with every passing day smart devices are
becoming more popular and more trendy
technologies that people were using once
upon a time are now remodeled and
modified as smart devices
they can be used in almost every
industry to improve efficiency and
optimize the operations
smart devices are everyday objects made
intelligent with advanced computations
which include artificial intelligence
and machine learning
they are electronic gadgets that are
able to connect share and interact with
its users and other smart devices
some of the smart devices are smart
watches smart glasses smart phones smart
speakers
etc
virtual agents
they are computer generated intelligence
that provides online customer assistance
they can effectively communicate with
humans
in most of the web and mobile
applications we see chatbots as customer
service agents who interact with us
answering our queries
in simple
virtual agents are a manifestation of a
technology which aims to create an
effective
but digital impersonation of humans
virtual agents can make reservations
book an appointment
place an order and can even avail
product information
some of the best examples of virtual
agents are google assistant and amazon
alexa and the companies that provide
virtual agents are microsoft google
amazon and assist ai
next we have speech recognition
speech recognition is yet another
sub-discipline of artificial
intelligence which is used to convert
human speech into a comprehensive and
useful format for computer applications
to process
it can be said as a bridge between
computer interactions and humans
it's presently used on interactive voice
response systems and mobile applications
some of the companies offering speech
recognition services are nuanced
communications open text nice and
variant systems
augmented reality
yet another trendy technology in the
field of artificial intelligence
augmented reality is an enhanced version
of the real physical world that is
achieved using sound digital visual
elements and other sensory stimuli
delivered via technology
augmented reality uses the existing
environment and adds information to it
to make a new artificial environment it
alters the perception of the real world
environment
augmented reality is making its way into
several retail stores that make makeup
selection and furnishing much more fun
and interactive
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
machine learning
machine learning is an application and
an important branch of artificial
intelligence which refers to machines
being able to learn by themselves
without being explicitly programmed
it enables systems to learn and improve
from experience automatically
machine learning platforms are becoming
more and more popular with the help of
algorithms
apis big data and applications and
training tools
enterprises are heavily investing in
machine learning to reap its benefits
for the various domains
machine learning is widely used for
categorization
and prediction
some of the sample vendors are amazon
fractal analytics
google
microsoft etc robotic process automation
configuring a robot to interpret
communicate and analyze data is robotic
process automation
it uses scripts and other methods to
automate the human actions which in turn
supports efficient business processes
robotic process automation is widely
used in those areas where the physical
presence of a human is dangerous
fields like warfare mining etc is where
it's currently being used
we need to remember that artificial
intelligence is not meant to replace
humans but instead it is to complement
their abilities and reinforce human
talent companies that are focusing on
robotic process automation are pika
systems automation anywhere blue prism
etc
next on the list we have decision
management
decision management is yet another
technology in artificial intelligence
that helps companies make valid
decisions by providing up-to-date and
relevant information and performing
analytic functions
artificial intelligence when combined
with decision management helps translate
customer data into predictive models of
key trends
it also helps in making quick decisions
avoidance of risks and in the automation
of the process
decision management is widely used in
the healthcare sector financial sector
insurance sector
e-commerce and many more
some of the companies that provide this
service are informatica advanced systems
concepts pica systems
mana
etc deep learning
deep learning is a branch of artificial
intelligence that mimics the workings of
the human brain in processing data
this data is used for a variety of
purposes like recognizing speech
detecting objects translating languages
and making decisions
deep learning uses hierarchical level of
artificial neural networks for carrying
out the process of machine learning
which is used across several industries
for various applications
some of the sample vendors are deep
instinct fluid ai
mathworks
saffron technology
etc
at last we have image recognition
image recognition is process of
detecting an object or feature in a
digital image or video
it can be used to analyze clients and
their opinions verify users based on
their faces detect license plates and
diagnose diseases the present-day image
recognition is comparable to human
visual perception
many social media platforms like
facebook use this technology to enhance
image search and aid visually impaired
users
clarify gums and sensetime provide this
technology
now
let's look at the different types of
artificial intelligence
so ai can be classified based on
capabilities and functionalities
under capabilities there are three types
of artificial intelligence
they are narrow ai general ai and super
ai
under functionalities we have four types
of artificial intelligence
reactive machine limited memory theory
of mind and self-awareness
let's look at them one by one
first we will look at the different
types of artificial intelligence based
on capabilities
so what is narrow ai
narrow ai also known as vki focuses on
one narrow task and cannot perform
beyond its limitations
it aims at a single subset of cognitive
abilities and advances in that spectrum
applications of narrow ai are becoming
increasingly common in our day to day
lives as machine learning and deep
learning methods continue to evolve
apple's siri is a simple example of an
arrow ai that operates with a limited
predefined range of functions
siri often has challenges with tasks
outside its range of abilities ibm
watson supercomputer is another example
of narrow ai which applies cognitive
computing machine learning and natural
language processing to process
information and answer your questions
ibm watson once outperformed human
contestant ken jenkins to become the
champion on the popular game show
jeopardy other examples of narrow ai
include google translate image
recognition software recommendation
systems spam filtering and google's page
ranking algorithm
next we have general artificial
intelligence or general ai
general ai also known as strong ai has
the ability to understand and learn any
intellectual task that a human can
general artificial intelligence has
received a one billion dollar investment
from microsoft through openai
it allows the machine to apply knowledge
and skills in different contexts
ai researchers and scientists have not
achieved strong ai so far to succeed
they would need to find a way to make
machines conscious programming a full
set of cognitive abilities
fujitsu built the k computer which is
one of the fastest computers in the
world
it is one of the most notable attempts
at achieving strong ai
it took 40 minutes to simulate a single
second of neural activity so it is
difficult to determine whether or not
strong ai will be achieved in the near
future
tan he too
is a supercomputer created by china's
national university of defense
technology
it currently holds the record for cps at
33.86 petaflops
although it sounds exciting the human
brain is estimated to be capable of one
example
now cps means characters per second that
a system can process
third in the list of ai that is based on
capabilities we have super ai
super ai exceeds human intelligence and
can't perform any tasks better than a
human
the concept of artificial super
intelligence sees ai evolve to be so
akin to human emotions and experiences
that it doesn't just understand them it
evokes emotions needs beliefs and
desires of its own its existence is
still hypothetical some of the key
characteristics of super ai include the
ability to think solve puzzles make
judgments and decisions on its own
now if you have enjoyed watching this
video so far please make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon to stay updated with all
the latest technologies also if you have
any questions related to this video
please put it in the chat section our
team of experts will help you address
your questions
moving ahead now we will see the
different types of artificial
intelligence based on functionalities
in this category first we have reactive
machine
a reactive machine is the basic form of
ai that does not store memories or use
past experiences to determine future
actions
it works only with present data they
simply perceive the world and react to
it
reactive machines are given certain
tasks and don't have capabilities beyond
those duties
ibm's deep blue which defeated just
grandmaster gary kasparov is a reactive
machine that sees the pieces on hs board
and reacts to them
it cannot refer to any of its prior
experiences and cannot improve with
practice
deep blue can identify the pieces on a
chessboard and know how each moves
it can make predictions about what moves
might be next for it and its opponent
it can choose the most optimal moves
from among the possibilities deep blue
ignores everything before the present
moment
all it does is look at the pieces on the
chessboard as it stands right now and
choose from possible next moves
up next we have limited memory
limited memory ai learns from past data
to make decisions
the memory of such systems is
short-lived
while they can use this data for a
specific period of time they cannot add
it to a library of their experiences
this kind of technology is used for
self-driving vehicles
they observe how other vehicles are
moving around them in the present and as
time passes
that ongoing collected data gets added
to the static data within the ai machine
such as lean markers and traffic lights
they are included when the vehicle
decides to change lanes to avoid cutting
of another driver or being hit by a
nearby vehicle
mitsubishi electric is a company that
has been figuring out how to improve
such technology for applications like
self-driving cars
then we have theory of mind
theory of mind represents a very
advanced class of technology and exists
as a concept
this kind of ai requires a thorough
understanding that the people and the
things within an environment can alter
feelings and behaviors
it should be able to understand people's
emotions sentiment and thoughts
even though a lot of improvements are
there in this field this kind of ai is
not complete yet
one real world example of theory of mind
ai is kismet a robot head made in the
late 90s by a massachusetts institute of
technology researcher
kismet can mimic human emotions and
recognize them
both abilities are key advancements in
theory of mind ai
but kismet can't follow gazes or convey
attention to humans
sophia
from hanson robotics is another example
where the theory of mind ai was
implemented
cameras within sofia's eyes combined
with computer algorithms allow her to
see
seek and follow faces sustain eye
contact and recognize individuals she is
able to process speech and have
conversations using natural language
subsystem
finally
we have self-awareness
self-awareness ai only exists
hypothetically
such systems understand that internal
traits states and conditions and
perceive human emotions
these machines will be smarter than the
human mind
this type of ai will not only be able to
understand and evoke emotions in those
it interacts with but also have emotions
needs and beliefs of its own
while we are probably far away from
creating machines that are self-aware we
should focus our efforts towards
understanding memory learning and the
ability to base decisions on past
experiences hello and welcome to machine
learning tutorial so why machine
learning why do we even care about
having these computers come up and be
able to do all these new things for us
well because machines can now drive your
car for you still very in the infant
stage but it's just exploding as we see
with google's waymo and then uber had
their program which unfortunately
crashed they know that this is huge this
is going to be the huge industry to
change our whole transportation
infrastructure machine learning is now
used to detect over 50 eye diseases do
you know how amazing that is to have a
computer that double checks for the
doctor for things they might miss that's
just huge in the health industry pretty
soon they actually do already have that
within some areas where maybe not for
eyes but for other diseases where
they're using the camera on your phone
to help pre-diagnose before you go in
and see the doctor and because the
machine can now unlock your phone with
your face i mean that's just cool having
it being able to identify your face or
your voice and be able to turn stuff on
and off for you depending on where
you're at and what you need talking
about an ultimate automation or world we
live in and as we dig in deeper we have
a nice example of facebook as you can
see here they have the facebook post
with halloween comment yes if you want
it order here nobody likes spam post on
facebook that annoy them into
interacting with likes shares comments
and other actions i remember the
original ones were all if you don't
click on here you will have bad luck or
some kind of fear factor well this is a
huge thing in social media when people
are getting spammed and so this tactic
known as engagement bait takes advantage
of facebook's news feed algorithm by
choosing engagement in order to get the
greater reach to eliminate engagement
bait the company reviewed and
categorized hundreds of thousands of
posts to train a machine learning model
that detects different types of
engagement bait so in this case we have
we're using facebook but this is of
course across all the different social
media they have different tools are
building and the facebook scroll gif
will be replaced kind of like a virus
coming in there and notices that there's
a certain setup with facebook and it's
able to replace it and they have like
vote baiting react baiting share baiting
they have all these different these are
kind of general titles but there
certainly are a lot of way of baiting
you to go in there and click on
something so they fed all this this data
was fed into the machine and then they
have the new post the new post comes up
that takes over part of the facebook
setup and that's what you're looking at
you're looking at this new post that's
replaced like a virus has replaced that
so what facebook do to eliminate this is
they start scanning for keywords and
phrases like this and checks the
click-through rate so it starts looking
for people who are clicking through it
without even looking at it or clicking
through it and it's not something that
normally would be clicked through once
facebook has scanned for these keywords
and phrases it is now able to identify
the spam coming in and this makes your
life easier so you're not getting
spammed it's not like walking through an
airport in a lot of countries you have
like hundreds of people trying to sell
you timeshare come join us sign up for
this eliminates that annoyingness so now
you can just enjoy your facebook and
your cat pictures or maybe it's your
family pictures mine is family certainly
people like their cat pictures too
another good example is google's
deepmind project alphago a computer
program that plays a board game go has
defeated the world's number one go
player and i hope i say his name right
kiji the ultimate go challenge game of
three of three was on may 27 2017. so
it's just last year that this happened
and what makes this so important is that
you know go is just is a game so it's
not like you're driving a car or
something in our real world but they are
using games to learn how to get the
machine learning program to learn they
want it to learn how to learn and that
is a huge step a lot of this is still in
its infant stage as far as development
as we saw what happened with the as i
referred to earlier the uber cars they
lost their whole division because they
jumped ahead too fast so still an infant
stage but boy is this like the beginning
of just an amazing world that is
automated in ways we can't even imagine
what tomorrow's going to look like we've
looked at a lot of examples of machine
learning so let's see if we can give a
little bit more of a concrete definition
what is machine learning machine
learning is the science of making
computers learn and act like humans by
feeding data and information without
being explicitly programmed we see here
we have a nice little diagram where we
have our ordinary system uh your
computer nowadays you can even run a lot
of stuff on a cell phone because cell
phones advance so much and then with
artificial intelligence and machine
learning it now takes the data and it
learns from what happened before and
then it predicts what's going to come
next and then really the biggest part
right now in machine learning that's
going on is it improves on that how do
we find a new solution so we go from
descriptive where it's learning about
stuff and understanding how it fits
together to predicting what it's going
to do to post scripting coming up with a
new solution and when we're working on
machine learning there's a number of
different diagrams that people have
posted for what steps to go through a
lot of it might be very domain specific
so if you're working on
photo identification versus language
versus medical or physics some of these
are switched around a little bit or new
things are put in they're very specific
to the domain this is kind of a very
general diagram first you want to define
your objective very important to know
what it is you're wanting to predict
then you're going to be collecting the
data so once you've defined an objective
you need to collect the data that
matches you spend a lot of time in data
science collecting data and the next
step preparing the data you've got to
make sure that your data is clean going
in there's the old saying bad data in
bad answer out or bad data out
and then once you've gone through and
we've cleaned all this stuff coming in
then you're going to select the
algorithm which algorithm are you going
to use you're going to train that
algorithm in this case i think we're
going to be working with svm the support
vector machine then you have to test the
model does this model work is this a
valid model for what we're doing and
then once you've tested it you want to
run your prediction you want to run your
prediction or your choice or whatever
output it's going to come up with and
then once everything is set and you've
done lots of testing then you want to go
ahead and deploy the model remember i
said domain specific this is very
general as far as the scope of doing
something a lot of models you get
halfway through and you realize that
your data is missing something and you
have to go collect new data because
you've run a test in here someplace
along the line you're saying hey i'm not
really getting the answers i need so
there's a lot of things that are domain
specific that become part of this model
this is a very general model but it's a
very good model to start with and we do
have some basic divisions of what
machine learning does that's important
to know for instance do you want to
predict a category well if you're
categorizing thing that's classification
for instance whether the stock price
will increase or decrease so in other
words i'm looking for a yes no answer is
it going up or is it going down and in
that case we'd actually say is it going
up true if it's not going up it's false
meaning it's going down this way it's a
yes no zero one do you want to predict a
quantity that's regression so remember
we just did classification now we're
looking at regression these are the two
major divisions and what data's doing
for instance predicting the age of a
person based on the height weight health
and other factors so based on these
different factors you might guess how
old a person is
and then there are a lot of domain
specific things like do you want to
detect an anomaly that's anomaly
detection this is actually very popular
right now for instance you want to
detect money withdrawal anomalies you
want to know when someone's making a
withdrawal that might not be their own
account we've actually brought this up
because this is really big right now if
you're predicting the stock whether to
buy stock or not you want to be able to
know if what's going on in the stock
market is an anomaly use a different
prediction model because something else
is going on you got to pull out new
information in there or is this just the
norm i'm going to get my normal return
on my money invested so being able to
detect anomalies is very big in data
science these days another question that
comes up which is on what we call
untrained data is do you want to
discover structure in unexplored data
and that's called clustering for
instance finding groups of customers
with similar behavior given a large
database of customer data containing
their demographics and past buying
records and in this case we might notice
that anybody who's wearing a certain set
of shoes go shopping at certain stores
or whatever it is they're going to make
certain purchases by having that
information it helps us to market or
group people together so that we can now
explore that group and find out what it
is we want to market to them if you're
in the marketing world and that might
also work in just about any arena you
might want to group people together
whether they're based on their different
areas and investments and financial
background whether you're going to give
them a loan or not before you even start
looking at whether they're a valid
customer for the bank you might want to
look at all these different areas and
group them together based on unknown
data so you're not you don't know what
the data is going to tell you but you
want to cluster people together that
come together
let's take a quick detour for
quiz time oh my favorite so we're going
to have a couple questions here under a
quiz time
and we'll be posting the answers in this
part two of this tutorial so let's go
ahead and take a look at these quiz
times questions and hopefully you'll get
them all right it'll get you thinking
about how to process data and what's
going on can you tell what's happening
in the following cases of course you're
sitting there with your cup of coffee
and you have your check box and your pen
trying to figure out what's your next
step in your data science analysis
so the first one is grouping documents
into different categories based on the
topic and content of each document very
big these days
you know you have legal documents you
have maybe it's the sports group
documents maybe you're analyzing
newspaper postings
but certainly having that automated is a
huge thing in today's world
b identifying handwritten digits in
images correctly
so we want to know whether uh they're
writing an a or capital a b c
what are they writing out in their hand
digit with their handwriting c behavior
of a website indicating that the site is
not working as designed d predicting
salary of an individual based on his or
her years of experience
hr hiring
set up there so stay tuned for part two
we'll go ahead and answer these
questions when we get to the part two of
this tutorial or you can just simply
write at the bottom and send a note to
simply learn and they'll follow up with
you on it
back to our regular content now these
last few bring us into the next topic
which is another way of dividing our
types of machine learning and that is
with supervised unsupervised
and reinforcement learning supervised
learning is a method used to enable
machines to classify predict objects
problems or situations based on labeled
data fed to the machine and in here you
see we have a jungle of data with
circles triangles and squares and then
we label them we have what's a circle
what's a triangle what's a square and we
have our model training and it trains it
so we know the answer very important
when you're doing supervised learning
you already know the answer to a lot of
your information coming in so you have a
huge group of data coming in and then
you have a new data coming in so we've
trained our model the model now knows
the difference between a circle a square
a triangle and now that we've trained it
we can send in in this case a square and
a circle goes in and it predicts that
the top one's a square and the next
one's a circle and you can see that this
is uh being able to predict whether
someone's going to default on a loan
because i was talking about banks
earlier supervised learning on stock
market whether you're going to make
money or not that's always important and
if you are looking to make a fortune in
the stock market keep in mind it is very
difficult to get all the data correct on
the stock market it is very it
fluctuates and weighs you really hard to
predict so it's quite a roller coaster
ride if you're running machine learning
on the stock market you start realizing
you really have to dig for new data so
we have supervised learning and if you
have supervised we should need
unsupervised learning in unsupervised
learning machine learning model finds
the hidden pattern in an unlabeled data
so in this case instead of telling it
what the circle is and what a triangle
is and what a square is it goes in there
looks at them and says for whatever
reason it groups them together maybe
they'll group it by the number of
corners and it notices that a number of
them all have three corners a number of
them all have four corners and a number
of them all have no corners and it's
able to filter those through and group
them together we talked about that
earlier with looking at a group of
people who are out shopping we want to
group them together to find out what
they have in common and of course once
you understand what people have in
common maybe you have one of them is a
customer at your store or you have five
of them our customer your store and they
have a lot in common with five others
who are not customers at your store how
do you market to those five who aren't
customers at your store yet they fit the
demographics of who's going to shop
there and you'd like them to shop at
your store not the one next door of
course this is a simplified version you
can see very easily the difference
between a triangle and a circle which
might not be so easy in marketing
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning is an important type of machine
learning where an agent learns how to
behave in an environment by performing
actions and seeing the result we have
here where the in this case a baby it's
actually great that they used an infant
for this slide because the reinforcement
learning is very much in its infant
stages but it's also probably the
biggest machine learning demand out
there right now or in the future it's
going to be coming up over the next few
years is reinforcement learning and how
to make that work for us and you can see
here where we have our action in the
action on this one it goes into the fire
hopefully the baby didn't it was just a
little candle not a giant fire pit like
it looks like here when the baby comes
out and the new state is the baby is sad
and crying because they got burned on
the fire and then maybe they take
another action the baby's called the
agent because it's the one taking the
actions and in this case they didn't go
into the fire they went a different
direction and now the baby's happy and
laughing and playing reinforcement
learning is very easy to understand
because that's how
as humans that's one of the ways we
learn we learn whether it is you bring
yourself on the stove don't do that
anymore don't touch the stove in the big
picture being able to have a machine
learning program or an ai be able to do
this is huge because now we're starting
to learn how to learn that's a big jump
in the world of computer and machine
learning and we're going to go back and
just kind of go back over supervised
versus unsupervised learning
understanding this is huge because this
is going to come up in any project
you're working on
we have in supervised learning we have
labeled data we have direct feedback so
someone's already gone in there and said
yes it's a triangle no that's not a
triangle and then you predict an outcome
so you have a nice prediction this is
this this new set of data is coming in
and we know what it's going to be and
then with unsupervised training it's not
labeled so we really don't know what it
is there's no feedback so we're not
telling it whether it's right or wrong
we're not telling it whether it's a
triangle or a square we're not telling
it to go left or right all we do is
we're finding hidden structure in the
data grouping the data together to find
out what connects to each other and then
you can use these together so imagine
you have an image and you're not sure
what you're looking for so you go in and
you have the unstructured data find all
these things that are connected together
and then somebody looks at those and
labels them now you can take that label
data and program something to predict
what's in the picture so you can see how
they go back and forth and you can start
connecting all these different tools
together to make a bigger picture there
are many interesting machine learning
algorithms let's have a look at a few of
them hopefully this gives you a little
flavor what's out there and these are
some of the most important ones that are
currently being used we'll take a look
at linear regression decision tree and
the support vector machine
let's start with a closer look at linear
regression linear regression is perhaps
one of the most well-known and
well-understood algorithms in statistics
and machine learning linear regression
is a linear model for example a model
that assumes a linear relationship
between the input variables x and the
single output variable y
and you'll see this if you remember from
your algebra classes y equals mx plus c
imagine we are predicting distance
traveled y from speed x our linear
regression model representation for this
problem would be y equals m times x plus
c or distance equals m times speed plus
c where m is the coefficient and c is
the y-intercept and we're going to look
at two different variations of this
first we're going to start with time is
constant and you can see we have a
bicyclist he's got a safety gear on
thank goodness
speed equals 10 meters per second and so
over a certain amount of time his
distance equals 36 kilometers
we have a second bicyclist who's going
twice the speed or 20 meters per second
and you can guess if he's going twice
the speed and time is a constant then
he's going to go twice the distance
and that's easy to compute 36 times 2
you get 72 kilometers and so if you had
the question of how fast would somebody
is going three times at speed or 30
meters per second is you can easily
compute the distance in our head we can
do that without needing a computer but
we want to do this for more complicated
data so it's kind of nice to compare the
two but let's just take a look at that
and what that looks like in a graph
so in a linear regression model we have
our distance to the speed and we have
our m equals the ve slope of the line
and we'll notice that the line has a
plus slope and as the speed increases
distance also increases hence the
variables have a positive relationship
and so your speed of the person which
equals y equals mx plus c distance
traveled in a fixed interval of time and
we could very easily compute either
following the line or just knowing it's
three times 10 meters per second that
this is roughly 102 kilometers distance
that this third bicep has traveled one
of the key definitions on here is
positive relationship so the slope of
the line is positive as distance
increase so does speed increase let's
take a look at our second example where
we put distance is a constant so we have
speed equals 10 meters per second they
have a certain distance to go and it
takes him 100 seconds to travel that
distance and we have our second
bicyclist who's still doing 20 meters
per second since he's going twice the
speed we can guess that he'll cover the
distance in about half the time 50
seconds and of course you could probably
guess on the third one 100 divided by 30
since he's going three times the speed
you can easily guess that this is 33.333
seconds time we put that into a linear
regression model or graph if the
distance is assumed to be constant let's
see the relationship between speed and
time and as time goes up the amount of
speed to go that same distance goes down
so now your m equals a minus ve slope of
the line as the speed increases time
decreases hence the variable has a
negative relationship again there's our
definition positive relationship and
negative relationship dependent on the
slope of the line and with a simple
formula like this
and even a significant amount of data
let's see with the mathematical
implementation of linear regression and
we'll take this data so suppose we have
this data set where we have x y x equals
1 2 3 4 5 standard series and the y
value is 3 2 2 4 3. when we take that
and we go ahead and plot these points on
a graph you can see there's kind of a
nice scattering and you could probably
eyeball a line through the middle of it
but we're going to calculate that exact
line for linear regression and the first
thing we do is we come up here we have
the mean of x i and remember mean is
basically the average so we added five
plus four plus three plus two plus one
and divide by five and that simply comes
out as three and then we'll do the same
for y we'll go ahead and add up all
those numbers and divide by five and we
end up with the mean value of y of i
equals 2.8 where the x i references it's
an average or means value and the y i
also equals a means value of y and when
we plot that you'll see that we can put
in the y equals 2.8 and the x equals 3
in there on our graph we kind of give it
a little different color so you could
sort it out with the dashed lines on it
and it's important to note that when we
do the linear regression the linear
regression model should go through that
dot now let's find our regression
equation to find the best fit line
remember we go ahead and take our y
equals mx plus c so we're looking for m
and c so to find this equation for our
data we need to find our slope of m and
our coefficient of c and we have y
equals mx plus c where m equals the sum
of x minus x average times y minus y
average or y means and x means over the
sum of x minus x means squared that's
how we get the slope of the value of the
line and we can easily do that by
creating some columns here we have x y
computers are really good about
iterating through data and so we can
easily compute this and fill in a graph
of data and in our graph you can easily
see that if we have our x value of 1 and
if you remember the x i or the means
value is 3 1 minus 3 equals a negative 2
and 2 minus 3 equals a negative 1 so on
and so forth and we can easily fill in
the column of x minus x i y minus y i
and then from those we can compute x
minus x i squared and x minus x i times
y minus y i and you can guess it that
the next step is to go ahead and sum the
different columns for the answers we
need so we get a total of 10 for our x
minus x i squared and a total of 2 for x
minus x i times y minus y i and we plug
those in we get 2 10 which equals 0.2 so
now we know the slope of our line equals
0.2 so we can calculate the value of c
that'd be the next step is we need to
know where it crosses the y axis and if
you remember i mentioned earlier that
the linear regression line has to pass
through the means value the one that we
showed earlier we can just flip back up
there to that graph and you can see
right here there's our means value which
is 3
x equals 3 and y equals 2.8 and since we
know that value we can simply plug that
into our formula y equals 0.2 x plus c
so we plug that in we get 2.8 equals 0.2
times 3 plus c and you can just solve
for c so now we know that our
coefficient equals 2.2 and once we have
all that we can go ahead and plot our
regression line y equals 0.2 times x
plus 2.2 and then from this equation we
can compute new values so let's predict
the values of y using x equals 1 2 3 4 5
and plot the points remember the 1 2 3 4
5 was our original x values so now we're
going to see what y thinks they are not
what they actually are and we plug those
in we get y of designated with y of p
you can see that x equals 1 equals 2.4 x
equals 2 equals 2.6 and so on and so on
so we have our y predicted values of
what we think is going to be when you
plug those numbers in and when we plot
the predicted values along with the
axial values we can see the difference
and this is one of the things that's
very important with linear regression in
any of these models is to understand the
error and so we can calculate the error
on all of our different values and you
can see over here we plotted x and y and
y predict and we draw a little line so
you can sort of see what the error looks
like there between the different points
so our goal is to reduce this error we
want to minimize that error value on our
linear regression model minimizing the
distance there are lots of ways to
minimize the distance between the line
and the data points like sum of squared
errors sum of absolute errors root mean
square error etc we keep moving this
line through the data points to make
sure the best fit line has the least
square distance between the data points
and the regression line so to recap with
a very simple linear regression model we
first figure out the formula of our line
through the middle and then we slowly
adjust the line to minimize the error
keep in mind this is a very simple
formula the math gets even though the
math is very much the same it gets much
more complex as we add in different
dimensions so this is only two
dimensions y equals mx plus c but you
can take that out to x
z i j q all the different features in
there and they can plot a linear
regression model on all of those using
the different formulas to minimize the
error let's go ahead and take a look at
decision trees a very different way to
solve problems in the linear regression
model decision tree is a tree-shaped
algorithm used to determine a course of
action each branch of a tree represents
a possible decision occurrence or
reaction we have data which tells us if
it is a good day to play golf and if we
were to open this data up in a general
spreadsheet you can see we have the
outlook whether it's a rainy overcast
sunny temperature
hot mild cool humidity windy and did i
like to play golf that day yes or no so
we're taking a census and certainly i
wouldn't want a computer telling me when
i should go play golf or not but you can
imagine if you got up in the night
before you're trying to plan your day
and it comes up and says tomorrow would
be a good day for golf for you in the
morning and not a good day in the
afternoon or something like that this
becomes very beneficial and we see this
in a lot of applications coming out now
where it gives you suggestions and lets
you know what would be fit the match for
you for the next day or the next
purchase or the next uh whatever you
know next meal out in this case is
tomorrow a good day for playing golf
based on the weather coming in and so we
come up and let's uh determine if you
should play golf when the day is sunny
and windy so we found out the forecast
tomorrow is going to be sunny and windy
and suppose we draw our tree like this
we're going to have our humidity and
then we have our normal which is if it's
if you have a normal humidity you're
going to go play golf and if the
humidity is really high then we look at
the outlook and if the outlook is sunny
overcast or rainy it's going to change
what you choose to do so if you know
that it's a very high humidity and it's
sunny you're probably not going to play
golf because you're going to be out
there miserable fighting off the
mosquitoes that are out joining you to
play golf with you maybe if it's raining
you probably don't want to play in the
rain but if it's slightly overcast you
get just the right
shadow that's a good day to play golf
and be outside out on the green now in
this example you can probably make your
own creep pretty easily because it's a
very simple set of data going in but the
question is how do you know what to
split where do you split your data what
if this is much more complicated data
where it's not something that you would
particularly understand like studying
cancer they take about 36 measurements
of the cancerous cells and then each one
of those measurements represents how
bulbous it is how extended it is how
sharp the edges are something that as a
human we would have no understanding of
so how do we decide how to split that
data up and is that the right decision
tree but since the question is going to
come up is this the right decision tree
for that we should calculate entropy and
information gain two important
vocabulary words there are the entropy
and the information gain entropy entropy
is a measure of randomness or impurity
in the data set entropy should be low so
we want the chaos to be as low as
possible we don't want to look at it and
be confused by the images or what's
going on there with mixed data and the
information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split also known as entropy reduction
information gain should be high so we
want our information that we get out of
the split to be as high as possible
let's take a look at entropy from the
mathematical side in this case we're
going to denote entropy as i of p of n n
where p
is the probability that you're going to
play a game of golf and n is the
probability where you're not going to
play the game of golf now you don't
really have to memorize these formulas
there's a few of them out there
depending on what you're working with
but it's important to note that this is
where this formula is coming from so
when you see it you're not lost when
you're running your programming unless
you're building your own decision tree
code in the back and we simply have a
log squared of p over p plus n minus n
over p plus n times the log squared of n
of p plus n but let's break that down
and see what actually looks like when
we're computing that from the computer
script side entropy of a target class of
the data set is the whole entropy so we
have entropy play golf and we look at
this if we go back to the data you can
simply count how many yeses and no in
our complete data set for playing golf
days in our complete set we find we have
five days we did play golf and nine days
we did not play golf and so our i equals
if you add those together 9 plus 5 is
14. and so our i equals 5 over 14 and 9
over 14. that's our p and n values that
we plug into that formula and you can go
5 over 14 equals 0.36 9 over 14 equals
0.64 and when you do the whole equation
you get the minus 0.36 log root squared
of 0.36 minus 0.64 log squared root of
0.64 and we get a set value we get
0.94 so we now have a full entropy value
for the whole set of data that we're
working with and we want to make that
entropy go down and just like we
calculated the entropy out for the whole
set we can also calculate entropy for
playing golf and the outlook is it going
to be overcast or rainy or sunny and so
we look at the entropy we have p of
sunny times e of 3 of 2 and that just
comes out how many sunny days yes and
how many sunny days no over the total
which is five don't forget to put the
we'll divide that five out later on
equals p overcast equals four comma zero
plus rainy equals two comma three and
then when you do the whole setup we have
5 over 14. remember i said there was a
total of 5. 5 over 14 times the i of 3
of 2 plus 4 over 14 times the 4 comma 0
and 5 14 over i of 2 3. and so we can
now compute the entropy of just the part
that has to do with the forecast and we
get 0.693 similarly we can calculate the
entropy of other predictors like
temperature humidity and wind and so we
look at the gain outlook how much are we
going to gain from this entropy play
golf minus entropy play golf outlook and
we can take the original 0.94 for the
whole set minus the entropy of just the
rainy day and temperature and we end up
with a gain of 0.247
so this is our information gain remember
we define entropy and we define an
information gain the higher the
information gain the lower the entropy
the better the information gain of the
other three attributes can be calculated
in the same way so we have our gain for
temperature equals 0.029
we have our gain for humidity equals
0.152 and our gain for a windy day
equals 0.048 and if you do a quick
comparison you'll see the 0.247
is the greatest gain of information so
that's the split we want
now let's build the decision tree so we
have the outlook is it going to be sunny
overcast or rainy that's our first split
because that gives us the most
information gain and we can continue to
go down the tree using the different
information gains with the largest
information we can continue down the
nodes of the tree where we choose the
attribute with the largest information
gain as the root node and then continue
to split each sub node with the largest
information gain that we can compute and
although it's a little bit of a tongue
twister to say all that you can see
that's a very easy to view visual model
we have our outlook we split it three
different directions if the outlook is
overcast we're going to play and then we
can split those further down if we want
so if the outlook is sunny but then it's
also windy if it's windy we're not going
to play if it's not windy we'll play so
we can easily build a nice decision tree
to guess what we would like to do
tomorrow and give us a nice
recommendation for the day so we want to
know if it's a good day to play golf
when it's sunny and windy remember the
original question that came out
tomorrow's weather report is sunny and
windy you can see by going down the tree
we go outlook sunny outlook windy we're
not going to play golf tomorrow so our
little smart watch pops up and says i'm
sorry tomorrow is not a good day for
golf it's going to be sunny and windy
and if you're a huge golf fan you might
go uh oh
it's not a good day to play golf we can
go in and watch a golf game at home so
we'll sit in front of the tv instead of
being out playing golf in the wind
multiple linear regression let's take a
brief look at what happens when you have
multiple inputs so in multiple linear
regression we have well we'll start with
the simple linear regression where we
had y equals m plus x plus c and we're
trying to find the value of y now with
multiple linear regression we have
multiple variables coming in so instead
of having just x we have x1 x2 x3 and
instead of having just one slope each
variable has its own slope attached to
it as you can see here we have m1 m2 m3
and we still just have the single
coefficient so when you're dealing with
multiple linear regression you basically
take your single linear regression and
you spread it out so you have y equals
m1 times x1 plus m2 times x2
so on all the way to m to the nth x to
the nth and then you add your
coefficient on there implementation of
linear regression now we get into my
favorite part let's understand how
multiple linear regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before we were looking at a
company and just based on its r d trying
to figure out its profit we're going to
start looking at the expenditure of the
company we're going to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r d
we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs marketing
costs and so on and from there we're
going to see if we can figure out what
the profit of that company is going to
be to start our coding we're going to
begin by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression we're going to take a look at
the data to see what we're playing with
then we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model and
then from there we'll go ahead and solve
it and just see how valid our solution
is so let's start with importing the
basic libraries now i'm going to be
doing this in anaconda jupiter notebook
a very popular ide i enjoy it it's such
a visual to look at and so easy to use
just any id for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python ide so here we are in our jupiter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries we're
importing first we're going to import
numpy as np and then i want you to skip
one line and look at import pandas as pd
these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as np and you have to
almost have that for your sk learn
toolbox you always import that right off
the beginning pandas although you don't
have to have it for your sklearn
libraries it does such a wonderful job
of importing data setting it up into a
data frame so we can manipulate it
rather easily and it has a lot of tools
also in addition to that so we usually
like to use the pandas when we can and
i'll show you what that looks like the
other three lines are for us to get a
visual of this data and take a look at
it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as plt and then
seaborn as sns seaborn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then seaborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the seaborne is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the amber scion map plot library
inline that is only because i'm doing an
inline ide my interface in the anaconda
jupiter notebook
requires i put that in there or you're
not going to see the graph when it comes
up let's go ahead and run this it's not
going to be that interesting so we're
just setting up variables in fact it's
not going to do anything that we can see
but it is importing these different
libraries and setup the next step is
load the data set and extract
independent and dependent variables now
here in the slide you'll see companies
equals pd.read csv and it has a long
line there with the file at the end 1000
companies.csv you're going to have to
change this to fit whatever setup you
have
and the file itself you can request just
go down to the commentary below this
video and put a note in there and simply
learn we'll try to get in contact with
you and supply you with that file so you
can try this coding yourself so we're
going to add this code in here and we're
going to see that i have companies
equals pd.reader underscore csv and i've
changed this path to match my computer c
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies dot csv and then
below there we're going to set the x
equals to companies under the eye
location and because this is companies
as a pd data set i can use this nice
notation that says take every row that's
what the colon the first colon is comma
except for the last column that's what
the second part is where we have a colon
minus one and we want the values set
into there so x is no longer a data set
a pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
i'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the panda sees it when i
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what pandas one of
the things pandas is really good about
is it looks just like an excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns r and d
spend administration marketing spend
state profit it even notes that the top
are column names it was never told that
but pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a csv so you can
actually see the raw data so here i've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have rnd spend
comma administration comma marketing
spin comma state comma profit carriage
return i don't know about you but i go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where i can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and investments and you understand what
uh 165 349 dollars and 20 cents compared
to the administration cost of a hundred
and thirty six thousand eight hundred
ninety seven dollars and eighty cents so
on so on helps to create the profit of
192 261 and 83 cents that makes no sense
to me whatsoever no pun intended so
let's flip back here and take a look at
our next set of code where we're going
to graph it so we can get a better
understanding of our data and what it
means so at this point we're going to
use a single line of code to get a lot
of information so we can see where we're
going with this let's go ahead and paste
that into our notebook and see what we
got going and so we have the
visualization and again we're using sns
which is pandas as you can see we
imported the map plot library dot pi
plot as plt which then the seaborn uses
and we imported the seaborn as sns and
then that final line of code helps us
show this in our
inline coding without this it wouldn't
display and you could display it to a
file in other means and that's the
matplot library in line with the amber
sign at the beginning so here we come
down to the single line of code seaborn
is great because it actually recognizes
the panda data frame so i can just take
the companies dot core for coordinates
and i can put that right into the
seaborn and when we run this we get this
beautiful plot and let's just take a
look at what this plot means if you look
at this plot on mine the colors are
probably a little bit more purplish and
blue than the original one we have the
columns and the rows we have r and d
spending we have administration we have
marketing spending and profit and if you
cross index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r and d spending is
going to be the same as r and d spending
and the same thing with administration
costs so right down the middle you get
this dark row or dark um diagonal row
that shows that this is the highest
corresponding data that's exactly the
same and as it becomes lighter there's
less connections between the data so we
can see with profit obviously profit is
the same as profit and next it has a
very high correlation with r d spending
which we looked at earlier and it has a
slightly less connection to marketing
spending and even less to how much money
we put into the administration so now
that we have a nice look at the data
let's go ahead and dig in and create
some actual useful linear regression
models so that we can predict values and
have a better profit now that we've
taken a look at the visualization of
this data we're going to move on to the
next step instead of just having a
pretty picture we need to generate some
hard data some hard values so let's see
what that looks like we're going to set
up our linear regression model in two
steps the first one is we need to
prepare some of our data so it fits
correctly and let's go ahead and paste
this code into our jupyter notebook and
what we're bringing in is we're going to
bring in the sklearn pre-processing
where we're going to import the label
encoder and the one hot encoder to use
the label encoder we're going to create
a variable called label encoder and set
it equal to capital l label capital e
encoder this creates a class that we can
reuse for transferring the labels back
and forth now about now you should ask
what labels are we talking about let's
go take a look at the data we processed
before and see what i'm talking about
here if you remember when we did the
companies dot head and we printed the
top five rows of data we have our
columns going across we have column zero
which is r and d spending column one
which is administration column two which
is marketing spending and column three
is state
and you'll see under state we have new
york california florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process new york it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that new york california and
florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the x also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a
new york it has a zero or a one or a two
and then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals one hot inc or
categorical features equals three and
then we take the x and we go ahead and
do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation preps our data force so
it's completely set the way we need it
is just a row of numbers even though
it's not in here let's go ahead and
print x and just take a look what this
data is doing you'll see you have an
array of arrays and then each array is a
row of numbers and if i go ahead and
just do row 0 you'll see i have a nice
organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why because the computer
has automatically transformed our header
into the setup and it's automatically
transformed all these different
variables so when we did the encoder the
encoder created two columns and what we
need to do is just have the one because
it has both the variable and the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x equals x colon comma one
colon all this is doing is removing that
one extra column we put in there when we
did our one hot encoder and our label
encoding let's go ahead and run that and
now we get to create our linear
regression model and let's see what that
looks like here and we're going to do
that in two steps the first step is
going to be in splitting the data now
whenever we create a predictive model of
data we always want to split it up so we
have a training set and we have a
testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and i'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sklearn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test
that is the standard way that they
usually reference these when we're doing
different uh models you usually see that
a capital x and you see the train and
the test and the lowercase y what this
is is x is our data going in that's our
rnd span our administration our
marketing and then why which we're
training is the answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity so that's what we're
going to shoot for in this tutorial the
next part train test split we take x and
we take y we've already created those x
has the columns with the data in it and
y has a column with profit in it and
then we're going to set the test size
equals point two that basically means
twenty percent
so twenty percent of the rows are going
to be tested we're gonna put them off to
the side so since we're using a thousand
lines of data that means that 200 of
those lines we're going to hold off to
the side to test for later and then the
random state equals zero we're going to
randomize which ones it picks to hold
off to the side we'll go ahead and run
this it's not overly exciting because
setting up our variables but the next
step is the next step we actually create
our linear regression model now that we
got to the linear regression model we
get that next piece of the puzzle let's
go ahead and put that code in there and
walk through it so here we go we're
going to paste it in there and let's go
ahead and since this is a shorter line
of code let's zoom up there so we can
get a good look and we have from the
sklearn dot linear underscore model
we're going to import linear regression
now i don't know if you recall from
earlier when we were doing all the math
let's go ahead and flip back there and
take a look at that do you remember this
where we had this long formula on the
bottom and we were doing all this
summarization and then we also looked at
uh setting it up with the different
lines and then we also looked all the
way down to multiple linear regression
where we're adding all those formulas
together all of that is wrapped up in
this one section so what's going on here
is i'm going to create a variable called
regressor and the regressor equals the
linear regression that's a linear
regression model that has all that math
built in so we don't have to have it all
memorized or have to compute it
individually and then we do the
regressor dot fit in this case we do x
train and y train because we're using
the training data x being the data in
and y being profit what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line we've
created the whole linear regression
model and we fit the data to the linear
regression model and you can see that
when i run the regressor it gives an
output linear regression it says copy x
equals true fit intercept equals true in
jobs equal one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model now that we've created
our linear regression model let's go
ahead and use it and if you remember we
kept a bunch of data aside so we're
going to do a y predict variable and
we're going to put in the x test and
let's see what that looks like scroll up
a little bit paste that in here
predicting the test set results so here
we have y predict
equals regressor dot predict x test
going in and this gives us y predict now
because i'm in jupiter inline i can just
put the variable up there and when i hit
the run button it'll print that array
out i could have just as easily done
print
why predict so if you're in a different
ide that's not an inline setup like the
jupiter notebook you can do it this way
print y predict and you'll see that for
the 200 different test variables we kept
off to the side is going to produce 200
answers this is what it says the profit
are for those 200 predictions but let's
don't stop there let's keep going and
take a couple look we're going to take
just a short detail here and calculating
the coefficients and the intercepts this
gives us a quick flash at what's going
on behind the line we're going to take a
short detour here and we're going to be
calculating the coefficient and
intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice about our
regressor we created is it already has a
coefficients for us we can simply just
print regressor dot coefficient
underscore when i run this you'll see
our coefficients here and if we can do
the regressor coefficient we can also do
the regressor intercept and let's run
that and take a look at that this all
came from the multiple regression model
and we'll flip over so you can remember
where this is going into where it's
coming from you can see the formula down
here where y equals m1 times x1 plus m2
times x2 and so on and so on plus c the
coefficient so these variables fit right
into this formula y equals slope 1 times
column 1 variable plus slope 2 times
column 2 variable all the way to the m
and to the n and x to the n plus c the
coefficient or in this case you have
minus 8.89
to the power of 2 etc etc times the
first column and the second column and
the third column and then our intercept
is the minus one zero three zero zero
nine point boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it this is
why we don't do this by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations easy to understand
and calculate now i told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script as you remember
from the beginning i said if we're going
to divide this information we have to
make sure it's a valid model that this
model works and understand how good it
works so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use to
predict
how good our prediction is and let's
take a look what that looks like in code
and so we're going to use this from
sklearn.metrics we're going to import r2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the r2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us so we know are true the y predict
of those 200 values is what we think it
was true and when we go ahead and run
this we see we get a 0.9352
that's the r2 score now it's not exactly
a straight percentage so it's not saying
it's 93 percent correct but you do want
that in the upper 90s o and higher shows
that this is a very valid prediction
based on the r2 score and if r squared
value of 0.91 or 9 2 as we got on our
model remember it does have a random
generation involved this proves the
model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression use case loan
repayment prediction let's get into my
favorite part and open up some python
and see what the programming code in the
scripting looks like in here we're going
to want to do a prediction and we start
with this individual here who's
requesting to find out how good his
customers are going to be whether
they're going to repay their loan or not
for his bank and from that we want to
generate a problem statement to predict
if a customer will repay loan amount or
not and then we're going to be using the
decision tree algorithm in python let's
see what that looks like and let's dive
into the code in our first few steps of
implementation we're going to start by
importing the necessary packages that we
need from python and we're going to load
up our data and take a look at what the
data looks like so the first thing i
need is i need something to edit my
python and run it in so let's flip on
over and here i'm using the anaconda
jupiter notebook now you can use any
python ide you like to run it in but i
find the jupiter notebook is really nice
for doing things on the fly and let's go
ahead and just paste that code in the
beginning and before we start let's talk
a little bit about what we're bringing
in and then we're going to do a couple
things in here we have to make a couple
changes as we go through this first part
of the import the first thing we bring
in is numpy as np that's very standard
when we're dealing with mathematics
especially with uh very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as pd
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to
taking your basic data and storing it in
a way that looks like an excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see np or pd those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and i'll show you a little
bit more we explore the data in just a
minute then we're going to need to split
the data so i'm going to bring in our
train test and split and this is coming
from the sk learn package cross
validation in just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the sk.tree
import decision tree classifier that's
the actual tool we're using remember i
told you don't be afraid of the
mathematics it's going to be done for
you well the decision tree classifier
has all that mathematics in there for
you so you don't have to figure it back
out again and then we have
sklearn.metrics
for accuracy score we need to score our
setup that's the whole reason we're
splitting it between the training and
testing data and finally we still need
the sklearn import tree and that's just
the basic tree function is needed for
the decision tree classifier and finally
we're going to load our data down here
and i'm going to run this and we're
going to get two things on here one
we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says i need to read a file and when this
was written
the person who wrote it this is their
path where they stored the file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full file
name and you'll see it's on my c drive
and this is very lengthy setup on here
where i stored the
data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer will be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated by
simply learn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below
and request it here in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding
understanding these different warnings
and these different errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation is depreciated so it's
a warning on it's being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have sklearn dot
cross validation and if you research
this and go to the sklearn site you'll
find out that you can actually just swap
it right in there with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning
what they've done is they've had two
different developers develop it in two
different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore2.csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet
this is what it looks like as a basic
text file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
uh in an actual spreadsheet so you can
see what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score
house number
if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then one thousand lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data i usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so i can see what i'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it would just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple lin
function from python
and when i run this
you'll see that it's a thousand long and
that's what we expected there's a
thousand lines of data in there if you
subtract the column head
this is one of the nice things when we
did the uh balance data from the panda
read csv
you'll see that the header is row zero
so it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscored data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas
module for head another beautiful thing
in the data set that we can utilize so
let's put that on our sheet here and we
have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
a print job here of dataset just a
simple print statement
and we run that
let's just take a closer look at that
let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas does such a wonderful job of
making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as a
head
it prints the first five lines of the
data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you want to start
with the zero position and that is what
the data head does it pulls the first
five rows of data puts in a nice format
that you can look at and view very
powerful tool to view the data so
instead of having to flip and open up an
excel spreadsheet or open office cal or
trying to look at a word doc where it's
all scrunched together and hard to read
you can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
data head you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to
train and build our data tree and to do
that we need to first
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
side to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data
and y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at a source and
target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines
in the database so it's all the data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns one through five
remember we always start with zero zero
is a yes or no and that's whether the
loan went default or not so we want to
start with 1. if we go back up here
that's the initial payment and it goes
all the way through the house number
well if we want to look at 1 through 5
we can do the same thing for y which is
the answers
and we're going to set that just equal
to the zero row so it's just the zero
row and then it's all rows going in
there so now we've divided this into two
different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data
and we have to know in the end what the
y was supposed to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the x train and since we know the
answers for x-trade or the y-train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case we set the
clf entropy called decision tree
classifier it automatically prints out
what's in that decision tree there's a
lot of variables you can play within
here and it's quite beyond the scope of
this
tutorial to go through all of these and
how they work but we're working on
entropy that's one of the options we've
added that it's completely a random
state of 100 so 100 percent and we have
a max depth of three now the max depth
if you remember above when we were doing
the different graphs of animals means
it's only going to go down three layers
before it stops and then we have minimal
samples of leaves as five so it's going
to have at least five leaves at the end
so i'll have at least three splits i'll
have no more than three layers and at
least five end leaves with the final
result at the bottom now that we've
created
our decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it let's go ahead
and apply it and see what that looks
like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our
variable clf entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the sk learn modules
that their different tools have the
predict when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here now if you delivered
this for use in actual commercial use
and distributed it this would be the new
loans you're putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not
in this case though we need to test out
the data and just see how good our
sample is how good of our tree does at
predicting the loan payments and finally
since anaconda jupiter notebook is it
works as a command line for python we
can simply put the y predict e in to
print it i could just as easily have put
the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out we'll go ahead and do that
it doesn't matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrics
import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage
and let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.6667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
the decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit's going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not let's start with
clustering
suppose we have a pile of books of
different genres now we divide them into
different groups like fiction horror
education and as we can see from this
young lady she definitely is into heavy
horror you just tell by those eyes and
the maple canadian leaf on her shirt but
we have fiction horror and education and
we want to go ahead and divide our books
up well organizing objects into groups
based on similarity is clustering and in
this case as we're looking at the books
we're talking about clustering things
with known categories but you can also
use it to explore data so you might not
know the categories you just know that
you need to divide it up in some way to
conquer the data and to organize it
better but in this case we're going to
be looking at clustering in specific
categories and let's just take a deeper
look at that we're going to use k means
clustering k means clustering is
probably the most commonly used
clustering tool in the machine learning
library k-means clustering is an example
of unsupervised learning if you remember
from our previous thing it is used when
you have unlabeled data so we don't know
the answer yet we have a bunch of data
that we want to cluster to different
groups define clusters in the data based
on feature similarity so we've
introduced a couple terms here we've
already talked about unsupervised
learning and unlabeled data so we don't
know the answer yet we're just going to
group stuff together and see if we can
find an answer of how things connect
we've also introduced feature similarity
features being different features of the
data now with books we can easily see
fiction and
horror and history books but a lot of
times with data some of that information
isn't so easy to see right when we first
look at it and so k-means is one of
those tools where we can start finding
things that connect that match with each
other suppose we have these data points
and want to assign them into a cluster
now when i look at these data points i
would probably group them into two
clusters just by looking at them i'd say
two of these group of data kind of come
together but in k means we pick k
clusters and assign random centroids to
clusters where the k clusters represents
two different clusters we pick k
clusters and cirando centroids to the
clusters then we compute distance from
objects to the centroids now we form new
clusters based on minimum distances
and calculate the centroids so we figure
out what the best distance is for the
centroid then we move the centroid and
recalculate those distances repeat
previous two steps iteratively till the
cluster centroid stop changing their
positions and become static
repeat previous two steps iteratively
till the cluster centroid stopped
changing and the positions become static
once the clusters become static then
k-means clustering algorithm is said to
be converged and there's another term we
see throughout machine learning is
converged that means whatever math we're
using to figure out the answer has come
to a solution or it's converged on an
answer should we see the flowchart to
understand make a little bit more sense
by putting it into a nice easy step by
step so we start we choose k we'll look
at the elbow method in just a moment we
assign random centroids to clusters and
sometimes you pick the centroids because
you might look at the data in a graph
and say ah these are probably the
central points then we compute the
distance from the objects to the
centroids
we take that and we form new clusters
based on minimum distance and calculate
their centroids then we compute the
distance from objects to the new
centroids and then we go back and repeat
those last two steps we calculate the
distances so as we're doing it brings
into the new centroid and then we move
the centroid around and we figure out
what the best which objects are closest
to each centroid so the objects can
switch from one centroid to the other
the centroids are moved around and we
continue that until it is converged
let's see an example of this
suppose we have this data set of seven
individuals and their score on two
topics a and b so here's our subject
in this case referring to the person
taking the test and then we have subject
a where we see what they've scored on
their first subject and we have subject
b and we can see what they score on the
second subject now let's take two
farthest apart points as initial cluster
centroids remember we talked about
selecting them randomly or we can also
just put them in different points and
pick the furthest one apart so they move
together either one works okay depending
on what kind of data you're working on
and what you know about it so we took
the two furthest points one and one and
five and seven and now let's take the
two farthest apart points as initial
cluster centroids each point is then
assigned to the closest cluster with
respect to the distance from the
centroids so we take each one of these
points in there we measure that distance
and you can see that if we measure each
of those distances and you use it the
pythagorean theorem for a triangle in
this case because you know the x and the
y and you can figure out the diagonal
line from that or you just take a ruler
and put it on your monitor that'd be
kind of silly but it would work if
you're just eyeballing it you can see
how they naturally come together in
certain areas now we again calculate the
centroids of each cluster so cluster one
and then cluster two and we look at each
individual dot there's one two three
we're in one cluster uh the centroid
then moves over it becomes one point
eight comma two point three so remember
was that one and one well the very
center of the data we're looking at
would put it at the one point roughly 2
2 but 1.8 and 2.3 and the second one if
we wanted to make the overall mean
vector the average vector of all the
different distances to that centroid we
come up with four comma one and five
four so we've now moved the centroids we
compare each individual's distance to
its own cluster mean and to that of the
opposite cluster and we find we can
build a nice chart on here that the as
we move that centroid around
we now have a new different kind of
clustering of groups and using euclidean
distance between the points and the mean
we get the same formula you see new
formulas coming up so we have our
individual dots distance to the mean
centroid of the cluster and distance to
the mean centroid of the cluster
only individual 3 is nearer to the mean
of the opposite cluster cluster 2 than
its own cluster 1. and you can see here
in the diagram where we've kind of
circled that one in the middle so when
we've moved the cluster the centroids of
the clusters over one of the points
shifted to the other cluster because
it's closer to that group of individuals
thus individual 3 is relocated to
cluster 2 resulting in a new partition
and we regenerate all those numbers of
how close they are to the different
clusters
for the new clusters we will find the
actual cluster centroids so now we move
the centroids over and you can see that
we've now formed two very distinct
clusters on here on comparing the
distance of each individual's distance
to its own cluster mean and to that of
the opposite cluster we find that the
data points are stable hence we have our
final clusters now if you remember i
brought up a concept earlier caming on
the k-means algorithm choosing the right
value of k will help in less number of
iterations and to find the appropriate
number of clusters in a data set we use
the elbow method and within sum of
squares wss is defined as the sum of the
squared distance between each member of
the cluster in its centroid and so you
see we've done here is we have the
number of clusters and as you do
the same k-means algorithm over the
different clusters and you calculate
what that centroid looks like and you
find the optimal you can actually find
the optimal number of clusters using the
elbow of the graph is called as the
elbow method and on this we guessed it
two just by looking at the data but as
you can see
the slope you actually just look for
right there where the elbow is in the
slope and you have a clear answer that
we want two different to start with
k-means equals two a lot of times people
end up computing k-means equals two
three four five until they find the
value which fits on the elbow joint
sometimes you can just look at the data
and if you're really good with that
specific domain remember domain i
mentioned that last time you'll know
that where to pick those numbers or
where to start guessing at what that k
value is
so let's take this when we're going to
use a use case using k-means clustering
to cluster cars into brands using
parameters such as horsepower cubic
inches make year etc so we're going to
use the dataset cars data having
information about three brands of cars
toyota honda and nissan we'll go back to
my favorite tool the anaconda navigator
with the jupiter notebook and let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupiter
notebook and in our jupiter notebook i'm
going to go ahead and just paste the
basic
code that we usually started a lot of
these off with we're not going to go too
much into this code because we've
already discussed numpy we've already
discussed matplot library and pandas
that'll be being the number array pandas
being the pandas data frame and map plot
for the graphing and don't forget uh
since if you're using the jupiter
notebook you do need the matplot library
inline so that it plots everything on
the screen if you're using a different
python editor then you probably don't
need that because it'll have a pop-up
window on your computer we'll go ahead
and run this just to load our libraries
and our setup into here the next step is
of course to look at our data which i've
already opened up in a spreadsheet and
you can see here we have the miles per
gallon cylinders cubic inches horsepower
weight pounds how you know how heavy it
is time it takes to get to 60
my card is probably on this one at about
80 or 90. what year it is so this is you
can actually see this is kind of older
cars and then the brand toyota honda
nissan so the different cars are coming
from all the way from 1971 if we scroll
down
to uh the 80s we have between the 70s
and 80s the number of cars that they've
put out and let's uh when we come back
here we're going to importing the data
so we'll go ahead and do data set
equals and we'll use pandas to read this
in and it's a from a csv file remember
you can always post this in the comments
and request the data files for these
either in the comments here on the
youtube video or go to simplylearn.com
and request that the car csv i put it in
the same folder as the code that i've
stored so my python code is stored in
the same folder so i don't have to put
the full path if you store them in
different folders you do have to change
this and double check your name
variables and we'll go ahead and run
this and we've chosen data set
arbitrarily because it's a data set
we're importing and we've now imported
our car csv into the data set
as you know you have to prep the data so
we're going to create the x data this is
the one that we're going to try to
figure out what's going on with and then
there's a number of ways to do this but
we'll do it in a simple loop so you can
actually see what's going on so we'll do
four i
and x dot columns so we're going to go
through each of the columns
and a lot of times it's important i'll
make lists of the columns and do this
because i might remove certain columns
or there might be columns that i want to
be processed differently but for this we
can go ahead and take x of i
and we want to go fill in a and that's a
pandas command but the question is what
are we going to fill the missing data
with we definitely don't want to just
put in a number that doesn't actually
mean something and so one of the tricks
you can do with this
is we can take x of i
and in addition to that we want to go
ahead and turn this into
an integer because a lot of these are
integers so we'll go ahead and keep it
integers and let me add the bracket here
and a lot of editors will do this
they'll think that you're closing one
bracket make sure you get that second
bracket in there if it's a double
bracket that's always something that
happens regularly so once we have our
integer of x of y this is going to fill
in any missing data with the average
and i was so busy closing one set of
brackets i forgot that the mean is also
has brackets in there for the pandas so
we can see here we're going to fill in
all the data with the average value for
that column so if there's missing data
it's in the average of the data it does
have
then once we've done that we'll go ahead
and loop through it again
and just check and see to make sure
everything is filled in correctly and
we'll print and then we take x
is null and this returns a set of the
null value or the how many lines are
null and we'll just sum that up to see
what that looks like and so when i run
this
and so with the x what we want to do is
we want to remove the last column
because that had the models that's what
we're trying to see if we can cluster
these things and figure out the models
there is so many different ways to sort
the x out for one we could take the x
and we could go data set our variable
we're using and use the i location one
of the features that's in pandas
and we could take that and then take all
the rows
and all but the last column of the data
set
and at this time we could do values we
just convert it to values so that's one
way to do this and if i let me just put
this down here and print
x
it's a capital x we chose and i run this
you can see it's just the values we
could also take out the values and
it's not going to return anything
because there's no values connected to
it what i like to do with this
is instead of doing the eye location
which does integers more common is to
come in here and we have our data set
and we're going to do data set
dot or data set dot columns and remember
that lists all the columns so if i come
in here
let me just mark that as red and i print
data set dot columns
you can see that i have my index here i
have my mpg cylinders everything
including the brand which we don't want
so the way to get rid of the brand
would be to do data columns of
everything but the last one minus one so
now if i print this you'll see the brand
disappears
and so i can actually just take
data set columns minus one
and i'll put it right in here for the
columns we're going to look at
and let's un mark this
and unmark this
and now if i do an x dot head i now have
a new data frame and you can see right
here we have all the different columns
except for the brand at the end of the
year
and it turns out when you start playing
with the data set you're going to get an
error later on and it'll say cannot
convert string to float value and that's
because if for some reason these things
the way they recorded them must been
recorded as strings so we have a neat
feature in here
on pandas to convert
and it is simply convert objects
and for this we're going to do convert
oops convert underscore
numeric numeric
equals
true and yes i did have to go look that
up i don't have it memorized the convert
numeric in there if i'm working with a
lot of these things i remember them but
depending on where i'm at what i'm doing
i usually have to look it up and we run
that oops i must have missed something
in here let me double check my spelling
and when i double check my spilling
you'll see i missed the first underscore
in the convert objects when i run this
it now has everything converted
into a numeric value because that's what
we're going to be working with is
numeric values down here
and the next part is that we need to go
through the data and eliminate null
values most people when they're doing
small amounts working with small data
pools discover afterwards that they have
a null value and they have to go back
and do this
so you know be aware whenever we're
formatting this data things are going to
pop up and sometimes you go backwards to
fix it
and that's fine that's just part of
exploring the data and understanding
what you
have and i should have done this earlier
but let me go ahead and increase the
size of my window one notch
there we go
easier to see
so we'll do 4i in
working with x dot
columns we'll page through all the
columns and we want to take
x of i and we're going to change that
we're going to alter it
and so
with this we want to go ahead and fill
in
x of i pandas has the fill in a
and that just fills in any non-existent
missing data
and we'll put my brackets up and there's
a lot of different ways to fill this
data
if you have a really large data set some
people just void out that data because
they and then look at it later in a
separate exploration of data
one of the tricks we can do is we can
take our column
and we can find the means
and the means is in other are quotation
marks
so we take the columns we're going to
fill in the non-existing one with the
means the problem is that returns a
decimal float so some of these aren't
decimals
certainly let me be a little careful of
doing this but for this example we're
just going to fill it in with the
integer version of this it keeps it on
par with the other data that isn't a
decimal point
and then what we also want to do is we
want to double check
a lot of times you do this first part
first to double check then you do the
fill and then you do it again just to
make sure you did it right so we're
going to go through and test
for missing data
and one of the ways you can do that is
simply go in here
and take our x of i
column so it's going to go through the x
of i column it says is null so it's
going to return any any place there's a
null value it actually goes through all
the rows of each column is null and then
we want to go ahead and sum that so we
take that and we add the sum value and
these are all pandas so is null is a
panda command and so is sum and if we go
through that we go ahead and run it
and we go ahead and take and run that
you'll see that all the columns have
zero null values so we've now tested and
double checked and our data is nice and
clean we have no null values everything
is now a number value we turned it into
numeric
and we've removed the last column in our
data
and at this point we're actually going
to
start using the elbow method to find the
optimal number of clusters so we're now
actually getting into the sk learn part
uh the k means clustering on here
well i guess we'll go ahead and zoom it
up one more not so you can see what i'm
typing in here
and then from
sk learn we're going to or sk sklearn
cluster
we're going to import
k
means
i always forget to capitalize the k and
the m when i do this
so it's capital k capital m k means
and we'll go and create a um
array wcss equals let me get an empty
array if you remember from the elbow
method from our slide
within the sums of squares wss is
defined as the sum of square distance
between each member of the cluster in a
centroid so we're looking at that change
in differences as far as a squared
distance and we're going to run this
over a number of k-mean values
in fact let's go for i in range we'll do
11 of them
range 0 11
and the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to create the actual
we'll do it all lowercase
and so we're going to create this object
from the k-means that we just imported
and the variable that we want to put
into this is in
clusters
and we're going to set that equals to i
that's the most important one because
we're looking at how increasing the
number of clusters
changes our answer there are a lot of
settings to the k-means
our guys in the back did a great job
just kind of playing with some of them
the most common ones that you see in a
lot of stuff is how you admit your
k-means so we have k means plus
plus
this is just a tool to let the model
itself be smart how it picks the
centroids to start with its initial
centroids we only want to iterate no
more than 300 times we have a max
iteration we put in there we have the
infinite the random state equals zero
you really don't need to worry too much
about these when you're first learning
this as you start digging in deeper you
start finding that these are shortcuts
that will speed up the process
as far as a setup but the big one that
we're working with is the in clusters
equals i so we're going to literally
train our k means 11 times we're going
to do this process 11 times and if
you're working with big data you know
the first thing you do is you run a
small sample of the data so you can test
all your stuff on it and you can already
see the problem that if i'm going to
iterate through a terabyte of data 11
times and then the k-means itself is
iterating through the data multiple
times that's a heck of a process
so you got to be a little careful with
this a lot of times though you can find
your
elbow using the elbow method find your
optimal number on a sample of data
especially if you're working with larger
data sources so we want to go ahead and
take our k means and we're just going to
fit it
if you're looking at any of the sklearn
very common you fit your model and if
you remember correctly our variable
we're using is the capital x
and once we fit this value we go back to
the array we made and we want to go and
just depend that value on the end
and it's not the actual fit we're
pinning in there it's when it generates
it it generates the value you're looking
for is inertia so k-means dot inertia
will pull that specific value out that
we need
and let's get a visual on this we'll do
our plt plot
and what we're plotting here
is first the x axis which is range 0
11 so that will generate a nice little
plot there and the wcss for our y axis
it's always nice to give our plot a
title
and let's see we'll just give it the
elbow method for the title and let's get
some labels so let's go ahead and do plt
x label
and we'll do a number of clusters for
that
and plt y label
and for that we can do oops there we go
wcss since that's what we're doing on
the plot on there and finally we want to
go ahead and display our graph which is
simply plt dot oops
dot show there we go and because we have
it set to inline it'll appear in line
hopefully i didn't make a type error on
there
and you can see we get a very nice graph
you can see a very nice elbow joint
there at
2 and again right around 3 and 4 and
then after that there's not very much
now as a data scientist if i was looking
at this
i would do either three or four and i'd
actually try both of them to see what
the
output looked like and they've already
tried this in the back so we're just
going to use three as a setup on here
and let's go ahead and see what that
looks like when we actually use this
to show the different kinds of cars
and so let's go ahead and apply the
k-means to the cars data set
and basically we're going to copy the
code that we loop through up above
where k-means equals k-means number of
clusters and we're just going to set the
number of clusters to three
since that's what we're going to look
for and you can do three and four on
this and graph them just to see how they
come up differently be kind of curious
to look at that but for this we're just
going to set it to three go ahead and
create our own variable y
k means for our answers
and we're going to set that equal to
whoops a double equal there to k means
but we're not going to do a fit we're
going to do a fit predict is the setup
you want to use and when you're using
untrained models you'll see
a slightly different because usually you
see fit and then you see just the
predict but we want to both fit and
predict the k-means on this and that's
fit underscore predict and then our
capital x is the data we're working with
and before we plot this data we're going
to do a little pandas trick we're going
to take our x value and we're going to
set x as matrix
so we're converting this into a nice
rows and columns kind of set up but we
want the we're going to have columns
equals none so it's just going to be a
matrix of data in here
and let's go ahead and run that
a little warning you'll see these
warnings pop up because things are
always being updated so there's like
minor changes in the versions and future
versions
instead of matrix now that it's more
common to set it dot values instead of
doing as matrix but math matrix works
just fine for right now and you'll want
to update that later on but let's go
ahead and dive in and plot this and see
what that looks like
and before we dive into plotting this
data i always like to take a look and
see what i am plotting so let's take a
look at y
k means i'm just going to print that out
down here
and we see we have an array of answers
we have 2 1 0 2 1 2. so it's clustering
these different
rows of data
based on the three different spaces it
thinks it's going to be
and then let's go ahead and print x and
see what we have for x and we'll see
that x is an array it's a matrix so we
have our different values in the array
and what we're going to do it's very
hard to plot all the different values in
the array so we're only going to be
looking at the first two or positions 0
and 1.
and if you were doing a full
presentation in front of the board
meeting
you might actually do a little different
than and dig a little deeper into the
different aspects because this is all
the different columns we looked at but
we look at columns one and two for this
to make it easy
so let's go ahead and clear this data
out of here and let's bring up our plot
and we're going to do a scatter plot
here so plt scatter
and
this looks a little complicated so let's
explain what's going on with this we're
going to take the x values
and we're only interested in y of k
means equals zero the first cluster
okay
and then we're going to take value 0 for
the x axis and then we're going to do
the same thing here
we're only interested in k means equals
zero but we're going to take the second
column so we're looking at the first two
columns in our answer or in the data
and then the guys in the back played
with this a little bit to make it pretty
and they discovered that it looks good
because the size equals 100 that's the
size of the dots
we're going to use red for this one and
when they were looking at the data and
what came out it was definitely the
toyota on this we're just going to go
ahead and label it toyota
again that's something you really have
to explore in here
as far as playing with those numbers and
see what looks good we'll go ahead and
hit enter in there and i'm just going to
paste in the next
two lines which is the next two cars
and this is our nissa and honda and
you'll see with our scatter plot we're
now looking at where y underscore k
means equals one
and we want the zero column and y k
means equals two again we're looking at
just the first two columns zero and one
and each of these rows then corresponds
to nissan and honda
and i'll go ahead and hit enter on there
and uh finally let's take a look and put
the centroids on there
again we're going to do a scatter plot
and on the centroids you can just pull
that from our k-means the model we
created
dot cluster centers
and we're going to just do
all of them
in the first number and all of them and
the second number which is 0 1 because
you always start with 0 and 1.
and then they were playing with the size
and everything to make it look good
we'll do a size of 300 we're going to
make the color yellow and we'll label
them it's always good to have some good
labels centroids
and then we do want to do a title plt
title
and pop up there
plt titles you always want to make your
graphs look pretty we'll call it
clusters of car make
and one of the features of the
plot library is you can add a
legend it'll automatically bring in
since we've already labeled the
different aspects of the legend with
toyota nissan and honda
and finally we want to go ahead and show
so we can actually see it and remember
it's inline so if you're using a
different editor that's not the jupiter
notebook you'll get a pop-up of this
and you should have a nice set of
clusters here so we can look at this we
have a clusters of honda and green
toyota and red
nissan and purple and you can see where
they put the centroids to separate them
when we're looking at this we can also
plot a lot of other different data on
here as far because we only looked at
the first two columns this is just
column one and two or zero one as you
label them in computer scripting but you
can see here we have nice clusters of
car make and we were able to pull out
the data and you can see how just these
two columns
form very distinct clusters of data
so if you were exploring new data you
might take a look and say well what
makes these different
almost going in reverse you start
looking at the date and pulling apart
the columns to find out why is the first
group set up the way it is maybe you're
doing loans and you want to go well why
is this group not defaulting on their
loans and why is the last group
defaulting on their loans and why is the
middle group 50 defaulting on their bank
loans and you start finding ways to
manipulate the data and pull out the
answers you want
so now that you've seen how to use k
mean for clustering
let's move on to the next topic
now let's look into logistic regression
the logistic regression algorithm is the
simplest classification algorithm used
for binary or multi-classification
problems and we can see we have our
little girl from canada who's into
horror books is back that's actually
really scary when you think about that
with those big eyes in the previous
tutorial we learned about linear
regression dependent and independent
variables so to brush up y equals mx
plus c
very basic algebraic function of
y and x the dependent variable is the
target class variable we are going to
predict
the independent variables x1 all the way
up to xn are the features or attributes
we're going to use to predict the target
class we know what a linear regression
looks like but using the graph we cannot
divide the outcome into categories
it's really hard to categorize 1.5 3.6
9.8
for example a linear regression graph
can tell us that with increase in number
of hours studied the marks of a student
will increase but it will not tell us
whether the student will pass or not in
such cases where we need the output as
categorical value we will use logistic
regression and for that we're going to
use the sigmoid function so you can see
here we have our marks 0 to 100 number
of hours studied that's going to be what
they're comparing it to in this example
and we usually form a line that says y
equals mx plus c and when we use the
sigmoid function we have p equals 1 over
1 plus e to the minus y it generates a
sigmoid curve and so you can see right
here when you take the ln which is the
natural logarithm i always thought it
should be nl not ln that's just the
inverse of e your e to the minus y and
so we do this we get ln of p over 1
minus p equals m times x plus c that's
the sigmoid curve function we're looking
for and we can zoom in on the function
and you'll see that the function as it
derives goes to 1 or to 0 depending on
what your x value is and the probability
if it's greater than 0.5 the value is
automatically rounded off to 1
indicating that the student will pass so
if they're doing a certain amount of
studying they will probably pass then
you have a threshold value at the 0.5 it
automatically puts that right in the
middle usually and your probability if
it's less than 0.5 the value rendered
off to 0 indicating the student will
fail so if they're not studying very
hard they're probably going to fail this
of course is ignoring the outliers of
that one student is just a natural
genius and doesn't need any studying to
memorize everything that's not me
unfortunately
i have to study hard to learn new stuff
problem statement to classify whether a
tumor is malignant or benign and this is
actually one of my favorite data sets to
play with because it has so many
features and when you look at them you
really are hard to understand you can't
just look at them and know the answer so
it gives you a chance to kind of dive
into what data looks like when you
aren't able to understand the specific
domain of the data but i also want you
to remind you that in the domain of
medicine if i told you that my
probability
was really good it classified things
that say 90 or 95 and i'm classifying
whether you're going to have a malignant
or a b9 tumor i'm guessing that you're
going to go get it tested anyways so you
got to remember the domain we're working
with so why would you want to do that if
you know you're just going to go get a
biopsy because you know it's that
serious this is like an all or nothing
just referencing the domain it's
important it might help the doctor know
where to look just by understanding what
kind of tumor it is so it might help
them or aid them and something they
missed from before so let's go ahead and
dive into the code and i'll come back to
the domain part of it in just a minute
so use case and we're going to do our
normal imports here we're importing
numpy pandas seaborn the matplot library
and we're going to do matplot library in
line since i'm going to switch over to
anaconda so let's go ahead and flip over
there and get this started
so i've opened up a new window in my
anaconda jupiter notebook
and by the way jupiter notebook you
don't have to use anaconda for the
jupyter notebook i just love the
interface and all the tools and anaconda
brings so we got our import numpy as np
for our numpy number array we have our
pandas pd we're going to bring in
seaborn to help us with our graphs as
sns
so many really nice tools in both
seaborne and matplot library and we'll
do our
matplotlibrary.piplot as plt and then of
course we want to let it know to do it
in line and let's go and just run that
so it's all set up
and we're just going to call our data
data
not creative today
equals pd and this happens to be in a
csv file
so we'll use the pd.read underscore csv
and i happen to name the file i renamed
it
data4p2.csv you can of course write in
the comments below the youtube and
requests for the data set itself or go
to the simply learn website and we'll be
happy to supply that for you
and let's just um open up the data
before we go any further and let's just
see what it looks like in a spreadsheet
so when i pop it open in a local
spreadsheet this is just a csv file
comma separated variables we have an id
so i guess they
categorize this for reference or what id
which test was done the diagnosis m for
malignant b for b9 so there's two
different options on there and that's
what we're going to try to predict is
the m and b and test it and then we have
like the radius
mean or average the texture average
perimeter mean area mean smoothness i
don't know about you but unless you're a
doctor in the field most of stuff i mean
you can guess what concave means just by
the term concave but i really wouldn't
know what that means in the measurements
they're taking so they have all kinds of
stuff like how smooth it is
the symmetry and these are all float
values let me just page through them
real quick and you'll see there's i
believe 36 if i remember correctly in
this one
so there's a lot of different values
they take and all these measurements
they take when they go in there and they
take a look at the different growth the
tumorous growth
so back in our data and i put this in
the same folder as a code so i saved
this code in that folder obviously if
you have it in a different location you
want to put the full path in there and
we'll just do
pandas
first five lines of data with the data
dot head
when we run that we can see that we have
pretty much what we just looked at we
have an id we have a diagnosis
if we go all the way across you'll see
all the different columns coming across
displayed nicely
for our data
and while we're exploring the data our
seaborn which we referenced as sns makes
it very easy to go in here and do a
joint plot you'll notice that
very similar to because it is sitting on
top of the
plot library so the joint plot does a
lot of work for us and we're just going
to look at the first two columns that
we're interested in the radius mean and
the texture mean we'll just look at
those two columns
and data equals data so that tells it
which two columns we're plotting and
then we're going to use the data that we
pulled in let's just run that and it
generates a really nice graph on here
and there's all kinds of cool things on
this graph to look at i mean we have the
texture mean and the radius mean
obviously the axes you can also see
and one of the cool things on here is
you can also see the histogram they show
that for the radius mean whereas the
most commons radius mean come up and
where the most common texture is so
we're looking at the tech the
on each growth its average texture and
on each radius it's average
radius on there it gets a little
confusing because we're talking about
the individual objects average and then
we can also look over here and see the
histogram showing us the median or how
common each measurement is
and that's only two columns so let's dig
a little deeper into seaborn they also
have a heat map and if you're not
familiar with heat maps a heat map just
means it's in color that's all that
means heat map i guess the original ones
were plotting heat density on something
and so ever since then it's just called
a heat map and we're going to take our
data
and get our corresponding numbers to put
that into the heat map and that's simply
data dot c-o-r-r
for that that's a pandas expression
let's remember we're working in a pandas
data frame so that's one of the cool
tools in pandas for our data and this is
pull that information into a heat map
and see what that looks like
and you'll see that we're now looking at
all the different features we have our
id we have our texture we have our area
our compactness concave points
and if you look down the middle of this
chart diagonal going from the upper left
to bottom right
it's all white that's because when you
compare texture to texture they're
identical so they're a hundred percent
or in this case a perfect one in their
correspondence
and you'll see that when you look at say
area or right below it it has almost a
black on there when you compare it to
texture so these have almost no
corresponding data they don't really
form a linear graph or something that
you can look at and say how connected
they are they're very scattered data
this is really just a really nice graph
to get a quick look at your data doesn't
so much change what you do but it
changes verifying so when you get an
answer or something like that or you
start looking at some of these
individual pieces you might go hey that
doesn't match according to showing our
heat map this should not correlate with
each other and if it is you're going to
have to start asking well why what's
going on what else is coming in there
but it does show some really cool
information on here and we can see from
the id
there's no real one feature that just
says if you go across the top line that
lights up there's no one feature that
says hey if the area is a certain size
then it's going to be b9 or malignant it
says there's some that sort of add up
and that's a big hint in the data that
we're trying to id this whether it's
malignant or b9 that's a big hint to us
as data scientists to go okay
we can't solve this with any one feature
it's going to be something that includes
all the features or many of the
different features to come up with the
solution for it and while we're
exploring the data let's explore one
more area and let's look at data dot is
null we want to check for null values in
our data if you remember from earlier in
this tutorial we did it a little
differently where we added stuff up and
summed them up you can actually with
pandas do it really quickly data.is null
and summit and it's going to go across
all the columns so when i run this
you're going to see all the columns come
up with no no data
so we've just just to re hash these last
few steps
we've done a lot of exploration we have
looked at the first two columns
and seen how they plot with the seaborn
with a joint plot which shows both the
histogram
and the data plotted on the xy
coordinates
and obviously you can do that more in
detail
with different columns and see how they
plot together
and then we took and did the seaborn
heat map the sns
dot heat map of the data and you can see
right here where it did a nice job
showing us some bright spots where stuff
correlates with each other and forms a
very nice combination or points of
scattering points and you can also see
areas that don't
and then finally we went ahead and
checked the data is the data null value
do we have any missing data in there
very important step because it'll crash
later on
if you forget to do this step it will
remind you when you get that nice error
code that says no values okay
so not a big deal if you miss it but
it's no fun having to go back when
you're you're in a huge process and
you've missed this step and now you're
10 steps later and you got to go
remember where you were pulling the data
in
so we need to go ahead and pull out our
x
and our y
let me just put that down here and we'll
set the x equal to
and there's a lot of different options
here certainly we could do x equals all
the columns except for the first two
because if you remember the first two is
the id and the diagnosis
so that certainly would be an option
but we're going to do is we're actually
going to focus on the worst the worst
radius the worst texture parameter area
smoothness compactness and so on one of
the reasons to start dividing your data
up
when you're looking at this information
is
sometimes the data will be the same data
coming in so if i have two measurements
coming into my model it might overweigh
them it might overpower the other
measurements because it's measuring it's
basically taking that information in
twice
that's a little bit past the scope of
this tutorial i want you to take away
from this though is that we are dividing
the data up into pieces and our team in
the back went ahead and said hey let's
just look at the worst so i'm going to
create a an array
and you'll see this array radius worst
texture worse perimeter worst we've just
taken the worst of the worst and i'm
just going to put that in my x so this x
is still a pandas data frame but it's
just those columns and our y if you
remember correctly is going to be oops
hold on one second it's not x it's data
there we go so x equals data and then
it's a list of the different columns the
worst of the worst and if we're going to
take that then we have to have our
answer for our y for the stuff we know
and if you remember correctly we're just
going to be looking at
the diagnosis that's all we care about
is what is it diagnosed is it b9 or
malignant
and since it's a single column we can
just do diagnosis oh i forgot to put the
brackets
there we go okay so it's just diagnosis
on there and we can also real quickly do
like x dot head if you want to see what
that looks like
and y dot head
and run this
and you'll see
it only does the last one i forgot about
that if you don't do print you can see
that the the y dot head is just mmm
because the first ones are all malignant
and if i run this the x dot head is just
the first five values of radius worst
texture worse parameter worst area worst
and so on
i'll go ahead and take that out
so moving down
to the next step we've built our two
data sets our answer and then the
features we want to look at
in data science it's very important to
test your
model
so we do that by splitting the data
and from sklearn model selection we're
going to import train test split so
we're going to split it into two groups
there are so many ways to do this i
noticed in one of the more modern ways
to actually split it into three groups
and then you model each group and test
it against the other groups so you have
all kinds and there's reasons for that
which is past the scope of this and for
this particular example isn't necessary
for this we're just going to split it
into two groups one to train our data
and one to test our data and the
sklearn
dot model selection we have train test
split you could write your own quick
code to do this we just randomly divide
the data up into two groups but they do
it for us nicely
and we actually can almost we can
actually do it in one statement with
this where we're going to generate four
variables
capital x train capital x test so we
have our training data we're going to
use to fit the model and then we need
something to test it and then we have
our y train so we're going to train the
answer and then we have our test so this
is the stuff we want to see how good it
did on our model
and we'll go ahead and take our train
test split that we just imported
and we're going to do x and our y are
two different data that's going in for
our split
and then the guys in the back came up
and wanted us to go ahead and use a test
size equals 0.3 that's test underscore
size random state it's always nice to
kind of switch the random state around
but not that important
what this means is that the test size is
we're going to take 30 percent of the
data
and we're going to put that into our
test variables our y test and our x test
and we're going to do 70 into the x
train and the y train so we're going to
use 70 of the data to train our model
and 30 to test it let's go ahead and run
that and load those up
so now we have all our stuff split up
and all our data ready to go and now we
get to the actual logistics part we're
actually going to do our create our
model so let's go ahead and bring that
in from sklearn we're going to bring in
our linear model and we're going to
import logistic regression that's the
actual model we're using and this we'll
call it log model
stereo model and let's just set this
equal to our logistic regression that we
just imported
so now we have a variable log model set
to that class for us to use
and with most the
models in the sk learn we just need to
go ahead and fix it fit
do a fit on there and we use our x train
that we separated out with our y
train and let's go ahead and run this so
once we've run this we'll have a model
that fits this data that 70 percent of
our training data
and of course it prints this out that
tells us all the different variables
that you can set on there there's a lot
of different choices you can make but
for word though we're just going to let
all the defaults sit we don't really
need to mess with those on this
particular example there's nothing in
here that really stands out as super
important until you start
fine tuning it but for what we're doing
the basics will work just fine and then
let's we need to go ahead and test out
our model is it working so let's create
a variable y predict and this is going
to be equal to
our log model
and we want to do a predict again very
standard format for the sk learn library
is taking your model and doing a predict
on it and we're going to test why
predict against the y test so we want to
know what the model thinks it's going to
be that's what our y predict is and with
that we want the capital x x
test
so we have our train set and our test
set and now we're going to do our y
predict and let's go ahead and run that
and if we uh print
y
predict
let me go ahead and run that
you'll see it comes up and it presents
and i prints a nice array of
b and m for b9 and malignant
for all the different test data we put
in there
so it does pretty good we're not sure
exactly how good it does but we can see
that it actually works and is functional
was very easy to create you'll always
discover with our data science that as
you explore this
you spend a significant amount of time
prepping your data
and making sure your data coming in is
good
there's a saying
good data in good answers out bad data
in
bad answers out that's only half the
thing that's only half of it
selecting your models becomes the next
part as far as how good your models are
and then of course fine-tuning it
depending on what model you're using
so we come in here we want to know how
good this came out so we have our y
predict here log model.predict x test
so for deciding how good our model is
we're going to go from the
sklearn.metrics we're going to import
classification report
and that just reports how good our model
is doing and then we're going to feed it
the model data let's just print this out
and we'll take our classification report
and we're going to put into there
our test our actual data so this is what
we actually know is true
and our prediction what our model
predicted for that data on the test side
and let's run that and see what that
does
so we pull that up you'll see that we
have
a precision for b9 and malignant b and m
and we have a precision of 93 and 91 a
total of 92 so it's kind of the average
between these two 92
there's all kinds of different
information on here your f1 score
your recall your support coming through
on this
and for this i'll go ahead and just flip
back to our slides that they put
together for describing it and so here
we're going to look at the precision
using the classification report and you
see this is the same printout i had up
above some of the numbers might be
different because it does randomly pick
out which data we're using so this model
is able to predict the type of tumor
with 91
accuracy so we look back here let's
you'll see where we have uh b9 and it
actually is 92 coming up here but we're
looking about a 92 91 precision and
remember i reminded you about domain so
we're talking about the domain of a
medical domain with a very catastrophic
outcome you know at 91 or 92 percent
precision you're still going to go in
there and have somebody do a biopsy on
it very different than if you're
investing money and there's a 92 percent
chance you're going to earn 10 percent
and 8 chance you're going to lose 8
you're probably going to bet the money
because at that odds it's pretty good
that you'll make some money and in the
long run you do that enough you
definitely will make money and also with
this domain i've actually seen them use
this to identify different forms of
cancer that's one of the things that
they're starting to use these models for
because then it helps the doctor know
what to investigate
by now we all know machine learning
models make predictions by learning from
the past data available so we have our
input values our machine learning model
builds on those inputs of what we
already know and then we use that to
create a predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there
watching the black cat cross their path
no dear you can differentiate between a
cat and a dog based on their
characteristics
cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws how sharp are their claws
and we can evaluate the length of the
ears and we can usually sort out cats
from dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now unless they live a place
where there's not many cats or dogs so
if we look at the sharpness of the claws
the length of the ears and we can see
that the cat has smaller ears and
sharper claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat
sharp claws length of ears and goes in
the cat group because knn is based on
feature similarity we can do
classification using knn classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knn what is the k
n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for is one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or is not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how its neighbors are
classified knn stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and k n is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5.
we'll talk about k in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals 5 i mean that's
what's the value we put in there so
we're going to talk about it how do we
choose a factor k k n algorithm is based
on feature similarity choosing the right
value of k
is a process called parameter tuning and
is important for better accuracy so at k
equals three we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to three we're going to
look at the three nearest neighbors
we're going to say this is a square and
if we put k equals a 7 we classify as a
triangle depending on what the other
data is around and you can see as the k
changes depending on where that point is
that drastically changes your answer and
we jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of k you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these factors
that's the face you get it's like oh my
gosh did i choose the right k did i set
it right my values in whatever machine
learning tool you're looking at so that
you don't have a huge bias in one
direction or the other and in terms of k
n n the number of k if you choose it too
low the bias is based on it's just two
noises it's it's right next to a couple
things and it's going to pick those
things and you might get a skewed answer
and if your k is too big then it's going
to take forever to process so you're
going to run into processing issues and
resource issues so what we do the most
common use and there's other options for
choosing k is to use the square root of
n so n is a total number of values you
have you take the square root of it in
most cases you also if it's an even
number so if you're using uh like this
case squares and triangles if it's even
you want to make your k value odd that
helps it select better so in other words
you're not going to have a balance
between two different factors that are
equal so usually take the square root of
n and if it's even you add one to it or
subtract one from it and that's where
you get the k value from that is the
most common use and it's pretty solid it
works very well when do we use knn we
can use knn when data is labeled so you
need a label on it we know we have a
group of pictures with dogs dogs cats
cats data is noise free and so you can
see here when we have a class and we
have like underweight 140 23 hello kitty
normal that's pretty confusing we have a
high variety of data coming in so it's
very noisy and that would cause an issue
data set is small so we're usually
working with smaller data sets where you
might get into a gig of data if it's
really clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because k n is a lazy learner i.e it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the knn but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does a k n algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we see right here we have two variables
you know true false they're either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn so if
we have new data coming in that says 57
kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance d equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus b squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're computing the third edge
since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknown point and we placed it
there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around the distance d1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13. and distance 3
is about 13.4 similarly we will
calculate the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
in the data set and because we're
dealing with small amount of data that's
not that hard to do it's actually pretty
quick for a computer and it's not a
really complicated mass you can just see
how close is the data based on the
euclidean distance hence we have
calculated the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
as shown where x1 and y1 equal 57 and
170 whose class we have to classify so
now we're looking at that we're saying
well here's the euclidean distance who's
going to be their closest neighbors now
let's calculate the nearest neighbor at
k equals three and we can see the three
closest neighbors puts them at normal
and that's pretty self-evident when you
look at this graph it's pretty easy to
say okay what we're just voting normal
normal normal three votes for normal
this is going to be a normal weight so
majority of neighbors are pointing
towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of knn positive
integer k is specified along with a new
sample we select the k entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through i
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight
eight columns with a particular
attribute and then the ninth column
which is the outcome is whether they
have diabetes as a data scientist the
first thing you should be looking at is
insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes because
that's why they're taking it and that
could cause issue in some of the machine
learning packages but for a very basic
setup this works fine for doing the k n
and the next thing you notice is it
didn't take very much to open it up i
can scroll down to the bottom of the
data there's 768.
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this into
my ram on my computer i can look at it i
can manipulate it and it's not going to
really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what ide i'm using
certainly you can use any particular
editor for python but i like to use for
doing uh very basic visual stuff the
anaconda which is great for doing demos
with the jupiter notebook and just a
quick view of the anaconda navigator
which is the new release out there which
is really nice you can see under home i
can choose my application we're going to
be using python36 i have a couple
different versions on this particular
machine if i go under environments i can
create a unique environment for each one
which is nice and there's even a little
button there where i can install
different packages so if i click on that
button and open the terminal i can use a
simple pip install to install different
packages i'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and i've already
you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case i'm going to
it's going to open up chrome because
that's my default that i use and since
the script is pre-done you'll see have a
number of windows open up at the top the
one we're working in and since we're
working on the k n predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not let's
go and put that title in there and i'm
also going to go up here and click on
cell actually we want to go ahead and
first insert a cell below and then i'm
going to go back up to the top cell and
i'm going to change the cell type to
markdown that means this is not going to
run this python it's a markdown language
so if i run this first one it comes up
in nice big letters which is kind of
nice remind us what we're working on and
by now you should be familiar with doing
all of our imports we're going to import
the pandas as pd import numpy is np
pandas is the pandas data frame and
numpy is a number array very powerful
tools to use in here so we have our
imports so we've brought in our pandas
our numpy our two general python tools
and then you can see over here we have
our trained test split by now you should
be familiar with splitting the data we
want to split part of it for training
our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take and get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so they're all
uniform between minus 1 and 1. and then
the actual tool this is the k neighbors
classifier we're going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
matrix our f1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the sk learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
pd and we'll take a look at the data in
python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually i like to also
pull it up so that we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read csv that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder i just put in the
same folder where my ipython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick links of the data set
that is a simple python command len for
length we might even let's go ahead and
print that we'll go print and if you do
it on its own line link that data set in
the jupyter notebook it'll automatically
print it but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there
if you put a bunch of these in a row you
know the data set one head data set two
head it only prints out the last one so
i usually always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame panda's
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose uh any of those
you'd be dead so not a really good
factor if they don't if they have a zero
in there because they didn't have the
data and we'll take a look at that
because we're going to start replacing
that information with a couple of
different things and let's see what that
looks like so first we create a nice
list as you can see we have the values
talked about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals dataset column.replace
this is this is still pandas you can do
a direct there's also one that's that
you look for your nan a lot of different
options in here but the nan
numpy nan is what that stands for is is
none it doesn't exist so the first thing
we're doing here is we're replacing the
zero with a numpy none there's no data
there that's what that says that's what
this is saying right here so put the
zero in and we're going to play zeros
with no data so if it's a zero that
means the person's well hopefully not
dead hope they just didn't get the data
the next thing we want to do is we're
going to create the mean which is the
integer from the data set from the
column dot mean where we skip n a's we
can do that that is a pandas command
there the skip n a so we're going to
figure out the mean of that data set and
then we're going to take that data set
column and we're going to replace all
the n p n a n with the means why did we
do that and we could have actually just
uh taken this step and gone right down
here and just replaced zero and skip
anything were except you could actually
there's a way to skip zeros and then
just replace all the zeros but in this
case we want to go ahead and do it this
way so you could see that we're
switching this to a non-existent value
and we're going to create the mean well
this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular value of
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines just not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose and if i run this this is going
to print all the different glucose
levels going down and we thankfully
don't see anything in here that looks
like missing data at least on the ones
it shows you can see it skipped a bunch
in the middle that's what it does if you
have too many lines in jupiter notebook
he'll skip a few and and go on to the
next in a data set let me go and remove
this and we'll just zero out that and of
course before we do any processing
before proceeding any further we need to
split the data set into our train and
testing data that way we have something
to train it with and something to test
it on and you're going to notice we did
a little something here with the pandas
database code there we go my drawing
tool we've added in this right here
off the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at 0 column 0 to 8. remember column 9
here it is right up here we put it in
here is outcome well that's not part of
the training data that's part of the
answer yes column nine but it's listed
as eight number eight so zero to eight
is nine columns so uh eight is the value
and when you see it in here zero this is
actually zero to seven it doesn't
include the last one and then we go down
here to y which is our answer and we
want just the last one just column eight
and you can do it this way with this
particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the train test
split that's part of the sk learn right
there and we simply put in our x and our
y
we're gonna do random state equals zero
you don't have to necessarily seat it
that's a seed number i think the default
is one when you see it i have to look
that up and then the test size test size
is point two that simply means we're
going to take 20 percent of the data and
put it aside so that we can test it
later that's all that is and again we're
going to run it not very exciting so far
we haven't had any printout other than
to look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there with the
actual writing of our knn we need to go
ahead and do a scale the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in a standard scalar which means
instead of the data being from you know
five to 303 in one column and the next
column is one to six we're going to set
that all so that all the data is between
minus one and one that's what that
standard scalar does keeps it
standardized and we only want to fit the
scaler with the training set but we want
to make sure the testing set is the x
test going in is also transformed so
it's processing it the same so here we
go with our standard scalar we're going
to call it sc underscore x for the
scalar and we're going to import the
standard scalar into this variable and
then our x train equals sc underscore x
dot fit transform so we're creating the
scalar on the x train variable and then
our x test we're also going to transform
it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're going to run this
and if you look at this we've now gone
through these steps all three of them
we've taken care of replacing our zeros
for key columns that shouldn't be zero
and we replace that with the means
of those columns that way that they fit
right in with our data models we've come
down here we split the data so now we
have our test data and our training data
and then we've taken and we scaled the
data so all of our data going in no no
we don't tr we don't train the y part
the y train and y test that never has to
be trained it's only the data going in
that's what we want to train in there
then define the model using k neighbors
classifier and fit the train data in the
model so we do all that data prep and
you can see down here we're only going
to have a couple lines of code where
we're actually building our model and
training it that's one of the cool
things about python and how far we've
come it's such an exciting time to be in
machine learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of y
and we get 768 and if we import math we
do math dot square root let's do y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do math square root
length of y test and when i run that we
get 12.409
i want to show you where this number
comes from we're about to use 12 is an
even number so if you know if you're
ever voting on things remember the
neighbors all vote don't want to have an
even number of neighbors voting so we
want to do something odd and let's just
take one away we'll make it 11. let me
delete this out of here this one the
reasons i love jupiter notebook is you
can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
k neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11.
we have an odd number of neighbors p
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are they diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means values
all kinds of measure this but the
euclidean is the most common one and it
works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion matrix why
test y predict so those are the two
values we're going to put in there and
let me go ahead and run that and print
it out and the way you interpret this is
you have the y predicted which would be
your title up here you could do let's
just do p r e d
predicted across the top
and actual going down actual
it's always hard to to write in here
actual that means that this column here
down the middle that's the important
column and it means that our prediction
said 94 and prediction in the actual
agreed on 94 and 32. this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with the third
row down here in the column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and i believe the zero is a 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct but our prediction said another
15 out of that 15 it classified as
incorrect so you can see where that
classification comes in and how that
works on the confusion matrix then we're
going to go ahead and print the f1 score
let me just run that and you see we get
a 0.69 in our f1 score
the f1
takes into account both sides of the
balance of false positives where if we
go ahead and just do the accuracy
account and that's what most people
think of is it looks at just how many we
got right out of how many we got wrong
so a lot of people when you're a data
scientist and you're talking to other
data scientists they're going to ask you
what the f1 score the f score is if
you're talking to the general public or
the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is the accuracy is always better than
the f1 score but the f1 score is more
telling it lets us know that there's
more false positives than we would like
on here but 82 percent not too bad for a
quick flash look at people's different
statistics and running an sk learn and
running the knn the k nearest neighbor
on it so we have created a model using
knn which can predict whether a person
will have diabetes or not or at the very
least whether they should go get a
checkup and have their glucose checked
regularly or not the print accuracy
score we got the 0.818 was pretty close
to what we got and we can pretty much
round that off and just say we have an
accuracy of 80
it tells us it is a pretty fair fit in
the model dimensionality reduction
dimensionality reduction refers to the
technique that reduces the number of
input variables in a data set
and so you can see on the table on the
right shows the orders made at an
automobile parts retailer the retailer
sells different automobile parts from
different companies and you can see we
have company bpex isomax and they have
the item the tire the axle an order id a
price number and a quantity in order to
predict the future cells
we find out that using correlation
analysis
that we just need three attributes
therefore we have reduced the number of
attributes from five to three
and clearly we don't really care about
the part number i don't think the part
number would have an effect on how many
tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those and we
just have the item the tire the price
and the quantity one of the things you
should be taking away from this is in
the scheme of things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data and we're
pre-processing the data what can we do
to clean it up
why dimensionality reduction
well number one less dimensions for a
given data set means less computation or
training time
that can be really important if you're
trying a number of different models
and you're re-running them over and over
again and even if you have seven
gigabytes of data that can start taking
days to go through all those different
models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing
our data set
redundancy is removed after removing
similar entries from the data set
again pre-processing some of our models
like a neural network if you put in two
of the same data it might give them a
higher weight than they would if it was
just once we want to get rid of that
redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple
data coming in
space required to store the data is
reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data
pool we might not send the company that
bought it why would we want to store two
whole extra columns when we added into
that pool of data
makes the data easy for plotting in 2d
and 3d plots this is my favorite part
very important you're in your
shareholder meeting
you want to be able to give them a
really good
clear
and simplified version you want to
reduce it down to something people can
take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in post scribing
uh leads to better human interpretation
that kind of goes with number four what
makes data easy for plotting you have a
better interpretation when we're looking
at it
principal component analysis
so what is it
uh principal component analysis is a
technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets increasing
interpretability but at the same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables we run it through the pca
we reduce the variables we end up with a
reduced variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because
if you look at the end result we have
the different colors all lined up so
what we're going to take a look at is
let's say we have a picture here
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some toddlers and you are
deciding which angle would be the best
to take the picture from so if we come
up here we look at this we say okay this
is you know one angle
we get the back of a lot of heads not
many faces
so we'll do it from here we might get
the one person up front smiling a lot of
the people in the class are missing so
we have a huge amount off to the right
of blank space maybe from up here again
we have the back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from might be this
bottom left angle you look at it you say
hey that makes sense it's a good
configuration of all the people in the
picture now when we're talking about
data
it's not
you really can't do it by what you think
is going to be the best we need to have
some kind of mathematical formula so
it's consistent and so it makes sense in
the back end
one of the projects i worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris if
you've ever done the iris data set it's
probably one of the most common ones out
there where they have the flower
and they're measuring the stamen in the
petals and they have width and they have
length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal we could just as
easily do the
width to length ratio we can divide the
width by the length and you get a single
number where you had two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
the very simplified example on my
iris pedal example
when we look at the similarity in pca we
find the best picture or projection of
the data points
and so we look down at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there
we can see these data points based on in
this case just two variables now keep in
mind we're usually talking about 36 40
variables
almost all of your
business models usually have about 26 to
27 different variables they're looking
at
same thing with like a bank loan model
we're talking 26 to 36 different
variables they're looking at that are
going in
so we want to do is we want to find the
best view in this case we're just
looking at the xy
we look down at it and we have our
second
idea pc2 and again we're looking at the
x i this x y this time from a different
direction
here for our e's we can consider that we
get two principal components namely pc1
and pc2
comparing both the principal components
we find the data points are sufficiently
spaced in pc1
so if you look at what we got here we
have pc1 you can see along the line how
the data points are spaced versus the
spacing in pc2 and that's what they're
coming up with what is going to give us
the best look for these data points when
we combine them and we're looking at
them from just a single angle
whereas in pc2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much more difficult
therefore we accept the pc-1 and not the
pc2 as the data points are more spaced
now obviously the back-end calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more valuable
this gives you an idea though that when
we're talking about this we're talking
about the perspective
which would help in understanding how
pca analysis works
we want to go ahead and do is dive into
the important terminologies under a pca
and important terminologies are views
the perspective through which data
points are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a pca presentation and
they're not taking the time to reduce it
to something that the average person
shareholders can understand you might
hear them refer to it as the different
views what view are we taking
dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set
and we talked about you'll hear features
dimensions um
i was talking about features there's
usually when you're running a business
you're talking 25 26 27 different
features minimal and then you have the
principal component new variables that
are constructed as linear combinations
or mixtures of the initial variables
principal component is very important
it's a combination if you remember my
flower example it would be the
width over the length of the petal as
opposed to putting both width and length
in you just put in the ratio instead
which is a single number versus two
separate numbers
projections the perpendicular distance
between the principal component and the
data points
and that goes to that line we had
earlier it's that right angle line of
where those point how those points fall
onto the line
important properties
important properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense you're not
going to do
10 principal properties with only three
features
you're trying to reduce them so it's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw
weird code out there and just randomly
do stuff with instead of really thinking
it through principle components are
orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line when we
when we do pc1 we're looking at how
those points fall on to that line
same thing with pc2
we want to make sure that pc1 does not
equal pc2 we don't want to have the same
two principal points
when we do two points
the priority of principal components
decreases as their numbers
increase this is important to understand
if you're going to create
one principle
component
everything is summarized into that one
component as we go to two components the
priority
how much
it holds value decreases as we go down
so if you have five different points
each one of those points is going to
have less value than just the one point
which has everything summarized in it
how pca works
i said there was more in the back end we
talked about the math this is what we're
talking about is how does it actually
work
so now we have understanding that you're
looking at a perspective
now we want to see how that math side
works pca performs the following
operations in order to evaluate the
principal components for a given data
set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance matrix
computation
and we use that to generate our i gene
vectors and i gene values
which is the feature vector and if you
remember the i gene vector is like a
translation for
moving the data
from x equals one to x equals two or
whatever we're altering it and the i
gene value is the final value that we
generate
when we talk about standardization the
main aim of this step is to standardize
the range of the attributes so that each
one of them lie within similar
boundaries
this process involves removal of the
mean from the variable values and
scaling the data with respect to the
standard deviation
and you can see here we have z equals
the variable values minus the mean
over the standard deviation
the covariance matrix computation
covariance matrix is used to express the
correlation between any two or more
attributes in multi-dimensional data set
the covariance matrix has the entries as
the variance and the covariance of the
attribute values the variance is denoted
by var and the covariance is denoted by
cov
on the right we can see the covariance
matrix for two attributes and their
values
when we do a hands-on and look at the
code we'll do a display of this so you
can see what we're talking about and
what that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance and then the covariance of x to
y
on the right side we can see the
covariance
table for more than two attributes in a
multi-dimensional data set
this is what i was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature two features
we're usually looking at 25 30 features
going on
and so if we do a setup like this we
should see all those different features
as the different variables
covariance matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related positive
covariance indicate that the value of
one variable is directly proportional to
the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is inversely
proportional to the other variable that
is always important to note whenever
we're doing any of these matrixes that
we're going to be looking at that
positive and negative whether it's
inverted or not
and then we have the iogene values in
the i gene vectors
iogene values and hygiene vectors are
the mathematical value
that are extracted from the covariance
table
they are responsible for the generation
of a new set of variables from the old
set of variables which further lead to
the construction of the principal
components
iogene vectors do not change directions
after linear transformation
igine values are the scalars or the
magnitude of the i gene vectors
and again this is just chain
transforming that data so we're going to
change
the vector b
to the b
prime as denoted on the chart
and so we have like multiple variables
how do we calculate that new variable
and then we have feature vectors feature
vectors is simply a matrix that has
hygiene vectors of the components that
we decide to keep as the columns here we
decide whether we must keep or discard
the less significant principal
components that we have generated in the
above steps this becomes really
important as we start looking at
the back end of this and we'll do this
in the demo
but one of the more important steps to
understand
and so we have the pca example consider
matrix x within rows or observations and
k columns or variables
now for this matrix we would construct a
variable space with as many dimensions
as the variable
but for our simplicity let's consider
this three dimensions for now
now each observation row of the matrix x
is placed in the k-dimensional variable
space such that the rows in the data
table form a swarm of points in this
space
now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the plot
the first principal component
is a line that best accounts for the
shape of the point swarm it represents
the maximal variance direction in the
data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1 this value is known
as a score
usually only one principal component is
insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set thus a second
principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source of variation in
the data while being orthogonal to pc1
pc2 also passes through the average
point
let's go ahead and pull this up and just
see what that means
inside our python scripting
i'm going to use the anaconda navigator
and i will be in python 3.6
for this example
i believe there's even like a 3.9 out
i tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models i use especially with the
neural networks are stable in 3 6.
and then we open up our
jupiter i'm in chrome and we go ahead
and create a new python 3.
and for ease of use our team in the back
was nice enough to put this together for
me
and we'll go and start with the
libraries
the first thing i like to do whenever
i'm looking at
any new setup
well you know what let's do let's do the
libraries first we're going to do our
basic libraries which is matplot library
the plt from the matplot library pandas
are data frame
pd numpy our numbers array np
seaborn for graphing sns that goes with
the plot that actually sits on matplot
library so the seaborn sits on there
and then we have our amber sign because
we're in jupiter notebook map plot
library in line the newer version
actually doesn't require that but i put
it in there either
anyway just because i'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the data
and in this case we're going to pull in
certainly you can have lots of fun with
different data but we're going to use
the cancer data set
and one of the reasons the cancer data
set is it has like 36 35 different
features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
and we'll go ahead and run this and look
at our keys and the first thing we
notice in our keys for the cancer data
set
is we have our data we have our target
our frame target names description
feature names and file name
so
what we're looking for in all this
is
let's take a look at the description
let's go in here and pull up the
description on here
i'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain we want to focus
on our pca setup
what's important is you start looking at
what the different attributes are what
they mean
if you were in the medical field you'd
want to note all these different things
whether what they're measuring where
it's coming from
you can actually see the actual
different
measurements they're taking
no missing attributes
we page all the way to the bottom and
you're going to have your data in this
case our target
and if you dig deep enough to the target
let's actually do this
let's go ahead and print target names
real quick here i always like to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
target
names
run that
yeah so the target name is is it
malignant or is it b9 um so in other
words is this
dangerous growth or is it something we
don't have to worry about that's the
bottom line with the cancer in this case
and then we can go ahead and load our
data
and you know let me go up a just a notch
here for easy of reading
it's hard to get that just right that's
all you have to do
uh so let's go ahead and look at our
data uh our we're going to use our
pandas
and we're going to go ahead and do our
data frame it's going to equal cancer
data columns equals cancer feature
equals feature names so remember up here
we already loaded the the
names up of our of the features in there
what is going to come out of this let me
just see if we can get to that
it's at the top of target names
that's just this list of names here in
the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and it'll print the head
and you can see here we have the mean
radius the mean texture mean perimeter
i don't know about you this is a
wonderful data set if you're playing
with it because
like many of the data that most the data
that comes in half the time we don't
even know we're looking at
we're just handed a bunch of stuff as a
data scientist going what the heck is
this and so this is a good place to
start because this has a number of
different features in there we have no
idea what these feature means or where
they come from we want to just look at
the data and figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
pca side of it as we've noticed before
is difficult to visualize high
dimensional data
we can use pca to find the first two
principal components and visualize the
data this new two-dimensional space with
a single scatter plot
before we do this we need to go ahead
and scale our data
now
i haven't run this to see if you really
have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time i almost do that as the first
step of any modeling even if it's
pre-modeling as we're doing here
in neural networks that is so important
with pca visualization it's already
going to scale it when we do the means
and deviation inside the pca
but just in case it's always good to
scale it
and then we're going to take our pca
with the scikit learn uses very similar
process to other pre-processing
functions that come with scikit-learn
we instantiate a pca object find the
principal components using the fit
method then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform we can also specify how many
components we want to
keep when creating the pca object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit ahead
let me go and run this code
so the code for this
is
from sklearn decomposition import pca
pca equals pca in components equals two
and that's really important to note that
because we're only going to want to look
at two components
i would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody else if you're showing
this to the shareholders
the whole idea is to reduce it to
something people can see
and then the pca fit we're going to is
going to take the scaled data that we
generated up here
and then you can see we've created our
pca model with in components equals two
now whenever i use a new tool
i like to go in there and actually see
what i'm using so let's go to the scikit
webpage for the pca
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different uh setups you have on there
probably the biggest one to look at
would be
well the biggest one is your components
how many components do you want
which you have to put in there pretty
much
and then you also might look at the svd
solver it's on auto right now but you
can override that and do different
things with it it does a pretty good job
as it is
and if we go down all the way down to
there we go
to our methods
if you notice we have fit
and we have fit transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not used for prediction
it's used to look at the data again
we're in the describe setup
we're fitting the data we're taking a
look at it we've already looked at our
minimum maximum we've already looked at
what's in each quarter we've done a full
description of the data this is part of
describing the data
that's the biggest thing i take away
when i come zooming in here and of
course they have examples of it down
here if you forget
and the biggest one of course is the
number of components
and then i mean the rest you can play
with
the actual solver whether you're doing a
full randomize there's different things
it does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two principal components
and so we have our xpca
we're going to set that equal to pca
transform scaled data
so there we go there's our first
transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape and the xpca data
shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us uh
what's going on here we've taken 30
features i think i said 36 or something
like that but it's 30
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from
we still have 569 data sets
i mean data rows data sets we still have
569 rows of data but instead of
computing 30 features we're now only
doing our model on two features
so let's go ahead and
plot these and take a look and see
what's going on
and uh
we're just going to use our plt figure
we'll set the figure size on here here's
our scatter plot
xpca
x underscore pca of
one these are two different
perceptions we're using
uh and then
you'll see right here c for color cancer
equals target and so remember we have
zero we have one
and if i remember correctly zero was
malignant one was b9
uh so everything in the zero column is
going to be one color and the other
color is going to be one and then we're
going to use the plasma map just kind of
telling you what color it is add some
labels first principle component second
principle component and we'll go ahead
and run this
and you can see here instead of having a
chart one of those heat maps with 30
different
columns in it
we can look at this and say hey this one
actually did a pretty good job
of separating the data
and a couple things when i'm looking at
this that i notice is first
we have a very clear area where it's
clumped together
where it's going to be benign
and we have a huge area it's still
clumped together more spread out where
it's going to be malignant or i think i
had that backwards
and then in the middle
because we're dealing with something
in this particular case cancer
we would try to separate i would be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out in other words there's an area
where everything overlaps and we're not
going to have a clear result on it
just because those are the people you
want to go in there and have extra tests
or treat it differently
versus going in and saying just cutting
into the can into the cancer so the body
absorbs it and it dissipates versus uh
actively going in there removing it
testing it going through chemo and all
the different things that's a big
difference you know as far as what's
going to happen here in that middle line
where the overlap is going to be huge
that's domain specific uh going back to
the data
we can see here
clearly by using these two components we
can easily separate these two classes so
the next step is what does that mean
interpreting the components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction comes the cost
of not being able to easily understand
what these components represent i don't
know what principle component one looks
work represents or second principle
the components correspond to
combinations of original features the
components themselves are stored as an
attribute of the filtered pca object and
so we talk look at that we can go ahead
and do look at the pca components this
is in our model we built we've trained
it we can run that and you can see
here's the actual components uh it's
the two components have each have their
own array
and within the array you can see the
what the scores are using
and these actually give weight to what
features are doing what
so in this numpy matrix array each row
represents a principal component and
each column relates back to the original
features
what's really neat about this is we can
now go in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map
and start seeing uh what this means and
so let me go ahead and just put this
down i've already got it down here
uh we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our
df comp data frame and we do our pca
components
and i want you to notice how easy this
is uh
we're going to set our columns equal to
cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy
and we're dumping it into a data frame
what's needed about a data frame is when
we get to seaborn it will pull that data
frame apart and
and set it up for us when we want and so
we're just going to do the cn the
seaborn heat map
of our data frame composition and we'll
use the plasma coloring
and it creates a nice little
color graph here
you can see we have the mean radius and
all the different features along the
bottom
on the right we have a scale so we can
see we have the dark colors all the way
to the really light colors which are
what's really shining there this is like
the primary stuff we want to look at
so this heat map in the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component itself
so you know very powerful map to look at
and then you can go in here and we might
notice that the mean radius
look how on the bottom of the map it is
on some of this
so you have some interesting
correlations here that change the
variations on that and what means what
this is more when you get to
a post scribe you can also use this to
try to guess as what these things mean
and what you want to change to get a
better result
regularization in machine learning
let's start with fitting the data and we
talk about what is data fitting it's a
process of plotting a series of data
points and drawing the best fit line to
understand the relationship between the
variables and this is what we called
data fitting and you can see here we
have a couple of lines we've drawn on
this graph we're going to go in a little
deeper on there so we might have in this
case just the two dimensions we have an
efficiency of the car and we have the
distance traveled in 1 000 kilometers
and so what is data fitting well it's a
linear relationship and a linear
relationship
very specifically linear means line
the line used to represent the
relationship is a straight line that
passes through the data points and the
variables have linear relationships
regression
so let's start with uh how linear
regression works a linear regression
finds a line that best fits the data
point and gives a relationship between
the two variables
and so you can see here we have the
efficiency of the car
versus the distance traveled and you can
see this nice straight line drawn
through there
and when you talk about multiple
variables all you're doing is putting
this instead of a line that now becomes
a plane
it gets a little more complicated with
multiple variables but they all come
down to this linear kind of drawing a
line through your data and finding what
fits the the data the best
and so we can consider an example let's
say that we want to find the
relationship between the temperature
outside versus the sales of ice cream
and so we start looking at that we're
looking at the how many ice cream cones
we're selling or how much money we sold
in ice cream and we're looking at how
warm it is outside which would hopefully
draw a lot of people into the ice cream
store
and suppose we have two lines we're
going to draw l1 and l2 and we're going
to kind of guess which one we think is
the best fit
and which claim to describe the
relationship between the variables
and so first we find the square of the
distance between the line l1
and each data point and add them all and
find the mean distance
and i want you to think about that when
we
uh square something if it's a negative
or positive number it no longer matters
because a minus 2 squared is 4 2 squared
is 4. so we're removing what side of the
line it's on and we're just looking for
the error in this case the mean distance
of each of the little dotted lines you
see here
this way of calculating the square of
the distance adding them and then taking
the mean is called mean square error or
loss function
and we talk about loss how far off are
we that's what we're really talking
about what did we miss when we have a
positive distance and a negative
distance and of course when we square it
it is neither it just becomes a positive
error
and so we take the mean
square error and a lot of times you'll
see it referred to as mse
if i look in a code and i'm going
through my python code and i see mse i
know that's a mean squared error
and we take all the dotted lines and we
calculate this error we add them all
together and then we average it or find
the means
and in this case
they ran a demo on this and it was uh
1127.27
for our l1 line
now we find the loss function for line
l2 in a similar fashion and we get the
mean square error to be 6397
and it's computed the same way so maybe
you put this line just way outside the
data range and this is the error you get
by analyzing our results we find that
the loss function or the mean square
error is less for l1 than l2 hence l1 is
the best fit line
this process describes a lot of machine
learning processes it is we're going to
keep guessing and get as close as we can
to find the right answer we have to have
some way to invite to
calculate this and figure out which
one's the best and the mean square error
is one of the better fits to doing for
doing this and most commonly used
we really want to talk about bias and
variance
very important terms to know in machine
learning
and with linear regression
so bias
bias occurs when an algorithm has
limited flexibility to learn from data
variance defines the algorithm's
sensitivity to specific sets of data
let's start with bias and variance you
can see here we have the two different
setups
bias you can think is very generalized
where variance is very specific
and so we talk about bias such models
pay very little attention to the
training data and over simplify the
model
therefore the validation error or
prediction error and training error
follow similar trends
and uh with bias if you oversimplify it
so much you're going to miss
your
local if if you have like a really
good fit you're going to miss it you're
you're going to just kind of
guess what the average is and that's
what your answer is going to be
with variance a model with a high
variance pays a lot of attention to
training data and does not generalize
therefore the validation error or
prediction error are far apart from each
other
such models always lead to a high error
on training and test data as a bias does
where variants such models usually
perform very well on training data but
have high error rates on test data
and i want you to think about this um
when we're talking about a bias
the error is going to be high both when
you're training it and you're testing it
why because we're just kind of
getting an average we're not really
fitting it close
with variance we're fitting it so close
that the test data does really good it's
going to nail it every time if you're
doing categorical testing that's a car
that's a truck that's a bicycle
but with variants
suddenly a
truck has to have certain features
and it might have to be red uh because
you had so many red pictures so if it
has if it's an 18 wheeler it has to be
red if it's blue then it has to be a
bicycle
that's the kind of variance we're
talking about where it picks up on
something and it it cannot get the right
answer unless it gets a very specific
data
and we see that so that as you're
testing it your models
and you programmed it you got to look
for how i trained it what is coming out
and if it's not if it's not looking good
on either bias or if it's not looking
good on the training or on the test data
then your bias then you're biasing your
data
if it really looks good on the training
data then that's going to be your
variance you've over fitted the data
and those are very important things to
know when you are building your models
in regression of any kind or any kind of
setup for predicting
so in dark games if all the data found a
particular pointer this can be
considered as a biased throw and the
player aims for the particular score
for variance if all the darts fall on
different pointers and no two darts fall
on the same pointer then this can be
considered as a varied throw and the
player aims for various scores
again the bias sums everything up in one
point kind of averages it together where
the variance really looks for the
individual
predictions coming out
so let's go ahead and talk about
overfitting uh when we talk about
overfitting it's a scenario where the
machine learning model tries to learn
from the details along with the noise
and the data tries to fit each data
point on the curve
you can see that
if you plug in your coordinates you're
just going to get the whatever is fitted
every point on the data stream there's
no average there's no
two points that might have that you know
why might have two different answers
because
if the wind blows a certain way
in the efficiency of your car maybe you
have a headwind
so your car might alter how efficient it
is as it goes and so there's going to be
this variance on here and this says no
you can't have any variance with you
know the this is it's going to be
exactly this it can't be any you can't
be the same speed or the same car and
have a slightly different efficiency
so as the model has very less
flexibility it fails to predict new data
points and thus the model rejects every
new data point during the prediction
uh so you'll get like a really high
error on here
and so uh reasons for overfitting
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage values in it
you can spend so much time cleaning your
data
and it's so important it's so important
that if you have if you have some kind
of
something wrong with the data coming in
it needs to be addressed whether it's a
source of the data maybe they use in
medical different measuring tools
so you now have to adjust for data that
came in from hospital a versus hospital
b or even off of machine a and machine b
is testing something and those those
numbers are coming in wrong
the model has a high variance
again wind is a good example i was
talking about that with the car you may
have 100 tests but because the wind's
blowing it's all over the place
size of training data used is not enough
so a small amount of data is going to
also cause this problem you only have a
few points and you try to plot
everything
the model is too complex
this comes up a lot
we put too many pieces together and how
they interact can't even be tracked
and so you have to go back back break it
up and find out actually what correlates
and what doesn't
so
what is underfitting a scenario where
machine learning models
can either learn
the relationship between the data points
nor predict
or classify a new data point
and you can see here we have our
efficiency of our car and our line drawn
and it's just going to be way off for
both the training and the predicting
data
as the model doesn't fully learn the
patterns it accepts every new data point
during the prediction
so instead of looking for a general
pattern we just kind of accept
everything
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage and values
again under fitting and overfitting same
issue you got to clean your data
the model has a high bias
we've seen this in all kinds of things
from uh the mod the most common is the
driving cars to facial identification or
whatever it is the model itself when
they build it might have a bias towards
one thing and this would be an
underfitted model would have that bias
because it's averaged it out so if you
have
five people from india and 10 people
from
africa and 20 people from the u.s you
created a bias
because it's looking at the 20 people
and you only have a small amount of data
to work with
size of training data used is not enough
that goes with the size i was just
talking about
so we have a model with a high bias we
have size of training data used it's not
enough
the model is too simple
again this is one straight line through
all the data when it needs a slight
shift to it for other reasons
so what is a good fit
uh a linear curve that best fits the
data is neither overfitting or
underfitting models but is just right
and of course we have the nice examples
here where we have overfitting
lines going up and down every point is
trying to be include included
underfitting
the line really is off from where the
data is and then a good fit is got to
get rid of that minimize that
error coming through regularization is
taking the guesswork out you're looking
at this graph and you're going oh which
one is that really over fit or is that
under fit that's pretty hard to tell
so we talk about regularization
regularization techniques are used to
calibrate the linear regression models
and to minimize the adjusted loss
function and prevent overfitting or
under fitting
so what that means in this case we're
going to go ahead and take a look at a
couple different things we're going to
look at regularization which we'll start
with a linear model we'll look at the
ridge regularization and the lasso
regularization
and these models are just like just like
we did the
mlp the multi-layered positron in the sk
learn module you could bring in the
ridge module and you can bring in the
lasso module
so when we talk about
ridge regression it modifies the
overfitted or underfitted models by
adding the penalty equivalent to the sum
of the squares of the magnitude of the
coefficients
and so we have a cost function equals
loss equals
lambda times the sum of w
squared or the absolute value of w
depending on how you're doing it now
remember we talked about error whether
we either square it or we absolute value
it
because that removes a plus or minus
sign on there and there's reasons to do
it either way but it is more common to
square the value
and then we have our
in this case the lambda is going to be
the penalty for the errors we've thrown
in a greek character for you just to
confuse everybody
and w is the slope of the curve of the
line
so
we're going to look at this and we're
going to draw a line this is going to be
like a linear regression model so if you
had in sklearn you could import just a
standard linear regression model
it would plot this line across whatever
data we're working on
and we look at this of course we're just
extrapolating this i know they use some
specific data but don't want to get into
the actual domain
and so for a linear regression line
let's consider two points that are on
the line
and we'll go ahead and have a loss
equals zero uh considering the two
points on the line we'll go and do
lambda equals one we'll set our w is
going to be one point four
then the cost function equals 0 plus
1 times 1.4 squared which equals 1.96
so
really don't get caught up too much in
the math on this other than
understanding
that this is something that's very easy
for a computer to calculate and if you
ever see the loss plus the plus the
lambda times w the sum of w squared
and then let's say we have a ridge
regression line and it does this we go
ahead and plot it and we do the
calculations on the data
and for the ridge regression let's
assume a loss equals 0.3 squared plus
0.2 squared equals 0.13 so when they put
all the calculations through
of the two points we end up with the
point
0.62
so we've now had a linear regression
model we now had a ridge regression
model
and the ridge regression model plots a
little differently than the standard
linear regression model
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
ridge regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and i find this true on a lot of data i
work with i'll end up using either the
ridge regression model or the lasso mars
regression model for fitting especially
dealing with a lot of like stock markets
daily
setup they come out slightly better you
get a slightly better
fit
and so we have our lasso we just talked
about lasso coming in here
and the cost function equals
instead of doing a squared we're just
going to do the absolute value and so if
you remember this is where ridge
regression changes where's my ridge
regression model uh we're squaring the
value here
and if you look at this we're not
squaring the value we're just finding
the absolute value on here and so the
loss of this of the squared individuals
and here is our
lambda symbol again penalty for errors
and w equals the slope of the curve
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
lasso regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and this is like i said i use these two
models a lot uh the ridge and this is
important this is
this is kind of the meat of the matter
how do you know which one to use some of
it is you just do it a bunch of times
and then you figure it out
uh ridge regularization is useful when
we have many variables with relatively
smaller data samples
the bottle does not encourage
conversions towards zero but is likely
to make them closer to zero and prevent
overfitting
the lasser regularization model is
preferred when we are fitting a linear
model with fewer variables
so in the la in the iris thing we had
four or five variables as you measure
the different leaf pieces uh you might
be doing the measurements on the cancer
project which has 36 different variables
um so as we get down to the iris with
four variables
lasso lar will probably work pretty good
where you might use the ridge
regularization with more model with if
you have something significantly larger
and it encourages the coefficients of
the variables to go towards zero because
of the shape of the constraint which is
an absolute value
and with any of this we want to go ahead
and
do a demo and lasso and ridge regression
so let's take a look and see what that
looks like in our code and bring up our
jupiter notebook
we'll start with our imports pandas is
pd import numpy is np import matplot
library is
sk plt
we're going to import our data sets it's
kind of more generic
we usually just import one data set
instead of all of them but you know
quick and dirty when you're putting some
of these together
we have our sklearn model selection
we're going to import our train test
split for splitting our data up
and then we'll bring in our linear
regression model
and we'll go ahead and run these just to
load them up
and then load our data set we're just
talking about that
you could just
have imported the load boston and boston
data set in there instead of loading all
the data sets
and then once we've loaded our data set
we want to go ahead and take a look at
that data and see what we got here
let me just go ahead and pop that down
there and go and run it
and so we've gone ahead and taken our
boston
data we're going to load we put it into
our pandas data frame
the boston data set and then the boston
columns we want to see what's going on
with them
we have our target
we have the house price
etc and so our x equals boston
eye location
now remember in pandas the new updates
to pandas they want eye location if
you're going to pull data we used to be
able to leave this off
but it does something different it
creates a slice versus a direct
setup so make sure using that eye
location and the i the output so this is
all just bringing our data together
and we can see here if we do we print
the boston
panda's head
we can see here all of our different
aspects we're looking for
and if you're following the x and the y
the x is
everything
except for the last column where y is uh
all the it's that's what this means all
the rows except for the last column and
then y is all the rows but just the last
column so y is our house price
and the x is the
crimson industry chas knox and all these
other different
statistics they've collected for house
sales in boston
there we go oops control
so we'll go ahead and split our data
x train and our x
test y train y test equals the train
test split which we imported
and we have our boston you could have
easily used the x and y on here as
opposed to boston
eye location
and we'll create our test size we're
going to take 25 percent of the data and
put it in as a test
and then we'll go ahead and run this
uh
i need an extra drink there
uh so we have our train and test and
then of course the print the train data
shape
i love doing this kind of thing whenever
i'm working with this data print out the
shape
make sure everything looks correct uh so
that we have 127 by 13 and 127 by one
379 by 13 they should match and if
they're if the the data sets are not
quite matching
then you know something's wrong and
you're going to get all those errors i
don't know how many times i've gone
through here and
it's dropped a row on one of them and
not on the other or something weird just
happened when i'm cleaning the data this
is pretty straightforward and simple
because the data comes in a nice
pre-package is all clean for you
so let's go ahead and apply apply the
multiple linear regression model
we'll call this l r e g l reg linear
regression and we're going to go ahead
and fit that linear regression model to
x train and y train
then we'll generate the prediction on
the test set
so here's our l reg y predict
with our x test going into the
prediction
and let's calculate that mean square
error mse i told you you'll see mse used
a lot
people use it in variables and things
like that it's pretty common and we get
our mean squared error equals
this is just the basic formula we've
already been talking about what's the
difference squared
and then we look for the average of that
we'll go ahead and just run this
and you can see when we get through the
end of this we have our mean square
error on test
we have our total and then we have each
column coming down
and at this point unless you really know
the data you're working with it's not
going to mean a whole lot so if it's in
your domain you might be know what
you're looking at when you see these
kinds of numbers coming up
uh but if it's not it's just a bunch of
numbers and that's okay
at least that's okay for this demo uh
and then we're gonna go ahead and plot
these so we can see what's going on
and this is always kind of fun it's
always nice to have a nice visual of
what you're looking at and you can see
here um we plot the coefficient scores
on here
and we
the guys in the back did a great job
putting some pretty colors together
making it look nice and setting up the
columns
you can see here
uh your nox has like just a huge
coefficient
when i look at a table like this i look
for what has very little
different coefficients they're not using
a huge change and what has huge changes
and that flags you for all kinds of
things as you're working with the data
but it depends so much on the domain
you're working with
these are great things though as just a
quick look to see what's going on with
your data and what you're looking for
and of course once we look at this
now our motive is to reduce the
coefficient score so now we want to take
these and and
uh bring them down as much as we can
and for that we're going to work with
the ridge regression on here
so let's start by going and we're going
to import our ridge model
the rid regression from the sk learn
library or the scikit
and we're going to go ahead and train
the model so here's our ridge
r equals alpha equals one and i
mentioned that earlier
when i work with the ridge model
you'll see alpha equals one if you set
alpha equal to zero that's a standard
linear regression model so you have
alpha equals one two three four and you
usually use 1 2 or 3 4 and a standard
integer on there
and we'll go ahead and fit the ridge
model on there with our x train and our
y train data
generate a prediction for that
for our x test
and we'll calculate the mean square
error
just like we did before this all look
familiar
and we'll go ahead and print that out
and we'll look at the ridge coefficients
for our data and see what that looks
like
now if i jump up and down between these
two
you'll get a headache ah
you'll still see the knox value let's
just look at the knocks because that was
the biggest value it's a minus nine here
and if we go back up here the nox value
is a minus 18. so right off the bat i'm
seeing a huge change
in the biggest coefficient there
so if we're going to do that nice setup
we want to go ahead and just print it
and see what that looks like
here we go and we've
set up our plot subplots and again the
team put together some nice colors so it
makes it look good
we're doing an x bar based on the
columns
and our l regress coefficients color
equals color x spine bottom and so forth
so just put together a nice little graph
and you're starting to see
one this when you compare this if you
put on the same graph as this one up
here this is up here minus 18.
this is at minus nine
and so this graph is half the size of
the graph above
the same thing with these values here
they might look the same but they're
actually all
almost half the value on here
and then finally you can do the same
thing for the lasso regression
this would all look very similar as far
as what we worked on before
and i'm just going to print that on here
and run it and again let's go up to uh
knox
look where nox is it's all the way down
to zero
and if we look at our next biggest
coefficient it's minus 0.8 and really
here's our 22.73
let me go up here
um
16.7
and we go up here and we look at the
same number
uh 16.69
and so we look at this uh if i was
running this and doing a working on a
project with this i would look at these
numbers i start with the 16.69
come down here and compare it to
16.78 six nine is better than seven
eight uh so from the very beginning we
might start looking at this first model
for overall
predicting
but there's other factors involved we
might know that
the knocked value is central and the
other ones aren't quite as good and so
we might start looking at just certain
setups like what is our what is this
particular coefficient because it might
have a certain meaning to us and so
forth and so you look at all those
different
items in there again but the bottom
dollar is our first model did better
than our other two models our mean
square error on the test set
continues to
come down on this
ever wondered how google translates an
entire web page to a different language
in a matter of seconds or your phone
gallery group's images based on their
location all of this is a product of
deep learning but what exactly is deep
learning deep learning is a subset of
machine learning which in turn is a
subset of artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence is a technique
that enables a machine to mimic human
behavior
machine learning is a technique to
achieve ai through algorithms trained
with data and finally deep learning is a
type of machine learning inspired by the
structure of the human brain in terms of
deep learning this structure is called
an artificial neural network let's
understand deep learning better and how
it's different from machine learning say
we create a machine that could
differentiate between tomatoes and
cherries if done using machine learning
we'd have to tell the machine the
features based on which the two can be
differentiated these features could be
the size and the type of stim on them
with deep learning on the other hand the
features are picked out by the neural
network without human intervention of
course that kind of independence comes
at the cost of having a much higher
volume of data to train our machine
now let's dive into the working of
neural networks
here we have three students each of them
write down the digit nine on a piece of
paper
notably they don't all write it
identically the human brain can easily
recognize the digits
but what if a computer had to recognize
them
that's where deep learning comes in
here's a neural network trained to
identify handwritten digits
each number is present as an image of 28
times 28 pixels
now that amounts to a total of 784
pixels neurons the core entity of a
neural network is where the information
processing takes place
each of the 784 pixels is fed to a
neuron in the first layer of our neural
network
this forms the input layer
on the other end we have the output
layer with each neuron representing a
digit with the hidden layers existing
between them
the information is transferred from one
layer to another over connecting
channels
each of these has a value attached to it
and hence is called a weighted channel
all neurons have a unique number
associated with it called bias
this bias is added to the weighted sum
of inputs reaching the neuron which is
then applied to a function known as the
activation function
the result of the activation function
determines if the neuron gets activated
every activated neuron passes on
information to the following layers
this continues until the second last
layer
the one neuron activated in the output
layer corresponds to the input digit the
weights and bias are continuously
adjusted to produce a well-trained
network so where is deep learning
applied in customer support when most
people converse with customer support
agents the conversation seems so real
they don't even realize that it's
actually a bot on the other side in
medical care neural networks detect
cancer cells and analyze mri images to
give detailed results self-driving cars
what seem like science fiction is now a
reality apple tesla and nissan are only
a few of the companies working on
self-driving cars so deep learning has a
vast scope but it too faces some
limitations the first as we discussed
earlier is data while deep learning is
the most efficient way to deal with
unstructured data a neural network
requires a massive volume of data to
train let's assume we always have access
to the necessary amount of data
processing this is not within the
capability of every machine and that
brings us to our second limitation
computational power training in neural
network requires graphical processing
units which have thousands of cores as
compared to cpus and gpus are of course
more expensive and finally we come down
to training time deep neural networks
take hours or even months to train the
time increases with the amount of data
and number of layers in the network so
here's a short quiz for you arrange the
following statements in order to
describe the working of a neural network
a the bias is added b the weighted sum
of the inputs is calculated c specific
neuron is activated d the result is fed
to an activation function some of the
popular deep learning frameworks include
tensorflow pytorch keras deep learning
4j cafe and microsoft cognitive toolkit
considering the future predictions for
deep learning and ai we seem to have
only scratched the surface in fact horus
technology is working on a device for
the blind that uses deep learning with
computer vision to describe the world to
the users replicating the human mind at
the entirety may be not just an episode
of science fiction for too long the
future is indeed full of surprises
welcome to this tutorial on deep
learning now there are several
applications of deep learning really
very interesting and innovative
applications and one of them is
identifying the geographic location
based on a picture and how does this
work the way it works is pretty much we
train an artificial neural network with
millions of images which are tagged
their geolocation is tagged and then
when we feed a new picture it will be
able to identify the geolocation of this
new image for example you have all these
images especially with maybe some
significant monuments or
significant locations and you train with
millions of such images and then when
you feed another image it need not be
exactly one of those that you have
claimed it can be completely different
that is the whole idea of training it
will be able to recognize for example
that this is a picture from paris
because it is able to recognize the
eiffel tower so the way it works
internally if we have to look a little
bit under the herd as these images are
nothing but this is digital information
in the form of pixels so each image
could be a certain size it can be 256 by
256 pixel kind of a resolution and then
each pixel is either having a certain
grade of color and all that is fed into
the neural network and it then gets
trained in and it's able to based on
these pixels pixel information it is
able to get trained and able to
recognize the features and extract the
features and thereby it is able to
identify these images and the location
of these images and then when you feed a
new image it kind of based on the
training it will be able to figure out
where this image is from so that's the
way a little bit under the hood how it
works so what are we going to do in this
tutorial we will see what is deep
learning and what do we need for deep
learning and one of the main components
of deep learning is neural network so we
will see what is neural network what is
a perceptron and how to implement logic
gates like and or nor and so on using
perceptrons the different types of
neural networks and then applications of
deep learning and we will also see how
neural networks
work so how do we do the training of
neural networks and at the end we will
end up with a small demo code
which will take you through in
tensorflow now in order to implement
deep learning code there are multiple
libraries or development environments
that are available and tensorflow is one
of them so the focus at the end of this
would be on how to use tensorflow to
write a piece of code using python as a
programming language and we will take up
an example which is a very common one
which is like the hello world of deep
learning the handwriting number
recognition which is a mnist commonly
known as mnist database so we will take
a look at mnist database and how we can
train a neural network to recognize
handwritten numbers so that's what you
will see
in this particular
video so let's get started what is deep
learning deep learning is like a subset
of what is known as a high level concept
called artificial intelligence you must
be already familiar must have heard
about this term artificial intelligence
so artificial intelligence is like the
high level concept if you will and in
order to implement artificial
intelligence applications we use what is
known as machine learning and within
machine learning a subset of machine
learning is deep learning machine
learning is a little bit more
generic concept and deep learning is one
type of machine learning if you will and
we will see a little later in maybe the
following slides a little bit more in
detail how deep learning is different
from traditional machine learning but to
start with we can mention here that deep
learning uses one of the differentiators
between deep learning and traditional
machine learning is that deep learning
uses neural networks and we will talk
about what are neural networks and how
we can implement neural networks and so
on and so forth as a part of this
tutorial so a little deeper into deep
learning deep learning primarily
involves working with complicated
unstructured data compared to
traditional machine learning with where
we normally use structured data in deep
learning the data would be primarily
images or voice or maybe text file so
and it is large amount of data as well
and deep learning can handle complex
operations it involves complex
operations and the other difference
between traditional machine learning and
deep learning is that the feature
extraction happens pretty much
automatically in traditional machine
learning feature engineering is done
manually the data scientists we data
scientists have to do feature
engineering feature extraction but in
deep learning that happens automatically
and of course deep learning for large
amounts of data complicated unstructured
data deep learning gives very good
performance now as i mentioned one of
the secret
sources of deep learning is neural
networks let's see what neural networks
is neural networks is based on our
biological
neurons the whole concept of deep
learning and artificial intelligence is
based on human brain and human brain
consists of billions of tiny stuff
called neurons and this is how a
biological
neuron looks and this is how an
artificial neuron look so neural
networks is like a simulation of our
human brain human brain has
billions of biological neurons and we
are trying to simulate the human brain
using artificial neurons this is how a
biological neuron looks it has dendrites
and the corresponding component with an
artificial neural network is or an
artificial neuron are the inputs they
receive the inputs through dendrites and
then there is the cell nucleus which is
basically the processing unit in a way
so in artificial neuron also there is a
piece which is an equivalent of this
cell nucleus and based on the weights
and biases we will see what exactly
weights in biases are as we move the
input gets processed and that results in
an output in a biological neuron the
output is sent through a synapse and in
an artificial neuron there is an
equivalent of that in the form of an
output and biological neurons are also
interconnected so there are billions of
neurons which are interconnected in the
same way artificial neurons are also
interconnected so this output of this
neuron will be fed as an input to
another neuron and so on now in neural
network one of the very basic
units is a perceptron so what is a
perceptron a perceptron can be
considered as one of the fundamental
units of neural networks it can consist
at least one neuron but sometimes it can
be more than one neuron but you can
create a perceptron with a single neuron
and it can be used to perform certain
functions it can be used as a basic
binary classifier it can be trained to
do some basic binary classification and
this is how a basic perceptron looks
like and this is nothing but a neuron
you have inputs x 1 x 2 x 2 x n and
there is a summation function and then
there is what is known as an activation
function and based on this input what is
known as the weighted sum the activation
function either gets gives an output
like a zero or a one so we say the
neuron is either activated or not so
that's the way it works so you get the
inputs these inputs are each of the
inputs are multiplied by a weight and
there is a bias that gets added and that
whole thing is fed to an activation
function and then that results in an
output and if the output is correct it
is accepted if it is wrong if there is
an error then that error is fed back and
the neuron then adjusts the weights and
biases to give a new output and so on
and so forth so that's what is known as
the training process of a neuron or a
neural network there's a concept called
perceptron learning so perceptron
learning is again one of the very basic
learning processes the way it works
is somewhat like this so you have all
these inputs like x1 to xn and each of
these inputs is multiplied by a weight
and then that sum this is the formula of
the equation so that sum w i x
sigma of that which is a sum of all
these product of x and w is added up and
then a bias is added to that the bias is
not dependent on the input but are the
input values but the bias is common for
one neuron however the bias value keeps
changing during the training process
once the training is completed the
values of these weights w1 w2 and so on
and the value of the bias gets fixed so
that is basically the whole training
process and that is what is known as the
perceptron training so the weights and
biases keep changing till you get the
accurate output and the summation is of
course passed through the activation
function as you see here this w i x i
summation plus b
is passed through activation function
and then the neuron gets either fired or
not and based on that there will be an
output that output is compared with the
actual or expected value which is also
known as labeled information this is the
process of supervised learning so the
output is already known and
that is compared and thereby we know if
there is an error or not and if there is
an error the error is fed back and the
weights and biases are updated
accordingly till the error is reduced to
the minimum so this iterative process
is
known as perceptron learning or
perceptron learning rule and this error
needs to be minimized so till the error
is minimized
this iteratively the weights and biases
keep changing and that is what is the
training process so the whole idea is to
update the weights and the bias of the
perceptron till the error is minimized
the error need not be zero the error may
not ever reach zero but the idea is to
keep changing these weights and bias so
that the error is minimum the minimum
possible that it can have so this whole
process is an iterative process and this
is the iteration continues till either
the error is zero which is uh unlikely
situation or it is the minimum possible
within these given conditions now in
1943 two scientists warren mcculloch and
walter pitts came up with an experiment
where they were able to implement the
logical functions like and or and nor
using neurons and that was a significant
breakthrough in a sense so they were
able to come up with the most common
logical gates they were able to
implement some of the most common
logical gates which could take two
inputs like a and b and then
give a corresponding result so for
example in case of an and gate a
and b and then the output is a b in case
of an or gate it is a plus b and so on
and so forth and they were able to do
this using a single
layer perceptron now most of these gates
it was possible to use single layer
perceptron except for xor and we will
see why that is in a little bit so this
is how an and gate works the inputs a
and b the output should be fired or the
neuron should be fired only when both
the inputs are one so if you have zero
zero the output should be zero for zero
one it is again zero one zero again zero
and one one the output should be
one so how do we implement this with a
neuron so it was found that by changing
the values of weights it is possible to
achieve this logic so for example if we
have equal weights like 0.7 0.7 and then
if we take the sum of the weighted
products so for example 0.7 into 0 and
then 0.7 into 0 will give you 0 and so
on and so forth and in the last case
when both the inputs are 1 you get a
value which is greater than 1 which is
the threshold so only in this case the
neuron gets activated and the output is
there is an output in all the other
cases there is no output because the
threshold value is one so this is
implementation of an and gate using a
single perceptron or a single neuron
similarly an or gate in order to
implement an or gate in case of an or
gate the output will be one if either of
these inputs is one so for example zero
one will result in one or other in all
the cases it is one except for zero zero
so how do we implement this using a
perceptron once again if you have a
perceptron with weights for example 1.2
now if you see here if in the first case
when both are 0 the output is 0. in the
second case when it is 0 and 1 1.2 into
0 is 0 and then 1.2 into 1 is 1. and in
the second case similarly the output is
1.2 in the last case when both the
inputs are 1 the output is 2.4 so during
the training process these weights will
keep changing and then at one point
where the weights are equal to w1 is
equal to 1.2 and w2 is equal to 1.2 the
system learns that it gives the correct
output so that is implementation of or
gate using a single neuron or a single
layer perceptron now xor gate this was
one of the challenging ones they tried
to implement an xor gate with a single
level perceptron but it was not possible
and therefore in order to implement an
xor so this was like a a roadblock in
the progress of
neural network however subsequently they
realize that this can be implemented an
xor gate can be implemented using
a multi-level perceptron or mlp so in
this case there are two layers instead
of a single layer and this is how you
can implement an xor gate so you will
see that x1 and x2 are the inputs and
there is a hidden layer and that's why
it is denoted as h3 and h4 and then you
take the output of that and feed it to
the output at 05 and provide a threshold
here so we will see here that this is
the numerical calculation so the weights
are in this case for x1 it is 20 and
minus 20 and once again 20 and minus 20.
so these inputs are fed into h3 and h4
so you'll see here for h3 the input is 0
1 1 1 and for h4 it is 1 0 1 1 and if
you now look at the output final output
where the threshold is taken as one if
we use a sigmoid with the threshold one
you will see that in these two cases it
is zero and in the last two cases it is
one so this is the implementation of xor
in case of x or only when one of the
inputs is one you will get an output so
that is what we are seeing here if we
have either both the inputs are one or
both the inputs are 0 then the output
should be 0. so that is what is an
exclusive or gate so it is exclusive
because only one of the inputs should be
1 and then only you will get an output
of 1 which is satisfied by this
condition so this is a special
implementation xor gate is a special
implementation of perceptron now that we
got a good idea about perceptron let's
take a look at what is the neural
network so we have seen what is a
perceptron we have seen what is a neuron
so we will see what exactly is a neural
network so neural network is nothing but
a network of these neurons and they are
different types of neural networks there
are about five of them these are
artificial neural network convolutional
neural network than recursive neural
network or recurrent neural network deep
neural network and deep belief network
so and each of these types of neural
networks have a special you know they
can
solve special kind of problems for
example convolutional neural networks
are very good at performing image
processing and image recognition and so
on whereas rnn are very good for speech
recognition and also text analysis and
so on so each type has some special
characteristics and they can they're
good at performing certain special kind
of tasks what are some of the
applications of deep learning deep
learning is today used extensively in
gaming you must have heard about alphago
which is a game created by a startup
called deepmind which got acquired by
google and alphago is an ai which
defeated the human world champion lee
sedol in this game of go so gaming is an
area where deep learning is being
extensively used and a lot of
research happens in the area of gaming
as well in addition to that nowadays
there are neural networks a special type
called generative adversarial networks
which can be used for synthesizing
either images or music or text and so on
and they can be used to compose music so
the neural network can be trained to
compose a certain kind of music and
autonomous cars you must be familiar
with google google's self-driving car
and today a lot of automotive companies
are investing in this space and deep
learning is a core component of this
autonomous cars the cars are trained to
recognize for example the road
the lane markings on the road
signals
any objects that are in front any
obstruction and so on and so forth so
all this involves deep learning so
that's another major application and
robots we have seen several robots
including sofia you may be familiar with
sophia who was given a citizenship by
saudi arabia and there are several such
robots which are very human like and the
underlying technology in many of these
robots is deep learning medical
diagnostics and health care is another
major area where deep learning is being
used and within healthcare diagnostics
again there are multiple areas where
deep learning and image recognition
image processing can be used for example
for cancer detection as you may be aware
if cancer is detected early on it can be
cured and one of the challenges is in
the availability of specialists who can
diagnose cancer using these diagnostic
images and various scans and and so on
and so forth so the idea is to train
neural network to perform some of these
activities so that the load on the
cancer specialist doctors or oncologists
comes down and there is a lot of
research happening here and there are
already quite a few applications that
are claimed to be performing better than
human beings in this space can be
lung cancer it can be breast cancer and
so on and so forth so health care is a
major area where deep learning is being
applied let's take a look at the inner
working of a neural network so how does
an artificial neural network let's say
identify can we train a neural network
to identify the shapes like squares and
circles and triangles when these images
are fed so this is how it works any
image is nothing but it is a digital
information of the pixels so in this
particular case let's say this is an
image of 28 by 28 pixel and this is an
image of a square there's a certain way
in which the pixels are lit up and so
these pixels have a certain value maybe
from 0 to 256 and 0 indicates that it is
black or it is dark and 256 indicates it
is completely it is white or lit up so
that is like an indication or a measure
of the how the pixels are lit up and so
this is an image is let's say consisting
of information of
784 pixels so all the information what
is inside this image can be kind of
compressed into this 784 pixels the way
each of these pixels is lit up provides
information about what exactly is the
image so
we can train neural networks to use that
information and identify the images so
let's take a look how this works so each
neuron the value if it is close to one
that means it is white whereas if it is
close to zero that means it is black now
this is a an animation of how this whole
thing works so these pixels one of the
ways of doing it is we can flatten
this image and take this complete 784
pixels and feed that as input to our
neural network the neural network can
consist of probably several layers there
can be a few hidden layers and then
there is an input layer and an output
layer now the input layer take the 784
pixels as input the values of each of
these pixels and then you get an output
which can be
of three types or three classes one can
be a square a circle or a triangle now
during the training process there will
be initially obviously you feed this
image and it will probably say it's a
circle or it will say it's a triangle so
as a part of the training process
we then send that error back and the
weights and the biases of these neurons
are adjusted till it correctly
identifies that this is a square that is
the whole training mechanism that
happens out here
now let's take a look at a circle same
way
so you feed these 784 pixels there is a
certain pattern in which the pixels are
lit up
and the neural network is trained to
identify that pattern
and during the training process once
again it would probably initially
identify it incorrectly saying this is a
square or a triangle and then that error
is fed back
and the weights and biases are adjusted
finally till it finally gets the image
correct
so that is the training process so now
we will take a look at
same way a triangle
so now if you feed another image which
is consisting of triangles so this is
the training process now we have trained
our neural network to classify these
images into
a triangle or a circle and a square so
now this neural network can
identify these three types of objects
now if you feed another image and it
will be able to identify whether it's a
square or a triangle or a circle now
what is important to be
observed is that
when you feed a new image it is not
necessary that
the image or the
the triangle is exactly in this position
now the neural network actually
identifies the patterns so even if the
triangle is let's say positioned here
not exactly in the middle but maybe at
the corner or in the side it would still
identify that it is a triangle and that
is the whole idea behind pattern
recognition so how does this training
process work this is a quick view of how
the training process works so we have
seen that a neuron consists of inputs it
receives inputs and then there is a
weighted sum which is nothing but this x
i wi summation of that plus the
bias and this is then fed to the
activation function and that in turn
gives us a output now during the
training process initially obviously
when you feed these images when you send
maybe a square it will identify it as a
triangle and when you maybe feed a
triangle it will identify as a square
and so on so that error information is
fed back and initially these weights can
be random maybe all of them have zero
values and then it will slowly keep
changing so the as a part of the
training process the values of these
weights w1 w2 up to wn keep changing in
such a way that towards the end of the
training process it should be able to
identify these images correctly so till
then the weights are adjusted and that
is known as the training process so and
these weights are numeric values it
could be 0.5 0.25 0.35 and so on it
could be positive or it could be
negative and the value that is coming
here is the pixel value as we have seen
it can be anything between 0 to 1 you
can scale it between 0 to 1 or 0 to 256
whichever way 0 being black and 256
being white and then all the other
colors in between so that is the input
so these are numerical values this
multiplication or the product w i x i is
a numerical value and the bias is also a
numerical value we need to keep in mind
that the bias is fixed for a neuron it
doesn't change with the inputs whereas
the weights are one per input so that is
one important point to be noted so but
the bias also keeps changing initially
it will again have a random value but as
a part of the training process the
weights the values of the weights w1 w2
wn and
the value of b
will change
and ultimately once the training process
is complete these values are fixed for
this particular neuron w1 w2 up to wn
and plus the value of the b is also
fixed for this particular neuron and in
this way there will be multiple neurons
and each there may be multiple levels of
neurons here and that's the way the
training process
works so this is another example of
multi-layer so there are two hidden
layers in between and then you have the
input layer values coming from the input
layer then it goes through multiple
layers hidden layers and then there is
an output layer and as you can see there
are weights and biases for each of these
neurons in each layer and all of them
gets keeps changing during the training
process and at the end of the training
process all these weights have a certain
value and that is a trained model and
those values will be fixed once the
training is completed all right then
there is something known as activation
function neural networks consists of one
of the components in neural networks is
activation function and every neuron has
an activation function and there are
different types of activation functions
that are used it could be a relu it
could be sigmoid and so on and so forth
and the activation function is what
decides whether a neuron should be fired
or not so whether the output should be 0
or 1 is decided by the activation
function and the activation function in
turn takes the input which is the
weighted sum you remember we talked
about w i x i plus b that weighted sum
is fed as an input to the activation
function and then the output can be
either a zero or a one and there are
different types of activation functions
which are covered in an earlier video
you might want to watch all right so as
a part of the training process we feed
the inputs the label data or the
training data and then it gives an
output which is the predicted output by
the network which we indicate as y hat
and then there is a labeled data because
we for supervised learning we already
know what should be the output so that
is the actual output and in the initial
process before the training is complete
obviously there will be error so that is
measured by what is known as a cost
function so the difference between the
predicted output and the actual output
is the error and
the cost function can be defined in
different ways there are different types
of cost functions so in this case it is
like the average of the squares of the
error so
and then
all the errors are added which can
sometimes be called as sum of squares
sum of square errors or sse and that is
then fed as a feedback in what is known
as backward propagation or back
propagation and that helps in
the network adjusting the weights and
biases and so the weights and biases get
updated till this value the error value
or the cost function
is minimum now there is a optimization
technique which is used here called
gradient descent optimization and this
algorithm
works in a way that the error which is
the cost function
needs to be minimized so there's a lot
of mathematics that goes behind this for
example they find the local minimum the
global minima using
the differentiation and so on and so
forth but the idea is this so as a
training process as a part of training
the whole idea is to
bring down the error which is like let's
say this is the function the cost
function at certain levels it is very
high the cost value of the cost function
the output of the cost function is very
high so the weights have to be adjusted
in such a way and also the bias of
course that the cost function is
minimized so there is this optimization
technique called gradient descent that
is used and this is known as the
learning rate now gradient descent
you need to specify what should be the
learning rate and the learning rate
should be optimal because if you have a
very high learning rate then the
optimization will not converge because
at some point it will cross over to the
side on the other hand if you have very
low learning rate then it might take
forever to convert so you need to come
up with the optimum value of the
learning rate and once that is done
using the gradient descent optimization
the error function
is reduced and that's like the end of
the training process all right so this
is another view of gradient descent so
this is how it looks this is your cost
function the output of the cost function
and that has to be minimized using
gradient descent algorithm and these are
like the parameters and weight could be
one of them so initially we start with
certain random values so cost will be
high and then the weights keep changing
and in such a way that the cost function
needs to come down and at some point it
may reach the minimum value and then it
may increase so that is where the
gradient descent algorithm decides that
okay it has reached a minimum value and
it will kind of try to stay here this is
known as the global
minima now sometimes these curves may
not be just for explanation purpose this
has been drawn in a nice way but
sometimes these curves can be pretty
erratic there can be some local minima
here and then there is a peak and then
and so on so the whole idea of gradient
descent optimization is to identify the
global minima and to find the weights
and the bias at that particular point so
that's what is gradient descent and then
this is another example so you can have
these multiple local minima so as you
can see at this point when it is coming
down it may appear like this is a
minimum value but then it is not this is
actually the global minimum value and
the gradient is an algorithm will make
an effort to reach this level and not
get stuck at this point so the algorithm
is already there and it knows how to
identify this global minimum and that's
what it does during the training process
now in order to implement deep learning
there are multiple platforms and
languages that are available but the
most common platform nowadays is
tensorflow and so that's the reason we
have this tutorial we have created this
tutorial for tensorflow so we will take
you through a quick demo of how to write
a tensorflow code using python and
tensorflow is
an open source platform created by
google so let's just take a look at the
details of tensorflow and so this is a
library a python library so you can use
python or any other languages it's also
supported in other languages like java
and r and so on but python is the most
common language that is used so
it is a library for
developing
deep learning applications especially
using neural networks and it consists of
primarily two parts if you will so one
is the tensors and then the other is the
graphs or the flow that's the way the
name that's the reason for this kind of
a name called tensorflow so what are
tensor sensors are like
multi-dimensional
arrays if you will that's one way of
looking at it so
usually you have a one-dimensional array
so first of all you can have what is
known as a scalar which means a number
and then you have a one-dimensional
array something like this which means
this like a set of numbers so that is a
one dimension array then you can have a
two dimensional array which is like a
matrix
and beyond that sometimes it gets
difficult so this is a three dimensional
array but tensorflow can handle many
more dimensions so it can have
multi-dimensional arrays that is the
strength of tensorflow and which makes
computation deep learning computation
much faster and that's the reason why
tensorflow is used for developing deep
learning applications so tensorflow is a
deep learning tool and this is the way
it works so the data basically flows in
the form of tensors and the way the
programming works as well is that you
first create a graph of how to execute
it and then you actually
execute that particular graph in the
form of what is known as a session we
will see this in the tensorflow code as
we move forward so all the data is
managed or manipulated in tensors and
then the processing happens using these
graphs there are certain terms called
like for example ranks of a tensor the
rank of a tensor is like a dimensional
dimensionality in a way so for example
if it is scalar so there is just a
number just a one number the rank is
supposed to be zero and then it can be a
one dimensional vector in which case the
rank is supposed to be one and then you
can have a two-dimensional
vector typically like a matrix then in
that case we say the rank is two and
then if it is a 3 dimensional array then
rank is 3 and so on so it can have more
than 3 as well so it is possible that
you can store
multi-dimensional arrays in the form of
tensors so what are some of the
properties of tensorflow i think today
it is one of the most popular
platform tensorflow is the most popular
deep learning platform or library
it is open source
it's developed by google developed and
maintained by google but it is open
source one of the most important things
about tensorflow is that it can run on
cpus as well as gpus gpu is a graphical
processing unit just like cpus central
processing unit now in earlier days gpu
was used for primarily for
graphics and that's how the name has
come and
one of the reasons is that it cannot
perform generic activities very
efficiently like cpu
but it can perform iterative actions or
computations extremely fast and much
faster than a cpu so they are really
good for computational activities and in
deep learning there is a lot of
iterative computation that happens so in
the form of matrix multiplication and so
on so gpus are very well suited for this
kind of computation and tensorflow
supports both gpu as well as cpu and
there's a certain way of writing code in
tensorflow we will see as we go into the
code and of course tensorflow can be
used for traditional machine learning as
well but then that would be an overkill
but just for understanding it may be a
good idea to start writing code for a
normal machine learning use case so that
you get a hang of how tensorflow code
works and then you can move into neural
networks so that is
just a suggestion but if you are already
familiar with how tensorflow works then
probably yeah you can go straight into
the neural networks part so in this
tutorial we will take the use case of
recognizing handwritten digits this is
like a hello world of deep learning and
this is a nice little mnist database is
a nice little database that has images
of handwritten digits nicely formatted
because very often in deep learning and
neural networks we end up spending a lot
of time in preparing the data for
training and with mnist database we can
avoid that you already have the data in
the right format which can be directly
used for training and mnist also offers
a bunch of
built-in utility functions that we can
straight away use and call those
functions without worrying about writing
our own functions and that's one of the
reasons why mnist database is very
popular for training purposes initially
when people want to learn about deep
learning and tensorflow this is the
database that is used and it has a
collection of 70 000 handwritten digits
and
a large part of them
are for training then you have test just
like in any machine learning process and
then you have validation and all of them
are labeled so you have the images and
their label and these images they look
somewhat like this so they are hand
written
images collected from a lot of
individuals people have
these are samples written by human
beings they have hand written these
numbers these numbers going from zero to
nine so people have written these
numbers and then the images of those
have been taken and formatted in such a
way that it is very easy to handle so
that is mnis database and the way we are
going to
implement this in our
tensorflow is we will feed this data
especially the training data along with
the label information and the data is
basically these images are stored in the
form of the pixel information as we have
seen in one of the previous slides all
the images are nothing but these are
pixels
so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training once the network is
trained when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler neural
network configurations called
softmax and for simplicity
what we will do is
we will flatten
these pixels so instead of taking them
in a two-dimensional arrangement we just
flatten them out so for example it
starts from here it is a 28 by 28 so
there are
784 pixels so pixel number one starts
here it goes all the way up to 28 then
29 starts here and goes up to 56 and so
on and the pixel number 784 is here so
we take all these pixels flatten them
out and feed them like one single line
into our
neural network and this is a what is
known as a soft max layer what it does
is once it is trained it will be able to
identify
what digit this is so there are in this
output layer there are 10
neurons each signifying a digit and at
any given point of time when you feed an
image only one of these 10 neurons gets
activated
so for example if this is trained
properly and if you feed
a number nine like this
then this particular neuron gets
activated so you get an output from this
neuron let me just use
a pen or a laser to show you here okay
so you're feeding the number nine let's
say this has been trained and now if
you're feeding a number nine this will
get
activated now let's say you fade
one to the trained
network then this neuron will get
activated if you feed two this neuron
will get activated and so on i hope you
get the idea so this is one type of a
neural network or an activation function
known as soft max layer so that's what
we will be using here this is one of the
simpler ones for
quick and easy understanding
so this is how the code would look we
will go into our lab environment in the
cloud and
we will show you there directly but very
quickly this is how the code looks and
let me run you through
briefly here and then we will go into
the jupiter notebook where the actual
code is and we will run that as well so
as a first step first of all we are
using python here and that's why the
syntax of the language is python and the
first step is to import the tensorflow
library so
and we do this by using this line of
code saying import tensorflow as tf tf
is just for convenience so you can name
give any name and once you do this tf is
tensorflow is available as an object in
the name of tf and then you can run its
methods and accesses its attributes and
so on and so forth and mnist database is
actually an integral part of tensorflow
and that's again another reason why we
as a first step we always use this
example mnist database example so you
just simply import mnist database as
well using this line of code and you
slightly modify this so that the labels
are in this format what is known as one
hot true which means that the label
information is stored like an array and
let me just
use pen to show what exactly it is so
when you do this one hot true what
happens is each label is stored in the
form of an array of
10 digits and let's say the number is
8 okay so in this case all the remaining
values there will be a bunch of zeros so
this is like array at position 0 this is
at position 1 position 2 and so on and
so forth let's say this is position 7
then this is position 8 that will be 1
because our input is 8 and again
position 9 will be 0. okay so one hot
encoding this one hot encoding true will
kind of
load the data in such a way that the
labels are in such a way that only one
of the digits has a value of one and
that indicates so based on which
digit is one we know what is the label
so in this case the eighth position is
one therefore we know this sample data
the value is eight similarly if you have
a 2 here let's say then the labeled
information will be somewhat like this
so you have your labels so you have this
as 0 the 0th position the first position
is also 0 the second position is one
because this indicates number two and
then you have third as zero and so on
okay so that is the significance of this
one hot true all right and then we can
check how the data is
looking by displaying the data and as i
mentioned earlier this is pretty much in
the form of digital form like numbers so
all these are like pixel values so you
will not really see an image in this
format but there is a way to
visualize that image i will show you in
a bit and this tells you how many images
are there in each set so the training
there are 55 000 images in training and
in the test set there are 10 000 and
then validation there are 5000 so all
together there are 70 000
images all right so let's
move on and we can
view the actual
image by
using the matplotlib library and this is
how you can view this is the code for
viewing the images and you can view them
in color or you can view them in
grayscale so the cmap is what tells in
what
way we want to view it and what are the
maximum values and the minimum values of
the pixel value so these are the max and
minimum values so of the pixel values so
maximum is one because this is a scaled
value so 1 means it is
white and
0 means it is black and in between is it
can be anywhere in between black and
white
and the way to train the model there is
a certain way in which you write your
tensorflow code and
the first step is to create some
placeholders and then you create a model
in this case we will use the softmax
model one of the simplest ones and
placeholders are primarily to get the
data from outside into the neural
network so this is a very common
mechanism that is used and then of
course you will have variables which are
your you remember these are your weights
and biases so for in our case there are
10 neurons and each neuron actually has
784 because each neuron takes all the
inputs if we go back to our slide here
actually every neuron takes all the 784
inputs right this is the first neuron it
has it receives all the 784 this is the
second neuron this also receives all the
700. so each of these inputs needs to be
multiplied with the weight and that's
what we are talking about here so these
are
this is a
matrix
of
values for each of the neurons and so it
is like a 10 by 784
matrix because there are 10 neurons and
similarly there are
biases now remember i mentioned
bias is only one per neuron so it is not
one per input unlike the weights so
therefore there are only 10 biases
because there are only 10 neurons in
this case so that is what we are
creating a variable for biases so this
is something little new in tensorflow
you will see unlike our regular
programming languages where everything
is a variable here the variables can be
of three different types you have
placeholders which are primarily used
for feeding data you have variables
which can change during the course of
computation and then a third type which
is not shown here are constants so these
are like fixed numbers all right so in a
regular programming language you may
have everything as variables or at the
most variables and constants but in
tensorflow you have three different
types placeholders variables and
constants and then you create what is
known as a graph so tensorflow
programming consists of graphs and
tensors as i mentioned earlier so this
can be considered ultimately as a tensor
and then the graph tells how to execute
the whole implementation so that the
execution is stored in the form of a
graph and in this case what we are doing
is we are doing a multiplication
tf you remember this tf was created as a
tensorflow object here one more level
one more so tf is available here now
tensorflow has what is known as a matrix
multiplication or matmal
function so that is what is being used
here in this case so we are using the
matrix multiplication of tensorflow so
that you multiply your input values x
with w right this is what we were doing
x w plus b you're just adding b and this
is in very similar to one of the earlier
slides where we saw sigma x i wi so
that's what we are doing here matrix
multiplication is multiplying all the
input values with the corresponding
weights and then adding the bias so that
is the graph we created and then we need
to define what is our loss function and
what is our optimizer so in this case we
again use the tensorflow's apis so tf
dot nn softmax cross entropy with logits
is the
api that we will use and reduce mean is
what is like the
mechanism whereby which says that you
reduce
the
error and optimizer for doing deduction
of the error what optimizer are we using
so we are using gradient descent
optimizer
we discussed about this in a couple of
slides uh earlier and for that you need
to specify the learning rate you
remember we saw that there was a slide
somewhat like this and then you define
what should be the learning rate how
fast you need to come down that is the
learning rate and this again needs to be
tested and tried and to find out the
optimum level of this learning rate it
shouldn't be very high in which case it
will not converge or shouldn't be very
low because it will in that case it will
take very long so you define the
optimizer and then you call the method
minimize for that optimizer and that
will kickstart the training process
and so far we've been creating the graph
and in order to actually execute that
graph we create what is known as a
session and then we run that session and
once the training is completed we
specify how many times how many
iterations we wanted to run so for
example in this case we are saying
thousand steps so that is a exit
strategy in a way so you specify the
exit condition so training will run for
thousand iterations and once that is
done we can then evaluate the model
using some of the techniques
shown here so
let us
get into the code quickly and see how it
works so this is our cloud environment
now you can install tensorflow on your
local machine as well i'm showing this
demo on our existing cloud but you can
also install tensorflow on your local
machine and there is a separate video on
how to set up your tensorflow
environment you can watch that if you
want to install your local environment
or you can go for
other any cloud service like for example
google cloud amazon or cloud labs any of
these you can
use and
run and try the code okay so it has got
started
we will login
all right so this is our deep learning
tutorial uh code
and this is our tensorflow environment
and
so let's get started
the first we have seen a little bit of a
code walkthrough
in the slides as well now you will see
the actual code in action so the first
thing we need to do is import tensorflow
and then we will import the data and we
need to adjust the data in such a way
that
the
one hot is encoding is set to true one
hot encoding right as i explained
earlier so in this case the label values
will be shown appropriately
and if we just check what is the type of
the data so you can see that this is a
data sets python
data sets and if we
check the number of
images the way it looks so this is how
it looks it is an array of type float 32
similarly
the
number if you want to see what is the
number of
training images there are 55 000 then
there are test images 10 000 and then
validation images 5000 now
let's take a quick look at the data
itself visualization so we will use
matplotlib for this
and
if we take a look at the shape now shape
gives us like the dimension of the
tensors or
or the arrays if you will so in this
case the training data set if we see the
size of the training data set using the
method shape it says there are 55 000
and
55 000 by 784 so remember the 784 is
nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into 28 so
that is equal to 784 so that's what it
is uh showing now we can take just
one image and just see
what is the
the first image and see what is the
shape so again size obviously it is only
784 similarly you can
look at the image itself the data of the
first image itself so this is how it it
shows so large part of it will probably
be zeros because as you can imagine
in the image only certain areas are
written rest is
black so that's why you will mostly see
zero say either it is black or white but
then there are these values are so the
values are actually they are scaled so
their values are between zero and one
okay so this is what you're seeing so
certain locations there are some values
and then other locations there are zeros
so
that is how the data is stored and
loaded
if we want to actually see what is the
value of the handwritten image
if you want to view it this is how you
view it so you
create like do this reshape and
matplotlib has this
feature to show you these images so we
will actually use the
function called
i am show and then if you pass this
parameters appropriately
you will be able to see the different
images now i can change the values in
this position so which image we are
looking at right so we can say
if i want to see what is there in maybe
5 000
right so
5000 has 3
similarly you can just say 5 what is in
5 as 8
what is in 50
again 8 so basically by the way if
you're wondering how i'm executing this
code shift enter
in case you're not familiar with jupyter
notebooks shift enter is how you execute
each cell individual cell and if you
want to execute the entire program you
can go here and say run all
so that is how
this code gets executed
and
here again we can check what is the
maximum value and what is the minimum
value of this pixel values as i
mentioned this is it is scaled so
therefore it is between the values lie
between one and zero now this is
where we create our model
the first thing is to create the
required placeholders and variables and
that's what we are doing here as we have
seen in the slides so we create
one placeholder and we create two
variables which is for the weights and
biases these two variables are actually
matrices so
each variable has
784 by 10 actual values okay so
one for this 10 is for each neuron there
are 10 neurons and 784 is for the pixel
values inputs that are given which is 28
into 28
and the biases as i mentioned
one for each neuron so there will be 10
biases they are stored in a variable by
the name b
and this is the graph which is basically
the multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of x into w and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize
the error so let me just execute i think
this code is executed then we define
what is our the y value is basically the
label value
so this is another placeholder we had x
as one placeholder and white underscore
true as a second place holder and this
will have values in the form of uh 10
digit 10 digit arrays
and
since we said one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the
label for that particular number all
right then we have cross entropy which
is nothing but
the
loss
loss function
and we have the optimizer we have chosen
gradient descent as our optimizer then
the training process itself so the
training process is nothing but to
minimize
the cross entropy which is again nothing
but the
loss function
so we define all of this in the form of
a graph so up to here remember what we
have done is we have not exactly
executed any tensorflow code till now we
are just preparing the graph the
execution plan that's how the tensorflow
code works so the whole
structure and format of this code will
be completely different from
how we normally do programming so even
with people with programming experience
may find this a little difficult to
understand it and it needs quite a bit
of practice so you may want to
view this
video also maybe a couple of times to
understand this flow
because the way tensorflow programming
is done is
slightly different from the normal
programming some of you who
let's say have done
maybe spark programming to some extent
will be able to easily understand this
but even in spark the the programming
the code itself is pretty
straightforward behind the scenes the
execution happens slightly differently
but in tensorflow even the code has to
be written in a completely different way
so the code doesn't get executed
in the same way as you have written so
that that's something you need to
understand and a little bit of practice
is needed for this
so so far what we have done up to here
is creating the variables and feeding
the variables and
or rather not feeding but setting up the
variables and
the graph that's all defining maybe the
what kind of a network you want to use
for example we want to use a softmax and
so on so you have
created the variables how to load the
data loaded the data viewed the data
and prepared everything but you have not
yet executed anything in tensorflow now
the next step is the execution intensive
law so the first step for
doing any execution in tensorflow is to
initialize the variable so anytime you
have any variables defined in your code
you have to run this piece of code
always so you need to basically create
what is known as a node for initializing
so this is a node you still are not yet
executing anything here you just created
a node for the initialization
so let us go ahead and create that
and
here onwards is where you will actually
execute your code
in tensorflow and in order to execute
the code what you will need is a session
tensorflow session so tf.session will
give you a session and there are a
couple of different ways in which you
can do this but one of the most common
methods of doing this is with what is
known as a with loop so you have uh with
tf.session
as says and with the
colon here and this is like a block
starting of the block and these
indentations tell how far this block
goes and
this session is valid
till
this block gets executed so that is the
purpose of creating this width block
this is known as a with block so with tf
dot session as says you say
says dot run init now says dot run will
execute
a node that is
specified here so for example here we
are saying says dot run says is
basically an instance of the session
right so here we are saying tf.session
so an instance of the session gets
created and we are calling that
says and then we run
a node within that one of the nodes in
the graph so one of the nodes here is
init so we say run that particular node
and that is when the initialization of
the variables happens now what this does
is if you have any
variables in your code in our case we
have w is a variable and b is a variable
so any variables that we created you
have to run this code
you have to run the initialization of
these variables otherwise you will get
an error okay so that is the that's what
this is doing then
we within this width block we specify a
for loop
and we are saying
we want the system to iterate for a
thousand steps
and perform
the training
that's what this for loop does
run training for thousand iterations
and what it is doing basically is it is
fetching
the data or these images remember there
are about fifty thousand images but it
cannot get all the images in one shot
because it will take up a lot of memory
and performance issues will be there so
this is a very common way of performing
deep learning training you always do in
batches so we have maybe 50 000 images
but you always do it in batches of 100
or maybe
500 depending on the size of your system
and so on and so forth so in this case
we are saying okay get me 100
images at a time and get me only the
training images remember we use only the
training data for training purpose and
then we use test data for test purpose
you must be familiar with machine
learning so you must be aware of this
but in case you are not in machine
learning also not this is not specific
to deep learning but in machine learning
in general you have what is known as
training data set and test data set your
available data typically you will be
splitting into two parts and using the
training data set for training purpose
and then to see how well the model has
been trained you use the test data set
to check or test the validity or the
accuracy of the model so that's what we
are doing here and you observe here that
we are actually calling an mnist
function here so we are saying mnist
train dot next batch
right so this is the advantage of using
mnist database because they have
provided some very nice helper functions
which are readily available otherwise
this activity itself we would have had
to write a piece of code to fetch this
data in batches that itself is a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using mnist database and that's why
we use this for the initial learning
phase okay so when we say fetch what it
will do is it will fetch the images into
x and the labels into y and then you
use this
batch of 100 images and you run the
training so says dot run basically what
we are doing here is we are running the
training mechanism which is nothing but
it passes this through the neural
network passes the images through the
neural network finds out what is the
output and if the output obviously they
initially it will be wrong so all that
feedback is given back to the neural
network and thereby all the ws and b's
get updated
till it reaches thousand iterations in
this case
the exit criteria is thousand but you
can also specify probably accuracy rate
or something like that for the as an
exit criteria
so here it is it just says that okay
this particular image was wrongly
predicted so you need to update your
weights and biases that's the feedback
given to each neuron and that is run for
1000 iterations and typically by the end
of this thousand iterations the model
would have learned to recognize these
handwritten images obviously it will not
be 100 accurate okay so once that is
done
after so this happens for 1000
iterations once that is done
you then
test the accuracy of these models by
using the test data set right so this is
what we are trying to do here the code
may appear a little complicated because
if you're seeing this for the first time
you need to understand uh the various
methods of tensorflow and so on but it
is basically comparing the output with
what has been what is actually there
that's all it is doing so you have your
test data and you're trying to find out
what is the actual value and what is the
predicted value and seeing whether they
are equal or not tf dot equal right and
how many of them are correct and so on
and so forth and based on that the
accuracy is
calculated as well so this is the
accuracy and that is what we are trying
to see how accurate the model is in
predicting these numbers or these digits
okay so let us run this this entire
thing is in one cell so we will have to
just run it in one shot it may take a
little while let us see
and
not bad so it has finished the thousand
iterations and what we see here as an
output is the accuracy so we see that
the accuracy of this model is around 91
percent okay now which is
pretty good for such a short exercise
within such a short time we got 90
percent accuracy however in real life
this is probably not sufficient so there
are other ways in to increase the
accuracy we will see probably in some of
the later tutorials how to improve this
accuracy how to change maybe the hyper
parameters like number of neurons or
number of layers and so on and so forth
and
so that this accuracy can be increased
beyond 90 so what is a neural network so
hi guys i heard you want to know what a
neural network is here we have
looks like you just went shopping in a
red tag cell my robot's back so as a
matter of fact you have been using
neural network on a daily basis and
today's world is just amazing how much
we use our new technology we're not even
aware of it when you ask your mobile
assistant to perform a search for you
like saying your google or siri or
whoever you use amazon web self-driving
cars so that's the newest thing coming
out they're just now trying to make
those legal and different states in the
u.s and around the world even in the uk
they now have a self-driving cars going
up and down the streets pretty amazing
these are all neural network driven
computer games use it a lot of computer
games are driven by neural networks in
the back end as part of the game system
and how it adjusts to the players and
it's also used in processing the map
images on your phone so every time you
do a navigation someplace and it opens
it up they now use neural networks to
help you find the quickest way to get
there neural network a neural network is
a system or hardware that is designed to
operate like a human brain in today's
development this is so important to
understand because we don't have
anything else to compare it to i'm sure
someday in the future the computer will
redefine or the neural network or the ai
artificial intelligence will redefine
what these mean but as far as we can
today's world in today's commercial
development we have to compare it to
what humans do so it's we want to
compare and how it operates to a human
brain and how it solves problems like a
human does
what can a neural network do and really
we're just going to dive in deeper to
what we just covered and look at other
examples so what can a neural network do
well let's list out the things neural
networks can do for you translate text
boy we got google translate and
microsoft has their own translate they
have some really cool they actually have
an earpiece it's supposed to start
translating as you talk what a cool
technology what a cool time to live
identify faces can you imagine all the
uses for facial identification in the
case of our sample or our code that
we're going to look at later we'll be
identifying dogs and cats so not quite
as detailed as understanding whose face
belongs to who i'm waiting for the
google glasses to come out so i can see
who's who would identify faces as i'm
walking around have a little name tag
over them not out there yet but boy we
are close we can identify the faces and
they have all kinds of technologies to
bring that information back to us
recognize speech goes along with the
translate text so now as you're talking
into your assistant it can use that to
do commands turn lights on all kinds of
things you can do with recognizing
speech read had written text they're
starting to translate all these old text
documents that they've had in storage
instead of doing it individually where
somebody's going through each text by
themselves in a room picture like an old
raiders of the lost ark theme where he's
in the back you know archaeologists
studying the text now it's fed into a
computer they take a picture they even
use neural networks to take a scroll
that is so messed up that they can't
undo the scroll and they x-ray it and
then they use that x-ray to translate
the text off of it without ever opening
the scroll i mean just way cool stuff
they're starting to do with all this and
of course control robots what would be a
neural network without bringing in the
robots and we have our own favorite
robot in the middle who goes to our red
tag cell and go shopping for us so you
know these are just a few of the
wonderful things that neural networks
are being applied to it's such an infant
stage technology what a wonderful time
to jump in and there are a lot of other
things it goes into i mean we could
spend just forever talking about all the
different applications from business to
whatever you can even imagine they're
now applying neural networks to help us
understand
so now we talked a little bit about all
the cool things you can do with the
neural network let's dive in and say how
does a neural network work so now we've
come far enough to understand how neural
network works let's go ahead and walk
through this in a nice graphical
representation they usually describe a
neural network as having different
layers you'll see that we've identified
a green layer an orange layer and a red
layer the green layer is the input so
you have your data coming in it picks up
the input signals and passes them to the
next layer the next layer does all kinds
of calculations and feature extraction
it's called the hidden layer a lot of
times there's more than one hidden layer
we're only showing one in this picture
but we'll show you how it looks like in
a more detail a little bit and then
finally we have an output layer this
layer delivers the final result so the
only two things we see is the input
layer and the output layer now let's
make use of this neural network and see
how it works wonder how traffic cameras
identify vehicles registration plate on
the road to detect speeding vehicles and
those breaking the law they got me going
through a red light the other day well
last month that's like the horrible
thing they sent you this picture of you
and all your information because they
pulled it up off of your license plate
and your picture that should have gone
through the red light so here we are and
we have an image of a car you can see
the license plates on there so let's
consider the image of this vehicle and
find out what's on the number plate the
picture itself is 28 by 28 pixels and
the image is fed as an input to identify
the registration plate each neuron has a
number called activation that represents
the grayscale value of the corresponding
pixel range and we range it from zero to
one one for a white pixel and zero for a
black pixel and you can see down here we
have an example where one of the pixels
is registered as like 0.82 meaning it's
probably pretty dark each neuron is lit
up when its activation is close to one
so as we get closer to black on white we
can really start seeing the details in
there and you can see again the pixel
shows this one up there it's like part
of the car and so it lights up so pixels
in the form of arrays are fed to the
input layer and so we see here the pixel
of a car image fed as an input and
you're going to see that the input layer
which is green is one dimension while
our image is two dimension now when we
look at our setup that we're programming
in python it has a cool feature that
automatically does the work for us if
you're working with an older neural
network pattern package you then convert
each one of those rows so it's all one
array so you'd have like row one and
then just tack row two on to the end you
can almost feed the image directly into
some of these neural networks the key is
though is that if you're using a 28 by
28 and you get a picture of this 30 by
30 shrink the 30 by 30 down to fit the
28 by 28 so you can't increase the
number of input in this case green dots
it's very important to remember when you
work on neural networks and let's name
the inputs x1 x2 x3 respectively so each
one of those represents one of the
pixels coming in and the input layer
passes it to the hidden layer and you
can see here we now have two hidden
layers in this image in the orange and
each one of those pixels connects to
each one of those hidden layers and the
interconnections are assigned weights at
random so they get these random weights
that come through if x1 lights up then
it's going to be x1 times this weight
going into the hidden layer and we sum
those weights the weights are multiplied
with the input signal and a bias is
added to all of them so as you can see
here we have x1 comes in and it actually
goes to all the different hidden layer
nodes or in this case whatever you want
to call them network setup the orange
dots and so you take the value of x1 you
multiply it by the weight for the next
hidden layer so x1 goes to hidden layer
1. x1 goes to hidden layer 2. x1 goes
hidden layer 1 node 2. hidden layer 1
node 3 and so on and the bias a lot of
times they just put the bias in as like
another green dot or another orange dot
and they give the bias a value 1 and
then all the weights go in from the bias
into the next node so the bias can
change we always just remember that you
need to have that bias in there there's
things that can be done with it
generally most the packages out there
control that for you so you don't have
to worry about figuring out what the
bias is but if you ever dive deep into
neural networks you've got to remember
there's a bias or the answer won't come
out correctly the weighted sum of the
input is fed as an input to the
activation function to decide which
nodes to fire and for feature extraction
as the signal flows within the hidden
layers the weighted sum of inputs is
calculated and is fed to the activation
function in each layer to decide which
nodes to fire so here's our feature
extraction of the number plate and you
can see these are still hidden nodes in
the middle and this becomes important
we're going to take a little detour here
and look at the activation function so
we're going to dive just a little bit
into the math so you can start to
understand where some of the games go on
when you're playing with neural networks
in your programming so let's look at the
different activation functions before we
move ahead here's our friendly red tag
shopping robot and so one is a sigmoid
function and the sigmoid function which
is one over one plus e to the minus x
takes the x value and you can see where
it generates almost a zero and almost a
one with a very small area in the middle
where it crosses over and we can use
that value to feed into another function
so if it's really uncertain it might
have a 0.1 or 0.2 or 0.3 but for the
most part it's going to be really close
to 1 and really close to this case 0 0
to 1. the threshold function so if you
don't want to worry about the
uncertainty in the middle you just say
oh if x is greater than or equal to 0 if
not then x is 0. so it's either 0 or 1.
really straightforward there's no in
between in the middle and then you have
the what they call the relu relu
function and you can see here where it
puts out the value but then it says well
if it's over one it's going to be one
and if it's less than zero it's zero so
it kind of just dead ends it on those
two ends but allows all the values in
the middle and again this like the
sigmoid function allows that information
to go to the next level so it might be
important to know if it's a 0.1 or a
minus 0.1 the next hidden layer might
pick that up and say oh this piece of
information is uncertain or this value
has a very low certainty to it and then
the hyperbolic tangent function and you
can see here it's a one minus e to the
minus two x over one plus e to the minus
two x and it's very much along the same
theme a little bit different in here in
that it goes between minus one and one
so you'll see some of these they go zero
to one but this one goes minus one to
one and if it's less than zero it's you
know it doesn't fire and if it's over
zero it fires and it also still puts out
a value so you still have a value you
can get off of that just like you can
with the sigmoid function and the relu
function very similar in use and i
believe the originally used to be
everything was done in the sigmoid
function that was the most commonly used
and now they just kind of use more the
relu function the reason is one it
processes faster because you already
have the value and you don't have to add
another compute the one over one plus e
to the minus x for each hidden node and
the data coming off works pretty good as
far as putting it into the next level if
you want to know just how close it is to
zero how close is it not to functioning
you know is it minus 0.1 minus 0.2
usually they're float values you get
like minus point minus 0.00138 or
something so you know important
information but the relu is most
commonly used these days as far as the
setup we're using but you'll also see
the sigmoid function very commonly used
also now that you know what an
activation function is let's get back to
the neural network so finally the model
would predict the outcome of applying a
suitable activation function to the
output layer so we go in here we look at
this we have the optical character
recognition ocr is used on the images to
convert it into a text in order to
identify what's written on the plate and
as it comes out you'll see the red node
and the red node might actually
represent just a letter a so there's
usually a lot of outputs when you're
doing text identification we're not
going to show that on here but you might
have it even in the order it might be
what order the license plates in so you
might have a b c d e f g
you know the alphabet plus the numbers
and you might have the one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
places so it's a very large array that
comes out it's not a small amount of you
know we show three dots coming in eight
hidden layer nodes you know two sets of
four we just saw one red coming out a
lot of times this is uh you know 28
times 28 if you did 30 times 30 that's
you know 900 nodes so 28 is a little bit
less than that uh just on the input and
so you can imagine the hidden layer is
just as big each hidden layer is just as
big if not bigger and the output is
going to be there's so many digits yeah
it's a lot there's it's a huge amount of
input and output but we're only showing
you just you know it would be hard to
show in one picture and so it comes up
and this is what it finally gets out on
the output as it identifies a number on
the plate and in this case we have zero
eight dash d
zero three eight five eight error in the
output is back propagated through the
network and weights are adjusted to
minimize the error rate this is
calculated by a cost function when we're
training our data this is what's used
and we'll look at that in the code when
we do the data training so we have stuff
we know the answer to and then we put
the information through and it says yes
that was correct or no because remember
we randomly set all the weights to begin
with and if it's wrong we take that
error how far off are you you know are
you off by is it if it was like minus
one you're just a little bit off if it's
like minus 300 was your output remember
when we're looking at those different
options you know hyperbolic or whatever
and we're looking at the rel the rel
doesn't have a limit on top or bottom it
actually just generates a number so if
it's way off you have to adjust those
weights a lot but if it's pretty close
you might adjust the weights just a
little bit and you keep adjusting the
weights until they fit all the different
training models you put in so you might
have 500 training models and those
weights will adjust using the back
propagation it sends the error backward
the output is compared with the original
result and multiple iterations are done
to get the maximum accuracy so not only
does it look at each one but it goes
through it and just keeps cycling
through these the data making small
changes in the network until it gets the
right answers with every iteration the
weights at every interconnection are
adjusted based on the error we're not
going to dive into that math because it
is a differential equation and it gets a
little complicated but i will talk a
little bit about some of the different
options they have when we look at the
code so we've explored a neural network
let's look at the different types of
artificial neural networks and this is
like the biggest area growing is how
these all come together let's see the
different types of neural network and
again we're comparing this to human
learning so here's a human brain i feel
sorry for that poor guy so we have a
feed for forward neural network simplest
form of a they call it a n a neural
network data travels only in one
direction input to output this is what
we just looked at so as the data comes
in all the weights are added it goes to
the hidden layer all the weights are
added it goes to the next hidden layer
all the weights are added and it goes to
the output the only time you use the
reverse propagation is to train it so
when you actually use it it's very fast
when you're training it it takes a while
because it has to iterate through all
your training data and you start getting
into big data because you can train
these with a huge amount of data the
more data you put in the better train
they get the applications vision and
speech recognition actually they're
pretty much everything we talked about a
lot of almost all of them used this form
of neural network at some level radial
basis function neural network this model
classifies the data point based on its
distance from a center point what that
means is that you might not have
training data so you want to group
things together and you create central
points and it looks for all the things
you know some of these things are just
like the other if you've ever watched a
sesame street as a kid that dates me so
it brings things together and this is a
great way if you don't have the right
training model you can start finding
things that are connected you might not
have noticed before applications power
restoration systems they try to figure
out what's connected and then based on
that they can fix the problem if you
have a huge power system cajon and
self-organizing neural network vectors
of random dimensions are input to
discrete map comprised of neurons so
they basically find a way to draw they
call them they say dimensions or vectors
or planes because they actually chop the
data in one dimension two dimension
three dimension four five six they keep
adding dimensions and finding ways to
separate the data and connect different
data pieces together applications used
to recognize patterns in data like in
medical analysis the hidden layer saves
its output to be used for future
prediction recurrent neural networks so
the hidden layers remember its output
from last time and that becomes part of
its new input you might use that
especially in robotics or flying a drone
you want to know what your last change
was and how fast it was going to help
predict what your next change you need
to make is to get which where the drone
wants to go applications text to speech
conversation model so you know i talked
about drones but you know just
identifying on lexus or google assistant
or any of these they're starting to add
in i'd like to play a song on my pandora
and i'd like it to be at volume 90
so you now can add different things in
there and it connects them together the
input features are taken in batches like
a filter this allows a network to
remember an image in parts convolution
neural network today's world in photo
identification and taking apart photos
and trying to you know you ever seen
that on google where you have five
people together this is the kind of
thing separates all those people so they
can do a face recognition on each person
applications used in signal and image
processing in this case i use facial
images or google picture images as one
of the options modular neural network it
has a collection of different neural
networks working together to get the
output so wow we just went through all
these different types of neural networks
and the final one is to put multiple
neural networks together i mentioned
that a little bit when we separated
people in a larger photo in individuals
in the photo and then do the facial
recognition on each person so one
network is used to separate them and the
next network is then used to figure out
who they are and do the facial
recognition applications still
undergoing research this is a cutting
edge you hear the term pipeline and
there's actual in python code and in
almost all the different neural network
setups out there they now have a
pipeline feature usually and it just
means you take the data from one neural
network and maybe another neural network
or you put it into the next neural
network and then you take three or four
other neural networks and feed them into
another one so how we connect the neural
networks is really just cutting edge and
it's so experimental i mean it's almost
creative in its nature there's not
really a science to it because each
specific domain has different things
it's looking at so if you're in the
banking domain it's going to be
different than the medical domain then
the automatic car domain and suddenly
figuring out how those all fit together
is just a lot of fun and really cool so
we have our types of artificial neural
network we have our feed forward neural
network we have a radial basis function
neural network we have our cohenin
self-organizing neural network recurrent
neural network convolution neural
network and modular neural network where
it brings them all together and no the
colors on the brain do not match what
your brain actually does but they do
bring it out that most of these were
developed by understanding how humans
learn and as we understand more and more
of how humans learn we can build
something in the computer industry to
mimic that to reflect that and that's
how these were developed so exciting
part use case problem statement so this
is where we jump in this is my favorite
part let's use the system to identify
between a cat and a dog if you remember
correctly i said we're going to do some
python code and you can see over here my
hair is kind of sticking up over the
computer cup of coffee on one side and a
little bit of old school a pencil and a
pen on the other side yeah most people
now take notes
i love the stickies on the computer
that's great that's that is my computer
i have sticky notes on my computer in
different colors so not too far from
today's programmer so the problem is is
we want to classify photos of cats and
dogs using a neural network and you can
see over here we have quite a variety of
dogs in the pictures and cats and you
know just sorting out it is a cat it's
pretty amazing and why would anybody
want to even know the difference between
a cat and a dog okay you know why well i
have a cat door it'd be kind of fun that
instead of it identifying instead of
having like a little collar with a
magnet on it which is what my cat has
the door would be able to see oh that's
the cat that's our cat coming in oh
that's the dog we have a dog too that's
a dog i want to let in maybe i don't
want to let this other animal in because
it's a raccoon so you can see where you
could take this one step further and
actually apply this you could actually
start a little startup company idea
self-identifying door so this use case
will be implemented on python i am
actually in python
3.6 it's always nice to tell people the
version of python because it does affect
sometimes which modules you load and
everything and we're going to start by
importing the required packages i told
you we're going to do this in karas so
we're going to import from karas models
sequential from the cross layers
conversion 2d or conv 2d max pooling 2d
flatten and dense and we'll talk about
what each one of these do in just a
second but before we do that let's talk
a little bit about the environment we're
going to work in and you know in fact
let me go ahead and open a
the website cross's website so we can
learn a little bit more about karass so
here we are on the cross website and
it's a k-e-r-a-s
dot io that's the official website for
karass and the first thing you'll notice
is that cross runs on top of either
tensorflow cntk and i think it's
pronounced thano or thiano what's
important on here is that tensorflow and
the same is true for all these but
tensorflow is probably one of the most
widely used currently packages out there
with the cross and of course you know
tomorrow this is all going to change
it's all going to disappear and they'll
have something new out there so make
sure when you're learning this code that
you understand what's going on and also
know the code i mean look when you look
at the code it's not as complicated once
you understand what's going on the code
itself is pretty straightforward and the
reason we like cross and the reason that
people are jumping on it right now is
such a big deal is if we come down here
let me just scroll down a little bit
they talk about user friendliness
modularity easy extensibility work with
python python is a big one because a lot
of people in data science now use python
although you can actually access cross
other ways if we continue down here is
layers and this is where it gets really
cool when we're working with cross you
just add layers on remember those hidden
layers we're talking about and we talked
about the relu
activation you can see right here let me
just up that a little bit in size there
we go that's big i can add in an r e l u
layer and then i can add in a soft max
layer in the next instance we didn't
talk about soft max so you could do each
layer separate now if i'm working in
some of the other kits i use i take that
and i have one set up and then i feed
the output into the next one this one i
can just add hidden layer after hidden
layer with the different information in
it which makes it very powerful and very
fast to spin up and try different setups
and see how they work with the data
you're working on and we'll dig a little
bit deeper in here and a lot of this is
very much the same so when we get to
that part i'll point that out to you
also now just a quick side note i'm
using anaconda with python in it and i
went ahead and created my own package
and i called it the cross python 36
because i'm in python 36. anaconda is
cool that way you can create different
environments real easily if you're doing
a lot of different experimenting with
these different packages probably want
to create your own environment in there
and the first thing is you can see right
here there's a lot of dependencies a lot
of these you should recognize by now if
you've done any of these videos if not
kudos for you for jumping in today pip
install numpy scipy the scikit-learn
pillow and h5py
are both needed for the tensorflow and
then putting the cross on there and then
you'll see here and pip is just a
standard installer that you use with
python you'll see here that we did pip
install tensorflow since we're going to
do cross on top of tensorflow and then
pip install and i went ahead and used
the github so git plus git and you'll
see here github.com this is one of their
releases one of the most current release
on there that goes on top of tensorflow
and you can look up these instructions
pretty much anywhere this is for doing
it on anaconda certainly you'd want to
install these if you're doing it in
ubuntu server setup you'd want to get i
don't think you need the h5py and ubuntu
but you do need the rest in there
because they are dependencies in there
and it's pretty straightforward and
that's actually in some of the
instructions they have on their website
so you don't have to initially go
through this just remember their website
on there and then when i'm under my
anaconda navigator which i like you'll
see where i have environments and on the
bottom i created a new environment and i
called it cross python 36 just to
separate everything you can see i have
python 30.5 and python 36. i used to
have a bunch of other ones but it kind
of cleaned house recently and of course
once i go in here i can launch my
jupiter notebook making sure i'm using
the right environment that i just set up
this of course opens up my um in this
case i'm using google chrome and in here
i could go and just create a new
document in here and this is all in your
browser winner when you use the anaconda
do you have to use anaconda in jupyter
notebook no you can use any kind of
python editor whatever setup you're
comfortable with and whatever you're
doing in there so let's go ahead and go
in here and paste the code in and we're
importing a number of different settings
in here we have import sequential that's
under the models because that's the
model we're going to use as far as our
neural network and then we have layers
and we have conversion 2d max pooling 2d
flatten dense and you can actually just
kind of guess at what these do we're
talking we're working in a 2d photograph
and if you remember correctly i talked
about how the actual input layer is a
single array it's not in two dimensions
it's one dimension all these do is these
are tools to help flatten the image so
it takes a two dimensional image and
then it creates its own proper setup you
don't have to worry about any of that
you don't have to do anything special
with the photograph you let the cross do
it we're going to run this and you'll
see right here they have some stuff that
is going to be depreciated and changed
because that's what it does everything's
being changed as we go you don't have to
worry about that too much if you have
warnings if you run it a second time the
warning will disappear and this is just
imported these packages for us to use
jupiter is nice about this that you can
do each thing step by step and i'll go
ahead and also zoom in there a little
control plus that's one of the nice
things about being in a browser
environment so here we are back another
sip of coffee
if you're familiar with my other videos
you'll notice i'm always sipping coffee
i always have a in my case latte next to
me an espresso so the next step is to go
ahead and initialize we're going to call
it the cnn or classifier neural network
and the reason we call it a classifier
is because it's going to classify it
between two things it's going to be cat
or dog so when you're doing
classification you're picking specific
objects you're specific it's a true or
false yes no it is something or it's not
so first thing we're going to create our
classifier and it's going to equal
sequential so their sequential setup is
the classifier that's the actual model
we're using that's the neural network so
we call it a classifier and the next
step is to add in our convolution and
let me just do a let me shrink that down
in size you can see the whole line and
let's talk a little bit about what's
going on here i have my classifier and i
add something what am i adding well i'm
adding my first layer this first layer
we're adding in is probably the one that
takes the most work to make sure you
have it set correct and the reason i say
that this is your actual input and we're
going to jump here to the part that says
input shape equals 64 by 64 by 3. what
does that mean well that means that our
picture's coming in and there's these
pictures remember we had like the
picture of the car was 128 by 128 pixels
well this one is 64 by 64 pixels and
each pixel has three values that's where
these numbers come from and it is so
important that this matches i mentioned
a little bit that if you have like a
larger picture you have to reformat it
to fit this shape if it comes in as
something larger there's no input notes
there's no input neural network there
that will handle that extra space so you
have to reshape your data to fit in here
now the first layer is the most
important because after that keras knows
what your shape is coming in here and it
knows what's coming out and so that
really sets the stage most important
thing is that input shape matches your
data coming in and you'll get a lot of
errors if it doesn't you'll go through
there and picture number 55 doesn't
match it correctly and guess what it
does it usually gives you an error and
then the activation if you remember we
talked about the different activations
on here we're using the relu model like
i said that is the most commonly used
now because one it's fast doesn't have
the added calculations in it it just
says here's the value coming out based
on the weights and the value going in
and
from there you know it's
if it's over one then it's good or over
zero it's good if it's under 0 then it's
considered not active and then we have
this conversion 2d what the heck is
conversion 2d i'm not going to go into
too much detail in this because this has
a couple of things it's doing in here a
little bit more in depth than we're
ready to cover in this tutorial but this
is used to convert from the photo
because we have 64 by 64 by three and
we're just converting it to
two-dimensional kind of setup so it's
very aware that this is a photograph and
that different pieces are next to each
other and then we're going to add in a
second convolutional layer that's what
the conv stands for 2d so these are
hidden layers so we have our input layer
and our two hidden layers and they are
two-dimensional because we're doing what
a two-dimensional photograph and you'll
see down here that on the last one we
add a max pooling 2d and we put a pool
size equals 2 2. and so what this is is
that as you get to the end of these
layers one of the things you always want
to think of is what they call mapping
and then reducing wonderful terminology
from the big data we're mapping this
data through all these layers and now we
want to reduce it to only two sets in
this case it's already in two sets
because the 2d photograph but we had you
know two dimensions by we actually have
64 by 64 by three so now we're just
getting it down to a two by two just the
two dimension two dimensional instead of
having the third dimension of colors and
we'll go ahead and run these we're not
really seeing anything on our run script
because we're just setting up this is
all set up and this is where you start
playing because maybe you'll add a
different layer in here to do something
else to see how it works and see what
your output is that's what makes cross
so nice is i can with just a couple
flips of code put in a whole new layer
that does a whole new processing and see
whether that improves my run or makes it
worse and finally we're going to do the
final setup which is to flatten
classifier add a flattened setup and
then we're going to also add a layer a
dense layer and then we're going to add
in another dense layer and then we're
going to build it we're going to compile
this whole thing together so let's flip
over and see what that looks like and
we've even numbered them for you so
we're going to do the flattening and
flatten is exactly what it sounds like
we've been working in a two-dimensional
array of picture which actually is in
three dimensions because of the pixels
the pixels have a whole nother dimension
to it of three different values and
we've kind of resized those down to two
by two but now we're just going to
flatten it i don't want to have multiple
dimensions being worked on by tensor and
by keras i want just a single array so
it's flattened out and then step four
full connection so we add in our final
two layers and you could actually do all
kinds of things with this you could
actually leave out this some of these
layers and play with them you do need to
flatten it that's very important then we
want to use the dents again we're taking
this and we're taking whatever came into
it so once we take all those different
the two dimensions or three dimensions
as they are and we flatten it to one
dimension we want to take that and we're
going to pull it into units of 128 they
got that you say where did they get 128
from you could actually play with that
number and get all kinds of weird
results but in this case we took the 64
plus 64 as 128. you could probably even
do this with 64 or 32. usually you want
to keep it in the same multiple of
whatever the data shape you're already
using is in and we're using the
activation the r e l u just like we did
before and then we finally filter all
that into a single output and it has how
many units one why because we want to
know whether true or false it's either a
dog or a cat you could say one is dog
zero is cat or maybe you're a cat lover
and it's one is cat and zero is dog if
you love both dogs and cats
you're gonna have to choose and then we
use the sigmoid activation if you
remember from before we had the relu and
there's also the sigmoid the sigmoid
just makes it clear it's yes or no we
don't want any kind of in-between number
coming out and we'll go ahead and run
this and you'll see it's still all in
setup and then finally we want to go
ahead and compile and let's put the
compiling our classifier neural network
and we're going to use the optimizer
atom and i hinted at this just a little
bit before where does adam come in where
does an optimizer come in well the
optimizer is the reverse propagation
when we're training it it goes all the
way through and says error and then how
does it readjust those weights there are
a number of them atom is the most
commonly used and it works best on large
data most people stick with the atom
because when they're testing on smaller
data see if their model is going to go
through and get all their errors out
before they run it on larger data sets
they're going to run it on atom anyway
so they just leave it on atom most
commonly used but there are some other
ones out there you should be aware of
that that you might try them if you're
stuck in a bind or you might blur that
in the future but usually atom is just
fine on there and then you have two more
settings you have loss and metrics we're
not going to dig too much into loss or
metrics these are things you really have
to explore cross because there are so
many choices this is how it computes the
error there's so many different ways to
on your back propagation and your
training so we're using the atom model
but you can compute the error by
standard deviation standard deviation
squared they use binary cross entropy
i'd have to look that up even know what
that is there's so many of these a lot
of times you just start with the ones
that look correct that are most commonly
used and then you have to go read the
cross site and actually see with these
different losses and metrics and what
different options they have so we're not
going to get too much into them other
than to reference you over to the karass
website to explore them deeper but we
are going to go ahead and run them and
now we've set up our classifier so we
have an object classifier and if you go
back up here you'll see that we've added
in step one we added in our layer for
the input we added a layer that comes in
there and uses the relu for activation
and then it pulls the data so this is
even though these are two layers the
actual neural network layer is up here
and then it uses this to pull the data
into a two by two so into two
dimensional array from a
three-dimensional array with the colors
then we flatten it so there's our outer
flatten and then we add another dense
what they call dense layer this dense
layer goes in there and it downsizes it
to 128 it reduces it so you can look at
this as we're mapping all this data down
the two-dimensional setup and then we
flatten it so we map it to a flattened
map and then we take it and reduce it
down to 128 and we use the relu again
and then finally we reduce that down to
just a single output and we use the
sigmoid to do that to figure out whether
it's yes no true false in this case cat
or dog and then finally once we put all
these layers together we compile them
that's what we've done here and we've
compiled them as far as how it trains to
use these settings for the training back
propagation so if you remember we talked
about training our setup and when we go
into this you'll see that we have two
data sets we have one called the
training set and the testing set and
that's very standard in any data
processing is you need to have that's
pretty common in any data processing is
you need to have a certain amount of
data to train it and then you got to
know whether it works or not is it any
good and that's why you have a separate
set of data for testing it or you
already know the answer but you don't
want to use that as part of the training
set so in here we jump into part two
fitting the classifier neural network to
the images and then from cross let me
just zoom in there i always love that
about working with jupiter notebooks you
can really see we're going to come in
here we do the cross pre-processing an
image and we import image data generator
so nice of course it's such a high-end
product right now going out and since
images are so common they already have
all this stuff to help us process the
data which is great and so we come in
here we do train data gin and we're
going to create our object for helping
us train it for reshaping the data so
that it's going to work with our setup
and we use an image data generator and
we're going to rescale it and you'll see
here we have one point which tells us
it's a float value on the rescale over
255. where does 255 come from well
that's the scale in the colors of the
pictures we're using their value from 0
to 255. so we want to divide it by 255
and it'll generate a number between 0
and 1. they have shear range and zoom
range horizontal flip equals true and
this of course has to do with if the
photos are different shapes and sizes
like i said it's a wonderful package you
really need to dig in deep to see all
the different options you have for
setting up your images for right now
though we're going to stick with some
basic stuff here and let me go ahead and
run this code and again it doesn't
really do anything because we're still
setting up the pre-processing let's take
a look at this next set of code
and this one is just huge we're creating
the training set so the training set is
going to go in here and it's going to
use our train data gen we just created
dot flow from directory it's going to
access in this case the path data set
training set that's a folder so it's
going to pull all the images out of that
folder now i'm actually running this in
the folder that the data sets in so if
you're doing the same setup and you load
your data in there and you're doing this
make sure wherever your jupyter notebook
is saving things to that you create this
path or you can do the complete path if
you need to you know see colon slash etc
and the target size the batch size and
class mode is binary so the classes
we're switching everything to a binary
value batch size what the heck is batch
size well that's how many pictures we're
going to batch through the training each
time and the target size 64 by 64. a
little confusing but you can see right
here that this is just a general
training and you can go in there and
look at all the different settings for
your training set and of course with
different data we're doing pictures
there's all kinds of different settings
depending on what you're working with
let's go ahead and run that and see what
happens and you'll see that it found 800
images belonging to one classes so we
have 800 images in the training set and
if we're going to do this with the
training set we also have to format the
pictures in the test set now we're not
actually doing any predictions we're not
actually programming the model yet all
we're doing is preparing the data so
we're going to prepare a training set
and the test set so any changes we make
to the training set at this point also
have to be made to the test set so we've
done this thing we've done a train data
generator we've done our training set
and then we also have remember our test
set of data so i'm going to do the same
thing with that i'm going to create a
test data gen and we're going to do this
image data generator we're going to
rescale 1 over 255 we don't need the
other settings just the single setting
for the test data gen and we're going to
create our test set we're going to do
the same thing we did with the test set
except that we're pulling it from the
test set folder and we'll run that and
you'll see in our test set we found 2
000 images that's about right we're
using 20 of the images as test and 80 to
train it and then finally we've set up
all our data we've set up all our layers
which is where all the work is is
cleaning up that data making sure it's
going in there correctly and we're
actually going to fit it we're going to
train our data set and let's see what
that looks like and here we go let's put
the information in here and let's just
take a quick look at what we're looking
at with our fit generator we have our
classifier dot fit generator that's our
back propagation so the information goes
through forward with a picture and it
says oh you're either right or you're
wrong and then the air goes backward and
reprograms all those weights so we're
training our neural network and of
course we're using the training set
remember we created the training set up
here and then we're going steps per epic
so it's 8 000 steps epic means that
that's how many times we go through all
the pictures so we're going to rerun
each of the pictures and we're going to
go through the whole data set 25 times
but we're going to look at each picture
during each epic 8 000 times so we're
really programming the heck out of this
and going back over it and then they
have validation data equals test set so
we have our training set and then we're
going to have our test set to validate
it so we're going to do this all in one
shot and we're going to look at that and
they're going to do 200 steps for each
validation and we'll see what that looks
like in just a minute let's go ahead and
run our training here and we're going to
fit our data and as it goes it says epic
1 of 25 you start realizing that this is
going to take a while on my older
computer it takes about 45 minutes i
have a dual processor and we're
processing uh 10 000 photos that's not a
small amount of photographs to process
so if you're on your laptop in which i
am it's going to take a while so let's
go ahead and go get our cup of coffee
and a sip and come back and see what
this looks like so i'm back you didn't
know i was gone that was actually a
lengthy pause there i made a couple
changes and let's discuss those changes
real quick and why i made them so the
first thing i'm going to do is i'm going
to go up here and insert a cell above
and let's paste the original code back
in there and you'll see that the
original thing was steps per epic 8 000
25 epics and validation steps 2 000 and
i change these to 4 000 epics or 4 000
steps per epic
10 epics and just 10 validation steps
and this will cause problems if you're
doing this as a commercial release but
for demo purposes this should work and
if you remember our steps per epic
that's how many photos we're going to
process in fact let me go ahead and get
my drawing pin out and let's just
highlight that right here well we have 8
000 pictures we're going through so for
each epic i'm going to change this to
four thousand and cut that in half so
it's going to randomly pick 4 000
pictures each time it goes through an
epic and the epic is how many processes
so this is 25 and i'm just going to cut
that to 10. so instead of doing 25 runs
through 8 000 photos each which you can
do the math of 25 times 8 000. i'm only
going to do 10 through 4 000 so i'm
going to run this 40 000 times through
the processes and the next thing i know
that you'll you'll want to notice is
that i also change the validation step
and this would cause some major problems
in releasing because i dropped it all
the way down to 10. what the validation
step does is it says we have 2 000
photos in our trainings or in our
testing set and we're going to use that
for validation well i'm only going to
use a random 10 of those to validate so
not really the best settings but let me
show you why we did that let's scroll
down here just a little bit and let's
look at the output here and see what
that what's going on there so i've got
my drawing tool back on and you'll see
here it lists a run so each time it goes
through an epic it's going to do 4 000
steps and this is where the 4000 comes
in so that's what we have we have epic
one of 10 4 000 steps it's randomly
picking half the pictures in the file
and going through them and then we're
going to look at this number right here
that is for the whole epic and that's
seconds and if you remember correctly
you divide that by 60 you get minutes if
you divide that by 60 you get hours or
you can just divide the whole thing by
60 times 60 which is 3600. if 3600 is an
hour this is roughly 45 minutes right
here and that's 45 minutes to process
half the pictures so if i was doing all
the pictures we're talking an hour and a
half per epic times 36 or no 25 they had
25 up above 25. so that's roughly a
couple days a couple days of processing
well for this demo we don't want to do
that i don't want to come back the next
day plus my computer did a reboot in the
middle of the night so we look at this
and we say okay let's we're just testing
this out my computer that i'm running
this on is a dual core processor runs
point nine gigahertz per second for a
laptop it was good about four years ago
but for running something like this is
probably a little slow so we cut the
times down and the last one was
validation we're only validating it on a
random 10 photos and this comes into
effect because you're going to see down
here where we have accuracy value loss
value accuracy and loss those are very
important numbers to look at so the 10
means i'm only validating across 10
pictures that is where here we have
value this is acc is for accuracy value
loss we're not going to worry about that
too much and accuracy now accuracy is
while it's running it's putting these
two numbers together that's what
accuracy is and value accuracy is at the
end of the epic what's our accuracy into
the epic what is it looking at in this
tutorial we're not going to go so deep
but these numbers are really important
when you start talking about these two
numbers reflect bias that is really
important let's just put that up there
and bias is a little bit beyond this
tutorial but the short of it is is if
this accuracy which is being our
validation per step is going down and
the value accuracy continues to go up
that means there's a bias that means i'm
memorizing the photos i'm looking at i'm
not actually looking for what makes a
dog a dog what makes a cat a cat i'm
just memorizing them and so the more
this discrepancy grows the bigger the
bias is and that is really the beauty of
the cross
neural network is a lot of built-in
features like this that make that really
easy to track so let's go ahead and take
a look at the next set of code so here
we are into part three we're going to
make a new prediction and so we're going
to bring in a couple tools for that and
then we have to process the image coming
in and find out whether it's an actual
dog or cat we can actually use this to
identify it and of course the final step
of part three is to print prediction
we'll go ahead and combine these and of
course you can see me there adding more
sticky notes to my computer screen
hidden behind the screen and you know
last one was don't forget to feed the
cat and the dog
so let's go and take a look at that and
see what that looks like in code and put
that in our jupiter notebook all right
and let's paste that in here and we'll
start by importing numpy as np numpy's a
very common package i pretty much
imported on any python project i'm
working on another one i use regularly
is pandas they're just ways of
organizing the data and then np is
usually the standard in most machine
learning tools as a return for the data
array although you use a standard data
array from python and we have cross
pre-processing import image things that
all look familiar because we're going to
take a test image and we're going to set
that equal to in this case cat or dog
one as you can see over here and you
know let me get my drawing tool back on
so let's take a look at this we have our
test image we're loading and in here we
have test image one and this one hasn't
data hasn't seen this one at all so this
is all new hope let me shrink the screen
down let me start that over so here we
have my test image and we went ahead and
the cross processing has this nice image
set up so we're going to load the image
and we're going to alter it to a 64 by
64 print so right off the bat we're
going to cross as nice that way it
automatically sets it up for us so we
don't have to redo all our images and
find a way to reset those and then we
use also to set the image to an array so
again we're all in pre-processing the
data just like we pre-processed before
with our test information and our
training data and then we use the numpy
here's our numpy that's uh from our
right up here important numpy as in p
expand the dimensions test image axes
equals zero so it puts it into a single
array and then finally
all that work all that pre-processing
and all we do is we run the result we
click on here we go result equals
classifier predict test image and then
we find out well what is the test image
and let's just take a quick look and
just see what that is and you can see
when i ran it it comes up dog and if we
look at those images there it is cat or
dog image number one that looks like a
nice floppy eared lab
friendly with his tongue hanging out
it's either that or a very floppy eared
cat i'm not sure which but according to
our software says it's a dog and uh we
have a second picture over here let's
just see what happens when we run the
second picture we can go up here and
change this from dog image one to two
we'll run that and it comes down here
and says cat you can see me highlighting
it down there as cat so our process
works you're able to label a dog a dog
and a cat a cat just from the pictures
there we go cleared my drawing tool and
the last thing i want you to notice when
we come back up here to when i ran it
you'll see that has an accuracy of 1 and
the value accuracy of 1. well the value
accuracy is the important one because
the value accuracy is what it actually
runs on the test data remember i'm only
testing it on i'm only validating it on
a random 10 photos and those 10 folders
just happened to come up one now when
they ran this on the server it actually
came up about 86
this is why cutting these numbers down
so far for a commercial release is bad
so you want to make sure you're a little
careful of that when you're testing your
stuff that you change these numbers back
when you run it on a more enterprise
computer other than your old laptop that
you're just practicing on or messing
with and we come down here and again you
know we have the validation of cat and
so we have successfully built a neural
network that could distinguish between
photos of a cat and a dog imagine all
the other things you could distinguish
imagine all the different industries you
could dive into with that just being
able to understand those two difference
of pictures what about mosquitoes could
you find the mosquitoes that bite versus
mosquitoes that are friendly it turns
out the mosquitoes that bite us are only
four percent of the mosquito population
if even that maybe two percent there's
all kinds of industries that use this
and there's so many industries that are
just now realizing how powerful these
tools are just in the photos alone there
is a myriad of industries sprouting up
and i said it before i'll say it again
what an exciting time to live in with
these tools and that we get to play with
so let's start with deep learning
frameworks to start with this chart
doesn't even do the filled um justice
because it's just exploded
these are just some of the major
frameworks out there there's a keras
which happens to sit on tensorflow so
they're very integrated there's
tensorflow
pie torches out there cafe theano
dl4j
and chainer these are just a few of the
deep learning frameworks we're talking
about neural networks if you're just
starting out never seen a neural network
you can go into python in the
scikit and do the neural network in
there which is probably the most
simplest version i know but the most
robust version out there the most top of
the ladder as far as the technology
right now is tensorflow and that of
course is changing from day to day and
some of these
are
better for different purposes
so let's dive into tensorflow
let's see what is tensorflow what is
tensorflow tensorflow is a popular open
source library released in 2015 by
google brain team for building machine
learning and deep learning models
it is based on python programming
language and performs numerical
computations using data flow graphs to
build models so let's take a look at
some of the features of tensorflow it
works efficiently with multi-dimensional
arrays
if you've ever played with any of the
simpler packages of neural networks
you're going to find that you have to
pretty much flatten them and make sure
your your stuff is set in a flat model
tensorflow works really good so we're
talking pictures here where you have
x and y coordinates where the picture is
and then each pixel has three or four
different channels that's a very
complicated array a very
multi-dimensional array it provides
scalability of computation across
machines and large data sets
this is so new right now
and you might think that's a minor thing
but when python is operating on one
computer and it has a float value
and it truncates it differently on each
computer you don't get the same results
and so your training model might work on
one machine and then another it doesn't
this is one of the things that
tensorflow
addresses and does a very good job on
it supports fast debugging and model
building
this is why i love tensorflow
i can go in there and i can build a
model with different layers each layer
might have different properties
they have like the convolutional neural
network which you can then sit on top of
a regular neural network with reverse
propagation there's a lot of tools in
here and a lot of options and each layer
that it goes through can utilize those
different options and stack differently
and it has a large community and
provides tensorboard to visualize the
model tensorboard is pretty uh recent
but it's a really nice tool to have so
you when you're working with other
people or showing your
clients or the
shareholders in the company you can give
them a nice visual model so they know
what's going on what are they paying for
and let's take a glance at some of the
different uses or applications for
tensorflow when we talk about tensorflow
applications
clearly this is data analytics we're
getting into the data science i like to
use data science it's probably a better
term this is the programming side
and it's really the sky is a limit
we can look at face detection language
translation fraud detection video
detection
there are so many different things out
there that tensorflow can be used for
when you think of neural networks
because tensorflow is a neural network
think of complicated chaotic data this
is very different than if you have a set
numbers like you're looking at the stock
market you can use this on the stock
market but if you're doing something
where the numbers are very clear
and not so chaotic as you have in a
picture then you're talking more about
linear regression models
and different regression models when
you're looking at that when you're
talking about these really complicated
data patterns
then you're talking neural networks in
tensorflow and if we're going to talk
about tensorflow we should talk about
what tensors are after all that is what
tensor that's what this is named after
so we talk about tensors in tensorflow
tensorflow is derived from its core
component known as a tensor a tensor is
a vector or a matrix of n dimensions
that represent all types of data and you
can see here we have the scalar which is
just a single
number you have your vector which is two
numbers uh might be a number in a
direction you have a simple matrix and
then we get into the tensor
i mentioned how a picture is a very
complicated tensor because it has your x
y coordinates and then each one of those
pixels
has three to four channels for your
different colors
and so each image coming in would be its
own tensor
and
in tensorflow tensors are defined by a
unit of dimensionality called as rank
and you can see here we have our
scalar which is a single number that has
a rank of zero because it has no real
dimensions to it other than it's just a
single point and then you have your
vector which would be a single list of
numbers
so that's a rank one
matrix would have rank two and then as
you can see right here as we get into
the full tensor it has a rank 3.
and so
the next step is to understand how a
tensorflow works
and if you haven't looked at
the basics of a neural network in
reverse propagation that is the basics
of tensorflow and then it goes through a
lot of different options and properties
that you can build into your different
tensors
so a tensorflow performs computations
with the help of data flow graphs
it has nodes that represent the
operations in your model and if you
look at this you should see a
neural network going on here we have our
inputs
b c and d
and you might have x equals b plus c y
equals d minus 4
a equals x times y and then you have an
output
and so
even though this isn't a neural network
here it's just a simple set of
computations going across
you can see how the more complicated it
gets the more because you can actually
one of the tensors is a neural network
with reverse propagation
but it's not limited to that there's so
much more you can do with it and this
here is just a basic uh flow of
computations of the data going across
and you can see we can plug in the
numbers b equals four c equals three d
equals six and you get x equals four
plus three
so x equals seven y equals 6 minus 4 so
y equals 2 and finally a equals 7 times
2 or a equals 14. like i said this is a
very simplified version of how
tensorflow works each one of these
layers can get very complicated
but tensorflow does such a nice job that
you can spin different setups up very
easily and test them out so you can test
out these different models to see how
they work now tensorflow has gone
through two major stages
we had the original tensorflow release
of 1.0 and then they came out with the
2.0 version and the 2.0 addressed so
many things out there that the 1.0
really needed so we start talking about
tensorflow 1.0 versus 2.0
i guess you would need to know this for
a legacy programming job if you're
pulling apart somebody else's code the
first thing is that tensorflow 2.0
supports eager execution by default it
allows you to build your models and run
them instantly and you can see here from
tensorflow 1 to tensorflow 2
we have
almost double the code to do the same
thing so if i want to do with tf.session
or tensorflow session as a session the
session run you have your variables your
session run you have your tables
initializer and then you do your model
fit
x train y train and then your validation
data your x value y value and your epics
and your batch size all that goes into
the fit
and you can see here where that was all
just compressed to make it run easier
you can just create a model and do a fit
on it
and you only have like that last set of
code on there so it's automatic that's
what they mean by the eager so if you
see the first part you're like what the
heck is all the session thing going on
that's tensorflow 1.0 and then when you
get into 2.0 it's just nice and clean
if you remember from the beginning i
said cross
on our list up there
and cross is the high level api in
tensorflow 2.0
cross is the official high level api of
tensorflow 2.0 it has incorporated cross
as tf.caras cross provides a number of
model building apis such as sequential
functional and subclassing so you can
choose the right level of abstraction
for your project and uh we'll hopefully
touch base a little bit more on this
sequential being the most common uh form
that is your your
layers are going from one side to the
other
so everything's going in a sequential
order
functional
is where you can split the layers so you
might have your input coming in one side
it splits into two completely mod
different models and then they come back
together
and one of them might be doing
classification the other one might be
doing just linear regression kind of
stuff or a neural basic
reverse propagation neural network and
then those all come together into
another layer which is your
neural network reverse propagation setup
subclassing
is the most complicated as you're
building your own models and you can
subclass your own models into cross so
very powerful tools here this is all the
stuff that's been coming out currently
in the tensorflow cross setup a third
big change we're going to look at is it
in tensorflow 1.0
in order to use tf layers as variables
you would have to write tf variable
block so you'd have to pre-define that
in tensorflow 2 you just add your layers
in under the sequential and it
automatically defines them as long as
they're flat layers
of course this changes a little bit as a
more complicated
tensor you have coming in but all of
it's very easy to do and that's what 2.0
does a really good job of and here we
have
a little bit more on the scope of this
and you can see how tensorflow 1 asks
you to do
these different layers and values if you
look at the scope and the default name
you start looking at all the different
code in there to create the variable
scope that's not even necessary in
tensorf 2.0 so you'd have to do one
before you do do what you see the code
in 2.0
in 2.0 you just create your model it's a
sequential model and then you can add
all your layers in you don't have to
pre-create the
variable scope so if you ever see the
variable scope you know that came from
an older version and then we have the
last two which is our api cleanup and
the autograph
in the api cleanup tensorflow 1 you
could build models using tf gans tf app
tf contrib tf flags etc in tensorflow 2
a lot of apis have been removed and this
is just they just cleaned them up
because people weren't using them and
they've simplified them and that's your
tf app your tf flags your tf logging are
all gone
so there's those are three legacy
features that are not in 2.0 and then we
have our tf function and autograph
feature in the old version tensorflow 1
0 the python functions were limited and
could not be compiled or exported
re-imported
so you were continually having to redo
your code you couldn't very easily just
put a pointer to it and say hey let's
reuse this
in tensorflow 2 you can write a python
function using the tf function to mark
it for the jit compilation for the
python jit so that tensorflow runs it as
a single graph autograph feature of tf
function helps to write graph code using
natural python syntax
now we just threw in a new word in you
graph a graph is not a picture of a
person
you'll hear graph x and some other
things
graph is what are all those lines that
are connecting different objects so if
you remember from before where we had
the different layers going through
sequentially each one of those white
lined arrows would be a graph x that's
where that computation is taken care of
and that's what they're talking about
and so if you had your own special code
or python way that you're sending that
information forward you can now put your
own function in there instead of using
whatever function they're using
in neural networks this would be your
activation function although it could be
almost anything out there depending on
what you're doing next let's go for
hierarchy and architecture and then
we'll cover three basic tools in
tensorflow before we roll up our sleeves
and dive into the example so let's just
take a quick look at tensorflow toolkits
in their hierarchy at the high level we
have our object oriented api so this is
what you're working with you have your
tf cross you have your estimators this
sits on top of your tf layers tf losses
tf metrics so you have your reusable
libraries for model building this is
really where tensorflow shines is
between the cross
running your estimators and then being
able to swap in different layers you can
your losses your metrics all of that is
so built into tensorflow makes it really
easy to use and then you can get down to
your low level tf api
you have extensive control over this you
can put your own formulas in there your
own procedures or models in there
you could have it split we talked about
that earlier so with the 2.0 you can now
have it split one direction where you do
a linear regression model and then go to
the other where it does a
neural network and maybe each neural
network has a different activation set
on it and then it comes together into
another layer which is another neural
network so you can build these really
complicated models and at the low level
you can put in your own apis you can
move that stuff around and most recently
we have the tf code can run on multiple
platforms
and so you have your cpu
which is
basically like in the computer i'm
running on i have
eight cores and 16 dedicated threads i
hear they now have one out there that
has over 100 cores
so you have your cpu running and then
you have your gpu which is your graphics
card
and most recently they also include the
tpu setup which is specifically for
tensorflow models
neural network kind of setup
so now you can export the tf code and it
can run on all kinds of different
platforms for the most
diverse setup out there and moving on
from the hierarchy to the architecture
in the tensorflow 2.0 architecture we
have
you can see on the left this is usually
where you start out with and 80 percent
of your time in data science is spent
pre-processing data making sure it's
loaded correctly and everything looks
right
so the first level in tensorflow is
going to be your read and pre-processed
data your tf data feature columns
this is going to feed into your tf cross
or your premade estimators
and kind of you have your tensorflow hub
that sits on top of there so you can see
what's going on uh once you have all
that set up you have your distribution
strategy where are you going to run it
you're going to be running it on just
your regular cpu are you going to be
running it with the gpu added in
like i have a pretty high end graphics
card so it actually grabs that gpu
processor and uses it or do you have a
specialized tpu setup in there that you
paid extra money for
it could be if you're in later on when
you're distributing the package you
might need to run this on some really
high processors because you're
processing at a server level for
let's say net you might be processing
this at a
distribute you're distributing it not
the distribution strategy but you're
distributing it into a server where that
server might be analyzing thousands and
thousands of purchases done
every minute
and so you need that higher speed to
give them a um to give them a
recommendation or a suggestion so they
can buy more stuff off your website or
maybe you're looking for
data fraud analysis working with the
banks you want to be able to run this at
a high speed so that when you have
hundreds of people
sending their transactions in it says
hey this doesn't look right someone's
scamming this person and probably has
their credit card so when we're talking
about all those fun things we're talking
about saved model this is we were
talking about that earlier where it used
to be when you did one of these models
it wouldn't truncate the float numbers
the same and so a model going from one
you build the model on your
machine in the office and then you need
to distribute it and so we have our
tensorflow serving cloud on premium
that's what i was talking about if
you're like a banking or something like
that
now they have tensorflow lite so you can
actually run a tensorflow on an android
or an ios or raspberry pi a little
breakout board there in fact they just
came out with a new one that has a
built-in there's just a little mini tpu
with the camera on it so it can
pre-process a video so you can load your
tensorflow model onto that
talking about an affordable way to beta
test a new product you have the
tensorflow js which is for browser and
node server so you can get that out on
the browser for some simple computations
that don't require a lot of heavy
lifting but you want to distribute to a
lot of endpoints and now they also have
other language bindings so you can now
create your tensorflow backend save it
and have it accessed from c java go
c sharp rust r or from whatever package
you're working on so we kind of have an
overview of the architecture and what's
going on behind the scenes and in this
case what's going on as far as
distributing it let's go ahead and take
a look at
three specific pieces of tensorflow
and those are going to be constants
variables and sessions
so very basic things you need to know
and understand when you're working with
the tensorflow setup so constants in
tensorflow in tensorflow constants are
created using the function constant in
other words they're going to stay static
the whole time whatever you're working
with the syntax for constant
value d type 9 shape equals none name
constant verify shape equals false
that's kind of the syntax you're looking
at and we'll explore this with our hands
on a little more in depth
and you can see here we do z equals
tf.constant 5.2 name equals x
d type is a float that means that we're
never going to change that 5.2 it's
going to be a constant value and then we
have our variables in tensorflow
variables in tensorflow are in memory
buffers that store tensors
and so we can declare a two by three
tensor populated by ones you could also
do constants this way by the way so you
can create a an array of ones for your
constants i'm not sure why you'd do that
but you know you might need that for
some reason
in here we have v equals tf.variables
and then in tensorflow you have tf.ones
and you have the shape which is 2 3
which is then going to create a nice 2x3
array that's filled with ones and then
of course you can go in there and
they're variables so you can change them
it's a tensor so you have full control
over that
and then you of course have sessions in
tensorflow a session in tensorflow is
used to run a computational graph to
evaluate the nodes
and remember when we're talking a graph
or graph x we're talking about all that
information then goes through all those
arrows and whatever computations they
have that take it to the next node and
you can see down here where we have
import tensorflow as tf if we do x
equals a tf.constant of 10
we do y equals a tf constant of 2.0 or
20.0 and then you can do z equals
tf.variable
and it's a tf.ad x comma y
and then once you have that set up in
there you go ahead and knit your tf
global variables initializer with tf
session as session you can do a session
run and knit
and then you print the session run y
uh and so when you run this you're going
to end up with of course the 10 plus 20
is 30. and we'll be looking at this a
lot more closely as we actually roll up
our sleeves and put some code together
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and for my coding today i'm going
to go ahead and go through anaconda and
then i'll use specifically the juke on
there and of course this code is going
to work whatever platform you choose
whether you're in a notebook
the jupiter lab which is just a jupiter
notebook but with tabs for larger
projects we're going to stick with
jupiter notebook
pycharm whatever it is you're going to
use in here you have your spider and
your qt console for different
programming environments the thing to
note
is kind of hard to see but i have my
main
pi 36
right now when i was writing this
tensorflow works in python version three
six
if you have python version three seven
or three eight you're probably going to
get some errors in there uh might be
that they've already updated and i don't
know it now you have an older version
but you want to make sure you're in a
python version 3 6 in your environment
and of course in anaconda i can easily
set that environment up make sure you go
ahead and and
pip in your tensorflow or if you're in
anaconda you can do a conda install
tensorflow to make sure it's in your
package
so let's just go ahead and dive in and
bring that up
this will open up a nice browser window
i just love the fact i can zoom in and
zoom out depending on what i'm working
on making it really easy to just um demo
for the right size go under new and
let's go ahead and create a new python
and once we're in our new python window
this is going to leave it untitled
let's go ahead and import import
tensorflow as tf
at this point we'll go ahead and just
run it real quick
no errors yay no errors
i
i do that whenever i do my imports
because i unbearably will have opened up
a new environment and forgotten to
install tensorflow into that environment
or something along those lines so it's
always good to double check
and if we're going to double check that
we also it's also good to know
what version we're working with and we
can do that simply by
using the version command in tensorflow
which you should know is is probably
intuitively the tf
dot underscore underscore version
underscore underscore
and
you know it always confuses me because
sometimes you do tf.version for one
thing you do tf dot underscore version
underscore for another thing
this is a double underscore in
tensorflow for pulling your version out
and it's good to know what you're
working with we're going to be working
in tensorflow version 2.1.0 and i did
tell you the the um we were going to dig
a little deeper into our constants and
you can do an array of constants and
we'll just create this nice array
a equals tf.constant
and we're just going to put the ray
right in there 4361.
uh we can run this and now that is what
a is equal to and if we want to just
double check that remember we're in
jupiter notebook where you can just put
the letter a
and it knows that that's going to be
print
otherwise you'd round you surround it in
print and you can see it's a tf tensor
it has the shape the type and the and
the array on here it's a two by two
array and just like we can create a
constant we can go and create a variable
and this is also going to be a 2 by 2
array and if we go ahead and print the v
out we'll run that
and sure enough there's our tf variable
in
here then we can also let's just go back
up here and add this in here
i could create another tensor and we'll
make it a constant this time
and we're going to put that in over here
we'll have b tf constant and if we go
and print out
v and b
i'm going to run that
and this is an interesting thing that
always that happens in here you'll see
right here when i print them both out
what happens it only prints the last one
unless you use print commands so
important to remember that in jupyter
notebooks we can easily fix that by go
ahead and print and surround v with
brackets and now we can see with the two
different variables we have
we have the 3152 which is a variable and
this is just a flat
constant so it comes up as a tf tensor
shape 2 kind of 2. and that's
interesting to note
that this label is a tf.tensor and this
is a tf variable
so that's how it's looking in the back
end when you're talking about the
difference between a variable and a
constant
the other thing i want you to notice is
that in variable we capitalize the v and
with the constant we have a lowercase c
little things like that can lose you
when you're programming and you're
trying to find out hey why doesn't this
work
so those are a couple little things to
note in here and just like any other
array in math
we can do like a concatenate or
concatenate the different values here
and you can see we can take a b
concatenated you just do a t f dot
concat
values and there's our a b axes on one
hopefully you're familiar with axes and
how that works when you're dealing with
matrixes and if we go ahead and print
this out
you'll see right here we end up with a
tensor so let's put it in as a constant
not as a variable
and you have your array four three seven
eight and six one four five it's
concatenated the two together and again
i want to highlight a couple things on
this our axis equals one this means
we're doing the columns um so if you had
a longer array like right now we have an
array that is like you know has a shape
one whatever it is two comma two
um axes
zero
is going to be your first one and axes
one is going to be your second one and
it translates as columns and rows
if we had a shape let me just put the
word shape here
um
so you know what i'm talking about it's
very clear and this is i'll tell you
what i spent a lot of time
looking at these shapes and trying to
figure out which direction i'm going in
and whether to flip it or whatever
so you can get lost in which way your
matrix is going which is column which is
rows are you dealing with the third axes
or the second axis
axis one you know zero one two that's
going to be our columns and if you can
do columns then we also can do rows and
that is simply just changing the
concatenate
we'll just grab this one here and copy
it we'll do the whole thing over
ctrl
copy ctrl v and changes from axes one
to axis zero and if we run that
you'll see that now we concatenate by
row as opposed to column
and you have four three six one seven
eight four seven so it just brings it
right down and turns it into rows versus
columns you can see the difference there
your output
this really you want to look at the
output sometimes just to make sure your
eyes are looking at it correctly and
it's in the format i find visually
looking at it is almost more important
than
understanding
what's going on because conceptually
your mind just just too many dimensions
sometimes
the second thing i want you to notice is
this says a numpy array so tensorflow is
utilizing numpy as part of their format
as far as python is concerned
and so you can treat you can treat this
output like a numpy array because it is
just that it's going to be a numpy array
another thing that comes up uh more than
you would think is filling uh one of
these with zeros or ones and so you can
see here we just create a tensor
tf.zeros
and we give it a shape we tell it what
kind of data type it is in this case
we're doing an integer
and then if we
print out our tensor again we're in
jupiter so i just type out tensor and i
run this you can see i have a nice
array of the shape three comma four of
zeros one of the things i want to
highlight here is integer 32. if i go to
the
tensorflow data types i want you to
notice how
we have float 16 float 32 float 64
complex if we scroll down you'll see the
integer down here 32 the reason for this
is that we want to control how many bits
are used in the precision
this is for exporting it to another
platform
so what would happen is i might run it
on this computer where python goes does
a float to indefinite however long it
wants to
and then we can take it but we want to
actually say hey we don't want that high
precision we want to be able to run this
on any computer and so we need to
control whether it's a tf float 16 in
this case we did an integer 32
we could also do this as a float
so if i run this as a float 32
that means this has a 32 bit precision
you'll see zero point whatever and then
to go with zeros
we have ones if we're going from the
opposite side and so we can easily just
create a tensorflow with ones
and you might ask yourself why would i
want zeros and ones and your first
thought might be to initiate a new
tensor
usually we initiate a lot of this stuff
with random numbers because it does a
better job solving it if you start with
a uniform
set of ones or zeros you're dealing with
a lot of bias so be very careful about
starting a neural network
for one of your rows or something like
that with ones and zeros
on the other hand
i use this for masking you can do a lot
of work with masking you can also have
it might be that
one tenser row is masked
you know zero is is false one is true or
whatever you want to do it
and so in that case you do want to use
the zeros and ones and there are cases
where you do want to initialize it with
all zeros or all ones and then swap in
different numbers as
the tensor learns so it's another form
of control
but in general
you see zeros and ones you usually are
talking about a mask over another array
and just like in numpy you can also
do reshapes so if we take our remember
this is shaped three comma four maybe we
wanna swap that to four comma three
and if we print this out
you will see let me just go and do that
ctrl v
let me run that
and you'll see that the the order of
these is now switched instead of four
across now we have three across and four
down
and just for fun let's go back up here
where we did the ones
and i'm going to change the ones to
tf.random
uniform
and we'll go ahead and just take off
well we'll go and leave that i'm going
to run this
and you'll see now we have
0.0441 and this way you can actually see
how the reshape looks a lot different
0.041.15.71 and then instead of having
this one it rolls down here to the 0.14
and this is what i was talking about
sometimes you feel a lot of times you
fill these with random numbers and so
this is the random dot uniform is one of
the ways to do that now i just talked a
little bit about this float 32 and all
these data types
one of the things that comes up of
course is
recasting your data
so if we have a d type float 32 we might
want to convert these to integers
because of the project we're working on
i know one of the projects i've worked
on
ended up wanting to do a lot of round
off so that it would take a dollar
amount or a float value and then have to
rent it off to a dollar amount so we
only wanted two decimal points
and in which case you have a lot of
different options you can multiply by
100 and then round it off or whatever
you want to do there's a lot of or then
converted to an integer was one way to
round it off
uh kind of
a cheap and dirty trick
uh so we can take this and we can take
this same
tensor and we'll go ahead and create a
as an integer and so we're going to take
this tensor we're going to tf.cast it
and if we print
tensor
and then we're going to go ahead and
print
our tensor
let me just do a quick copy and paste
and when i'm actually programming i
usually type out a lot of my stuff just
to double check it
in doing a demo
copy and paste works fine but sometimes
be aware that copy and paste can copy
the wrong code over
personal choice depends on what i'm
working on
and you can see here we took
a float 32 4.6 4.2 and so on and it just
converts it right down to a integer
value
sorry integer 32 set up and
remember we talked about
a little bit about reshape
as far as flipping it and i just did
four comma three on the reshape up here
and we talked about axes zero axis one
uh one of the things that is important
to be able to do is to take one of these
variables we'll just take this last one
tensor as integer
and i want to go ahead and transpose it
and so i can do
we'll do a
equals tf.transpose
and we'll do our tensor integer in there
and then if i print the a out and we run
this
you'll see that's the same array but
we've flipped it so that our columns and
rows are flipped this is
the same as reshaping so when you
transpose you're just doing a reshape
what's nice about this is if you look at
the numbers the columns
when we went up here and we did the
reshape they kind of rolled down to the
next row so you're not maintaining the
structure of your matrix so when we do a
reshape up here they're similar but
they're not quite the same and you can
actually go in here and there's settings
in the reshape that would allow you to
turn it into a transform
uh so we come down here it's all done
for you and so there are so many times
you have to transpose
your digits that this is important to
know that you can just do that you can
flip your rows and columns rather
quickly here and just like numpy you can
also do multiple your different math
functions we'll look at multiplication
and so we're going to take matrix
multiplication of tensors
we'll go ahead and create a
as a constant 5839
and we'll put in a vector v 4 comma 2.
and we could have done this where they
matched where this was a two by two
array
but instead
we're going to do just a
two by one array and the code for that
is your tf.mat
mole
so matrix multiplier and we have a times
v and if we go ahead and run this up
let's
make sure we print out our av on there
and if we go ahead and run this
you'll see that we end up with 36 by 30.
and if it's been a while since you've
seen the matrix math
this is
5 times 4 plus 8 times 2
3 times 4 plus 9 times 2.
and that's where we get the 36 and 30.
now i know we're covering a lot really
quickly as far as the basic
functionality
so the matrix or your matrix multiplier
is a very commonly used backend tool as
far as computing
different models or linear regression
stuff like that
one of the things
is to note is that just like in
numpy you have all of your different
math so we have our tf math
and if we go in here we have
functions we have our cosines absolute
angle all of that's in here so all of
these
are available for you to use in the
tensorflow model
and if we go back to our example and
let's go ahead and pull
oh let's do some multiplication that's
always good we'll stick with our
av
our
constant a and our vector v
and we'll go ahead and do some bit wise
multiplication and we'll create an av
which is a times b let's go and print
that out
and you can see coming across here
we have the 4 2 and the 5 8 3 9 and it
produces 20 32 6 18.
and that's pretty straight forward if
you look at you have 4 times
5 is 20 4 times 8 is
that's where those numbers come from
now we can also quickly create an
identity matrix
which is basically
your main values on the diagonal being
ones and zeros across the other side
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what that
looks like and we can do let's do this
so we're going to get the shape this is
a simple way very similar to your numpy
you can do a dot shape and it's going to
return a tuple in this case our rows and
columns and so we can do a quick
print
we'll do rows
oops
and we'll do columns
and if we run this
you can see we have three rows uh two
columns
and then if we go ahead and create an
identity matrix
the
scoops the script for that
got a wrong button there the script for
that looks like this
where we have the number of rows equals
rows the number of columns equals
columns and d type is a 32 and then if
we go ahead and just print out our
identity
you can see we have a nice identity
column with our ones going across here
now clearly we're not going to go
through every math module
available but we do want to start
looking at this as a prediction model
and seeing how it functions
so we're going to move on to a more of a
direct setup we can actually see the
full tensorflow in use for that let's go
back and create a
new setup
and we'll go in here new python 3 module
there we go
bring this out so it takes up the whole
window because i like to do that
hopefully you made it through that first
part and you have a basic understanding
of tensorflow as far as being a series
of numpy arrays you've got your math
equations and different things that go
into them
we're going to start building a full
setup as far as the numpy so you can see
how
kara sits on top of it and the different
aspects of how it works
the first thing we want to do is we're
going to go ahead and do a lot of
imports
date times warning scipy scipy is your
math so the back end scientific math
warnings because
whenever we do a lot of this you have
older versions newer versions
and so sometimes when you get warnings
you want to go ahead and just suppress
them
we'll talk about that if it comes up on
this particular setup and of course date
time pandas again is your data frame
think rows and columns we import it as
pd
numpy is your numbers array
which of course tensorflow is integrated
heavily with
seaborn for our graphics and the seaborn
as sns is going to be set on top of our
map plot library which we import as mpl
and then of course we're going to import
our matplot library pi plot as plt and
right off the bat we're going to set
some graphic colors
patch force edge color equals true
the style we're going to use the 538
style you can look this all up there's
when you get into matplot library into
seaborne there are so many options in
here it's just kind of nice to make it
look pretty when we start the um
when we start up that way we don't have
to think about it later on
uh and then we're going to take we have
our
mplrc we're going to put a patch ed
color dim gray line width again this is
all part of our graphics here in our
setup we'll go ahead and do an
interactive shell node interactivity
equals last expression
uh here we are pd for pandas options
display max columns so we don't want to
display more than 50.
and then our map plot library is going
to be inline this is a jupiter notebook
thing the map plot library in line
then warnings we're going to filter our
warnings and we're just going to ignore
warnings that way when they come up we
don't have to worry about them
not really what you want to do when
you're working on a major project you
want to make sure you know those
warnings and then
filter them out and ignore them later on
and if we run this it's just going to be
loading all that into the background
so that's a little back end kind of
stuff then we want to go ahead and do is
we want to go ahead and import
our specific packages
that we're going to be working with
which is under cross now remember cross
kind of sits on tensorflow so when we're
importing cross and the sequential model
we are in effect importing
tensorflow underneath of it
we just brought in the math probably
should have put that up above
and then we have our cross models we're
going to import sequential now if you
remember from our
slide there was three different options
let me just flip back over there so we
can have a quick
recall on that and so in carass
we have sequential functional and
subclassing so remember those three
different setups in here we talked about
earlier and if you remember from here we
have a sequential where it's going
one tensorflow layer at a time you go
kind of look at think of it as going
from left to right or top to bottom or
whatever direction it's going in but it
goes in one direction all the time where
functional can have a very complicated
graph of directions you can have the
data split into two separate
tensors and then it comes back together
into another tensor
all those kinds of things and then
subclassing is really the really
complicated one where now you're adding
your own subclasses into the tensor to
do external computations right in the
middle of like a huge flow of data
but we're going to stick with sequential
it's not a big jump to go from
sequential to functional
but we're running a sequential
tensorflow and that's what this first
import is here we want to bring in our
sequential and then we have our layers
and let's talk a little bit about these
layers this is where cross and
tensorflow
really are happening this is what makes
them so nice to work with is all these
layers are pre-built
so from cross we have layers import
dense
from cross layers import lstm
when we talk about these layers
cross has so many built-in layers you
can do your own layers
the dense layer is your standard neural
network
by default it uses relu for its
activation
and then the lstm is a long short-term
memory layer since we're going to be
looking probably at sequential data
we want to go ahead and do the lstm and
if we go into
cross and we look at their layers this
is across website you can see as we
scroll down for the cross layers that
are built in
we can get down here and we can look at
let's see here we have our layer
activation our base layers um
activation layer weight layer waste
there's a lot of stuff in here we had
the relu which is the basic activation
that was listed up here for layer
activations you can change those and
here we have our core layers
and our dense layers we have an input
layer a dense layer
and then we've added a more customized
one with the long-term short-term memory
layer and of course you can even do your
own custom layers in cross there's a
whole functionality in there if you're
doing your own thing
what's really nice about this is it's
all built in even the convolutional
layers this is for processing graphics
there's a lot of cool things in here you
can do
this is white cross is so popular it's
open source and you have all these tools
right at your fingertips so from cross
we're just going to import a couple
layers the dense layer
and the long short term memory layer
and then of course from
sk learn our scikit
we want to go ahead and do our min max
scalar standard scalar for pre editing
our
data and then metrics just so we can
take a look at the errors and compute
those let me go ahead and run this and
that just loads it up we're not
expecting anything from the output and
our file coming in is going to be air
quality.csv
let's go ahead and take a quick look at
that this is in open office it's just a
standard you know like we can do excel
whatever you're using for your
spreadsheet and you can see here we have
a number of columns a number of rows it
actually goes down to like 8 000
the first thing we want to notice is
that the first row
is kind of just a random number put in
going down
probably not something we're going to
work with
the second row
is bendung i'm guessing that's a
reference for the profile
if we scroll to the bottom which i'm not
going to do because it takes forever to
get back up
they're all the same
the same thing with the status the
status is the same
we have a date so we have a sequential
order here
here is the jam which i'm going to guess
is the time stamp on there so we have a
date and time
we have our o3 co no2 reading so2 no co2
voc
and then some other numbers here pm1 pm
2.5 pm 4 pm 10
without actually
looking through the data i mean some of
the second guesses like temperature
humidity i'm not sure what the pms are
but we have a whole slew of data here so
we're looking at air quality as far as
an area in a region and what's going on
with our date time stamps on there and
so code wise we're going to read this
into a pandas data frame so our data
frame df is a nice abbreviation commonly
used for data frames equals pd.read csv
and then our the path to it just happens
to be on my d drive
separated by spaces and so if we go
ahead and run this
we'll print out the head of our data and
again this looks very similar to what we
were just looking at
being in jupiter i can take this and go
the other way
make it real small so you can see all
the columns going across and we get a
full view of it
or we can bring it back up in size
that's pretty small on there overshot
but you can see it's the same data we
were just looking at we're looking at
the number we're looking at the profile
which is the bandung
the
date we have a time stamp
our 03 count co and so forth on here
and this is just your basic
pandas printing out the top five rows we
could easily have done
three rows
uh five rows ten whatever you want to
put in there by default that's five for
pandas now i talk about this all the
time so i know i've already said it at
least once or twice during this video
most of our work is in pre-formatting
data what are we looking at how do we
bring it together
so we want to go ahead and start with
our date time it's come in in two
columns
we have our date here and we have our
time
and we want to go ahead and combine that
and then we have this is just a simple
script in there that says combined date
time that's our formula we're building
our we're going to submit our
pandas data frame
and the tab name when we go ahead and do
this
that's all of our information that we
want to go ahead and create
and then goes for i in range df
shape 0.
so we're going to go through
the whole setup and we're going to list
tab append df location i
and here is our date going in there and
then return the numpy array list tab d
types date time 64. that's all we're
doing we're just switching this to a
date time stamp and if we go ahead and
do df date time equals combined date
time
and then i always like to uh print we'll
do df head
just so we see what that looks like
and so when we come out of this
we now have our setup on here and of
course it's edited on to the far right
here's our date time
you can see the format's changed
so there's our we've added in the date
time column and we've brought the date
over and we've taken this format here
and it's an actual variable with a 0 0 0
on here well that doesn't look good so
we need to also include the time part of
this we want to convert it into hourly
data
so let's go ahead and do that
to do that to finish combining our date
time let's go ahead and create a
little
script here to combine the time in there
same thing we just did we're just
creating a numpy array returning a numpy
array and cr forcing this into a date
time format and we can actually spend
hours just going through
these conversions how do you
pull it from the pandas data frame
how do you set it up
so i'm kind of skipping through it a
little fast because i want to stay
focused on tensorflow and cross
keep in mind this is like 80 of your
coding when you're doing a lot of this
stuff is going to be reformatting these
things resetting them back up uh so that
it looks right on here and you know it
just takes time to get through all that
but that is usually what the companies
are paying you for that's what the big
bucks are for
and we want to go ahead and a couple
things going on here is we're going to
go ahead and do our date time we're
going to reorganize some of our setup in
here convert into hourly data we just
put a pause in there
now remember we can select from df are
different columns we're going to be
working with and you're going to see
that we actually dropped
a couple of the columns those ones i
showed you earlier they're just
repetitive data so there's nothing in
there that exciting
and then we want to go ahead and we'll
create a
second
data frame here let me just get rid of
the df head
and df2 is we're going to group by date
time and we're looking at the mean value
and then we'll print that out so you can
see we're talking about
we have now reorganized this so we put
in date time 03 co
so now this is in the same order
as it was before and you'll see the date
time now has our zero zero
uh same date one two three and so on so
let's group the data together
so there's a lot more manageable and in
the format we want and in the right
sequential order
and if we go back to
there we go our air quality
you can see right here we're looking at
these columns going across we really
don't need since we're going to create
our own
date time column we can get rid of those
these are the different columns of
information we want and that should
reflect right here in the columns we
picked coming across so this is all the
same columns on there that's all we've
done is reformatted our data
grouped it together by date and then you
can see the different data coming out
set up on there and then as a data
scientist
first thing i want to do is get a
description what am i looking at uh and
so we can go ahead and do the df2
describe and this gives us our you know
describe gives us our basic data
analytics information we might be
looking for like what is the mean
standard
deviation uh minimum amount maximum
amount we have our first quarter second
quarter and third quarter
um
numbers also in there
so you can get a quick look at a glance
describing the data or descriptive
analysis
and even though we have our quantile
information in here we're going to dig a
little deeper into that
we're going to calculate the quantile
for each variable
we're going to look at a number of
things for each variable and we'll see
right here q1 we can simply do the
quantile 0.25 percent
which should match um our 25 percent up
here and we're going to be looking at
the min the max
and we're just going to do this is
basically we're breaking this down
for each uh different
variable in there
one of the things that's kind of fun to
do
we're going to look at that in just a
second let me get put the next piece of
code in here
clean out some of our
we're going to drop a couple thing our
last rows and first row because those
have
usually have a lot of null values and
the first row is just our titles so
that's important it's important to drop
those rows in here and so this right
here as we look at our different
quantiles
again it's it's the same you know we're
still looking at the 25
quantile here
we're going to do a little bit more with
this
so now that we've cleared off our first
and last rows
we're going to go ahead and go through
all of our columns and this way we can
look at each
column individually and so we'll
just create a q1 q3 min max min iqr max
iqr
and calculate the quantile of i of df2
we're basically doing
the math that they did up here but we're
splitting it apart that's all this is
and
this happens a lot because you might
want to look at individual if this was
my own project i would probably spend
days and days going through
what these different values mean
one of the biggest
data science
things we can look at that's important
is uh use your use your common sense
you know if you're looking at this data
and it doesn't make sense and you go
back in there and you're like wait a
minute what the heck did i just do
at that point you probably should go
back and double check what you have
going on
now uh we're looking at this and you can
see right here here's our attribute for
our o3 so we've broken it down uh we
have our q1 5.88 q3 10.37 if we go back
up here here's our 5.8 we've rounded it
off 10.37 is in there
so we've basically done the same math
just split it up we have our minimum and
our max iqr and that's computed let's
see where is it here we go
q1 minus 1.5 times iqr and the iqr is
your q3 minus q1 so that's the
difference between our two different
quarters and this is all
data science
as far as the hard math
really not we're actually trying to
focus on cross and tensorflow you still
got to go through all this stuff i told
you 80
of your programming is going through and
understanding what the heck
uh happened here
what's going on what does this data mean
and so when we're looking in that we're
going to go ahead and say hey
we've computed these numbers and the
reason we've computed these numbers is
if you take the minimum value and it's
less than your minimum iqr
that means something's going wrong there
and they usually in this case is going
to show us an outlier
so we want to go ahead and find the
minimum value if it's less than the min
minimum iqr it's an outlier and if the
max value is greater than the
max iqr we have an outlier and that's
all this is doing low outliers found
minimum value high outliers found
really important actually outliers are
almost everything in data sometimes
sometimes you do this project just to
find the outliers because you want to
know uh crime detection what are we
looking for we're looking for the
outliers what doesn't fit a normal
business deal and then we'll go ahead
and throw in just threw in a lot of code
oh my goodness uh so we have if your max
is greater than iqr print outlier is
found what we want to do is we want to
start cleaning up these outliers and so
we want to convert
we'll do create a convert nand
x max iqr equals max uh underscore iqr
min iqr equals mini qr so this is just
saying this is the data we're going to
send that's all that is in python and if
x is greater than the max iqr and x is
less than the min iqr x equals
null we're going to set it to null why
because we want to clear
these outliers out of the data now again
if you're doing fraud detection you
would do the opposite you would be
cleaning everything else that's not in
that series so that you can look at just
the outlier uh and then we're going to
convert the nand hum again we have x
max iqr is 100 percent min iqr is men
iqr
if x is greater than max iqr and x is
less than min iqr again we're going to
return a null value otherwise it's going
to remain the same value x x equals x
and you can see as we go through the
code if i equals
our hum
then we go ahead and do this
that's a column specific to humidity
that's your hum column
uh then we're going to go ahead and
convert do the
run a map on there and convert the non
e2m
uh you can see here it's this is just
cleanup uh we run we found out that
humidity probably has some weird values
in it
we have our outliers um
that's all this is
and so when we go ahead and finish this
and we take a look at our outliers
and we run this code here
we have a low outlier 2.04 we have a
high outlier
99.06
outliers have been interpolated
that means we've given them a new value
chances are these days when you're
looking at something like
these sensors coming in
they probably have a failed sensor in
there something went wrong
that's the kind of thing that you really
don't want to do your data analysis on
so that's what we're doing is we're
pulling that out and then converting it
over and setting it up method linear
so we interpolate left linears it's
going to fill that data in
based on a linear regression model of
similar data
same thing with this up here with the um
df2y interpolate that's what we're doing
again this is all data prep we're not
actually talking about tensorflow we're
just trying to get all our data
set up correctly so that when we run it
it's not going to cause problems or have
a huge bias
so we've dealt with outliers
specifically in humidity
and again this is one of these things
where when we start running
we ran through this you can see down
here that we have our
outliers found
high low outliers
migrated them in
we also know there's other issues going
on with this data
how do we know that
some of it's just looking at the data
playing with it until you start
understanding what's going on let's take
the temp value
and we're going to go ahead and use a
logarithmic function on the temp value
and
it's interesting because it's like how
do you how do you heck do you even know
to use logarithmic on the temp value
that's domain specific
we're talking about being an expert in
air care i'm not an expert in air care
um you know it's not
what i go look at i don't look at air
care data in fact this is probably the
first air care data set up i've looked
at but the experts come in there and
they come to you and say hey in data
science this is a exponentially variable
variable on here so we need to go ahead
and do
transform it
and use a logarithmic scale on that
so at that point that would be coming
from your
data here we go data science programmer
overview does a lot of stuff connecting
the database and connecting in with the
experts
data analytics a lot of times you're
talking about somebody who is a data
analysis might be all the way usually a
phd level data science programming level
interfaces database manager that's going
to be the person who's your admin
working on it
so when we're looking at this we're
looking at something they've sent to me
and they said hey
domain air care this needs to be this is
a skew because the data just goes up
exponentially and affects everything
else and we'll go ahead and take that
data let me just go ahead and run this
just for another quick look at it
we have our
uh we'll do a distribution df
we'll create another data frame from the
temp values and then from a data set
from the log temp so we can put them
side by side and we'll just go ahead and
do a quick histogram and this is kind of
nice plot of figure figure size here's
our plt from matplot library
and then we'll just do a distribution
underscore df there's our data frames
this is nice because it just integrates
the histogram right into pandas love
pandas
and this is a chart you would send back
to your data analysis and say hey is
this what you wanted this is how the
data is converting on here as a data
science scientist the first thing i note
is we've gone from a 10 20 30 scales at
2.5 3.0 3.5 scale
and the data itself has kind of been
adjusted a little bit based on some kind
of a skew on there so let's jump into
we're getting a little closer to
actually doing our
cross on here
we'll go ahead and split our data up
and this of course is any good data
scientists
you want to have a training set and a
test set
and we'll go ahead and do the train size
we're going to use 0.75 percent of the
data make sure it's an integer we don't
want to take a slice as a float value
give you a nice error
and we'll have our train size of 75
and the test size is going to be
of course the train size minus the
length of the data set and then we can
simply do train comma test
here's our data set
which is going to be the train size the
test size and then if we go and print
this let me just go ahead and run this
we can see how these values
split it's a nice split of 1298 and then
433 points of value
they're going to be for our
setup on here and if you remember we're
specifically looking at the data set
where did we create that data set from
that was from up here that's what we
called the
logarithmic
value of the temp
that's where the data set came from so
we're looking at just that column with
this train size and the test with the
train and test data set here and let's
go ahead and do uh convert an array of
values into a data set matrix we're
going to create a little
setup in here we create our data set our
data set's going to come in we're going
to do a look back of one so we're going
to look back one piece of data going
backward
and we have our data x and our data y
for i and range length of data set look
back -1
this is creating let me just go ahead
and run this actually the best way to do
this
is to go ahead and create this data
and take a look at the shape of it let
me go ahead and just put that code in
here
so we're going to do a look back one
here's our train x our train y and it's
going to be adding the data on there and
then when we come up here
and we take a look at the shape
there we go
and we run this piece of code here
we look at the shape on this and we have
a new slightly different change on here
but we have a shape of x 1296 comma 1
shape of y train y test x text y
and so what we're looking at is that
the x comes in
and we're only having a single value at
out
uh we want to predict what the next one
is that's what this little piece of code
is here for what are we looking for well
we want to look back one that's the um
that we're going to train the data with
is yesterday's data yesterday says hey
the humidity was at
97 percent what should today's humidity
be at if it's 97 yesterday is it going
to go up or is it going to go down today
if 97 does it go up to 100 what's going
on there and so our we're looking
forward to the next piece of data which
says hey tomorrow's is going to you know
today's humidity is this this is what
tomorrow's humidity is going to be
that's all that is all that is is
stacking our data so that
our y is basically
x plus 1 or x could be y minus 1.
and then a couple of things to note is
our x data
we're only dealing with the one column
but you need to have it in a shape that
has it by the columns so you have the
two different numbers and since we're
doing just a single point of data
we have and you'll see with the train y
we don't need to have the extra shape on
here
now this is going to run into a problem
and the reason is is that we have what
they call a time step
and the time step is that long term
short term memory layer
so we're going to add another reshape on
here let me just go down here and put it
into the next cell
and so we want to reshape the input
array in the form of sample time step
features
we're only looking at one feature
and i mean this is one of those things
when you're playing with this you're
like why am i getting an error in the
numpy array why is this giving me
something weird going on uh so we're
gonna do is we're gonna add one more uh
level on here instead of being 12.99
1299.1 we want to go one more
and when they put the code together in
the back you can see we kept the same
shape the 1299
we added the one dimension and then we
have our train x shape one
and this could have depends again on how
far back in the long short term memory
you want to go
that is what that piece of code is for
and that reshape is and you can see the
new shape is now one uh
1299 one one
versus the 1299 one and then the other
part of the shape 432 one one again this
is our tr our x in and of course our
test x and then our y is just a single
column because we're just doing one
output that we're looking for
so now we've done our 80 percent um you
know that's all the the
writing all the code reformatting our
data
um
bringing it in now we want to go ahead
and do the fun part which is we're going
to go ahead and create and fit
the lstm neural network
and if we're going to do that the first
thing we need is we're going to need to
go ahead and create a model and we'll do
this sequential model and if you
remember sequential means it just goes
in order that means we have if you have
two layers the layers go from layer one
to layer two or layer zero to layer one
this is different than functional
functional allows you to split the data
and run two completely separate models
and then bring them back together
we're doing just sequential on here and
then we decided to do the long short
term memory uh and we have our input
shape which it comes in again this is
what all this switching was we could
have easily made this one two three or
four going back as far as the end number
on there we just stuck to going back one
and it's always a good idea when you get
to this point where the heck
is this model coming from
what kind of models do we have available
and there's
let me go and put the next model in
there
because we're going to do two models and
the next model is going to go ahead and
we're going to do dent so we have model
equal sequential
and then we're going to add the lstm
model and then we're going to add a
dense model and if you remember from the
very top of our code
where we did the imports oops there we
go our cross
this is it right here here's our
importing a dense model and here's our
importing an lstm now just about every
tensorflow model uses dents
your dense model is your basic
forward propagation reverse propagation
error
or it does reverse propagation to
program the model
so any of your neural networks you've
already looked at that
luxon says here's the error and sends
the error backwards that's what this is
the long short term memory is a little
different
the real question that we want to look
at right now is where do you find these
models what kind of models do you have
available and so for that let's go to
the cross website
which is the cross dot io
if you go under api
layers and i always have to do a search
just search for cross api layers it'll
open up and you can see we have um
your base layers right here class
trainable weights all kinds of stuff
like there your activation
so a lot of your layers you can switch
how it activates uh relu which is like
your smaller arrays or if you're doing
convolutional neural networks the
convolution usually uses a relu
your sigmoid all the way up to softmax
soft plus all these different choices as
far as how those
are set up and what we want to do is we
want to go ahead and if you scroll down
here you'll see your core layers and
here is your dense layer
so you have an input object your dense
layer your activation layer embedding
layer
this is your your kind of your one set
up on there that's most common
uh convolutional neural networks or
convolutional layers these are like for
doing uh image categorizing uh so trying
to find objects in a picture that kind
of thing
uh we have pooling layers so as you have
the layers come together
usually you bring them down into
a single layer although you can still do
like global max pulling 3d and there is
just i mean this list just goes on and
on there's all kinds of different things
hidden in here as far as what you can do
and it changes you know you go in here
and you just have to do a search for
what you're looking for
and figure out what's going to work best
for you
as far as which project you're working
on uh long short-term memory is a big
one because this is when we start
talking about text
uh what if someone says the what comes
after the uh the cat in the hat a little
kid's book there
it starts programming it and so you
really want to know not only
what's going on but it's going to be
something that has a history the history
behind it tells you what the next one
coming up is
now once we've built all our different
you know we built our model we've added
our different layers we went in there
play with it remember if you're in
functional you can actually link these
layers together and they branch out and
come back together if you do a
the sub
setup then you can create your own
different model you can embed a model in
there that might become linear
regression you can embed a linear
regression model
as part of your functional split and
then have that come back together with
other things so we're going to go ahead
and compile your model this brings
everything together we're going to put
in what the loss is which we'll use the
mean squared error
and we'll go ahead and use the atom
optimizer clearly there's a lot of
choices on here depending on what you're
doing and just like any of these
different prediction models if you've
been doing any uh
scikit from python
you'll recognize that we have to then
fit the model
so what are we doing in here we're going
to send in our train x our train y
we're going to decide how many epochs
we're going to run it through
500 is probably a lot for this i'm
guessing it'd probably be about two or
three hundred probably do just fine
our batch size
so how many different uh when you
process it this is the math behind it if
you're in data analytics
you might try know what this number is
as a data scientist where i haven't had
the phd level math that says this is why
you want to use this particular batch
size you kind of play with this number a
little bit
you can dig deeper into the math
see how it affects the results depending
what you're doing
and there's a number of other settings
on here we did verbose 2. i'd have to
actually look that up to tell you what
verbose means i think that's actually
the default on there if i remember
correctly
there's a lot of different settings when
you go to fit it
the big ones are your epic and your
batch size those are what we're looking
for
and so we're going to go ahead and run
this
and this is going to take a few minutes
to run because it's going through
500 times
through all the data so if you have a
huge data set this is the point where
you're kind of wondering oh my gosh is
this going to finish tomorrow
if i'm running this on a single machine
and i have a tera terabyte of data
going into it
if this is my personal computer and i'm
running a terabyte of data into this
you know this is running rather quickly
through all 500 iterations uh but yeah a
terabyte of data we're talking something
closer to days week
you know even with a
3.5 gigahertz machine and in eight cores
it's still going to take a long time to
go through a full terabyte of data
and then we want to start looking at
putting it into some other framework
like spark or something that will print
the process on there more across
multiple
processors and multiple computers
and if we scroll all the way down to the
bottom you're going to see here's our
square mean error of 0.0088
if we scroll way up you'll see it kind
of oscillates between 0.088 and 0.8089
it's right around 2 to 250 where you
start seeing that oscillation where it's
really not going anywhere so we really
didn't need to go through a full 500
epics
you know if you're retraining this stuff
over and over again it's kind of good to
know where that
error zone is so you don't have to do
all the extra processing of course if
you're going to build a model
we want to go ahead and run a prediction
on it
so let's go ahead and make our
prediction remember we have our training
test set
and our test set or the
we have the
train x and the train y for training it
or train predict and then we have our
test x and our test y going in there so
we can test to see how good it did
and we come in here we have
you'll see right here we go ahead and do
our train predict equals
model predict train x
and test predict model predict test x
why would we want to run the prediction
on train x well it's not a hundred
percent on its prediction we know it has
a certain amount of error and we want to
compare the error we have on what we
programmed it with with the error we get
when we run it on new data that's never
seen the model's never seen before and
one of the things we can do we go ahead
and invert the predictions
this helps us
level it off a little bit more
get rid of some of our bias we have
train predict equals and np
exponential m1 the train predict
and then train y equals the exponential
m1 for train y and then we do the again
that with train test predict and test
why
again reformatting the data so that we
can it all matches and then we want to
go ahead and calculate the root mean
square error
so we have our train score
which is your math square root times the
mean square root error train
y and train predict and again we're just
um this is just feeding the data through
so we can compare it and the same thing
with the test
and let's take a look at that because
really
the code makes sense if you're going
through it line by line you can see what
we're doing but the answer really helps
to zoom in
so we have a train score which is 2.40
of our root mean square error
and we have a test score of 3.16 of the
root mean square error
if these were reversed if our test score
is better than our training score then
we've over trained something's really
wrong at that point you got to go back
and figure out what you did wrong
because you should never have a better
result on your test data than you do
when you're training data and that's why
we put them both through that's why we
look at the error for both the training
and the testing
when you're going out and quoting you're
publishing this you're saying hey how
good is my model it's the test score
that you're showing people this is what
it did on my test data that the model
had never seen before this is how good
my model is and a lot of times you
actually want to put together like a
little formal
code where we actually want to print
that out and if we print that out you
can see down here
test prediction standard deviation of
data set 3.16 is less than 4.40
i have to go back
and we're
up here if you remember we did the
square means error this is standard
deviation that's why these numbers are
different
it's saying the same thing that we just
talked about
3.16 is less than 4.40 model is good
enough we're saying hey this is this
model is valid we have a valid model
here so we can go ahead and go with that
uh and along with
putting a formal print out of there
we want to go ahead and plot what's
going on
and this we just want to pretty graft
here so that people can see what's going
on when i walk into a meeting and i'm
dealing with a number of people
they really don't want these numbers
they don't want to say hey what's i mean
standard deviation unless you know what
statistics are
you might be dealing with a number of
different departments head of cells
might not work with standard deviation
or have any idea what that really means
number wise and so at this point we
really want to put it in a graph so we
have something to display and with
displaying you remember that we're
looking at uh the data
today going into it and what's going to
happen tomorrow
so let's take a quick look at this we're
going to go ahead and shift the train
predictions for plotting we have our
train predict plot uh np empty leg data
set uh train predict plot
uh set it up with uh null values
yeah
you know it's just kind of it's kind of
a weird thing where we're creating the
um the
data groups as we like them
and then putting the data in there is
what's going on here so we have our
train predict plot
which is going to be our look back our
length
plus look back
we're just is going to equal train
train predict
so we're creating this basically we're
taking this and we're dumping the train
predict into it so now we have our nice
train predict plot
and then we have the shift test
predictions for the plotting we're going
to continue more of that oops looks like
i put it in here double no it's just uh
yeah they put it in here double
um didn't mean to do that
we really only need to do it once oh
here we go
um this is where the problem was is
because
this is the test predict
so we have our training prediction we're
doing the shift on here and then the
test predict we're going to look at that
same thing we're just creating those two
data sets
test
predict plot length prediction set up on
there
and then we're going to go through the
plotting the original data set and the
predictions so we have a time axis
always nice to have your time set on
there
set that to the time array
time axes lap
all this is setting up the time variable
for the bottom and then we have a lot of
stuff going on here as far as setting up
our figure
let's go ahead and run that and then
we'll break it down
we have on here
our main plot we have two different
plots going on here
the ispu going up and the data and the
ispu here with all these different
settings on it
and so we look at this we have our ax1
that's the main plot i mean our ax
that's the main plot and we have our ax1
which is the secondary plot over here so
we're doing a figure plt
or plt.figure
and we're going to dump those two graphs
on there
and so we take
and if you
go through the code piece by piece
which we're not going to do we're going
to do the
the
data set here exponential reverse
exponential so it looks correctly we're
going to label it the original data set
we're going to plot the train predict
plot that's what we just created
we're going to make that orange and
we'll label it train prediction
test predicts plot we're going to make
that red and label it test prediction
and so forth
set our ticks up this actually just put
ticks time axes gets its ticks
the little little marks they're going
along the axes that kind of thing and
let's take a look and see what these
graphs look like
and these are just kind of fun you know
when you show up into a meeting and this
is the final output you say hey this is
what we're looking at
here's our original data in blue
here's our training prediction
you can see that it trains pretty close
to what the data is up there
i would also probably put a
like a little
little time stamp and do just right
before and right after where we go from
train to test prediction
and you can see with the test prediction
the data comes in in red
and then you can also see what the
original data set look like behind it
and how it differs
and then we can just isolate that here
on the right that's all this is
is just the
test prediction on the right uh and it's
you know there's you'll see with the
original data set there's a lot of peaks
were missing and a lot of lows were
missing
but as far as the actual test prediction
it's pretty it does pretty good it's
pretty right on you can get a good idea
what to expect for your ispu
and so from this we would probably
publish it and say hey this is um
what you expect and this is our area of
this is a range of error that's the kind
of thing i put out
on a daily basis maybe we predict the
cells are going to be this or maybe
weekly so you kind of get a nice kind of
flatten the
data coming out and you say hey this is
what we're looking at the big takeaway
from this is that we're working with
let me go back up here oops oh too far
there we go
is this model here this is what this is
all about we worked through all of those
pieces um all the tensorflows and that
is to build this sequential model and
we're only putting in the two layers
this can get pretty complicated if you
get too complicated it never
it it never verges into a usable model
so if you have like 30 different layers
in here there's a good chance you might
crash it kind of thing
so don't go too haywire on that and that
you kind of learn as you go again it's
domain knowledge
and also starting to understand all
these different layers and what they
mean
the data
analytics behind those layers
is something that your data analysis
professional will come in and say this
is what we want to try
but i tell you as a data scientist
a lot of these basic setups are common
and i don't know how many times
working with somebody and they're like
oh my gosh if i only did a tangent h
instead of a relu activation
i worked for two weeks to figure that
out well as a data science i can run it
through the model in you know five
minutes instead of spending two weeks
doing the the math behind it
so that's one of the advantages of data
scientist is we do it from programming
side and a data analytics is going to
look for it how does it work in math
and this is really the core right here
of tensorflow and cross is being able to
build your data model quickly and
efficiently and of course uh with any
data science putting out a pretty graph
so that your shareholders again we want
to take and
reduce the information down to something
people can look at and say oh that's
what's going on they can see stuff
what's going on as far as the dates and
the change in the ispu
in this video i will walk you through
the tensorflow code to perform object
detection in a video so let's get
started this part is basically we are
importing all the libraries we need a
lot of these libraries for example numpy
we need image i o date time and pill and
so on and so forth and of course
matplotlib so we import all these
libraries and then there are a bunch of
variables which have some paths for the
files and folders so this is regular
stuff let's keep moving then we import
the matplotlib and make it inline and
a few more imports all right and then
these are some warnings we can just
ignore them so if i run this code once
again we could go away right and then
here onwards we do the model preparation
now what we're going to do is we're
going to use an existing neural network
model so we are not going to chain a new
one because that really will take a long
time and it needs a lot of computation
resources and so on and it is really not
required there are already models that
have been trained and in this case it is
the ssd with mobilenet that's the model
that we are going to use and this model
is trained to detect objects and it is
readily available as open source so we
can actually use this and if you want to
use other models there are a few more
models available so you can click on
this
link here and let me just take you there
there are few more models but we have
chosen this particular one because this
is faster it may not be very accurate
but that is one of the faster models but
on this link you will see a lot of other
models that are readily available these
are trained models some of them would
take a little longer but they may be
more accurate and so on so you can
probably play around with these other
models okay so we will be using that
model so this
piece of code this line is basically
importing that model and this is also
known as
frozen model the term we use is frozen
model so we import download and import
that and then we will actually use that
model in our code all right so these two
cells
we have downloaded and import the model
and then once it is available locally we
will then load this into our program all
right so
we are loading this into memory and
you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to to map the numbers to text as
you may be aware when we actually build
the model and when we run predictions
the model will not give a text the
output of the model is usually a number
so we need to map that to a text so for
example if the network predicts that the
output is 5 we know that 5 means it is
an airplane things like that so this
mapping is done in this next cell all
right so let's keep moving and then we
have a helper code which will basically
load the data or load the images and
transform into numpy arrays this is also
used in doing object detection in images
so we are actually going to reuse
because video is nothing but it consists
of frames which in turn are images so we
are going to pretty much use reuse the
same code which we use for doing object
detection in images so this is where the
actual detection starts so here this is
the path for where the images are stored
so this is here once again we are
reusing the code which we wrote for
detecting objects in an image so this is
the path where the images were stored
and this is the extension and this was
done for about two or three images so we
will continue to use this and
we go down i'll skip this section so
this is the cell where we are actually
loading the video and converting it into
frames and then using frame by frame we
are detecting the objects in the image
so in this code what we are doing
basically is there are a few lines of
code what they do is basically once they
find an object a box will be drawn
around those
each of those objects and the input file
the name of the input video file is
traffic it is the extension is mp4 and
we have this video reader it's a
excellent object which is basically part
of this class called image i o so we can
read and write videos using that and the
video that we are going to use is
traffic.mp4 you can use any mp4 file but
in our case i picked up video which has
uh like car so let me just show you so
this is in this object detection folder
i have this mp4 file i'll just quickly
play this video it's a little slow yeah
okay so here we go this is the video
it's a short one relatively small video
so that for this particular demo and
what it will do is once we run our code
it will detect each of these cars and it
will annotate them as cars so in this
particular video we only have cars we
can later on see with another video i
think i have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this traffic video so let me go back so
we will be reading this frame by frame
and
you know actually we will be
reading the video file but then we will
be analyzing it frame by fame and we
will be reading them at 10 frames per
second that is the rate we are
mentioning here and analyzing it and
then annotating and then writing it back
so you will see that we will have a
video file named something like this
traffic underscore annotated and
we will see the annotated video so let's
go back and run through this piece of
code and then we will come back and see
the annotated video this might take a
little while so i will pause the video
after
running this particular cell and then
come back to show you the results all
right so let's go ahead and run it so it
is running now and it is also important
that at the end you close the video
writer so that it is similar to a file
pointer when you open a file you should
also make sure you close it so that it
doesn't hog the resources so it's very
similar at the end of it the last piece
or last line of code should be video
underscore writer dot close all right so
i'll pause and then i'll come back okay
so i will see you in a little bit all
right so now as you can see here the
processing is done the hourglass has
disappeared that means the video has
been processed so let's go back and
check the annotated video we'll go back
to my file manager so this was the
original
traffic.mp4 and now you have here
traffic underscore annotated mp4 so
let's go and run this and see how it
looks
you see here just got each of these cars
are getting detected let me pause and
show you so we pause here it says car 70
percent let us allow it to go a little
further it detects something on top what
is that truck okay so i think because of
the board on top it somehow thinks there
is a truck let's play some more and see
if it detects anything else so this is
again a car looks like so let us yeah so
this is a car and
it has confidence level of 69 percent
okay this is again a car all right so
basically till the end it goes and
detects each and every car that is
passing by now we can quickly repeat
this process for another video let me
just show you the other video which is a
cat again there is uh this cat is not
really moving or anything but it is just
standing there staring and moving a
little slowly and our application will
our network will detect that this is a
cat and
even when the cat moves a little bit in
the other direction it will continue to
detect and show that it is a cat okay so
yeah so this is how the original video
is let's go ahead and change our code to
analyze this one and see if it detects
our network detects this cat close this
here we go and i'll go back to my code
all we need to do is change this traffic
to
cat the extension it will automatically
pick up because it is given here and
then it will run through so very quickly
once again what it is doing is this
video reader video underscore reader has
a neat little feature or interface
whereby you can say for frame in video
underscore reader so it will basically
provide frame by frame so you're in a
loop frame by frame and then you take
that each frame that is given to you you
take it and analyze it as if it is an
image individual image so that's the way
it works so it is very easy to handle
this all right so now let's once again
run just this cell the rest of the stuff
remains the same so i will run this cell
again it will take a little while so the
r classes come back i will pause and
then come back in a little while all
right so the processing is done let's go
and check the annotated video go here so
we have get annotated dot mp4 let's play
this all right so you can see here it is
detecting the cat and in the beginning
you also saw it detected something else
here there looks like it detected one
more object so let's just go back and
see what it has detected here
let's see yes so
what is it trying to show here it's too
small not able to see but uh it is
trying to detect something i think it is
saying it is a car i don't know
all right okay so in this video there's
only pretty much only one object which
is the cat and uh let's wait for some
time and see if it continues to detect
it when the cat turns around and moves
as well just
in a little bit that's going to happen
and we will see there we go and
in spite of turning the other way i
think our network is able to detect that
it is a cat so let me freeze and then
show here it is actually still continues
to detect it as a cat all right so
that's pretty much it i think that's the
only object that it detects in this
particular video okay welcome to the rnn
tutorial that's the recurrent neural
network so we talk about a feed forward
neural network in a feed forward neural
network information flows only in the
forward direction from the input nodes
through the hidden layers if any into
the output nodes there are no cycles or
loops in the network and so you can see
here we have our input layer i was
talking about how it just goes straight
forward into the hidden layers so each
one of those connects and then connects
to the next hidden layer connects to the
output layer and of course we have a
nice simplified version where it has a
predicted output the refer to the input
is x a lot of times and the output as y
decisions are based on current input no
memory about the past no future scope
why recurrent neural network issues in
feed forward neural network so one of
the biggest issues is because it doesn't
have a scope of memory or time a feed
forward neural network doesn't know how
to handle sequential data it only
considers only the current input so if
you have a series of things and because
three points back affects what's
happening now and what your output
affects what's happening that's very
important so whatever i put as an output
is going to affect the next one um a
feed forward doesn't look at any of that
it just looks at this is what's coming
in and it cannot memorize previous
inputs so it doesn't have that list of
inputs coming in solution to feed
forward neural network you'll see here
where it says recurrent neural network
and we have our x on the bottom going to
h going to y that's your feed forward
but right in the middle it has a value c
so there's a whole another process so
it's memorizing what's going on in the
hidden layers and the hidden layers as
they produce data feed into the next one
so your hidden layer might have an
output that goes off to y
but that output goes back into the next
prediction coming in what this does is
this allows it to handle sequential data
it considers the current input and also
the previously received inputs and if
we're going to look at general drawings
and solutions we should also look at
applications of the rnn image captioning
rnn is used to caption an image by
analyzing the activities present in it a
dog catching a ball in midair uh that's
very tough i mean you know we have a lot
of stuff that analyzes images of a dog
and the image of a ball but it's able to
add one more feature in there that's
actually catching the ball in midair
time series prediction any time series
problem like predicting the prices of
stocks in a particular month can be
solved using rnn and we'll dive into
that in our use case and actually take a
look at some stock one of the things you
should know about analyzing stock today
is that it is very difficult and if
you're analyzing the whole stock the
stock market at the new york stock
exchange in the u.s produces somewhere
in the neighborhood if you count all the
individual trades and fluctuations by
the second
it's like three terabytes a day of data
so we're going to look at one stock just
analyzing one stock is really tricky in
here we'll give you a little jump on
that so that's exciting but don't expect
to get rich off of it immediately
another application of the rnn is
natural language processing text mining
and sentiment analysis can be carried
out using rnn for natural language
processing and you can see right here
the term natural language processing
when you stream those three words
together is very different than i if i
said processing language natural leap so
the time series is very important when
we're analyzing sentiments it can change
the whole value of a sentence just by
switching the words around or if you're
just counting the words you might get
one sentiment where if you actually look
at the order they're in you get a
completely different sentiment when it
rains look for rainbows when it's dark
look for stars both of these are
positive sentiments and they're based
upon the order of which the sentence is
going in machine translation given an
input in one language rnn can be used to
translate the input into a different
languages as output i myself very
linguistically challenged but if you
study languages and you're good with
languages you know right away that if
you're speaking english you would say
big cat and if you're speaking spanish
you would say cat big so that
translation is really important to get
the right order to get there's all kinds
of parts of speech that are important to
know by the order of the words here this
person is speaking in english and
getting translated and you can see here
a person is speaking in english in this
little diagram i guess that's denoted by
the flags i have a flag i own it no um
but they're speaking in english and it's
getting translated into
chinese italian french german and
spanish languages some of the tools
coming out are just so cool so somebody
like myself who's very linguistically
challenged i can now travel into worlds
i would never think of because i can
have something translate my english back
and forth readily and i'm not stuck with
a communication gap so let's dive into
what is a recurrent neural network
recurrent neural network works on the
principle of saving the output of a
layer and feeding this back to the input
in order to predict the output of the
layer sounds a little confusing when we
start breaking it down it'll make more
sense and usually we have a propagation
forward neural network with the input
layers the hidden layers the output
layer with the recurrent neural network
we turn that on its side so here it is
and now our x comes up from the bottom
into the hidden layers into y and they
usually draw very simplified x to h with
c as a loop a to y where a b and c are
the perimeters a lot of times you'll see
this kind of drawing in here digging
closer and closer into the h and how it
works going from left to right you'll
see that the c goes in and then the x
goes in so the x is going upward down
and c is going to the right a is going
out and c is also going out that's where
it gets a little confusing so here we
have xn
cn and then we have y out and c out and
c is based on ht minus one so our value
is based on the y and the h value are
connected to each other they're not
necessarily the same value because h can
be its own thing and usually we draw
this or we represent it as a function h
of t equals a function of c where h of t
minus 1 that's the last h output
and x of t going in so it's the last
output of h combined with the new input
of x where h t is the new state fc is a
function with the parameters c that's a
common way of denoting it ht minus one
is the old state coming out and then x
of t is an input vector at time of step
t
well we need to cover types of recurrent
neural networks and so the first one is
the most common one which is a one to
one single output
one-to-one neural network is usually
known as a vanilla neural network used
for regular machine learning problems
why because vanilla is usually
considered kind of a just a real basic
flavor but because it's very basic a lot
of times they'll call it the vanilla
neural network which is not the common
term but it is you know kind of a slang
term people will know what you're
talking about usually if you say that
then we run one to many so you have a
single input and you might have a
multiple outputs in this case
image captioning as we looked at earlier
where we have not just looking at it as
a dog but a dog catching a ball in the
air and then you have many to one
network takes in a sequence of inputs
examples sentiment analysis where a
given sentence can be classified as
expressing positive or negative
sentiments and we looked at that as we
were discussing if it rains look for a
rainbow so positive sentiment where rain
might be a negative sentiment if you're
just adding up the words in there and
then of course if you're going to do a
one-to-one mini to one one to many
there's many to many networks takes in a
sequence of inputs and generates a
sequence of outputs example machine
translation so we have a lengthy
sentence coming in english and then
going out in all the different languages
you know just a wonderful tool very
complicated set of computations you know
if you're a translator you realize just
how difficult it is to translate into
different languages one of the biggest
things you need to understand when we're
working with this neural network is
what's called the vanishing gradient
problem while training an rnn your slope
can be either too small or very large
and this makes training difficult when
the slope is too small the problem is
known as vanishing gradient and you'll
see here they have a nice uh image loss
of information through time so if you're
pushing not enough information forward
that information is lost and then when
you go to train it you start losing the
third word in the sentence or something
like that or doesn't quite follow the
full logic of what you're working on
exploding gradient problem oh this is
one that runs into everybody when you're
working with this particular neural
network when the slope tends to grow
exponentially instead of decaying this
problem is called exploding gradient
issues in gradient problem long tracking
time poor performance bad accuracy and
i'll add one more in there uh your
computer if you're on a lower end
computer testing out a model will lock
up and give you the memory error
explaining gradient problem consider the
following two examples to understand
what should be the next word in the
sequence
the person who took my bike and blank a
thief the students who got into
engineering with blank from asia and you
can see in here we have our x value
going in we have the previous value
going forward and then you back
propagate the error like you do with any
neural network and as we're looking for
that missing word maybe we'll have the
person took my bike and blank was a
thief and the student who got into
engineering with a blank were from asia
consider the following example the
person who took the bike so we'll go
back to the person who took the bike was
blank a thief in order to understand
what would be the next word in the
sequence the rnn must memorize the
previous context whether the subject was
singular noun or a plural noun so was a
thief as singular the student who got
into engineering well in order to
understand what would be the next word
in the sequence the rnn must memorize
the previous context whether the subject
was singular noun or a plural noun and
so you can see here the students who got
into engineering with blank were from
asia it might be sometimes difficult for
the air to back propagate to the
beginning of the sequence to predict
what should be the output so when you
run into the gradient problem we need a
solution the solution to the gradient
problem first we're going to look at
exploding gradient where we have three
different solutions depending on what's
going on one is identity initialization
so the first thing we want to do is see
if we can find a way to minimize the
identities coming in instead of having
it identify everything just the
important information we're looking at
next is to truncate the back propagation
so instead of having whatever
information it's sending to the next
series we can truncate what it's sending
we can lower that particular set of
layers make those smaller and finally is
a gradient clipping so when we're
training it we can clip what that
gradient looks like and narrow the
training model that we're using when you
have a vanishing gradient the option
problem we can take a look at weight
initialization very similar to the
identity but we're going to add more
weights in there so it can identify
different aspects of what's coming in
better choosing the right activation
function that's huge so we might be
activating based on one thing and we
need to limit that we haven't talked too
much about activation function so we'll
look at that just minimally there's a
lot of choices out there and then
finally there's long short term memory
networks the lstms and we can make
adjustments to that so just like we can
clip the gradient as it comes out we can
also
expand on that we can increase the
memory network the size of it so it
handles more information and one of the
most common problems in today's
setup is what they call long term
dependencies suppose we try to predict
the last word in the text the clouds are
in the and you probably said sky here we
do not need any further context it's
pretty clear that the last word is going
to be sky suppose we try to predict the
last word in the text i have been
staying in spain for the last 10 years i
can speak fluent maybe you said
portuguese or french no he probably said
spanish the word we predict will depend
on the previous few words in context
here we need the context of spain to
predict the last word in the text it's
possible that the gap between the
relevant information and the point where
it is needed to become very large
lstms help us solve this problem so the
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default behavior all recurrent
neural networks have the form of a chain
of repeating modules of neural network
connections in standard rnns this
repeating module will have a very simple
structure such as a single tangent h
layer lstms's
also have a chain like structure but the
repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way lstms are a special
kind of recurrent neural network capable
of learning long-term dependencies
remembering information for long periods
of time is their default behavior ls
tmss also have a chain like structure
but the repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way as you can see the
deeper we dig into this the more
complicated the graphs get in here i
want you to note that you have x of t
minus 1 coming in you have x of t coming
in and you have x a t plus 1. and you
have h of t minus 1 and h of t coming in
and h of t plus 1 going out and of
course on the other side is the output a
in the middle we have our tangent h but
it occurs in two different places so not
only when we're computing the x a t plus
one are we getting the tangent h from x
to t but we're also getting that value
coming in from the x of t minus one so
the short of it is as you look at these
layers not only does it does the
propagate through the first layer goes
into the second layer back into itself
but it's also going into the third layer
so now we're kind of stacking those up
and this can get very complicated as you
grow that in size it also grows in
memory too and in the amount of
resources it takes but it's a very
powerful tool to help us address a
problem of complicated long-sequential
information coming in like we're just
looking at in the sentence and when
we're looking at our long short term
memory network there's three steps of
processing in the lstms that we look at
the first one is we want to forget
irrelevant parts of the previous state
you know a lot of times like you know is
as in a unless we're trying to look at
whether it's a plural noun or not they
don't really play a huge part in the
language so we want to get rid of them
then selectively update cell state
values so we only want to update the
cell state values that reflect what
we're working on and finally we want to
put only output certain parts of the
cell state so whatever is coming out we
want to limit what's going out too and
let's dig a little deeper into this
let's just see what this really looks
like
so step one decides how much of the past
it should remember first step in the
lstm is to decide which information to
be omitted in from the cell in that
particular time step it is decided by
the sigmoid function it looks at the
previous state h to t minus 1 and the
current input x of t and computes the
function so you can see over here we
have a function of t
equals the sigmoid function of the
weight of f the h at t minus one and
then x a t plus of course you have a
bias in there with any of our neural
networks so we have a bias function so f
of t equals forget gate decides which
information to delete that is not
important from the previous time step
considering an stm is fed with the
following inputs from the previous and
present time step alice is good in
physics john on the other hand is good
in chemistry so previous output john
plays football well he told me yesterday
over the phone that he had served as a
captain of his college football team
that's our current input so as we look
at this the first step is the forget
gate realizes there might be a change in
context after encountering the first
full stop compares with the current
input sentence of x a t so we're looking
at that full stop and then compares it
with the input of the new sentence the
next sentence talks about john so the
information on alice is deleted okay
that's important to know so we have this
input coming in and if we're going to
continue on with john then that's going
to be the primary information we're
looking at the position of the subject
is vacated and is assigned to john and
so in this one we've seen that we've
weeded out a whole bunch of information
and we're only passing information on
john since that's now the new topic so
step two is then to decide how much
should this unit add to the current
state in the second layer there are two
parts one is the sigmoid function and
the other is the tangent h in the
sigmoid function it decides which values
to let through zero or one tangent h
function gives a weightage to the values
which are passed deciding their level of
importance minus one to one and you can
see the two formulators that come up uh
the i of t equals the sigmoid of the
weight of i h to t minus one x of t plus
the bias of i and the c of t equals the
tangent of h of the weight of c of h of
t minus 1 x of t plus the bias of c so
our i of t equals the input gate
determines which information to let
through based on its significance in the
current time step if this seems a little
complicated don't worry because a lot of
the programming is already done when we
get to the case study understanding
though that this is part of the program
is important when you're trying to
figure out these what to set your
settings at you should also note when
you're looking at this it should have
some semblance to your forward
propagation neural networks where we
have a value assigned to a weight plus a
bias very important steps than any of
the neural network layers whether we're
propagating into them the information
from one to the next or we're just doing
a straightforward neural network
propagation let's take a quick look at
this what it looks like from the human
standpoint as i step out of my suit
again consider the current input at x of
t john plays football well he told me
yesterday over the phone that he had
served as a captain of his college
football team that's our input input
gate announces the important information
john plays football and he was the
captain of his college team is important
he told me over the phone yesterday is
less important hence it is forgotten
this process of adding some new
information can be done via the input
gate now this example is as a human form
and we'll look at training this stuff in
just a minute but as a human being if i
wanted to get this information from a
conversation maybe it's a google voice
listening in on you or something like
that um how do we weed out the
information that he was talking to me on
the phone yesterday well i don't want to
memorize it he talked to me on the phone
yesterday or maybe that is important but
in this case it's not i want to know
that he was the captain of the football
team i want to know that he served i
want to know that john plays football
and he was a captain of the college
football team those are the two things
that i want to take away as a human
being again we measure a lot of this
from the human viewpoint and that's also
how we try to train them so we can
understand these neural networks finally
we get to step three decides what part
of the current cell state makes it to
the output the third step is to decide
what will be our output first we run a
sigmoid layer which decides what parts
of the cell state make it to the output
then we put the cell state through the
tangent h to push the values to be
between -1 and 1 and multiply it by the
output of the sigmoid gate so when we
talk about the output of t we set that
equal to the sigmoid of the weight of
zero of the h of t minus one and back
one step in time by the x of t plus of
course the bias the h of t equals the
outer t times the tangent of the tangent
h of c of t so our o t equals the output
gate allows the passed in information to
impact the output in the current time
step let's consider the example to
predicting the next word in the sentence
john played tremendously well against
the opponent and one for his team for
his contributions brave blank was
awarded player of the match there could
be a lot of choices for the empty space
current input brave is an adjective
adjectives describe a noun john could be
the best output after brave thumbs up
for john awarded player of the match and
if you were to pull just the nouns out
of the sentence team doesn't look right
because that's not really the subject
we're talking about contributions you
know brave contributions or brave teen
brave player brave match um so you look
at this and you can start to train this
these this neural network so starts
looking at and goes oh no john is what
we're talking about so brave is an
adjective
john's going to be the best output and
we give john a big thumbs up and then of
course we jump into my favorite part the
case study use case implementation of
lstm let's predict the prices of stocks
using the lstm network based on the
stock price data between 2012 2016.
we're going to try to predict the stock
prices of 2017. and this will be a
narrow set of data we're not going to do
the whole stock market it turns out that
the new york stock exchange generates
roughly three terabytes of data per day
that's all the different trades up and
down of all the different stocks going
on and each individual one
second to second or nanosecond to
nanosecond but we're going to limit that
to just some very basic fundamental
information so don't think you're going
to get rich off this today but at least
you can give an eye you can give a step
forward in how to start processing
something like stock prices a very valid
use for machine learning in today's
markets
use case implementation of lstm let's
dive in we're going to import our
libraries we're going to import the
training set and get the scaling going
now if you watch any of our other
tutorials a lot of these pieces just
start to look very familiar because it's
very similar setup let's take a look at
that and just reminder we're going to be
using anaconda the jupiter notebook so
here i have my anaconda navigator when
we go under environments i've actually
set up a cross python 36 i'm in python
36 and uh nice thing about anaconda
especially the newer version i remember
a year ago messing with anaconda in
different versions of python in
different environments anaconda now has
a nice interface
and i have this installed both on an
ubuntu linux machine and on windows so
it works fine on there you can go in
here and open a terminal window and then
in here once you're in the terminal
window this is where you're going to
start
installing using pip to install your
different modules and everything now
we've already pre-installed them so we
don't need to do that in here but if you
don't have them installed in your
particular environment you'll need to do
that and of course you don't need to use
the anaconda or the jupiter you can use
whatever favorite python id you like i'm
just a big fan of this because it keeps
all my stuff separate you can see on
this machine i have specifically
installed one for cross since we're
going to be working with cross under
tensorflow we go back to home i've gone
up here to application and that's the
environment i've loaded on here and then
we'll click on the launch jupiter
notebook now i've already in my jupyter
notebook um have set up a lot of stuff
so that we're ready to go kind of like
uh martha stewart's in the old cooking
show so we want to make sure we have all
our tools for you so you're not waiting
for them to load and if we go up here to
where it says new you can see where you
can
create a new python three that's what we
did here underneath the setup so it
already has all the modules installed on
it and i'm actually rename this if you
go under file you can rename it we've
i'm calling it rnn stock and let's just
take a look and start diving into the
code let's get into the exciting part
now we've looked at the tool and of
course you might be using a different
tool which is fine let's start putting
that code in there and seeing what those
imports and uploading everything looks
like now first half is kind of boring
when we hit the run button because we're
going to be importing numpy as np that's
uh the number python which is your numpy
array and the matplot library because
we're going to do some plotting at the
end and our pandas for our data set our
pandas is pd and when i hit run it
really doesn't do anything except for
load those modules just a quick note let
me just do a quick draw here oops shift
alt there we go you'll notice when we're
doing this setup if i was to divide this
up oops i'm going to actually let's
overlap these here we go
this first part that we're going to do
is
our data
prep
a lot of prepping involved
um in fact depending on what your system
is since we're using karas i put an
overlap here uh but you'll find that
almost
maybe even half of the code we do is all
about the data prep and the reason i
overlapped this with uh cross let me
just put that down because that's what
we're working in uh is because cross has
like their own preset stuff so it's
already pre-built in which is really
nice so there's a couple steps a lot of
times that are in the kara setup we'll
take a look at that to see what comes up
in our code as we go through and look at
stock and the last part is to evaluate
and if you're working with
shareholders or
classroom whatever it is you're working
with uh the evaluate is the next biggest
piece um so the actual code here crossed
is a little bit more but when you're
working with uh some of the other
packages you might have like three lines
that might be it all your stuff is in
your preprocessing and your data since
cross has is is cutting edge and you
load the individual layers you'll see
that there's a few more lines here and
crosses a little bit more robust and
then you spend a lot of times like i
said with the evaluate you want to have
something you present to everybody else
and say hey this is what i did this is
what it looks like so let's go through
those steps this is like a kind of just
general overview and let's just take a
look and see what the next set of code
looks like and in here we have a data
set train and it's going to be read
using the pd or pandas dot read csv and
it's a google stock price train dot csv
and so under this we have training set
equals data set train dot ilocation and
we've kind of sorted out part of that so
what's going on here let's just take a
look at let's look at the actual file
and see what's going on there now if we
look at this
ignore all the extra files on this i
already have a train and a test set
where it's sorted out this is important
to notice because a lot of times we do
that as part of the pre-processing of
the data we take
20 percent of the data out so we can
test it and then we train the rest of it
that's what we use to create our neural
network that way we can find out how
good it is but let's go ahead and just
take a look and see what that looks like
as far as the file itself and i went
ahead and just opened this up in a basic
word pad and text editor just so we can
take a look at it certainly you can open
up an excel or any other kind of
spreadsheet
and we note that this is a comma
separated variables we have a date
open high low close volume this is the
standard stuff that we import into our
stock or the most basic set of
information you can look at in stock
it's all free to download in this case
we downloaded it from google that's why
we call it the google stock price um and
this specifically is google this is the
google stock values from as you can see
here we started off at 1 3 2012.
so when we look at this first setup up
here we have a data set train equals pd
underscore csv and if you noticed on the
original frame
let me just go back there
they had it set to home ubuntu downloads
google stock price train i went ahead
and changed that because we're in the
same file where i'm running the code so
i've saved this particular python code
and i don't need to go through any
special paths or have the full path on
there and then of course we want to take
out
certain values in here and you're going
to notice that we're using
our data set
and we're now in pandas
so pandas basically it looks like a
spreadsheet
and in this case we're going to do
ilocation which is going to get specific
locations the first value is going to
show us that we're pulling all the rows
and the data and the second one is we're
only going to look at columns 1 and 2.
and if you remember here from our data
as we switch back on over columns we
always start with zero which is the date
and we're going to be looking at open
and high which would be one and two
we'll just label that right there so you
can see now
when you go back and do this you
certainly can extrapolate and do this on
all the columns
but for the example let's just limit a
little bit here so that we can focus on
just some
key aspects of stock
and then we'll go up here and run the
code and again i said the first half is
very boring whenever we hit the run
button it doesn't do anything because
we're still just loading the data and
setting it up
now that we've loaded our data we want
to go ahead and scale it we want to do
what they call feature scaling and in
here we're going to pull it up from the
sk learn or the sk kit pre-processing
import min max scaler and when you look
at this you got to remember that
biases in our data we want to get rid of
that so if you have something that's
like a really high value let's just draw
a quick graph
and i have something here like the maybe
the stock has a value one stock has a
value of 100 and another stock has a
value of five
you start to get a bias between
different stocks and so when we do this
we go ahead and say okay 100 is going to
be the max
and 5 is going to be the min and then
everything else goes and then we change
this so we just squish it down
i like the word squish so it's between 1
and 0. so 100 equals 1 or 1 equals 100
and zero equals five and you can just
multiply it's usually just a simple
multiplication we're using uh
multiplication
so it's going to be uh minus five and
then a hundred divided or 95 divided by
one so or whatever value is is divided
by 95.
and once we've actually created our
scale we're telling is going to be from
zero to one we want to take our training
set and we're going to create a training
set scaled and we're going to use our
scalar sc we're going to fit we're going
to fit and transform the training set
so we can now use the sc this this
particular object will use it later on
our testing set because remember we have
to also scale that when we go to test
our model and see how it works and we'll
go ahead and click on the run again
it's not going to have any output yet
because we're just setting up all the
variables
okay so we paste the data in here and
we're going to create the data structure
with the 60 time steps and output
first note we're running 60 time steps
and that is where this value here also
comes in so the first thing we do is we
create our x train and y train variables
we set them to an empty python array
very important to remember what kind of
array we're in what we're working with
and then we're going to come in here
we're going to go for i in range 60 to
1258 there's our 60 60 time steps and
the reason we want to do this is as
we're adding the data in there's nothing
below the 60. so if we're going to use
60 time steps we have to start at point
60 because it includes everything
underneath of it otherwise you'll get a
pointer error and then we're going to
take our x train and we're going to
append training set scaled this is a
scaled value between 0 and 1
and then as i is equal to 60 this value
is going to be
60 minus 60 is 0. so this actually is
0 to i so it's going to be 0 60 1 to 61.
let me just circle this part right here
1 to 61
2 to 62 and so on and so on and if you
remember i said 0 to 60 that's incorrect
because it does not count remember it
starts at zero so this is a count of 60
so it's actually 59 important to
remember that as we're looking at this
and then the second part of this that
we're looking at
so if you remember correctly here we go
we go from
0 to 59 of i and then we have a comma a
zero right here and so finally we're
just going to look at the open value now
i know we did put it in there for one to
two
um if you remember quickly it doesn't
count the second one so it's just the
open value we're looking at just open
and then finally we have y train dot
append training set i to zero and if you
remember correctly i two or i comma zero
if you remember correctly this is zero
to 59 so there's 60 values in it uh so
we do i down here this is number 60. so
we're going to do this is we're creating
an array and we have 0
to 59
and over here we have number 60 which is
going into the y train it's being
appended on there and then this just
goes all the way up so this is down here
is a
0 to 59 and we'll call it 60 since
that's the value over here and it goes
all the way up to 12
58 that's where this value here comes in
that's the length of the data we're
loading
so we've loaded two arrays we've loaded
one array that has which is filled with
arrays from zero to 59 and we loaded one
array which is just the value and what
we're looking at you want to think about
this as a time sequence uh here's my
open open open open openopen what's the
next one in the series so we're looking
at the google stock and each time it
opens we want to know what the next one
0 through 59 what's 60 1 through 60
what's 61 2 through 62 what's 62 and so
on and so on going up and then once
we've loaded those in our for loop we go
ahead and take x train and y-train
equals
np.arrayxtrain.npray train we're just
converting this back into a numpy array
that way we can use all the cool tools
that we get with numpy array including
reshaping so if we take a look and see
what's going on here we're going to take
our x train
we're going to reshape it
wow what the heck does reshape mean uh
that means we have an array if you
remember correctly
so many numbers by 60.
that's how wide it is
and so we're when you when you do x
train dot shape that gets one of the
shapes and you get
x train dot shape of one gets the other
shape and we're just making sure the
data is formatted correctly and so you
use this to pull the fact that it's 60
by um
in this case where's that value 60 by
1199 1258 minus 60 11.99 and we're
making sure that that is shaped
correctly so the data is grouped into
99 by 60 different arrays and then the
one on the end just means at the end
because this when you're dealing with
shapes and numpy they look at this as
layers and so the end layer needs to be
one value that's like the leaf of a tree
where this is the branch and then it
branches out some more
and then you get the leaf np.reshape
comes from and using the existing shapes
to form it we'll go ahead and run this
piece of code again there's no real
output and then we'll import our
different cross modules that we need so
from cross models we're going to import
the sequential model dealing with
sequential data we have our dense layers
we have actually three layers we're
going to bring in our dents our lstm
which is what we're focusing on and our
dropout and we'll discuss these three
layers more in just a moment but you do
need the with the lstm you do need the
drop out and then the final layer will
be the dents but let's go ahead and run
this and they'll bring port our modules
and you'll see we get an error on here
and if you read it closer it's not
actually an error it's a warning what
does this warning mean these things come
up all the time when you're working with
such cutting edge modules are completely
being updated all the time we're not
going to worry too much about the
warning all it's saying is that the
h5py module which is part of cross is
going to be updated at some point and if
you're running new stuff on cross and
you start updating your cross system you
better make sure that your h5 pi is
updated too otherwise you're going to
have an error later on and you can
actually just run an update on the h5 pi
now if you wanted to not a big deal
we're not going to worry about that
today and i said we were going to jump
in and start looking at what those
layers mean i meant that and we're going
to start off with initializing the rnn
and then we'll start adding those layers
in and you'll see that we have the lstm
and then the dropout lstm then dropout
lstm then dropout what the heck is that
doing so let's explore that we'll start
by initializing the rnn regressor equals
sequential because we're using the
sequential model and we'll run that and
load that up and then we're going to
start adding our lstm layer and some
dropout regularization and right there
should be the q dropout regularization
and if we go back here and remember our
exploding gradient well that's what
we're talking about the dropout drops
out unnecessary data so we're not just
shifting huge amounts of data through
the network so and so we go in here
let's just go ahead and add this in i'll
go ahead and run this and we had three
of them so let me go ahead and put all
three of them in and then we can go back
over them there's the second one and
let's put one more in let's put that in
and we'll go ahead and put two more in i
mean i said one more in but it's
actually two more in and then let's add
one more after that and as you can see
each time i run these they don't
actually have an output so let's take a
closer look and see what's going on here
so we're going to add our first lstm
layer in here we're going to have units
50. the units is the positive integer
and it's the dimensionality of the
output space this is what's going out
into the next layer so we might have 60
coming in but we have 50 going out we
have a return sequence because it is a
sequence data so we want to keep that
true and then you have to tell it what
shape it's in well we already know the
shape by just going in here and looking
at x train shape so input shape equals
the x train shape of one comma one makes
it real easy you don't have to remember
all the numbers that put in 60 or
whatever else is in there you just let
it tell the regressor what model to use
and so we follow our stm with a dropout
layer now understanding the dropout
layer is kind of exciting because one of
the things that happens is we can over
train our network that means that our
neural network will memorize such
specific data that it has trouble
predicting anything that's not in that
specific realm to fix for that each time
we run through the training mode we're
going to take point two or twenty
percent of our neurons they just turn
them off so we're only going to train on
the other ones and it's going to be
random that way each time we pass
through this we don't over train these
nodes come back in in the next training
cycle we randomly pick a different 20.
and finally i see a big difference as we
go from the first to the second and
third and fourth the first thing is we
don't have to input the shape because
the shapes already the output units is
50 here this item the next step
automatically knows this layer is
putting out 50 and because it's the next
layer it automatically sets that and
says so 50 is coming out from our last
layer that's coming up you know goes
into the regressor and of course we have
our drop out and that's what's coming
into this one and so on and so on and so
the next three layers we don't have to
let it know what the shape is it
automatically understands that and we're
gonna keep the units the same we're
still gonna do 50 units it's still a
sequence coming through 50 units and a
sequence now the next piece of code is
what brings it all together let's go
ahead and take a look at that and we
come in here we put the output layer the
dense layer and if you remember up here
we had the three layers we had lstm
dropout and dents dense just says we're
going to bring this all down into one
output instead of putting out a sequence
we just know i want to know the answer
at this point and let's go ahead and run
that and so in here you notice all we're
doing is setting things up one step at a
time so far we've brought in our way up
here we brought in our data we bought in
our different modules we formatted the
data for training it we set it up you
know we have our y x train and our y
train we have our source of data and the
answers where we know so far that we're
gonna put in there we've reshaped that
we've come in and built our cross we've
imported our different layers and we
have in here if you look we have what
five total layers now cross is a little
different than a lot of other systems
because a lot of other systems put this
all in one line and do it automatic but
they don't give you the options of how
those layers interface and they don't
give you the options of how the data
comes in cross is cutting edge for this
reason so even though there's a lot of
extra steps in building the model this
has a huge impact on the output and what
we can do with this these new models
from keras so we brought in our dents we
have our full model put together a
regressor so we need to go ahead and
compile it and then we're going to go
ahead and fit the data we're going to
compile the pieces so they all come
together and then we're going to run our
training data on there and actually
recreate our regressor so it's ready to
be used so let's go ahead and compile
that and i'd go ahead and run that and
if you've been looking at any of our
other tutorials on neural networks
you'll see we're going to use the
optimizer atom atom is optimized for big
data there's a couple other optimizers
out there beyond the scope of this
tutorial but certainly atom will work
pretty good for this and loss equals
mean squared value so when we're
training it this is what we want to base
the loss on how bad is our error we're
going to use the mean squared value for
our error and the atom optimizer for its
differential equations you don't have to
know the math behind them but certainly
it helps to know what they're doing and
where they fit into the bigger models
and then finally we're going to do our
fit fitting the rn into the training set
we have the regressor.fit x train y
train epics and batch size so we know
where this is this is our data coming in
for the x train our y train is the
answer we're looking for of our data our
sequential input epics is how many times
we're going to go over the whole data
set we created a whole data set of x
trains so this is each each of those
rows which includes a time sequence of
60. and bad size another one of those
things where cross really shines is if
you were pulling this save from a large
file instead of trying to load it all
into ram it can now pick smaller batches
up and load those indirectly we're not
worried about pulling them off a file
today this isn't big enough to cause a
computer too much of a problem to run
not too straining on the resources but
as we run this you can imagine what
happened if i was doing a lot more than
just one column in one set of stock in
this case google stock imagine if i was
doing this across all the stocks and i
had instead of just the open i had open
close high low and you can actually find
yourself with about 13 different
variables times 60 because there's a
time sequence suddenly you find yourself
with a gig of memory you're loading into
your ram which will just completely you
know if it's just if you're not on
multiple computers or cluster you're
gonna start running into resource
problems but for this we don't have to
worry about that so let's go ahead and
run this and this will actually take a
little bit on my computer it's an older
laptop and give a second to kick in
there there we go all right so we have
epic so this is going to tell me it's
running the first run through all the
data and as it's going through it's
batching them in 32 pieces so 32 lines
each time and there's 1198 i think i
said 11.99 earlier but it's 11.98 i was
off by one and each one of these is 13
seconds so you can imagine this is
roughly 20 to 30 minutes run time on
this computer like i said it's an older
laptop running at 0.9 gigahertz on a
dual processor and that's fine what
we'll do is i'll go ahead and stop go
get a drink of coffee and come back and
let's see what happens at the end and
where this takes us and like any good
cooking show
i've gotta gotten my latte i also have
some other stuff running in the
background so you'll see these numbers
jumped up to like 19 seconds 15 seconds
but you can scroll through and you can
see we've run it through 100 steps or
100 epics so the question is what does
all this mean one of the first things
you'll notice is that our loss can is
over here it kind of stopped at 0.0014
but you can see it kind of goes down
until we hit about 0.014 three times in
a row so we guessed our epic pretty
close since our losses remain the same
on there so to find out we're looking at
we're going to go ahead and load up our
test data the test data that we didn't
process yet and a real stock price data
set test eye location this is the same
thing we did when we prepped the data in
the first place so let's go ahead and go
through this code and we can see we've
labeled it part three making the
predictions and visualizing the results
so the first thing that we need to do is
go ahead and read the data in from our
test csv you see i've changed the path
on it for my computer and then we'll
call it the real stock price and again
we're doing just the one column here and
the values from ilocation so it's all
the rows and just the values from these
that one location that's the open stock
open let's go ahead and run that so
that's loaded in there and then let's go
ahead and create we have our inputs
we're going to create inputs here and
this should all look familiar because
this is the same thing we did before
we're going to take our data set total
we're going to do a little panda concat
from the data state train now remember
the end of the dataset train is part of
the data going in and let's just
visualize that just a little bit here's
our train data let me just put tr for
train and it went up to this value here
but each one of these values generated a
bunch of columns it was 60 across and
this value here equals this one and this
value here equals this one and this
value here equals this one and so we
need these top 60 to go into our new
data so to find out we're looking at
we're going to go ahead and load up our
test data the test data that we didn't
process yet and a real stock price data
set test eye location this is the same
thing we did when we prepped the data in
the first place so let's go ahead and go
through this code and we can see we've
labeled it part three making the
predictions and visualizing the results
so the first thing that we need to do is
go ahead and read the data in from our
test csv you see i've changed the path
on it for my computer and then we'll
call it the real stock price and again
we're doing just the one column here and
the values from i location so it's all
the rows and just the values from these
that one location that's the open stock
open let's go ahead and run that so
that's loaded in there and then let's go
ahead and create we have our inputs
we're going to create inputs here and
this should all look familiar this is
the same thing we did before we're going
to take our data set total we're going
to do a little pandas concat from the
datastate train now remember the end of
the dataset train is part of the data
going in and let's just visualize that
just a little bit here's our train data
let me just put tr for train and it went
up to this value here but each one of
these values generated a bunch of
columns it was 60 across and this value
here equals this one and this value here
equals this one and this value here
equals this one and so we need these top
60 to go into our new data because
that's part of the next data or it's
actually the top 59 so that's what this
first setup is over here is we're going
in we're doing the real stock price and
we're going to just take the data set
test and we're going to load that in and
then the real stock price is our data
test test location so we're just looking
at that first column the open price and
then our data set total we're going to
take pandas and we're going to concat
and we're going to take our data set
train for the open and our dataset test
open and this is one way you can
reference these columns we've referenced
them a couple different ways we've
referenced them up here with the one two
but we know it's labeled as a panda set
as open so pandas is great that way lots
of versatility there and we'll go ahead
and go back up here and run this there
we go and you'll notice this is the same
as what we did before we have our open
data set we pended our two different or
concatenated our two data sets together
we have our inputs equals data set total
length data set total minus length data
set minus test minus 60 values so we're
going to run this over all of them and
you'll see why this works because
normally when you're running your test
set versus your training set you run
them completely separate but when we
graph this you'll see that we're just
going to be we'll be looking at the part
that we didn't train it with to see how
well it graphs and we have our inputs
equals inputs dot reshapes or reshaping
like we did before we're transforming
our inputs so if you remember from the
transform between zero and one and uh
finally we want to go ahead and take our
x test and we're going to create that x
test and for i in range 60 to 80. so
here's our x test and we're appending
our inputs i to 60 which remember is 0
to 59 and i comma 0 on the other side so
it's just the first column which is our
open column and once again we take our x
test we convert it to a numpy array we
do the same reshape we did before and
then we get down to the final two lines
and here we have something new right
here on these last two lines let me just
highlight those or mark them predicted
stock price equals regressor dot
predicts x test so we're predicting all
the stock including both the training
and the testing model here and then we
want to take this prediction and we want
to inverse the transform so remember we
put them between zero and one well
that's not going to mean very much to me
to look at a float number between zero
and one i want the dollar amount so i
want to know what the cash value is and
we'll go ahead and run this and you'll
see it runs much quicker than the
training that's what's so wonderful
about these neural networks once you put
them together it takes just a second to
run the same neural network that took us
what a half hour to train add and plot
the data we're going to plot what we
think it's going to be and we're going
to plot it against the real data what
the google stock actually did so let's
go ahead and take a look at that in code
and let's uh pull this code up so we
have our plt that's our uh oh if you
remember from the very beginning let me
just go back up to the top we have our
matplotlibrary.pi plot as plt that's
where that comes in and we come down
here we're going to plot let me get my
drawing thing out again we're going to
go ahead and plt is basically kind of
like an object it's one of the things
that always through me when i'm doing
graphs in python because i always think
you have to create an object and then it
loads that class in there well in this
case plt is like a canvas you're putting
stuff on so if you've done html5 you'll
have the canvas object this is the
canvas so we're going to plot the real
stock price that's what it actually is
and we're going to give that color red
so it's going to be in bright red we're
going to label it real google stock
price and then we're going to do our
predicted stock and we're going to do it
in blue and it's going to be labeled
predicted and we'll give it a title it's
always nice to give a title to your
graph especially if you're going to
present this to somebody you know to
your shareholders in the office and the
x label is going to be time because it's
a time series and we didn't actually put
the actual date and times on here but
that's fine we just know they're
incremented by time and then of course
the y label is the actual stock price
plt.legend tells us to build the legend
on here so that the color red and real
google stock price show up on there and
then the plot shows us that actual graph
so let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like and you can see
here we have a nice graph and let's talk
just a little bit about this graph
before we wrap it up here's our legend i
was telling you about that's why we have
the legend to show the prices we have
our title and everything and you'll
notice on the bottom we have a time
sequence we didn't put the actual time
in here now we could have we could have
gone ahead and
plotted the x since we know what the
dates are and plotted this to dates but
we also know that it's only the last
piece of data that we're looking at so
last piece of data which in somewhere
probably around here on the graph i
think it's like about 20 of the data
probably less than that we have the
google price and the google price has
this little up jump and then down and
you'll see that the actual google
instead of a turn down here just didn't
go up as high and didn't load go down so
our prediction has the same pattern but
the overall value is pretty far off as
far as
stock but then again we're only looking
at one column we're only looking at the
open price we're not looking at how many
volumes were traded like i was pointing
out earlier we talk about stock just
right off the bat there's six columns
there's open high low close volume then
there's weather i mean volume shares
then there's the adjusted open adjusted
high adjusted low adjusted close they
have a special formula to predict
exactly what it would really be worth
based on the value of the stock and then
from there there's all kinds of other
stuff you can put in here so we're only
looking at one small aspect the opening
price of the stock and as you can see
here we did a pretty good job this curve
follows the curve pretty well it has
like a little jumps on it bins they
don't quite match up so this bin here
does not quite match up with that bin
there but it's pretty darn close we have
the basic shape of it and the prediction
isn't too far off and you can imagine
that as we add more data in and look at
different aspects in the specific domain
of stock we should be able to get a
better representation each time we drill
in deeper of course this took a half
hour for my program my computer to train
so you can imagine that if i was running
it across all those different variables
might take a little bit longer to train
the data not so good for doing a quick
tutorial like this what do you think is
making our lives easier off late and how
do you think the world is rapidly
changing imagine getting into a car
feeding your destination as the input
and automatically getting dropped off at
your destination at the same time you
sit back and relax through the ride
without having to do anything at all
physically whoa life has become so much
simpler with all kinds of automation
taking us through everyday life what do
you think is making all this possible
artificial intelligence thanks to
numerous advancements in technology
which is bringing about a lot of changes
in our day-to-day lives to drive
innovation ai is using machine learning
taking things one step further so what
exactly do you mean by artificial
intelligence
in simple terms ai refers to simulating
a machine with human intelligence and
programming the device to think and act
like humans artificial intelligence also
called machine intelligence is far
beyond roboz as portrayed by science
fiction from google search algorithm to
amazon's alexa to apple siri to
self-driven cars ai progresses rapidly
towards a harmonious future between
technology and man bringing together the
best of both worlds
since the machines are artificially
incorporated with human-like
intelligence and perform tasks as we do
it's termed as artificial intelligence
and it was coined in 1956.
the programs that were developed after
ai was founded were simply astonishing
people could witness computers proving
theorems in geometry solving algebra
word problems and much more between the
1950s and 1970s neural networks emerged
from the 1980s until the last decade
machine learning took over the world now
is the era of deep learning the boons of
ai undoubtedly ai has changed our lives
in many ways at number one we have
safety factor there are many fields like
defense mining etc where human health is
at significant risk ai is the biggest
boon in these fields where a robo or a
drone does the work instead of a human
with the invention of self-driven cars
ai is aiding at our road safety by
reducing the number of road traffic
accidents compared to those caused by
humans
speaking of language processing and
speech recognition ai helps in effective
communication by processing and
understanding the language spoken by
humans
it is also capable of comprehending the
words spoken by humans and reciprocate
in the same way all this is possible by
the voice assistant feature which the ai
bots have at number three we have daily
needs
be it alexa or apple siri we are
surrounded by various applications that
run on ai fingerprint detection face
detection gps grammarly all these run on
artificial intelligence
google maps calculate the traffic
congestion to find the best route to
your destination which works on ai
whether it is the mathematical
calculations booking a ticket buying a
product online and driving a car ai has
limited human interaction and provides
various services in all the unexpected
ways ai is helping humans in the
day-to-day needs
at number four we have healthcare ai is
a promising tool for supporting
healthcare administration it helps
healthcare workers and stakeholders to
manage vast amounts of data and
transform them into potentially
life-saving information
in the present scenario people are
threatened by the growing health
emergency due to the spread of the
corvid 19 coronavirus a who report
released said that ai is a vital part of
the response to this disease
ai systems are being developed
predicting people's temperatures and
survival rates with more than 90
accuracy one promising approach of ai in
the field of healthcare is it guides
vaccine design as covet-19 began to
spread globally machine learning tools
were used to search immunogenic
components of the virus that would make
good vaccine candidates yet another
field where the ml is significantly
evolving is genomics which is the study
of the complete set of genes within an
organism ai can sequence and analyze dna
much faster cheaper and accurate than
the researchers ever will at number 5 we
have robus one of the most amazing
inventions by humans that thinks
intelligently and acts autonomously the
disinfecting robots are playing a
significant role in these uncertain
times they rove around healthcare
facilities spreading uv light to
disinfect places contaminated with
viruses
the benefits of ai robots far exceed the
apprehensions
speaking of role of technology
advancements artificial intelligence is
rapidly advancing with a lot of
computers and robots capable of doing
miracles
though the machines and robots cannot
have human feelings they can think and
act like humans companies use techniques
like machine learning and neural
networks to accomplish artificial
intelligence which is also called
machine intelligence in the present
scenario considering the total
intelligence we can conclude that 95
percent of it is machine intelligence
and the remaining 5 is what we call
human knowledge
speaking of ai versus human ai has a
positive as well as a negative impact on
us and society according to some recent
studies seven million existing jobs will
be replaced by ai in the uk between 2017
and 2037
but at the same time 7.2 million jobs
could be created as well
a study from mckinsey global institute
states that by 2030 automation will
replace 400 to 800 million jobs
requiring as many as 375 million people
to switch their job categories entirely
this is indeed going to cause fear and
concern to many vulnerable countries
the biggest challenge is how people
would make a living with these changes
and uncertainty
google ceo sundar pichai has claimed
that ai will be more transformative to
humanity than electricity ever will
google even launched an ai system which
bet some of the best atari 2600 game
players
also did you know that the best choice
player in the world is a machine how
would it be when the best doctor in the
world is a machine the best teacher is a
machine the best architect is a machine
and the best of many professions are
various machines and robots ais and
robos will replace fast food joints and
radiologists in hospitals
someday ai will diagnose your cancer and
a robo will perform your surgery it
won't be long until a machine is
superior in every single professional
field
warning by musk
this is extremely important um
i think the danger of ai is much greater
than the the danger of nuclear warheads
by a lot
um
and nobody would suggest that we allow
anyone to just build nuclear warheads if
they want
that would be insane and mark my words
ai is far more dangerous than nudes
or so why do we have no regulatory
oversight
this is insane
though ai is a boon to humankind in many
different ways not everyone is ready to
welcome ai with open arms some ai
experts like stephen hawking and elon
musk have warned us about the looming
dangers that ai mapo says to humanity
they have even suggested that ai is
likely to be the greatest threat that
could end the human species elon musk
says that he is close to the cutting
edge in ai which scares him a lot ai is
vastly more than almost anyone knows and
the rate of improvement is exponential
he also says that ai is far more
dangerous than nuclear warheads
earlier in 2014 musk had described ai as
our biggest existential threat ai can be
harmful to us in two different ways the
idea that ai will become conscious and
responsive and seek to destroy us
also the notion that people with evil
hands can turn this ai into a critical
tool for wicked purposes if the super
intelligent ai more intelligent than us
becomes conscious they will look at
humans like how humans will look at
monkeys
people are afraid of ai by watching
movies like 2001 a space odyssey where
one of the most well-known ais turned
terrible the terminator the matrix and
few others
these movies have speculated about ai
that far exceeds the expectations of its
creators and escapes their control
eventually targeting humans for
extinction speaking of the real reasons
to be afraid of ai there are doctors
engineers accountants judges architects
who seek information from an ei system
they treat this information as it is
from a trusted colleague
this trust is what we should be afraid
of it is not because of how often ai
gets it wrong ai researchers pride
themselves on the accuracy of results it
is how bad it gets it wrong when it
makes a mistake these systems do not
fail gracefully one such incident is
when facebook had to shut down a
controversial chatbot experiment where
the two ais developed their own language
for communication a research was
conducted with two chatbots named alice
and bob focusing on how to negotiate
with each other unfortunately the
researchers found that the bots had
deviated from the actual script and had
started inventing their new phrases
without any human script as the bots
were left unsupervised they developed
their machine language which was
otherwise developed to converse with
people that's the scary part of ai
neural networks and deep learning the
developers and researchers working on
this would have no idea what it's doing
this technology can get complicated and
we have to make sure what we are doing
with it holds value we must also handle
it cautiously because ai is a direct
reflection of us
people should lead and not follow so
here's the question should we be afraid
of ai
we all know that ai is a transformative
technology that we have ever seen in the
history of humankind
on the other hand we should be scared of
this so-called transformative power it
has the potential to be transformative
both for good reasons as well as for the
wrong however fear of the unknown has
always been the case with technology
fears that ai will develop awareness and
overthrow humanity are grounded in
misconceptions of what ai is
ai is defined by the algorithms that
dictate its behavior and operate under
definite limitations
people are afraid of what happens when
ai reaches its consciousness what if an
ai machine starts to have human feelings
and emotions
well there has been no progress in
research in these areas also we don't
think that is anywhere in our near
future pretty much any type of machine
can be used for either good or bad
reasons
we as developers and researchers should
know where to stop or pause
in a depth jog peter says imagine you're
driving up a mountain and it's raining
very heavily as you climb into the
mountains the rain is turning into snow
and pretty soon that snow is a white out
you cannot see the taillights of the car
in front of you you start skidding you
see some vehicle was coming to crash
into you all this wouldn't have happened
if you paused your journey as the rain
was getting worse
this is to tell you how something small
and seemingly mundane can quickly grow
into something hazardous
consider yourself driving the rain with
ai right now that rain will turn into
snow soon and that snow could quickly
become a dangerous blizzard so we need
to pause check the conditions put in
place safety standards and ask ourselves
how far we want to go
only the healthy skepticism of these
systems is going to help keep people in
the loop
spot checking what the ai algorithms are
doing keeping people in the loop will
probably solve some of our most
significant challenges
at the moment ai isn't dangerous in
itself unless you're living in the
realms of the movies as mentioned
earlier however evolved these air
machines are they still lack human
empathy and consciousness
so instead of running away from this
technology we should understand this
revolutionary technology and make sure
it is used in the right way to make our
lives better
and on that note if you want to master
ai and machine learning you can check
out simplylearn's postgraduate program
in ai and machine learning in
partnership with purdue university
[Music]
what's interesting to me is we will use
ai as we have been
to specifically target tasks that we
need or want done in place of ourselves
that's how ai will ultimately unfold
it is a renaissance
it is a golden age we are now solving
problems with machine learning and
artificial intelligence that were you
know kind of in the realm of science
fiction for the last several decades
ai is probably the most important thing
humanity has ever worked on and i think
of it as something more profound than
electricity or fire and anytime you work
with technology
you need to learn to harness the
benefits and while minimizing the
downside
[Music]
is we're focusing on autonomous systems
and clearly one purpose of autonomous
systems is self-driving cars there are
others
and we sort of see it as the mother of
all ai projects
there's a class of things like game
plane
or speech recognition or image
recognition
that the performance levels are
phenomenal
you know if you compare human speech
recognition computer speech recognition
the computer is slightly better and
that's you know mind blowing
certainly we use ai to do
drug discovery
these biological systems are very
complicated and so the fact that we have
you know vaccines for tb and hiv coming
that's partly enabled by this rich data
advance in biology and machine learning
when i look at
seeing ai which is an application we
just launched for anybody with visual
impairment they can go download this app
that uses the latest cutting edge
computer vision technology in our cloud
to give anyone the ability to see and in
fact angela mills was a colleague of
mine was just telling me about how it's
changed her life inside of microsoft she
can go into our cafeteria order food
using this app with confidence walk into
conference rooms with confidence because
she knows she's walking into the right
conference room or what we've done with
our onenote and word learning tools
anyone who has dyslexia can now use ai
to be able to read better the latest
release of windows 10 has this
capability called eye gaze which is
something that we learned working with
steve gleason and the als patients
saying if you all you have is the eye
muscle
and the gaze can we help you type
yeah you have to be careful
uh when there's advances in a sense
we're all better off if the machines can
make all the food and the clothes
and none of us have to work
uh and you think okay now we have all
the freedom if we want to stand behind
the
the counter and you know
make sandwiches okay you can if you want
but there's this other way to make those
goods and services but it will be very
disruptive
because you know say your mid-career
in manufacturing or driving
then it's a disruption now we've had
that in a slow way for hundreds of years
you know we used to all be farmers now
very few of us are farmers i said it's
right to be concerned absolutely you
have to worry about it otherwise you're
not going to solve it right and it's
important to understand tomorrow whether
google is there or not
you know artificial intelligence is
going to progress uh you know technology
has
this nature it's a it's going to evolve
i think
pulling back history shows pulling back
countries which pull back don't do well
with the change we know that
20 30 years ago you educated yourself
and that carried you through for the
rest of your life
that is not going to be true for the
generation which is being born now
they have to learn continuously over
their lives we know that so we have to
transform how we do education
look i think i mean you nailed it
anything that's repetitive and done
you know on the back of
you know technology or you know is going
to be fundamentally vulnerable yeah so i
think
technology in particular ai can in fact
bring more empowerment more
inclusiveness and at the same time we
should be clear-eyed about displacement
clear-eyed about unintended consequences
like any other technology and work both
skilling so that you know people can
find the jobs of the future
create new jobs and
lastly i think have a set of policy
decisions uh that really help people
as they go through this change
[Music]
the risks are
important and i think the way we solve
it is
we think ahead we worry about it
we
do things like from from be up front
you know have ethical charters think
about ai safety from day one be very
transparent and open in how we
perceive progress there and figure out
global frameworks by which we can engage
just like paris agreement and climate
change you know using forums like this i
think we bring people together to engage
on the hard questions and i think ansys
will emerge
um you know i have exposure to the very
most cutting edge
ai um
and i think people should be really
concerned about it um i keep sounding
the alarm bell but
until
people see like robots going down the
street killing people like they don't
know how to react you know because it
seems so ethereal
and
i think we should be really concerned
about ai and i think we should
this ai is a rare case where i think we
need to be proactive in regulation
instead of reactive
because i think by the time we are
reactive in ai regulation it's too late
right now we have
machine learning algorithms that can
solve an incredibly complex problem
beyond any human intelligence but
they're essentially complete idiots and
like two-year-olds and anything that's
not that problem they're dumb they're
like that you can give them this
enormous data set and they come up with
brilliant correlations and insights but
they're not going to plug into skynet
and you know like like like threaten us
anytime soon
so i'm quite optimistic
and uh i don't think
artificial intelligence is a threat i
don't think that if at fish intelligence
is something terrible
but human beings are smart enough to
learn that
[Music]
now this video will probably help you
when you're attending interviews for
machine learning positions and the
attempt here is to probably consolidate
30 most commonly asked questions and to
help you in answering these questions we
tried our best to give you the best
possible answers but of course what is
more important here is rather than the
theoretical knowledge you need to kind
of add to the answers or supplement your
answers with your own experience so the
responses that we put here are a bit
more generic in nature so that if there
are some concepts that you are not clear
this video will help you in kind of
getting those concepts cleared up as
well but what is more important is that
you need to supplement these responses
with your own practical experience okay
so with that let's get started so one of
the first questions that you may face is
what are the different types of machine
learning now what is the best way to
respond to this there are three types of
machine learning if you read any
material you will always be told there
are three types of machine learning but
what is important is you would probably
be better off emphasizing that there are
actually two main types of machine
learning which is supervised and
unsupervised and then there is a third
type which is reinforcement learn so
supervised learning is where
you have some historical data and then
you feed that data to your model to
learn now you need to be aware of a
keyword that they will be looking for
which is labeled data right so if you
just say past data or historical data
the impact may not be so much you need
to emphasize on labeled data so what is
label data basically let's say if you
are trying to do train your model for
classification you need to be aware of
for your existing data which class each
of the observations belong to right so
that is what is labeling so it is
nothing but a fancy name you must be
already aware but just make it a point
to throw in that keyword labeled so that
will have the right impact okay so that
is what is supervised learning when you
have existing labeled data which you
then use to train your model that is
known as supervised learning and
unsupervised learning is when you don't
have this labeled data so you have data
it is not labeled so the system has to
figure out a way to do some analysis on
this okay so that is unsupervised
learning and you can then add a few
things like what are the ways of
performing
supervised learning and unsupervised
learning and what are some of the
techniques so supervised learning we
perform or we do
regression and classification and
unsupervised learning uh we do
clustering and clustering can be of
different types similarly regression can
be of different types but you don't have
to probably elaborate so much if they
are asking uh for uh just the different
types you can just mention these and
just at a very high level but if they
want you to elaborate give examples then
of course i think there is a different
question for that we will see that later
then the third so we have supervised
then we have unsupervised and then
reinforcement you need to provide a
little bit of information around that as
well because it is sometimes a little
difficult to come up with a good
definition for reinforcement learning so
you may have to little bit elaborate on
how reinforcement learning works right
so reinforcement learning works in in
such a way that it basically has two
parts to it one is the agent and the
environment and the agent basically is
working inside of this environment and
it is given a target that it has to
achieve and
every time it is moving in the direction
of the target so the agent basically has
to take some action and every time it
takes an action which is moving uh the
agent towards the target right towards a
goal a target is nothing but a goal
then it is rewarded and every time it is
going in a direction where it is away
from the goal then it is punished so
that is the way you can little bit
explain and
this is used primarily or very very
impactful for teaching the system to
learn games and so on examples of this
are basically used in alphago you can
throw that as an example where alphacore
used reinforcement learning to actually
learn to play the game of go and finally
it defeated the co-world champion right
this much of information that would be
good enough okay then there could be a
question on overfitting so the question
could be what is overfitting and how can
you avoid it so
what is overfitting so let's first try
to understand the concept because
sometimes overfitting may be a little
difficult to understand overfitting is a
situation where the model has kind of
memorized the data so this is an
equivalent of memorizing the data so we
can draw an analogy so that it becomes
easy to explain this now let's say
you're teaching a child about
recognizing some fruits or something
like that okay and you're teaching this
child about recognizing let's say three
fruits apples oranges and pineapples
okay so this is a small child and for
the first time you're teaching the child
to recognize fruits then so what will
happen so this is very much like that is
your training data set so what you will
do is you will take a basket of fruits
which consists of apples oranges and
pineapples okay and
you take this basket to this child and
there may be let's say hundreds of these
fruits so you take this basket to this
child and keep showing each of this food
and then first time obviously the child
will not know what it is so you show an
apple and you say hey this is apple then
you show maybe an orange and say this is
orange and so on and so forth and then
again you keep repeating that right so
till the basket is over this is
basically how training work in machine
learning also that's how training works
so till the basket is completed maybe
100 fruits you keep showing this child
and then the process what has happened
the child has pretty much memorized
these so even before you finish that
basket right by the time you are halfway
through the child has learned about
recognizing the apple orange and
pineapple now what will happen after
halfway through initially you remember
it made mistakes in recognizing but
halfway through now it has learned so
every time you show a fruit it will
exactly hundred percent accurately it
will identify it will say the child will
say this is an apple this is an orange
and if you show a pineapple it will say
this is a pineapple right so that means
it has kind of memorized this data now
let's say you bring another basket of
fruits and it will have a mix of maybe
apples which were already there in the
previous set but it will also have in
addition to apple it will probably have
a banana or maybe another fruit like a
jackfruit right so this is an equivalent
of your test data set which the child
has not seen before some parts of it it
probably has seen like the apples it has
seen but this banana and jackfruit it
has not seen so then what will happen in
the first round which is an equivalent
of your training data set towards the
end it has 100 percent it was telling
you what the fruits are right apple was
accurately recognized orange was
accurately recognized and pineapples
were accurately recognized right so that
is like a hundred percent accuracy but
now when you get another a fresh set
which we're not part of the original one
what will happen all the apples maybe it
will be able to recognize correctly but
all the others like the jackfruit or the
banana will not be recognized by the
child right so this is an analogy this
is an equivalent of overfitting so what
has happened during the training process
it is able to recognize or reach 100
accuracy maybe very high accuracy okay
and we call that as very low loss right
so that is the technical term so the
loss is pretty much zero and accuracy is
pretty much hundred percent whereas when
you use testing there will be a huge
error which means the loss will be
pretty high and therefore the accuracy
will be also low okay this is known as
overfitting this is basically a process
where training is done training
processes it goes very well almost
reaching 100 accuracy but while testing
it really drops down now how can you
avoid it so that is the extension of
this question there are multiple ways of
avoiding overfitting there are
techniques like what you call
regularization that is the most common
technique that is used for
avoiding overfitting and within
regularization there can be a few other
subtypes like dropout in case of neural
networks and a few other examples but i
think if you give example or if you give
regularization as the technique probably
that should be sufficient so so there
will be some questions where the
interviewer will try to test your
fundamentals and your knowledge and
depth of knowledge and so on and so
forth and then there will be some
questions which are more like trick
questions that will be more to stump you
okay then the next question is around
the methodology so when we are
performing machine learning training we
split the data into training and test
right so this question is around that so
the question is what is training set and
test set in machine learning model and
how is the split done so the question
can be like that so in machine learning
when we are trying to train the model so
we have a three-step process we train
the model and then we test the model and
then once we are satisfied with the test
only then we deploy the model so what
happens in the train and test is that
you remember the labeled data so let's
say you have 1000 records with labeling
information now one way of doing it is
you use all the thousand records for
training and then maybe right which
means that you have exposed all these
thousand records during the training
process and then you take a small set of
the same data and then you say okay i
will test it with this okay and then you
probably what will happen you may get
some good results all right but there is
a flaw there what is the flaw this is
very similar to human beings it is like
you are showing this model the entire
data as a part of training okay so
obviously it has become familiar with
the entire data so when you are taking a
part of that again and you are saying
that i want to test it obviously you
will get good results so that is not a
very accurate way of testing so that is
the reason what we do is we have the
label data of this thousand records or
whatever we set aside before starting
the training process we set aside a
portion of that data and we call that
test set and the remaining we call as
training set and we use only this for
training our model now the training
process remember is not just about
passing one round of this data set so
let's say now your training set has 800
records it is not just one time you pass
this 800 records what you normally do is
you actually as a part of the training
you may pass this data through the model
multiple times so this thousand records
may go through the model maybe 10 15 20
times till the training is perfect till
the accuracy is high till the errors are
minimized okay now so which is fine
which means that your that is what is
known as the model has seen your data
and gets familiar with your data and now
when you bring your test data what will
happen is this is like some new data
because that is where the real test is
now you have trained the model and now
you are testing the model with some data
which is kind of new that is like a
situation like a realistic situation
because when the model is deployed that
is what will happen it will receive some
new data not the data that it has
already seen right so this is a
realistic test so you put some new data
so this data which you have set aside is
for the model it is new and if it is
able to accurately predict the values
that means your training has worked okay
the model got trained properly but let's
say while you're testing this with this
test data you're getting lot of errors
that means you need to probably either
change your model or retrain with more
data and things like that now coming
back to the question of how do you split
this what should be the ratio there is
no fixed
number again this is like individual
preferences some people split it into 50
50 50 test and 50 training some people
prefer to have a larger amount for
training and a smaller amount for test
so they can go by either 60 40 or 70 30
or some people even go with some odd
numbers like 65 35 or
63.33 and 33 which is like one third and
two thirds so there is no fixed rule
that it has to be something that the
ratio has to be this you can go by your
individual preferences all right then
you may have questions around uh data
handling data manipulation
or what you call data management or
preparation so these are all some
questions around that area there is
again no one answer one single good
answer to this it really varies from
situation to situation and depending on
what exactly is the problem what kind of
data it is how critical it is what kind
of data is missing and what is the type
of corruption so there are a whole lot
of things this is a very generic
question and therefore you need to be
little careful about responding to this
as well so probably have to illustrate
this again if you have experience in
doing this kind of work in handling data
you can illustrate with examples saying
that i was on one project where i
received this kind of data these were
the columns where data was not filled or
these were this many rows where the data
was missing that would be in fact a
perfect way to respond to this question
but if you don't have that obviously you
have to provide some good answer i think
it really depends on what exactly the
situation is and there are multiple ways
of handling the missing data or corrupt
data now let's take a few examples now
let's say you have data where some
values in some of the columns are
missing and you have pretty much half of
your data having these missing values in
terms of number of rows okay that could
be one situation another situation could
be that you have records or data missing
but
when you do some initial calculation how
many records are correct or how many
rows or observations as we call it has
this missing data let's assume it is
very minimal like 10
okay now
between these two cases how do we so
let's assume that this is not a mission
critical situation and in order to fix
this 10 percent of the data the effort
that is required is much higher and
obviously effort means also time and
money right so
it is not so mission critical and it is
okay to let's say get rid of these
records so obviously one of the easiest
ways of handling the data part or
missing data is remove those records or
remove those observations from your
analysis so that is the easiest way to
do but then the downside is as i said in
as in the first case if let's say 50
percent of your data is like that
because some column or the other is
missing so it is not like every in every
place in every row the same column is
missing but you have in maybe ten
percent of the records column one is
missing and another ten percent column
two is missing another ten percent
column three is missing and so on and so
forth so it adds up to maybe half of
your data set so you cannot completely
remove half of your data set then the
whole purpose is lost okay so then how
do you handle then you need to come up
with ways of filling up this data with
some meaningful value right that is one
way of handling so when we say
meaningful value what is that meaningful
let's say for a particular column you
might want to take a mean value for that
column and fill wherever the data is
missing fill up with that mean value so
that when you're doing the calculations
your analysis is not completely way off
so you have values which are not missing
first of all so your system will work
number two these values are not so
completely out of whack that your whole
analysis goes for a task right there may
be situations where if the missing
values instead of putting mean may be a
good idea to fill it up with the minimum
value or with a zero so or with the
maximum value again as i said there are
so many possibilities so there is no
like one correct answer for this you
need to basically talk around this and
illustrate with your experience as i
said that would be the best otherwise
this is how you need to handle this
question okay so
then the next question can be how can
you choose a classifier based on a
training set data size so again this is
one of those questions uh where you
probably do not have like a
one-size-fits-all answer first of all
you
may not let's say
decide your classifier based on the
training set size maybe not the best way
to decide the type of the classifier and
even if you have to there are probably
some thumb rules which we can use but
then again every time so in my opinion
the best way to respond to this question
is you need to try out few classifiers
irrespective of the size of the data and
you need to then decide on your
particular situation which of these
classifiers are the right ones this is a
very generic issue so
you will never be able to just by if
somebody defines a problem to you and
somebody even if they show the data to
you or tell you what is the data or even
the size of the data i don't think there
is a way to really say that yes this is
the classifier that will work here no
that's not the right way so you need to
still
you know test it out get the data try
out a couple of classifiers and then
only you will be in a position to decide
which classifier to use you try out
multiple classifiers see which one gives
the best accuracy and only then you can
decide then you can have a question
around confusion matrix so the question
can be explained confusion matrix right
so confusion matrix i think the best way
to explain it is by taking an example
and drawing like a small diagram
otherwise it can really become tricky so
my suggestion is to take a piece of pen
and paper and
explain it by drawing a small matrix and
confusion matrix is about to find out
this is used especially in
classification
learning process and when you get the
results and our model predicts the
results you compare it with the actual
value and try to find out what is the
accuracy okay so in this case let's say
this is an example of a confusion matrix
and
it is a binary matrix so you have the
actual values which is the labeled data
right and which is so you have how many
yes and how many know so you have that
equation and you have the predicted
values how many yes and how many know
right so the total actual values the
total yes is 12 plus 130 and they are
shown here and the actual value those
are 9 plus 3 12 okay so that is what
this information here is so this is
about the actual and this is about the
predicted similarly the predicted values
there are yes are 12 plus 3 15 yeses and
no are one plus nine ten knows okay so
this is the way to look at this
confusion matrix okay and
out of this what is the meaning
conveying so there are two or three
things that needs to be explained
outright the first thing is for a model
to be accurate the values across the
diagonal should be high like in this
case right that is one number two the
total sum of these values is equal to
the total observations in the test data
set so in this case for example you have
12 plus 3 15 plus 10 25 so that means we
have 25 observations in our test data
set okay so these are the two things you
need to first explain that the total sum
in this matrix the numbers is equal to
the size of the test data set and the
diagonal values indicate the accuracy so
by just by looking at it you can
probably have a idea about is this uh an
accurate model is the model being
accurate if they're all spread out
equally in all these four boxes that
means probably the accuracy is not very
good okay now how do you calculate the
accuracy itself right how do you
calculate the accuracy itself so it is a
very simple mathematical calculation you
take some of the diagonals right so in
this case it is 9 plus 12 21 and divided
by the total so in this case what will
it be let me take a pen so your your
diagonal values is equal to if i say d
is equal to 12 plus 9 so that is 21
right and the total data set is equal to
right we just calculated it is 25 so
what is your accuracy it is 21 by your
accuracy is equal to 21 by 25 and this
turns out to be about 85 percent right
so this is 85
so that is our accuracy okay so this is
the way you need to explain draw diagram
give an example maybe it may be a good
idea to be prepared with an example so
that it becomes easy for you don't have
to calculate those numbers on the fly
right so a couple of uh hints are that
you take some numbers which are with
which add up to 100 that is always a
good idea so you don't have to really do
this complex calculations so the total
value will be 100 and then diagonal
values you divide once you find the
diagonal values that is equal to your
percentage okay all right so
the next question can be a related
question about
false positive and false negative so
what is false positive and what is false
negative now once again the best way to
explain this is using a piece of paper
and pen otherwise it will be pretty
difficult to explain this so we use the
same example of the confusion matrix
and
we can explain that so a confusion
matrix looks somewhat like this and
when we just
yeah it looks somewhat like this and we
continue with the previous example where
this is the actual value this is the
predicted value and
in the actual value we have 12 plus 1 13
yeses and 3 plus 9 12 nose and the
predicted values there are 12 plus 3 15
yeses and
1 plus 9 10 nos okay now in this
particular case which is the false
positive what is a false positive first
of all the second word which is positive
okay is referring to the predicted value
so that means the system has predicted
it as a positive but the real value so
this is what the false comes from but
the real value is not positive okay that
is the way you should understand this
term false positive or even false
negative so false positive so positive
is what your system has predicted so
where is that system predicted this is
the one positive is what yes so you
basically consider this row okay now if
you consider this row so this is this is
all positive values this entire row is
positive values okay now the false
positive is the one which where the
value actual value is negative predicted
value is positive but the actual value
is negative so this is a false positive
right and here is a true positive so the
predicted value is positive and the
actual value is also positive okay i
hope this is making sense now let's take
a look at what is false negative false
negative so negative is the second term
that means that is the predicted value
that we need to look for so which are
the predicted negative values this row
corresponds to predicted negative values
all right so this row corresponds to
predicted negative values and what they
are asking for false so this is the row
for predicted negative values and the
actual value is this one right this is
predicted negative and the actual value
is also negative therefore this is a
true negative so the false negative is
this one predicted is negative but
actual is positive right so this is the
false negative so this is the way to
explain and this is the way to look at
false positive and false negative same
way there can be true positive and true
negative as well so again positive the
second term you will need to use to
identify
the predicted row right so if we say
true positive positive we need to take
for the predicted part so predicted
positive is here okay and then the first
term is for the actual so true positive
so true in case of actual is yes right
so true positive is this one okay and
then in case of actual the negative now
we are talking about let's say true
negative true negative negative is this
one and the true comes from here so this
is true negative right nine is true
negative the actual value is also
negative and the predicted value is also
negative okay so that is the way you
need to explain this the terms false
positive false negative and true
positive true negative then
you might have a question like what are
the
steps involved in the machine learning
process or what are the three steps in
the process of developing a machine
learning model right so it is around the
methodology that is applied so basically
the way you can probably answer in your
own words but the way the model
development of the machine learning
model happens is like this so first of
all you try to understand the problem
and try to figure out whether it is a
classification problem or a regression
problem based on that you select a few
algorithms and then you start the
process of training these models okay so
you can either do that or you can after
due diligence you can probably decide
that there is one particular algorithm
which is most suitable usually it
happens through trial and error process
but at some point you will decide that
okay this is the model we are going to
use okay so in that case we have the
model algorithm and the model decided
and then you need to do the process of
training the model and testing the model
and this is where if it is supervised
learning you split your data the label
data into training data set and test
data set and you use the training data
set to train your model and then you use
the test data set to check the accuracy
whether it is working fine or not so you
test the model before you actually put
it into production right so once you
test the model you're satisfied it's
working fine then you go to the next
level which is putting it for production
and then in production obviously new
data will come and the inference happens
so the model is readily available and
only thing that happens is new data
comes and the model predicts the values
whether it is regression or
classification now so this can be an
iterative process so it is not a
straightforward process where you do the
training through the testing and then
you move it to production now so during
the training and test process there may
be a situation where because of either
overfitting or things like that the test
doesn't go through which means that you
need to put that back into the training
process so that can be an iterative
process not only that even if the
training and test goes through properly
and you deploy the model in production
there can be a situation that the data
that actually comes the real data that
comes with that this model is failing so
in which case you may have to once again
go back to the drawing board or
initially it will be working fine but
over a period of time maybe due to the
change in the nature of the data once
again the accuracy will deteriorate so
that is again a recursive process so
once in a while you need to keep
checking whether the model is working
fine or not and if required you need to
tweak it and modify it and so on and so
forth so net net this is a continuous
process of uh tweaking the model and
testing it and making sure it is up to
date then you might have question around
deep learning so because deep learning
is now associated with ai artificial
intelligence and so on so can be as
simple as what is deep learning so i
think the best way to respond to this
could be deep learning is a part of
machine learning and
then obviously the question would be
then what is the difference right so
deep learning you need to mention there
are two key parts that interviewer will
be looking for when you are defining
deep learning so first is of course deep
learning is a subset of machine learning
so machine learning is still the bigger
let's say
scope and deep learning is one part of
it so then what exactly is the
difference deep learning is primarily
when we are implementing these our
algorithms or when we are using neural
networks for doing our training and
classification and regression and all
that right so when we use neural network
then it is considered as deep learning
and the term deep comes from the fact
that you can have several layers of
neural networks and these are called
deep neural networks and therefore the
term deep you know deep learning the
other difference between machine
learning and deep learning which the
interviewer may be wanting to hear is
that in case of machine learning the
feature engineering is done manually
what do we mean by feature engineering
basically when we are trying to train
our model we have our training data
right so we have our training label data
and
this data has several let's say if it is
a regular table it has several columns
now each of these columns actually has
information about a feature right so if
we are trying to predict the height
weight and so on and so forth so these
are all features of human beings let's
say we have census data and we have all
this so those are the features now there
may be probably 50 or 100 in some cases
there may be 100 such features now all
of them do not contribute to our model
right so we as a data scientist we have
to decide whether we should take all of
them all the features or we should throw
away some of them because again if we
take all of them number one of course
your accuracy will probably get affected
but also there is a computational part
so if you have so many features and then
you have so much data it becomes very
tricky so in case of machine learning we
manually take care of identifying the
features that do not contribute to the
learning process and thereby we
eliminate those features and so on right
so this is known as feature engineering
and in machine learning we do that
manually whereas in deep learning where
we use neural networks the model will
automatically determine which features
to use and which to not use and
therefore feature engineering is also
done automatically so this is a
explanation these are two key things
probably
will add value to your response all
right so the next question is what is
the difference between or what are the
differences between machine learning and
deep learning so here this is a quick
comparison table between machine
learning and deep learning and in
machine learning learning enables
missions to take decisions on their own
based on past data so here we are
talking primarily of supervised learning
and
it needs only a small amount of data for
training and then works well on low end
systems so you don't need large machines
and most features need to be identified
in advance and manually coded so
basically the feature engineering part
is done manually and the problem is
divided into parts and solved
individually and then combined so that
is about the machine learning part in
deep learning deep learning basically
enables machines to take decisions with
the help of artificial neural networks
so here in deep learning we use neural
nets so that is the key differentiator
between machine learning and deep
learning and usually deep learning
involves a large amount of data and
therefore the training also requires
usually the training process requires
high-end machines because it needs a lot
of computing power and the machine
learning features are the or the feature
engineering is done automatically so the
neural networks takes care of doing the
feature engineering as well and in case
of deep learning therefore it is said
that the problem is handled end-to-end
so this is a quick comparison between
machine learning and deep learning in
case you have that kind of a question
then you might get a question around the
uses of machine learning or some real
life applications of machine learning in
modern business the question may be
worded in different ways but the meaning
is how exactly is machine learning used
or actually supervised machine learning
it could be a very specific question
around supervised decision learning so
this is like give examples of supervised
machine learning use of supervised
machine learning in modern business so
that could be the next question so there
are quite a few examples or quite a few
use cases if you will for supervised
machine learning the very common one is
email spam detection so you want to
train your application or your system to
detect between spam and non-spam so this
is a very common business application of
supervised machine learning so how does
this work the way it works is that you
obviously have historical data above
your emails and they are categorized as
spam and not spam so that is what is the
labeled information and then you feed
this information or the all these emails
as an input to your model right and the
model will then get trained to detect
which of the emails are to detect which
is spam and which is not spam so that is
the training process and this is
supervised machine learning because you
have label data you already have emails
which are tagged as spam or not spam and
then you use that to train your model
right so this is one example now there
are a few industry specific applications
for supervised machine learning one of
the very common ones is in healthcare
diagnostics in healthcare diagnostics
you have these images and you want to
train models to detect whether from a
particular image whether it can find out
if the person is sick or not whether a
person has cancer or not right so this
is a very good example of supervised
machine learning here the way it works
is that existing images it could be
x-ray images it be mri or any of these
images are available and they are tagged
saying that okay this x-ray image is
defective or the person has an illness
or it could be cancer whichever illness
right so it is tagged as a defective or
clear or good image and defective
something like that so we come up with a
binary or it could be multi-class as
well saying that this is defective to 10
percent this is 25 and so on but let's
keep it simple you can give an example
of just a binary classification that
would be good enough so
you can say that in healthcare
diagnostics using image we need to
detect whether a person is ill or
whether a person is having cancer or not
so here the way it works is you feed
labeled images and you allow the model
to learn from that so that when new
image is fed it will be able to predict
whether this person is having that
illness or not having cancer or not
right so i think this would be a very
good example for supervised machine
learning in modern business all right
then we can have a question like so
we've been talking about supervised and
unsupervised and so there can be a
question around semi-supervised machine
learning so what is semi-supervised
machine learning now semi-supervised
learning as the name suggests it falls
between supervised learning and
unsupervised learning but for all
practical purposes it is considered as a
part of supervised learning and the
reason this has come into existence is
that in supervised learning you need
labeled data so all your data for
training your model has to be labeled
now this is a big problem in many
industries or in many under many
situations getting the label data is not
that easy because there's a lot of
effort in labeling this data let's take
an example of diagnostic images we can
just let's say take x-ray images now
there are actually millions of x-ray
images available all over the world but
the problem is they are not labeled so
their images are there but whether it is
effective or whether it is good that
information is not available along with
it right in a form that it can be used
by a machine which means that somebody
has to take a look at these images and
usually it should be like a doctor and
then say that okay yes this image is
clean and this image is cancerous and so
on and so forth now that is a huge
effort by itself so this is where
semi-supervised learning comes into play
so what happens is there is a large
amount of data maybe a part of it is
labeled then we try some techniques to
label the remaining part of the data so
that we get completely labeled data and
then we train our model so i know this
is a little long winding explanation but
unfortunately there is no
quick and easy definition for semi
supervised machine learning this is the
only way probably to explain this
concept
we may have another question as
what are unsupervised machine learning
techniques or what are some of the
techniques used for performing
unsupervised machine learning so it can
be worded in different ways so how do we
answer this question so unsupervised
learning you can say that there are two
types clustering and association and
clustering is a technique where similar
objects are put together and there are
different ways of finding similar
objects so their characteristics can be
measured and if they have in most of the
characteristics if they are similar then
they can be put together this is
clustering then association you can i
think the best way to explain
association is with an example in case
of association you try to find out how
the items are linked to each other so
for example if somebody bought
maybe a laptop the person has also
purchased a mouse so this is more in an
e-commerce scenario for example so you
can give this as an example so people
who are buying laptops are also buying
the mouse so that means there is an
association between laptops and mouse or
maybe people who are buying bread are
also buying butter so that is the
association that can be created so this
is unsupervised learning one of the
techniques okay all right then we have
very fundamental question what is the
difference between supervised and
unsupervised machine learning so
machine learning these are the two main
types of machine learning supervised and
unsized and in case of supervised and
again here probably the keyword that the
person may be wanting to hear is labeled
data now very often people say we have
historical data and if we run it it is
supervised and if we don't have
historical data yes but you may have
historical data but if it is not labeled
then you cannot use it for supervised
learning so it is it's very key to
understand that we put in that keyword
label okay so when we have labeled data
for training our model then we can use
supervised learning and if we do not
have label data then we use unsupervised
learning and there are different
algorithms available to perform both of
these types of trainings so
there can be another question a little
bit more theoretical and conceptual in
nature this is about inductive machine
learning and
deductive machine learning so the
question can be what is the difference
between inductive machine learning and
deductive machine learning or
somewhat in that manner so the exact
phrase or exact question can vary they
can ask for examples and things like
that but that could be the question so
let's first understand what is inductive
and deductive training inductive
training is induced by somebody and you
can illustrate that with a small example
i think that always helps so whenever
you're doing some explanation try as
much as possible as i said to give
examples from your work experience or
give some analogies and that will also
help a lot in explaining as well and for
the interviewer also to understand so
here we'll take an example or rather we
will use an analogy so inductive
training is when we induce some
knowledge or the learning process into a
person without the person actually
experiencing it okay what can be an
example so we can probably tell the
person or show a person a video that
fire can burn the thing burn his finger
or fire can cause damage so what is
happening here this person has never
probably seen a fire or never seen
anything getting damaged by fire but
just because he has seen this video he
knows that okay fire is dangerous and if
a fire can cause damage
right so this is inductive learning
compared to that what is deductive
learning so here you draw conclusion or
the person draws conclusion out of
experience so we will stick to the
analogy so compared to the showing a
video let's assume a person is allowed
to play with fire right and then he
figures out that if he puts his finger
it's burning or if throw something into
the fire it burns so he is learning
through experience so this is known as
deductive learning okay so you can have
applications or models that can be
trained using inductive learning or
deductive learning all right i think uh
probably that explanation will be
sufficient the next question is are knn
and k means clustering similar to one
another or are they same right because
the letter k is kind of common between
them okay so let us take a
for the letter k being common between
them k n is completely different k means
clustering is completely different k nnn
is a classification process and
therefore it comes under supervised
learning whereas k means clustering is
actually unsupervised okay when you have
k and n when you want to implement k n
which is basically k nearest neighbors
the value of k is a number so you can
say k is equal to 3 you want to
implement k n n with k is equal to 3 so
which means that it performs the
classification in such a way that how
does it perform the classification so it
will take three nearest objects and
that's why it's called nearest neighbor
so basically based on the distance it
will try to find out its nearest objects
that are let's say three of the nearest
objects and then it will check whether
the class they belong to which class
right so if all three belong to one
particular class obviously this new
object is also classified as that
particular class but it is possible that
they may be from two or three different
classes okay so let's say they are from
two classes and then if they are from
two classes now usually you take a odd
number you assign a odd number to so if
there are three of them and two of them
belong to one class and then one belongs
to another class so this new object is
assigned to the class to which the two
of them belong now the value of k is
sometimes tricky whether should you use
three should you use five should you use
seven that can be tricky because the
ultimate classification can also vary so
it's possible that if you're taking k as
three the object is probably in one
particular class but if you take k is
equal to five maybe the object will
belong to a different class because when
you are taking three of them probably
two of them belong to a class one and
one belong to class two whereas when you
take five of them it is possible that
only two of them belong to class one and
three of them belong to class two so
which means that this object will belong
to class two right so you see that so it
is the class allocation can vary
depending on the value of k now k means
on the other hand is a clustering
process and it is unsupervised where
what it does is the system will
basically identify how the objects are
how close the objects are with respect
to some of their features okay and but
similarity of course is the the letter k
and in case of k means also we specify
its value and it could be three or five
or seven there is no technical limit as
such but it can be any number of
clusters that you can create okay so
based on the value that you provide the
system will create that many clusters of
similar objects so there is a similarity
to that extent that k is a number in
both the cases but actually these two
are completely different processes
we have what is known as naive bayes
classifier and people often get confused
thinking that naive bayes is the name of
the person who found this classifier in
order to develop this classifier which
is not 100 true base is the name of the
person bayes is the name of the person
but naive is not the name of the person
right so naive is basically an english
word and that has been added here
because of the nature of this particular
classifier naive bayes classifier is a
probability based classifier and
it makes some assumptions that
presence of one feature of a class is
not related to the presence of any other
feature of maybe other classes right so
which is not a very strong or not a very
what do you say accurate assumption
because these features can be related
and so on but even if we go with this
assumption this whole algorithm works
very well even with this assumption and
that is the good side of it but the term
comes from that so that is the
explanation that you can
then there can be question around
reinforcement learning it can be
paraphrased in multiple ways one could
be can you explain how a system can play
a game of chess using reinforcement
learning or it can be any game so the
best way to explain this is again to
talk a little bit about what
reinforcement learning is about and then
elaborate on that to explain the process
so first of all reinforcement learning
has an environment and an agent and the
agent is basically performing some
actions in order to achieve a certain
goal and this goals can be anything
either if it is related to game then the
goal could be that you have to score
very high score high value high number
or it could be that your
number of lives should be as high as
possible don't lose life so this could
be some of them more advanced examples
could be for driving the automotive
industry self-driving cars they actually
also make use of reinforcement learning
to teach the car how to navigate through
the roads and so on and so forth that is
also another example now how does it
work so if the system is basically there
is an agent and environment and every
time the agent takes a step or performs
a task which is taking it towards the
goal the final goal let's say to
maximize the score or to minimize the
number of lives and so on or minimize
the debts for example it is rewarded and
every time it takes a step which goes
against that code right contrary or in
the reverse direction it is penalized
okay so it is like a carrot and a stick
system now how do you use this to create
a game of chess so to create a system to
play a game of chess now the way this
works is and this could probably go back
to this alphago example where alphago
defeated a human champion so the way it
works is in reinforcement learning the
system is allowed for example in this
case we are talking about chess so we
allow the system to first of all watch
playing a game of chess so it could be
with a human being or it could be the
system itself there are computer games
of chess right so
either this new learning system has to
watch that game or watch a human being
play the game because this is
reinforcement learning is pretty much
all visual so when you're teaching the
system to play a game the system will
not actually go behind the scenes to
understand the logic of your software of
this game or anything like that it is
just visually watching the screen and
then it learns okay so reinforcement
learning to a large extent works on that
so you need to create a mechanism
whereby your model will be able to watch
somebody playing the game and then you
allow the system also to start playing
the game so it pretty much starts from
scratch okay and as it moves forward it
it's at right at the beginning and the
system really knows nothing about the
game of chess okay so initially it is a
clean slate it just starts by observing
how you're playing so it will make some
random moves and keep losing badly but
then what happens is over a period of
time so you need to now
allow the system or you need to play
with the system not just one two three
four or five times but hundreds of times
thousands of times maybe even hundreds
of thousands of times and that's exactly
how alphago has done it played millions
of games between itself and the system
right so for the game of chess also you
need to do something like that you need
to allow the system to purchase and then
learn on its own over a period of
repetitions so i think you can probably
explain it to this much to this extent
and it should be
sufficient
now this is another question which is
again somewhat similar but here the size
is not coming into picture so the
question is how will you know which
machine learning algorithm to choose for
your classification problem now this is
not only classification problem it could
be a regression problem i would like to
generalize this question so if somebody
asks you how will you choose how will
you know which algorithm to use the
simple answer is there is no way you can
decide exactly saying that this is the
algorithm i am going to use in a variety
of situations there are some guidelines
like for example you will obviously
depending on the problem you can say
whether it is a classification problem
or a regression problem and then in that
sense you are kind of restricting
yourself to if it is a classification
problem there are you can only apply a
classification algorithm right to that
extent you can probably let's say limit
the number of algorithms but now within
the classification algorithms you have
decision trees you have svm you have
logistic regression is it possible to
outright say yes so for this particular
problem since you have explained this
now this is the exact algorithm that you
can use that is not possible okay so we
have to try out a bunch of algorithms
see which one gives us the best
performance and best accuracy and then
decide to go with that particular
algorithm so in machine learning a lot
of it happens through trial and error
there is no real possibility that
anybody can just by looking at the
problem or understanding the problem
tell you that okay in this particular
situation this is exactly the algorithm
that you should use
then the questions may be around
application of machine learning and this
question is specifically around how
amazon is able to recommend other things
to buy so this is around recommendation
engine how does it work how does the
recommendation engine work so this is
basically the question is all about so
the recommendation engine again works
based on various inputs that are
provided obviously something like uh you
know amazon a website or e-commerce site
like amazon collects a lot of data
around the customer behavior who is
purchasing what and if somebody is
buying a particular thing they are also
buying something else so this kind of
association right so this is the
unsupervised learning we talked about
they use this to associate and link or
relate items and that is one part of it
so they kind of build association
between items saying that somebody
buying this is also buying this that is
one part of it then they also profile
the users right based on their age their
gender their geographic location they
will do some profiling and then when
somebody is logging in and when somebody
is shopping kind of the mapping of these
two things are done they try to identify
obviously if you have logged in then
they know who you are and your
information is available like for
example your age maybe your agenda and
where you're located what you purchased
earlier right so all this is taken and
the recommendation engine basically uses
all this information and comes up with
recommendations for a particular user so
that is how the recommendation engine
works all right then the question can be
something very basic like when will you
go for classification versus regression
right when do you do classification
instead of regression or when you use
classification instead of regression now
yes so so this is basically going back
to the understanding of the basics of
classification and regression so
classification is used when you have to
identify or categorize things into
discrete classes so the best way to
respond to this question is to take up
some examples and use it otherwise it
can become a little tricky the question
may sound very simple but explaining it
can sometimes be very tricky in case of
regression we use of course there will
be some keywords that they will be
looking for so just you need to make
sure you use those keywords one is the
discrete values and other is the
continuous values so for regression if
you are trying to find some continuous
values you use regression whereas if you
are trying to find some discrete values
you use classification and then you need
to illustrate what are some of the
examples so classification is like let's
say there are images and you need to put
them into classes like cat dog elephant
tiger something like that so that is a
classification problem or it can be that
is a multi-class classification problem
it could be binary classification
problem like for example whether a
customer will buy or he will not buy
that is a classification binary
classification it can be in the weather
forecast area now weather forecast is
again combination of regression and
classification because on the one hand
you want to predict whether it's going
to rain or not that's a classification
problem that's a binary classification
right whether it's going to rain or not
rain however you also have to predict
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow right now temperature is a
continuous value you can't answer the
temperature in a yes or no kind of a
response right so what will be the
temperature tomorrow so you need to give
a number which can be like 20 degrees 30
degrees or whatever right so that is
where you use regression one more
example is stock price prediction so
that is where again you will use
regression so these are the various
examples so you need to illustrate with
examples and make sure you include those
keywords like discrete and continuous so
the next question is more about a little
bit of a design related question to
understand your concepts and things like
that so it is how will you design a spam
filter so how do you basically design or
develop a spam filter so i think the
main thing here is he is looking at
probably understanding your concepts in
terms of what is the algorithm you will
use or what is your understanding about
difference between classification and
regression
and things like that right and the
process of course the methodology and
the process so the best way to go about
responding to this is we say that okay
this is a classification problem because
we want to find out whether an email is
a spam or not spam so that we can apply
the filter accordingly so first thing is
to identify what type of a problem it is
so we have identified that it is a
classification then the second step may
be to find out what kind of algorithm to
use now since this is a binary
classification problem logistic
regression is a very common very common
algorithm but however right as i said
earlier also we can never say that okay
for this particular problem this is
exactly the algorithm that we can use so
we can also probably try decision trees
or even support vector missions for
example svm so we will kind of list down
a few of these algorithms and we will
say okay we want we would like to try
out these algorithms and then we go
about taking your historical data which
is the labeled data which are marked so
you will have a bunch of emails and then
you split that into training and test
data sets you use your training data set
to train your model that or your
algorithm that you have used or rather
the model actually
so and you actually will have three
models let's say you are trying to test
out three algorithms so you will
obviously have three models so you need
to try all three models and test them
out as well see which one gives the best
accuracy and then you decide that you
will go with that model okay so training
and tests will be done and then you zero
in on one particular model and then you
say okay this is the model will be used
we will use and then go ahead and
implement that or put that in production
so that is the way you design a spam
file the next question is about random
foreign so what is random forest so this
is a very straightforward question
however the response you need to be
again a little careful while we all know
what is random forest explaining this
can sometimes be tricky so one thing is
random forest is kind of in one way it
is an extension of decision trees
because it is basically nothing but you
have multiple decision trees and
trees will basically you will use for
doing if it is classification mostly it
is classification you will use the trees
for classification and then you use
voting for finding that the final class
so that is the underlyings but how will
you explain this how will you respond to
this so first thing obviously we will
say that random forest is one of the
algorithms and the more important thing
that you need to probably the
interviewer is waiting to hear is
ensemble learner right so this is one
type of ensemble learner what is
ensemble learner ensemble learner is
like a combination of algorithms so it
is a learner which consists of more than
one algorithm or more than one maybe
models okay so in case of random forest
the algorithm is the same but instead of
using one instance of it we use multiple
instances of it and we use so in a way
that is a random forest is an ensemble
learner there are other types of
ensemble learners where we have like we
use different algorithms itself so you
have one maybe logistic regression and a
decision tree combined together and so
on and so forth or there are other ways
like for example splitting the data in a
certain way and so on so that's all
about ensembl we will not go into that
but random foreign i think the interview
will be happy to hear this word ensemble
learners and so then you go and explain
how the random forest works so if the
random forest is used for classification
then we use what is known as a voting
mechanism so basically how does it work
let's say your random forest consists of
100 trees okay and each observation you
pass through this forest and each
observation let's say it is a
classification problem binary
classification 0 or 1 and you have 100
trees now if 90 trees say that it is a 0
and 10 of the trees say it is a 1 you
take the majority you may take a vote
and since 90 of them are saying 0 you
classify this as 0. then you take the
next observation and so on so that is
the way uh random forest works for
classification if it is a regression
problem it's somewhat similar but only
thing is instead of vote what we will do
is sorry in regression remember what
happens you actually calculate a value
right so for example you're using
regression to predict the temperature
and you have 100 trees and each tree
obviously will probably predict a
different value of the temperature they
may be close to each other but they may
not be exactly the same value so these
100 trees so how do you now find the
actual value the output for the entire
forest right so you have outputs of
individual trees which are a part of
this forest but then you need to find
the final output of the forest itself so
how do you do that so in case of
regression you take like an average or
the mean of all the 100 trees right so
this is also a way of reducing the error
so maybe if you have only one tree and
if that one tree makes a error it is
basically hundred percent wrong or 100
right right but if you have on the other
hand if you have a bunch of trees you
are basically mitigating that
reducing that error okay so that is the
way random forest works so the next
question is considering the long list of
machine learning algorithms how will you
decide on which one to use so once again
here there is no way to outright say
that this is the algorithm that we will
use for a given data set this is a very
good question but then the response has
to be like again there will not be a one
size fits all so we need to first of all
you can probably shorten the list in
terms of by saying okay whether it is a
classification problem or it is a
regression problem to that extent you
can probably shorten the list because
you don't have to use all of them if it
is a classification problem you only can
pick from the classification algorithms
right so for example if it's a
classification you cannot use linear
regression algorithm there or if it is a
regression problem you cannot use svm or
maybe now you can use svm but maybe a
logistic regression right so to that
extent you can probably shorten the list
but still you will not be able to 100
decide on saying that this is the exact
algorithm that i am going to use so the
way to go about is you choose a few
algorithms based on what the problem is
you try out your data you train some
models of these algorithms check which
one gives you the lowest error or the
highest accuracy and based on that you
choose that particular algorithm okay
all right then they can be questions
around bias and variance so the question
can be what is bias and variance in
machine learning uh so you just need to
give out a definition for each of these
for example a bias in machine learning
it occurs when the predicted values are
far away from the actual values so that
is a bias okay and whereas they are all
all the values are probably they are far
off but they are very near to each other
though the predicted values are close to
each other right while they are far off
from the actual value but they are close
to each other you see the difference so
that is bias and then the other part is
your variance now variance is when the
predicted values are all over the place
right so
the variance is high that means it may
be close to the target but it is kind of
very scattered so the points the
predicted values are not close to each
other right in case of bias the
predicted values are close to each other
but they are not close to the target but
here they may be close to the target but
they may not be close to each other so
they are a little bit more scattered so
that is what in case of a variance okay
then the next question is about again
related to bias and variance what is the
trade-off between bias and variance yes
i think this is a interesting question
because these two are heading in
different directions so for example if
you try to minimize the bias variance
will keep going high and if you try to
minimize the variance bias will keep
going high and there is no way you can
minimize both of them so you need to
have a trade-off saying that okay this
is the level at which i will have my
bias and this is the level at which i
will have variance so the trade-off is
that pretty much uh attack you you
decide what is the level you will
tolerate for your bias and what is the
level you will tolerate for variance and
a combination of these two in such a way
that your final results are not way off
and having a trade-off will ensure that
the results are consistent right so that
is basically the output is consistent
and which means that they are close to
each other and they are also accurate
that means they are as close to the
target as possible right so if either of
these is high then one of them will go
off the track define precision and
recall now again here i think it would
be best to
draw a diagram and take
the confusion matrix and it is very
simple the definition is like a formula
your precision is true positive by true
positive plus false positive and your
recall is true positive by true positive
plus false negative okay so that's you
can just show it in a mathematical way
that's pretty much you know that can be
shown that's the easiest way to define
so the next question can be about
decision tree what is decision tree
pruning and why is it so
basically decision trees are really
simple to implement and understand but
one of the drawbacks of decision trees
is that it can become highly complicated
as it grows right and the rules and
conditions can become very complicated
and this can also lead to overfitting
which is basically that during training
you will get 100
accuracy but when you are doing testing
you will get a lot of errors so that is
the reason pruning needs to be done so
the purpose or the reason for doing
decision tree pruning is to reduce
overfitting or to cut down on
overfitting and
what is decision tree pruning it is
basically that you reduce the number of
branches because as you may be aware a
tree consists of the root node and then
there are several internal nodes and
then you have the leaf nodes now if
there are too many of these internal
nodes that is when you face the problem
of overfitting and pruning is the
process of reducing those internal nodes
all right so the next question can be
what is logistic regression
so basically logistic regression is
one of the techniques used for
performing classification especially
binary classification now there is
something special about logistic
regression and there are a couple of
things you need to be careful about
first of all the name is a little
confusing it is called logistic
regression but it is used for
classification so this can be sometimes
confusing so you need to probably
clarify that to the interviewer if it's
really you know if it is required and
they can also ask this like a trick
question right so that is one part
second thing is the term logistic has
nothing to do with the usual logistics
that we talk about but it is derived
from log so that the mathematical
derivation involves log and therefore
the name logistic regression so what is
logistic regression and how is it used
so logistic regression is used for
binary classification and the output of
a logistic regression is either a 0 or a
1 and it varies so it's basically it
calculates a probability between 0 and 1
and we can set a threshold that can vary
typically it is 0.5 so any value above
0.5 is considered as 1 and if the
probability is below 0.5 it is
considered as zero so that is the way we
calculate the probability or the system
calculates the probability and based on
the threshold it sets a value of zero or
one which is like a binary
classification zero or one okay then we
have a question around k nearest
neighbor algorithm so explain k nearest
neighbor algorithm so first of all what
is a k nearest neighbor algorithm this
is a classification algorithm so that is
the first thing we need to mention and
we also need to mention that the k is a
number it is an integer and this is
variable and we can define what the
value of k should be it can be 2 3 5 7
and usually it is an odd number so that
is something we need to mention
technically it can be even number also
but then typically it would be odd
number and we will see why that is okay
so based on that we need to classify
objects okay we need to classify objects
so again it will be very helpful to draw
a diagram you know if you're explaining
i think that will be the best way so
draw some diagram like this and let's
say we have three clusters or three
classes existing and now you want to
find for a new item that has come you
want to find out which class this
belongs to right so you go about as the
name suggests if you go about finding
the nearest neighbors right the points
which are closest to this and how many
of them you will find that is what is
defined by k now let's say our initial
value of k was 5
so you will find the k the five nearest
data points so in this case as it is
illustrated these are the five nearest
data points but then all five do not
belong to the same class or cluster so
there are one belonging to this cluster
one the second one belonging to this
cluster two three of them belonging to
this third cluster okay so how do you
decide that's exactly the reason we
should as much as possible try to assign
an odd number so that it becomes easier
to assign this so in this case you see
that the majority actually if there are
multiple classes then you go with the
majority so since three of these items
belong to this class we assign which is
basically the in in this case the green
or the tennis or the third cluster as i
was talking about right so we assign it
to this third class so in this case it
is uh that's how it is decided okay so k
nearest neighbor so first thing is to
identify the number of neighbors that
are mentioned as k so in this case it is
k is equal to 5 so we find the five
nearest points and then find out out of
these five which class has the maximum
number in that and and then the
new data point is assigned to that class
okay so that's pretty much how k nearest
neighbors work we're going to help you
prepare for interview questions dealing
with deep learning and we're going to go
from the very basics of neural networks
and deep learning into some of the more
commonly used models so you can have an
understanding of what kind of questions
are going to come up and what you need
to know in interview questions we'll
start with a very general concept of
what is deep learning this is where we
take large volumes of data in this case
on cats and dogs or whatever a lot of
times you use
a training setup to train your model
remember it's kind of like a magic black
box going on there then we use that to
extract features or extract information
and in this case classify the image of a
cat and a dog so the primary takeaway
we're talking about deep learning is it
learns from large volumes of structured
and even unstructured data and uses
complex algorithms to train neural
network it also performs complex
operations to extract hidden patterns
and features and if we're going to
discuss deep learning in this very
simplified overview and we also have to
go over what is a neural network this is
a common image you'll see of a drawing
of a forward propagation neural network
and it's it's a human brain inspired
system which replicates the way humans
learn so this is inspired how our own
neurons in our brain fire but at a much
simplified level obviously it's not
ready to take over the human population
and be our leader yet not for many years
it's very much in its infant stage but
it's inspired by how our brains work and
they use a lot of other inspirations you
can study brains of moths and other
animals that they've used to figure out
how to improve these neural networks the
most common one consists of three layers
of network and this is generally how you
view these networks is you have an input
you have a hidden layer and an output
and the neural network is broken up into
many pieces but we focus just on the
neural network it's always on the hidden
layers that we're making all the
adjustments and figuring out how to best
set up those hidden layers for their
functions to both train faster and to
function better when we look at this of
course we have our input hidden and
output each layer contains neurons
called as nodes perform various
operations
as we go down the list and we study the
deep learning and the neural network
framework
let's start with what is a multi-layer
perceptron or mlp a lot of time is
referred to and you'll see these
abbreviations i'll be honest i have to
write them down on a piece of paper and
go through them because i never remember
what they all mean even though i play
with them all the time what is a
multi-layer precipitant well if you look
at the image on the right it's very
similar to what we just looked at you
have your input layer your hidden layer
and your output layer and that's exactly
what this is it has the same structure
of a single layer perceptron with one or
more hidden layers except the input
layer each node in the other layers uses
a non-linear activation function what
that means is your input layers your
data coming in and then your activation
function is based upon all those nodes
and weights being added together and
then it has the output mlp uses
supervised learning method called back
propagation for training the model very
key word there is back propagation
single layer persepotron can classify
only linear separable classes with
binary output 0 1 but the mlp can
classify non-linear classes so let's
break this down just a little bit the
multi-layer perceptron with an input
layer and a hidden layer and an output
layer as you see that it comes in there
it has adds up all the numbers and
weights depending on how your setup is
that then goes to the next layer that
then goes to the next hidden layer if
you have multiple hidden layers and
finally to the output layer the back
propagation takes the error that it sees
so whatever the output is it says hey
this has an error to it it's wrong and
it sends that error backwards from where
it came from and there's a lot of
different functions used to
train this based on that error and how
that error goes backwards in the notes
so forward is you get your answers
backward is for training you see this
every day even my uh google pixel phone
has this it they train the neural
network which takes a lot more data to
train than it does to use and then they
load up that neural network into in this
case i have a pixel 2 which actually has
a built-in neural network for processing
pictures and so it's just the forward
propagation i use when it processes my
photos but when they were training it
used the back propagation to train it
with the errors they had we'll be coming
back to different models that are used
for right now though multi-layer
persepotron mlp put that down as your
vocabulary word and of course back
propagation
what is data normalization and why do we
need it this is so important we spend so
much time in normalizing our data and
getting our data clean and setting it up
so we talk about data there's a
pre-processing step to standardize the
data so whatever we have coming in we
don't want it to be a
one gigabyte file here a two gigabyte
picture here and a three kilobyte text
there even as a human i can't process
those all in the same group i have to
reformat them in some way that loops
them together so the standardized format
we use this uh data normalization in
pre-processing to reduce it and
eliminate data redundancy a lot of times
the data comes in and you end up with
two of the same images or
the same information in different
formats then we want to rescale values
to fit into a particular range for
achieving better convergence what this
means is with most neural networks they
form a bias we've seen this in recently
in attacks on neural networks where they
light up one pixel or one piece of the
view and it skews the whole answer so
suddenly
because one pixel is really bright it
doesn't know what to do but when we
start rescaling it we put all the values
between say -1 and 1 and we change them
and re-fit them to those values it helps
get rid of that bias helps fix for some
of those problems and then finally we
restructure the data and improve the
integrity we want to make sure that
we're not missing values or we don't
have partial data coming in one way to
look at this is
bad data in bad data out
so we want clean data in and you want
good answers coming out one of the most
basic models used is a boltzmann machine
so let's address what is a boltzmann
machine and if you know we just did the
mlp multi-layer perceptron so now we're
going to come into almost a simplified
version of that and in this we have our
visible input layer and we have our
hidden layer the boltzmann machines are
almost always shallow they're usually
just two layer neural nets that make
stochastic decisions whether a neuron
should be on or off true false yes no
first layer is a visible layer and
second layer is the hidden layer nodes
are connected to each other across
layers but no two nodes of the same
layer are connected hence it is also
known as restricted boltzmann machine
now that we've covered a basic mlp or
multi-layer perceptron and we've gone
over the boltzmann machine also known as
the restricted boltzmann machine let's
talk a little bit about activation
formulas and this is a huge topic that
can get really complicated but it also
is automated so it's very simple so you
have both a complicated and a simple at
the same time so what is the role of
activation functions in a neural network
activation function decides whether a
neuron should be fired or not that's the
most basic one and that actually changes
a little bit because it's either whether
fired or not in this case activation
function or what value should come out
when it's fired but in these models
we're looking at just the boltzmann
restricted layers so this is what causes
them to fire either they don't or they
do it's a yes or no true false all or
nothing it accepts the weighted sum of
the inputs the bias as input to any
activation function so whatever
activation function is it needs to have
the sum of the weights times the input
so each input if you remember on that
model and let's just go back to that
model real quick and then you always
have to add a bias and you can look at
the bias if you remember from your
euclidean geometry you draw a straight
line formula for that line has a
y-coordinate at the end it's always cx
plus m or something like that where m is
where it crosses the y-coordinates if
you're doing a straight line with these
weights it's very similar but a lot of
times we just add it in as its own
weight we take it as a node of a one
value coming in and then we compute its
new weight and that's how we compute
that bias just like we compute all the
other weights coming in the node which
gets fires depends on the y value and
then we have a step function and the
step function this is where i remember i
said is going to get complicated and
simple all at the same time we have a
lot of different step functions we have
the sigmoid function we have just a
standard step function we have the relu
it's pronounced like ray the ray of from
the sun and lu like a name so relu
function and we have the tangent h
function and if you look at these they
all have something similar they all
either force it to be
one value or the other they force it to
be in the case of the first three is
zero or one and in the last one it's
either a minus one or a one and you can
easily convert that to a zero one yes no
true false and on this one of the most
common ones is the step function itself
because there is no middle value there
is no
discrepancy that says well i'm not quite
sure but as you get into different
models probably the most commonly used
used to be the sigmoid was most commonly
used but i see the relu used more often
really depending on what you're doing
you just have to play with these and
find out which one works best depending
on the data and your output the reason
to have a non-zero one answer or
something kind of in the middle is when
you're looking at this and it's coming
out you can actually process that middle
ground as part of the answer into
another neural network so it might be
that the rayleigh function says hey this
is only a 0.6 not a one and uh even
though the one is what's going into the
next neural network or the next hidden
layer as an input the 0.6 value might
also be going in there to let you know
hey this is not a straight up 1 or
straight up 0 is someplace in the middle
this is a little uncertain what's coming
out here so it's a very powerful tool
but the basic neural network you usually
just use the step function it's yes or
no let's take a a big step back and take
a kind of an overview the next function
is what is a cost function that we're
going to cover this is so important
because this is your end result that
you're going to do over and over again
and use to decide whether the model is
working or not whether you need to try a
different step function whether you need
to try a different activation whether
you need to try a fully different model
used
so what is the cost function cost
function is the measure to evaluate how
good your model's performance is it is
also referred as loss or error used to
compute the error of the output layer
during back propagation there's our back
propagation where we're training our
model that's one of our key words mean
squared error is an example of a popular
cost function and so here we have the
cost function c equals half of y minus y
predicted and then you square that so
the first thing is
you know real quick if you haven't done
statistics this is not a percentage it's
not a percentage of how accurate it is
it's just a measurement of the error and
we take that error for training it and
we push that error backwards through the
neural network and we use that through
the different training functions
depending on what model you're using to
train the neural network so when you
deploy the network you're usually done
training it because it takes a lot of
computational force to train it this is
a very simple model and so you deploy
the trained one but we want to know how
your error is and so how do we do that
well you split your data part of your
data is for trading and part of your
data is for testing and then we can also
test the error on there so it's very
important and then we're going to go one
more step on this we got to look at both
the local and the global setup it might
work great to test your data on what you
have on your computer but that's
different than in the field so when
we're talking about all these different
tests in the error test as far as your
loss you don't you want to make sure
that you're in a closed environment when
you do initial testing but you also want
to open that up and make sure you follow
up with the testing on the larger scale
of data because it will change it might
not fit the larger scale there might be
something in there in the way you
brought the data in specifically or the
data group you used or any of those
could cause an error so it's very
important to remember that we're looking
at both the local and the global context
of our error and just one other side
note on a lot of the newer models of
neural networks by comparing the error
we get on the data our training data
with a portion of the test data we can
actually figure out how good the model
is whether it's overfitted or not we'll
go into that a little bit more as we go
into some of the different models so we
have our output we're able to figure out
the error on it based on the square
means usually although there's other
functions used so we want to talk about
what is gradient descent another
vocabulary word gradient descent is an
optimization algorithm to minimize the
cost function or to minimize the error
aim is to find the local or global
minima of a function determine the
direction the model should take to
reduce the error so as we're looking at
this we have our squared error that we
just figured out the cop based on the
cost function it says how bad is my
model fitting the data i just put
through it and then we want to reduce
that error so how do you figure out what
direction to do that in well it could be
that you're looking at just that line of
that line of data coming in so that
would be a local minima we want to know
the error of that particular setup
coming in and then you have your global
your global minima we want to minimize
it based on the overall data we're
putting through it and with this we can
figure out the global minimum cost we
want to take all those local minimum
costs of each piece of data coming in
and figure out the global one how we're
going to adjust this model to fit all
the data we don't want it to be biased
just on three or four lines of data
coming in we wanted to kind of
extrapolate a general answer for all the
data coming in but this of course we
mentioned it briefly about back
propagation this is where really comes
in handy is training our model neural
network technique to minimize the cost
function helps to improve the
performance of the network back
propagates the error and updates the
weights to reduce the error so as you
can see here is a very nice depiction of
a back propagation we have our predicted
y coming out and then we have since it's
a training set we already know the
answer and the answer comes back and
based on case of the square means was
one of the functions we looked at uh one
of the activation functions based on
cost function that cost function then
depending on what you choose for your
back propagation method and there's a
number of them we'll change the weights
it will change the weight going to each
of the one of those nodes in the hidden
layer and then based upon the error
that's still being carried back it'll
change the way it's going to the next
hidden layer and then it computes an
error level on that and sends that back
up and you're going to say well if it
computes the air into the first hidden
layer and fixes it why would it stop
there well remember we don't want to
create a biased neural network so we
only make small adjustments on these
weights we don't make a big adjustment
that changes everything right off the
bat so no matter how far back you go
you're always going to have a small
amount of error and that's still going
to continue to go all the way back up
the hidden layers for right now focus on
the back propagation is taking that
error and moving it backwards on the
neural network to change the weights and
help program it so that it'll have the
correct answers so far we've been
talking about forward propagation neural
networks everything goes forwards goes
left to right uh but let's just take a
little detour and see what is the
difference between a feed forward neural
network and a recurrent neural network
now this is in the function not when
we're training it using the back
propagation so you've got new
information coming in and you want to
get the answer and there's a couple
different networks out there and we want
to know we have a feed forward neural
network and we have a new vocabulary
term recurrent neural network a feed
forward neural network signals travel in
one direction from input to output no
feedback loops considers only the
current input cannot memorize previous
inputs one example of one of these feed
forward neural networks and we've
covered a number of them but one of the
ones that has a big highlight nowadays
is the cnn a convolutional neural
network tensorflow the one put out by
google is probably most known for their
cnn where the information goes forward
it first takes a picture splits it apart
goes through the individual pixels on
the picture so it picks up a different
reading then calculates based on that
goes into a regular feed forward neural
network and then gives your
categorization on there now we're not
covering the cnn today but we do have a
video out that you can look up on
youtube put out by simplylearn the
convolutional neural network wonderful
tutorial check that out and learn a lot
more about the convolutional neural
network but you do need to know that the
cnn is a forward propagation neural
network only so it's only moving in one
direction so we will look at a recurrent
neural network signals travel in both
directions making it a looped network
considers the current input along with
the previous received inputs for
generating the output of a layer has the
ability to memorize past data due to its
internal memory and you can see they
have a nice image here we have our
input and for some reason they always do
the recurrent neural network
in reverse from bottom up in the images
kind of a standard although i'm not sure
why your x goes into your hidden layer
and your hidden layer the answer for
part of the answer from that it
generates feeds back into the hidden
layer so now you have an input of both x
and part of the hidden layer and then
that feeds into your output now if we go
back to the forward let me just go back
a slide and we're looking at our forward
propagation network one of the tricks
you can do to use just a forward
propagation network is if you're in a
what they call a time sequence that's a
good term to remember are a time series
meaning that a sequential data each term
comes after the other you can trick this
by creating your input nodes as with the
history so if you know that you have
values 1 5 and 7 going in and you know
what the output is from one what those
outputs are you can expand the input to
include the history input that's one of
the ways to trick a forward propagation
network into looking at that but when
you do with a near recurrent neural
network you let the hidden layer do that
for you it sends that data and
reprocesses it back into itself what are
some of the applications of recurrent
neural network the rnn can be used for
sentiment analysis and text mining
getting up early in the morning is good
for health and it's a positive sentiment
one of the catches you really want to
look at this when you're looking at the
language is that i could switch this
around and totally negate the meaning of
what i'm doing so would no longer be
positive so when you're looking at a
sentence knowing the order of the words
is as important as the meaning of the
words you can't just count how many good
words there are versus bad words to get
some positive sentiment you now have to
know what they're addressing and there's
lots of other different uses
kids are playing football or soccer as
we call it in the us rn can help you
caption an image so based on previous
information coming in it refeeds that
back in and you have a image setter and
then time series problems like
predicting the prices of stocks in a
month or quarter or sell a product can
be solved using an rnn and this is a
really good example you have whatever
your stocks were doing earlier this
month will have a huge effect on what
they're doing today if you're investing
so having an rnn model a recurrent
neural network feeding into itself what
was happening previously allows it to
take that model and program in the whole
series without having to put in the
whole a month at a time of data you only
put in one day at a time but if you keep
them in order it will look back and say
oh this because what happened yesterday
i need some information from that and
i'm going to use that to help predict
today's and so on and so on we're going
to go back to our activation functions
remember i told you rayleigh was one of
the most common functions used
so let's talk a little bit more about
relu and also softmax softmax is an
activation function that generates the
output between 0 and 1. it divides each
output such that the total sum of the
outputs is equal to 1. it is often used
in the output layers softmax l of the n
equals e to l on the n over the absolute
value of e to the l so what does this
function mean i mean what is actually
going on here so we have our output
notes and our output nodes are giving us
let's say they gave us
0.9 and 0.4 as a human being i look at
that and i say well the greatest value
is 1.2 so whatever category that is if
you have three different categories
maybe you're not just doing if it's a
cat or it's a dog or well let's say it's
a cow we had cats and dogs earlier why
the cats and dogs are hanging out with a
cow i don't know but we have a value and
it might say 1.2 is a cat 0.9 is the dog
and 0.4 is a cow for some reason it
thinks that there's a chance of it being
any one of these three items and that's
how it comes out of the output layer
well as a human i can look at 1.2 and
say this is definitely what it is it's
definitely a cat or whatever it is maybe
it's looking at different kinds of cars
might be a better whether it's a car
truck or a motorcycle maybe that'd be a
better example well from a computer
standpoint that might be a little
confusing because they're just numbers
waving at us and so with the soft max we
want all those numbers to always add up
to one so when i add three numbers
together i want the final output to be
one on there and so it goes through this
formula changes each of these numbers in
this case it changes them to 0.46 0.34
and 0.20 they all add up to 1. and
that's a lot easier to register because
it's very set it's a set output it's
never going to be more than one it's
never going to be less than zero and so
you can see here that there's probably a
pretty high chance that it's the first
one so you're a human being we have no
problem knowing that but this output can
then also go into say another input so
it might be
an automated car that's picking up
images and it says that image in front
of us is probably a big truck we should
deal with it like it's a big truck it's
probably not a motorcycle or whatever
those categories are that's the soft max
part of it but now we have the relu well
where's the relu coming from well the
relu is what's generating the 1.2 and
the 0.9 and the 0.4 and so if you
remember our relu stands for rectified
linear unit and is the most widely used
activation function we looked at a
number of different activation functions
including tangent h the step function
remember i said the step function is
really used if that's what your actual
output is because then you know it's a
zero or one but the ray loop if you have
that as your output you now have a
discrepancy in there and if that's going
into another neural network or another
process having that discrepancy is
really important and it gives an output
of x if x is positive and 0 otherwise so
it says my x value is going to be
somewhere between 0 or 1 and then the
usually unless it's really uncertain the
output is usually a one or zeros and
then you have that little piece of
uncertainty there that you can send
forward to another network or you can
look at to know that there's uncertainty
involved and is often used in the hidden
layers this is what's coming out of the
hidden layers into the output layer
usually or as we reference the
convolutional neural network the cnn
you'd have to go to another video to
review the relu is the most common used
for convolutional part of that network
it has a bunch of little pieces that are
very simplified looking at all the
different images or different sections
of the map and the rayleigh works really
good for that like i said there's other
formulas used but that this is the most
common one and you'll see that in the
hidden layers going maybe between one
layer and the next layer so just a quick
recap we have our soft max which means
that if you have numerous categories
only one of them is going to be picked
but you also want to have some value
attached to it how well it picked it and
you put that between zero one so it's
very uh standardized so we have our soft
max we looked at that let's go back one
we looked at that here where it
transforms the numbers and then we have
our relu function which takes the
information and the summation and puts
it between a zero and a one where it's
either clearly a zero or depending on
how confident our model is it'll go
between the zero and one value what are
hyper parameters well this is a great
interview question hyper parameters when
you are doing neural networks this is
what you're playing with most the time
once you've gotten the data formatted
correctly a hyperparameter is a
parameter whose value is set before the
learning process begins determines how a
network is trained and the structure of
the network this includes things like
the number of hidden units how many
hidden layers are you going to have and
how many nodes in each layer learning
rate learning rate is usually multiplied
once you've figured out the error and
how much you want to change the weights
we talked about or i mentioned it
earlier just briefly you don't want to
just make a huge change otherwise you're
going to have a biased model so you only
take some little incremental changes and
that's what the learning rate is is
those small incremental changes epics
how many times are you going to go
through all the data in your training
set so one epic is one trip through all
the data and there's a lot of other
things depending on which model you're
working with and which programming
script you're working with like the
python sk learn package will have it
slightly different than say google's
tensorflow package which will be a
little bit different than the spark
machine learning package so these are
just some examples of the hyper
parameters and so you see in here we
have a nice image of our data coming in
and we train our model then we do a
comparison to see how good our model is
and then we go back and we say hey this
this model is pretty good but it's
biased so and we send it back and we
change our hyper parameters to see if we
can get an unbiased model or we can have
a better prediction on it it matches our
data closer what will happen if learning
rate is set too low or too high we have
a nice couple graphs here we have one
over here so the learning rate set to
load you can see that it slowly works
its way down the curve and on the right
you can see a learning rate set too high
it's just bouncing back and forth when
your learning rate is too low that's
what we studied at two slides what the
learning rate was training of the model
will progress very slowly as we are
making very tiny updates to the weights
we'll take many updates before reaching
the minimum point so i just mentioned
epic going through all the data you
might have to go through all the data a
thousand times instead of 500 times for
it to train learning rate too high
causes undesirable divergent behavior to
the loss function due to drastic updates
and weights at times it may fail to
converge or even diverge so if you have
your learning rate set too high and it's
training too quickly maybe you'll get
lucky and it trains after one epic run
but a lot of times it might never be
able to train because the weights are
changing too fast they flip back and
forth too easy and you see down here
we've introduced two new terms converge
and diverge a converge means that our
model has reached a point where it's
able to give a fairly good answer for
all the data we put in all those weights
have adjusted and it's minimized the
error diverged means that the data is so
chaotic that it can never manage to to
train to that data the data is just too
chaotic for it to train so we have two
new words there converge and diverge are
important to know also what is dropout
and batch normalization dropout is a
technique of dropping out hidden and
visible units of a network randomly to
prevent overfitting of data it doubles
the number of iterations needed to
converge the network so here we have our
standard neural network and then after
applying dropout now it doesn't mean we
actually delete the node the node is
still there and we're still going to use
that node what it means is that we're
only going to work with a few of the
nodes
a lot of times i think the most common
one right now used is 20
so you'll drop out 20 of the nodes when
you do your training you reverse
propagate your data and then you'll
randomly pick another 20 nodes the next
time you go through an epic data
training so each time you go through one
epic you will randomly pick 20 of those
nodes not not to mess with and this
allows for less overfitting of the data
so by randomly doing this you create
some i guess it just kind of pulls some
nodes off to the side it says we're
going to handle the data later on so we
don't over fit batch normalization is a
technique to improve the performance and
stability of neural network the idea is
to normalize the inputs in every layer
so that they have mean output and
activation of zero and standard
deviation of one this question covers a
lot of different things which is great
it's a great uh interview question
because it pulls in that you have to
understand what the mean value is so a
mean output activation of zero that
means our average activation is zero so
when you normalize it remember usually
we're going between minus one and one on
a lot of these it's a very standard
setup so you have to be very aware that
this is your mean output activation of
zero and then we have our standard
deviation of one so we want to keep our
error down to just a one value the
benefits of this doing a batch
normalization is it provides
regularization it trains faster higher
learning rates and weights are easier to
initialize what is the difference
between batch gradient descent and
stochastic gradient descent batch
gradient descent batch gradient computes
the gradient using the entire data set
it takes time to converge because the
volume of data is huge and weights
update slowly so you can look at the
batch as a lot of times if you're using
big data batch the data in but you still
go through a full epic you still go
through all the data on there so batch
gradient descent means you're going to
use it to fit all the data and look for
convergence there stochastic gradient
descent stochastic gradient computes the
gradient using a single sample it
converges much faster than batch
gradient because it updates weight more
frequently explain overfitting and
underfitting and how to combat them
overfitting happens when a model learns
the details and noise and the training
data to the degree that it adversely
impacts the execution of the model on
the new information it is more likely to
occur with non-linear models that have
more flexibility when learning a target
function an example of this would be
if you're looking at say cars and trucks
and motorcycles it might only recognize
trucks that have a certain box-like
shape it might not be able to notice a
flatbed truck unless it's only a
specific kind of flatbed truck or only
ford trucks because that's what it saw
on the training set this means that your
model performs great on your train data
and great on maybe a small test amount
of data but when you go to use it in the
real world it leaves out a lot and start
and is not very functional outside of
your small area your slow laboratory
data coming in under fitting doing the
opposite when you under fit your data
under fitting alludes to a model that is
neither well trained on training data
nor can generalize to new information
usually happens when there is less an
improper data to train a model has a
verb performance and accuracy so if
you're using underfitted data and you
generate a model and you distribute that
in a commercial zone you'll have a lot
of people unhappy with you because it's
not going to give them very good answers
so we've explained overfitting and under
fitting so now we want to ask how to
combat them combating overfitting and
underfitting resampling the data to
estimate the model accuracy k-fold
cross-validation having a validation
data set to evaluate the model so we do
the resampling we're randomly going to
be picking out data and we'll run it a
few times to see how that works
depending on our random data and how we
sample the data to generate our model
and then we want to go ahead and
validate the data set by having our
training data and then keeping some data
on the side
testing data to validate it how are
weights initialized in a network
initializing all weights to zero all the
weights are set to zero this makes your
model similar to a linear model so if
you have linear data coming in doing a
basic setup like that might work all the
neurons in every layer perform the same
operation given the same output and
making the deep net useless right there
is a key word it's going to be useless
if you initialize everything to zero at
that point be looking into some other
machine learning tools initializing all
weights randomly here the weights are
assigned randomly by initializing them
very close to zero it gives better
accuracy to the model since every neuron
performs different computations and here
we have the weights are set randomly we
have our input layer the hidden layers
and the output layer and w equals np
random random in layer size l layer size
l minus one this is the most commonly
used is to randomly generate your
weights what are the different layers in
cnn convolutional neural network first
is the convolutional layer that performs
a convolutional operation we have our
other video out if you want to explore
that more so go into detail exactly how
to see the convolutional layer works on
the cnn as far as creating a number of
smaller picture windows to go over the
data the second step is as a rayleigh
layer relu brings non-linearity to the
network and converts all the negative
pixels to zero output is rectified
feature map so it goes into a mapping
feature there pooling layer pooling is a
down sampling operation that reduces the
dimensionality of the feature map so we
have all our relu layer which is pulling
all these little maps out of our
convolutional layer it's taking that
picture and little creating little tiny
neural networks to look at different
parts of the picture then we need to
pull it together and then finally the
fully connected layer so we flatten our
pulling layer out and we have a fully
connected layer recognizes and
classifies the objects in the image and
that's actually your forward propagation
reverse propagation training model
usually i mean there's a number of
different models out there of course
what is pooling in cnn and how does it
work pooling used to reduce the spatial
dimensions of a cnn performs down
sampling operation to reduce the
dimensionality creates a pooled feature
map by sliding a filter matrix over the
input matrix i mentioned that briefly on
the previous slide
it's important to know that you have if
you see here they have a rectified
feature map and so each one of those
colors like the yellow color that might
be one of the a smaller little neural
network using the relu you'll look at
it'll just kind of
go over the main picture and look at all
the different areas on the main picture
so you might step one two three four
spaces um and then you have another one
that's also looking at features and it
has a 2785 each one of those is a map so
it might be the first one might be a map
looking for cat ears the second one
looking for human eyes when it does this
you then have this rectified feature map
looking at these different features and
the max pooling with the two by two
filters in a stride of two stride means
instead of skipping every pixel you're
gonna go every two pixels you take the
maximum values and you can see over here
we look at a pool feature map one of the
features says hey i had a max value of
eight so somewhere in here we saw a
human eye labeled as eight pretty high
label and maybe seven was a human hand
and maybe four was cat whiskers or
something that we thought might be cat
whiskers four is kind of a low number in
this particular case compared to the
other ones so you have your full pool
feature map you can see the process here
is we have our stepping we look for the
max value and then we create a pool
feature map of the max values how does a
lstm network work that's long short term
memory so the first thing to know is
that an lstms are a special kind of
recurrent neural network capable of
learning long term dependencies
remembering information for long periods
of time is their default behavior we did
look at the rnn briefly talked about how
the hidden layer feeds back into itself
with the lstm as a much more complicated
feedback and you can see here we have
the hidden layer of t minus one and
hidden area that's what the h stands for
hidden layer of t and the formula is
going in as we can see here we have the
hidden layers we have t minus one and
then h of t where t stands for time so
this is a series remember working with
series and we want to remember the past
and you can see you have your x your
input of t and that might be a frame in
a
video as a frame comes in they usually
use in this one the tangent h activation
formula but you also see that it goes
through a couple other formulas the
omega formula and so when it combines
these that then goes into the next layer
your next hidden layer that then goes
into the data that's submitted to the
next input so you have your x of t plus
one so when you have that coming in then
you have your h value that's coming
forward from the last process and
depending on how many of these omega
structures you put in there depends on
how long term the memory gets so it's
important to remember this is more for
your long-term recurrent neural networks
the three steps in an lstm step one
decides what to forget and what to
remember step two selectively update
cell state values so based on what we
want to remember and forget we want to
update those cell values and then
decides what part of the current state
make it to the output so now we have to
also have an output on there what are
vanishing and exploding gradients this
is a great question that affects all our
neural networks while training an rnn
your slope can become either too small
or too large and this makes the training
difficult when the slope is too small
the problem is known as vanishing
gradient so our slope we have our change
in x and our change in y when the slope
decreases gradually to a very small
value sometimes negative and makes
training difficult when the slope tends
to grow exponentially instead of
decaying this problem is called
exploding gradient the slope grows
exponentially you see a nice graph of
that here issues in gradient problem
long training time poor performance and
low accuracy what is the difference
between epic batch and iteration and
deep learning epic an epic represents
one iteration over the entire data set
so that's everything you're going to go
ahead and put into that training model
batch we cannot pass the entire data set
into the neural network at once so we
divide the data set into a number of
batches and then iteration if we have 10
000 images as data and a batch size of
200 then the epic should run 10 000
times over 200 so that means we have our
total number over the 200 equals 50
iteration so in each epic we're running
over all the data set we're going to
have 50 iterations and each of those
iterations includes a batch of 200
images in this case why tensorflow is
the most preferred library in deep
learning uh well first tensorflow
provides both c plus plus and python
apis that makes it easier to work on has
a faster compilation time than other
deep learning libraries like cross and
torch tensorflow supports both cpus and
gpus computing devices so right now
tensorflow is at the top of the market
because it's so easy to use for both
programmer side and for hardware side
and for the speed of getting something
up and running what do you mean by
tensor in tensorflow tensor is a
mathematical object represented as
arrays of higher dimensions these arrays
of data with different dimensions and
ranks that are fed as input to the
neural network are called tensors and
you can see here we have a tensor of
dimensions five comma four so it's a two
dimensional tensor coming in um you can
look at an image like this that each one
of those pixels is a different value if
it's a black and white so it might be
zero and ones and then each one
represents a black and white image in a
color photo you might
either find a different value system or
you might have a tensor value that has
the x y coordinates as we see here plus
the colors so you might have three more
different dimensions for the three
different images the red the blue and
the yellow coming in and even as you go
from one layer or one tensor to the next
these layers might change we might
flatten them might bring in numerous in
the case of the convergence neural
network we have all those smaller
different mappings of features that come
in so each one of those layers coming
through is a tensor if it has multiple
dimensions coming in and weights
attached to it what are the programming
elements in tensorflow well we have our
constants constants are parameters whose
value does not change to define a
constant we use tf.constant command
example a equals tf.constant 2.0 tf
float32 so it's a tensorflow value of
32. b equals tf constant 3.0 print a b
if we did a print of a b we'd have
tf.constant and then of course b is that
instance of it variables variables allow
us to add new trainable parameters to
graph to define a variable we use
tf.variable command and initialize them
before running the graph in session
example w equals tf variable 0.3 d type
tf float 32 or b equals the tf variable
minus 3 comma d type float32
placeholders placeholders allow us to
feed data to a tensorflow model from
outside a model it permits a value to be
assigned later to define a placeholder
we use tf placeholder command example a
equals tf placeholder b equals a times
two with the tf session as sess result
equals session run b comma feed
dictionary equals a 3.0 print result uh
so we have a nice example there replace
holder session a session is run to
evaluate the nodes this is called as the
tensorflow runtime so for example you
have a equals tf constant 2.0 b equals
tf constant 4.0 c equals a plus b and at
this point you'd go ahead and create a
session equals tf session and then you
could evaluate the tensor c print
session run c that would input c as an
input into your session what do you
understand by a computational graph
everything in tensorflow is based on
creating a computational graph it has a
network of nodes where each node
performs an operation nodes represent
mathematical operation and edges
represent tensors since data flows in a
form of a graph it is also called a data
flow graph and we have a nice visual of
this graph or graphic image of a
computational graph and you can see here
we have our input nodes our add multiply
nodes and our multiply node at the end
and then we have the edges where the
data flows so we have from a going to c
a going to d you can see we have a two
flowing four flowing explain generative
adversarial network along with an
example suppose there is a wine shop
that purchases wine from dealers which
they will resell later so we have our
dealer going to the wine or shop owner
that then sells it for a profit but
there are some malfactor dealers who
sell fake wine in this case the shop
owner should be able to distinguish
between fake and authentic wine the
forger will try to different techniques
to sell fake wine and make sure certain
techniques go past the shop owner's
check so here's our forager fake wine
shop owner the shop owner would probably
get some feedback from the wine experts
that some of the wine is not original
the owner would have to improve how he
determines whether a wine is fake or
authentic goal of forger to create wines
that are indistinguishable from the
authentic ones goal of shop owner to
accurately tell if the wine is real or
not there are two main components of
generative adversarial network and we
refer to as a noise vector coming in we
have our forger who's going to generate
fake wine and then we have our real
authentic wine and of course our shop
owner who has to figure out whether it's
real or fake the generator is a cnn that
keeps producing images that are closer
in appearance to the real images while
the discriminator tries to determine the
difference between real and fake images
the ultimate aim is to make the
discriminator learn to identify real and
fake images what is an auto encoder the
network is trained to reconstruct its
inputs it is a neural network that has
three layers here the input neurons are
equal to the output neuron the network's
target outside is same as the input it
uses dimensionality reduction to
restructure the input input image comes
in we have our latin space
representation and then it goes back out
reconstructing the image it works by
compressing the input to a latin space
representation and then reconstructing
the output from this representation what
is bagging and boosting bagging and
boosting are ensemble techniques where
the idea is to train multiple models
using the same learning algorithm and
then take a call so we have in here
where we're bagging we take a data set
and we split it we're gonna have our
training data and our test data very
standard thing to do then we're going to
randomly select data into the bags and
train your model separately so we might
have bag one model one bag two model two
bag three model three and so on in
boosting the emphasis is to select the
data points which give wrong output in
order to improve the accuracy so in
boosting we have our data set again we
split it to test data and train data and
we'll take a bag one and we'll train the
model data points with wrong predictions
then go into bag two and we then train
it thank you all for watching this live
session on artificial intelligence
engineer full course i hope it was
useful and informative thanks again stay
safe and keep learning
you